MORNING AND WELCOME TO
CALIFORNIA STATE ASSEMBLY PUBLIC
SAFETY COMMITTEE WE WILL BEGIN
AS A SUB COMMITTEE- BUT FIRST WE
NEED TO READ- THE FOLLOWING TO
THE PUBLIC. WE ENCOURAGE THE
PUBLIC TO PROVIDE WRITTEN
TESTIMONY BEFORE THE HEARING BY
VISITING THE COMMITTEE WEBSITE
AT- H. T. T. P. S. DOT. A. P. S.
F. DOT EIGHT A. S. S. E. M. B.
L. Y. DOT C. A. DOT G. O. V.
PLEASE NOTE THAT ANY WRITTEN
TESTIMONY SUBMITTED TO THE
COMMITTEE IS CONSIDERED PUBLIC
CAN COMMENT AND MAYBE READ INTO
THE RECORD OR REPRINTED. ALL ARE
ENCOURAGED TO WATCH THE HEARING
FROM ITS LIVE STREAM ON THE
ASSEMBLY'S WEBSITE W. W. DOT
ASSEMBLY DOT CA DOT GOV SLASH
TODAY'S EVENTS THE HEARING WILL
BE OPEN FOR ATTENDANCE OF THIS
HEARING ANY MEMBER OF THE PUBLIC
ATTENDING IS HERE A HEARING IS
ENCOURAGED TO WEAR A MASK AT ALL
TIMES WHILE IN THE BUILDING. THE
PUBLIC MAY ALSO PARTICIPATE IN
HIS HEARING BY TELEPHONE WE
ENCOURAGE THE PUBLIC TO MONITOR
THE COMMITTEE'S WEBSITE FOR
UPDATES IN ORDER TO FACILITATE
THE GOAL OF HEARING AS MUCH FROM
THE PUBLIC WITHIN THE LIMITS OF
OUR TIME WE WILL NOT PERMIT
CONDUCT THAT DISRUPTS AND
DISTURBS OR OTHERWISE IMPEDE THE
ORDERLY CONDUCT OF LEGISLATIVE
PROCEEDINGS. PLEASE BE AWARE
THAT BY LEGIONS OF THE RULES MAY
SUBJECT YOU TO REMOVAL OR OTHER
ENFORCEMENT PROCESS. SO WE WILL
. I WILL BEGIN BY AT LEAST.
TELLING THE MEMBERS THAT ARE
HERE WHICH ITEMS HAVE BEEN
PULLED FROM THE CALENDAR- IDMS
OFF CALENDAR UP ALL POLL BY THE
AUTHOR. BOB ITEM NUMBER TWO AB
SEVENTEEN NINETY CERVANTES PULL
BY AUTHOR ITEM NUMBER FIVE A. B.
TWO SEVEN ONE EIGHT COOPER CO BY
AUTHOR. ITEM NUMBER NINETEEN AB
TWO ONE THREE EIGHT MARETTE CITY
POLL BY AUTHOR ITEM NUMBER
TWENTY AB TWENTY THREE NINETY
MARETTE CITY OF PROBIOTIC- ITEM
NUMBER TWENTY TWO AB TWENTY
SEVEN SIXTY NINE O'DONNELL
PULLED BY AUTHOR. AND I DON'T
HAVE A TWENTY FIVE AB TWENTY
EIGHT TWENTY EIGHT RODRIGUEZ
POLL BY AUTHOR. AND WE ARE NOW
WAITING FOR. NOT ONLY MEMBERS OF
THE COMMITTEE SO WE CAN
ESTABLISH A QUORUM TO GET HERE
WE ARE ALSO WAITING FOR AUTHORS
. SO THAT WE MAY BEGIN WE HAVE A
FULL CALENDAR WE HAVE A WITH WE
GET THIRTY THREE ITEMS. SO THE
SOONER WE CAN BEGIN THE SOONER
WE CAN. GET TO THE PEOPLE'S
BUSINESS. GET IN AND GET OUT.
THANK YOU.
THIS IS A. THE MAPS EXTRA
BELIEVE WE NOW HAVE A QUORUM YOU
MAY CALL THE ROLL. JONES SAWYER
HERE LACKEY HERE. BONTA BRIAN
WORK HERE SANTIAGO THEY ARE TO.
THE QUORUM IS PRESENT- ARE NOW
WILL READ THE CONSENT CALENDAR
OF THE FOLLOWING ITEMS ARE
PROPOSED FOR CONSENT ITEM NUMBER
ONE AB TWENTY ONE OH THREE POWER
KIANA CRISIS RESPONSE FOR
VICTIMS AND SURVIVORS OF
VIOLENCE PILOT PROGRAM ITEM
NUMBER THREE AB NINETEEN SEVENTY
FOUR CHAD CORRECTIONAL FACILITY
SERVICE OF PROCESS ITEM NUMBER
THIRTEEN- AB SIXTEEN EIGHTY LEE
TRANSPORTATION PRO PROHIBITION
ORDERS ITEM NUMBER FOURTEEN. AB
TWO FIVE EIGHT EIGHT MAIENSCHEIN
CRIMES INSTRUCTION OF JUSTICE
ITEM NUMBER FIFTEEN AB TWO SIX
SIX ZERO MAIENSCHEIN YOUR CHILD
DEATH INVESTIGATIONS REVIEW TEAM
ITEM NUMBER SIXTEEN AB TWENTY
FIVE FIFTY ONE MCCARTY OF
FIREARMS ITEM NUMBER EIGHTEEN AB
TWO SEVEN SEVEN EIGHT MCCARTY
CRIME RATE RACE BLIND CHARGING.
AN ITEM NUMBER SEVENTEEN AB TWO
SEVEN ONE SEVEN WALDRON
PRISONERS CALIFORNIA HEALTH
START. BUT ROBERT HELPS START AT
THREE THE- SO. BOB SECTOR CALL
THE ROLL ON THE CONSENT CALENDAR
JONES SAWYER I DON'T FIGURE HI
BLACKIE BLACKIE HI BONTA BONTA
HI BRIAN BRIAN I WORK I WORK I
SANTIAGO SEYARTO THEY ARE TO I.
CONSENT CALENDARS ADOPTED- WE
ARE STILL WAITING FOR AUTHORS-
GOOD AUTHORS PLEASE COME ANYONE
IT SHOWS UP OUT OF ORDER FIRST
ONE FIRST SERVICE. OR WE CAN GO. IF SHE'S READY WE GO TO
MEMBERS SINCE THEY'RE NOT HERE.
THAT'S WHAT I'M SAYING RESPOND
TO WOULD YOU LIKE TO PRESENT
YOUR TWO BILLS SINCE WE DON'T
HAVE ANY OFFICE RIGHT NOW. SO
YOU HAVE TO ITEM NUMBER TWENTY
EIGHT AB TWENTY TWO FIFTY ME
ABOUT TO. ITEM NUMBER TWENTY
NINE. AB TWENTY FIVE FIFTY SEVEN
MIA BONTA. SECOND. INEPT-
BECTON SHARPLY WE'RE EXPECTING A
JOB LATER.
WHAT WOULD YOU LIKE TO DO TO DO
WHAT. IS IT ANY OF YEAR
WITNESSES HERE. OKAY. AND I HAVE
DO YOU WANT ME TO SEATTLE TO GO
WHILE YOU'RE WAITING. OKAY OKAY
THIS IS YOUR TO. THIS IS YOUR
TOTAL- AB SIXTEEN SEVENTY THREE
CALIFORNIA BENT THE LAW ABUSE
TASK FORCE YOU MAY PRESENT.
THANK YOU ARMEL CHAIR AND I'M
HERE TO PRESENT A VALID THREE
SECOND. THANK YOU. FIRST I'D
LIKE TO THANK THE COMMITTEE
STAFF FOR WORKING WITH MY STAFF
TO REFINE AND FORM THE
AMENDMENTS FOR THIS VERY
IMPORTANT BILL WHICH I AM
ACCEPTING. I AB SIXTEEN SEVENTY
THREE IS A BIPARTISAN BILL THAT
ESTABLISHES THE CALIFORNIA
FEDERAL ABUSE TASK FORCE THE
TASK FORCE WILL COLLECT AND
ORGANIZE DATA ON THE NATURE AND
EXTENT OF FENNEL ABUSE AND
EVALUATE APPROACHES TO TREAT AND
PREVENT OVERDOSES AS WELL AS
INCREASED PUBLIC AWARENESS OF
FENNEL. THIS TASK FORCE'S
MEMBERSHIP IS DIVERSE INCLUDING
REPRESENTATIVES FROM THE JUSTICE
SYSTEM NONPROFITS AND HEALTH
AGENCIES. OVER THE LAST TWO
DECADES CALIFORNIA AND THE REST
OF THE NATION HAVE SEEN A RISE
IN OVERDOSES RELATED TO OPIOID
USE. AS MEMBERS OF THIS
COMMITTEE WE HAVE BECOME WELL
AWARE OF THIS. THE AT HOW THIS
NEW WAVE OF DRUG DEATHS CAUSED
BY FENTANYL AFFECTS CALIFORNIANS
OF ALL DEMOGRAPHICS AND
COMMUNITIES. COSTS IN LIVES OF
ALMOST FOUR THOUSAND
CALIFORNIANS IN TWENTY TWENTY
ALONE. IN TWENTY TWENTY ONE
PHENYL OVERDOSE BECAME
RECOGNIZED AS THE LEADING CAUSE.
OF AMERICANS OF DEATH FOR
AMERICANS AGED EIGHTEEN TO FORTY
FIVE. AND THAT'S MORE THAN
SUICIDE GUN HOMICIDE AND CAR
ACCIDENTS. DATA FROM LAW
ENFORCEMENT YIELDS OF THE BAY
AREA ALONE HAD OVER TWENTY NINE
THOUSAND GRAMS OF FENTANYL THAT
WAS SEIZED IN TWO THOUSAND
TWENTY ONE. WHICH IS ENOUGH
FATAL OVERDOSES TO KILL FOURTEEN
POINT FIVE MILLION PEOPLE. THE
VALUE OF BRINGING TOGETHER A
STATEWIDE TASK FORCE OF
INDIVIDUALS ALREADY TRYING TO
ADDRESS THIS CRISIS CANNOT BE
UNDERSTATED AN EPIDEMIC OF THESE
PROPORTIONS DESERVES A RESPONSE
THAT BRINGS TOGETHER THE BEST OF
OUR STATE'S RESOURCES. AB
SEVENTEEN ARE SIXTEEN SEVENTY
THREE WILL ASSEMBLE THAT DATA
AND INDIVIDUALS TO IDENTIFY THE
RESOURCES NECESSARY TO RESPOND
TO THIS FORM OF SYNTHETIC OPIOID
ABUSE. I DID NOT I DO NOT HAVE
ANY WITNESSES WITH ME. SO GOOD
BOB WAS SAYING THAT- ANY
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT OF. BILL.
GOOD MORNING MR CHAIRMAN VERSES
SHAUN MUTCHLER ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA STATE SHERIFFS
ASSOCIATION IN SUPPORT THANK YOU
. FOR MR RANCHERO THE RIVERSIDE
SHERIFF'S ASSOCIATION AND THE
RIVERSIDE POLICE OFFICERS
ASSOCIATION SUPPORT THANK YOU
THANK YOU. NOW HERE. ME
WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION THEY'RE
IN A ROW. SEEING NONE UP BOOKS I
FORGOT TO OPEN UP THE PHONES FOR
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT. AND
OPPOSITION WAS DOING BOTH AT THE
SAME TIME AT T. OPERATOR COULD
YOU OPEN UP LINES FOR SUPPORT
AND OPPOSITION FOR A C. R. TWO
AB SIXTEEN SEVENTY THREE.
EIGHTEEN THE OPERATOR YOU STILL
THERE. HELLO.
ARE WE HAVING PROBLEMS WITH THE
EIGHTEEN T. OPERATOR AGAIN. I
DON'T KNOW. HANDICAPPER AIRLINE
IS RECONNECTED. YEAH A THANK YOU.
WHERE ARE AB SIXTEEN SEVENTY
THREE SEYARTO ITEM NUMBER THIRTY
COULD YOU OPEN UP THE LINES FOR
AND AGAINST.
ADD A COMMENT. A PUBLIC COMMENT. IN GERMANY WHO WISH TO MAKE
ANY PUBLIC COMMENTS FOR OR
AGAINST PLEASE PRESS ONE THEN
ZERO. AND I HAVE NO ONE IN Q.
THANK YOU BRING IT BACK TO
COMMITTEE- ANY QUESTIONS. SEEN
NONE YOU MAY CLOSE OUR MEMBERS I
JUST ASK FOR AYE VOTE THE AND I
WANT TO THANK YOU FOR PUTTING
THIS TASK FOR TOGETHER- I THINK
DID THE COMPOSITION IS BRILLIANT
AND I WANT TO COMMEND YOU FOR
TAKING THIS ON THE MOST
IMPORTANT PUTTING TOGETHER. BUT
TASK FORCE TO HAS BOTH SIDES SO
WE CAN HEAR ALL OF THE POSSIBLE
SOLUTIONS- TO JUST DREADED
DREADED PROBLEM INSIDE I WANT TO
PERSONALLY THANK YOU IDT
COMMITTEE THANK YOU BECAUSE WE
GET A LOT OF FEDERAL YEAH BILLS
AND DISCUSSION I THINK YOU WILL
GET US ON THE PATH TO A SOLUTION
SO AGAIN I WANT THANK YOU.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER FOR BRINGING
THIS YOUR- MAY THE ROLL. ON AB
SEVENTY THREE BY SEVEN MEMBERS
TO YOUR TO THE MOTION IS TO PASS
TO THE APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE
JONES SAWYER HI THERE HI LACKEY
LACKEY I BONTA BONTA HI BRIAN HI
BRIAN I WORK. I WORK I SANTIAGO
. SEYARTO HI THEY ARE TOO HIGH.
THANK YOU OKAY SO GENTLEMEN I
MISTER GIBSON YOUR FIRST BECAUSE
IN ORDER MISTER COOPER MISTER
GIBSON IS HERE SO WHAT. YOU TO
WORK IT OUT. MISTER GUEST GIPSON
YIELDED AND MISSED COOPER WAS
THE FIRST ON OUR CALENDAR. YEAH. OKAY. WHAT NO. YOUR RECORD. I
DON'T CARE. THE. WHENEVER YOU'RE
READY I THINK THEY'RE PILING IN
NOW. THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN
BURST AB EIGHTEEN TWENTY SEVEN
OR THE CAPE TIBBETTS FACT WILL
HELP PREVENT VIOLENT MURDERS AND
ASSAULTS LIKE WHAT HAPPENED TO
K. TO THIS LAST YEAR. IN
SEPTEMBER TWENTY TWENTY ONE
SIXTY ONE YEAR OLD WAS LIVING
ALONE WITH APPROPRIATE LARGE
BROKE INTO A HOME ASSAULTED AND
THEN MURDERED HER. IS ONE A
PREDATOR ALSO KILLED BOTH CASE
DOGS ATTEMPTED TO BURN DOWN A
HOME TO CONCEAL HIS REFER CRIMES
EARLY THAT EVENING BEFORE KATE'S
MURDER OUR NEIGHBOR CALLED
POLICE REPORTING A SUSPECT WHO
IS STANDING ON THE PORT MANN. IN
FOR THE DOOR CAMERA AT THAT TIME
THE SUSPECT WAS ON PAROLE FOR
THE VIOLENCE SERIOUS CRIMES OF
ROBBERY AND ASSAULT WITH DEADLY
WEAPON. HE WAS A TRANSIENT WAS
IN VIOLATION OF HIS PAROLE FOR
NOT CHECKING IN PRO HAD NO WAY
TO CONTACT HIM EVEN KNOW HIS
WHEREABOUTS. IT IS NOT UNCOMMON
THREE VIOLENT OR SEXUAL PREDATOR
PAROLE THE TO BE AT LARGE
BECAUSE THEY ARE TRANSIENT AND
REFUSED TO CHECK IN.
UNFORTUNATELY IS ALSO NOT
UNCOMMON FOR A VOTE IMPROVE THE
POTENTIALLY VIOLATES THE
CONDITIONS OF PAROLE NOT TO BE
HELD ACCOUNTABLE AND TO CONTINUE
TO DO AS THEY PLEASE AND WONDER
UNCHECKED. LET ME BE CLEAR. THIS
IS NOT THE FAULT OF THE PRO
AGENTS THE FILLION SYSTEMS GIRLY
FALLS UPON POOR POLICY BY THE
CDC ARE HERE'S WHAT AB EIGHTEEN
TWENTY SEVEN DOES TO ADDRESS
THESE ISSUES THE FIND A HIGH
RISK FRAWLEY AS ONE HAS BEEN
CONVICTED OF A VIOLENT CRIME
FELONY SEXUAL OFFENSE OR SERIOUS
FELONY LIKE DOMESTIC VIOLENCE OR
RIPPING OF A DISABLED PERSON.
CREATES A MISDEMEANOR SAID AT
THE COUNTY JAIL TIME NOT PRISON
WITH A HIGH RISK POOL YOU FELT
TO REPORT TO A PAROLE AGENT.
RICARDO HIRES PEARLY WHO'S
TRANSIENT TO BE FITTED WITH A
MONITORING DEVICE UPON RELEASE
FROM PRISON OR TILL THEY HAVE
ESTABLISHED RESIDENCE. THIS
GIVES TOTAL A FULL DISCRETION TO
THE COURTS. NOT TO SUBJECT IT A
HIGH RISK PROCEDURAL TIME TOTAL
COURT DISCRETION. THIS BILL ONLY
APPLIES TO THOSE WHO ARE ON
PAROLE AFTER BEING CONVICTED OF
A VIOLENT SERIOUS FELONY OR
SEXUAL FELONY. HERE TODAY IS
DENTED ITS CASE BROTHER AND ASK
THE DOC IS. KATE'S FRIEND. THANK
YOU HAVE FIVE FIVE MINUTES
ALTOGETHER WHATEVER WAY YOU WANT
TO SPLIT UP TWO AND A HALF
MINUTES OR FOUR MINUTES TO ONE
WHATEVER WHENEVER YOU'RE READY
YOU MAY BEGIN. GOOD MORNING MR
CHAIRED COMMITTEE MEMBERS YOU
PULL THE MIGHT CLOSE AS WE CAN
HERE. GOOD MORNING MISTER CHAIR
AND COMMITTEE MEMBERS THANK YOU
FOR HAVING US HERE TODAY. MY
NAME IS DAN TIBBETTS ONE OF
KATE'S BROTHERS MY BROTHER
GEORGE IS ALSO HERE TODAY. ON
THE MORNING OF SEPTEMBER THIRD
OF LAST YEAR MY SISTER MARY KATE
TIBET'S WAS AT HER HOME IN THE
LAND PARK COMMUNITY OF
SACRAMENTO WHEN THE SUSPECT
BROKE INTO HER HOME AND
ASSAULTED AND MURDERED HER. HE
ALSO KILLED HER TWO DOGS AND
THEN SAID KATE'S HOUSE ON FIRE.
MY SISTER WAS A GOOD PERSON A
REGULAR VOLUNTEER FOR THE SPCA
AND ALWAYS WORKED ELECTIONS. SHE
BELIEVED IN THE CIVIC PROCESS
AND BELIEVE THAT ELECTED
OFFICIALS AND OUR GOVERNANCE
STRUCTURE WOULD ALWAYS DO THEIR
BEST TO PROTECT SOCIETY. THE
PERSON WHO KILLED MY SISTER
VIOLATED HIS PAROLE HE FAILED TO
APPEAR IN COURT FOR NEW CRIMES
HE COMMITTED WHILE ON PAROLE AND
HAD A WARRANT OUT FOR HIS ARREST
AT THE TIME HE MURDERED KATE.
UNFORTUNATELY BECAUSE THIS
PERSON WAS TRANSIENT PAROLE
OFFICERS HAD NO MEANS TO BE ABLE
TO FIND THIS PERSON TO ENSURE HE
MET THE SIMPLE LIST STIPULATIONS
OF HIS PAROLE. THEREFORE THE
SYSTEM THAT QUE BELIEVED IN AND
TRUSTED. DRASTICALLY FELT HER
AND IT COST HER HER LIFE. MY
SISTER'S MURDER HAD. HAS HAD
PROFOUND IMPACTS TO NOT JUST MY
FAMILY BUT TO THE ENTIRE
COMMUNITY. PRIOR TO KATE'S
MURDER I FELT SAFE IN MY HOME.
BECAUSE OF KATE'S MURDER AND THE
NUMEROUS OTHER MURDERS AND
VIOLENT CRIMES TAKING PLACE EACH
WEEK IN OUR STATE THE ENTIRE
COMMUNITY NOTE NO LONGER FEEL
SAFE FROM VIOLENT PREDATORS EVEN
IN OUR OWN HOMES. LATELY ALL TOO
OFTEN CONVICTED FELONS ARE BEING
RELEASED EARLY FROM PRISON ON
PAROLE. HER ROLE IS BASICALLY AN
AGREEMENT BETWEEN THE
GOVERNMENTS GOVERNANCESYSTEM
AND A VIOLENT CONDUCT THAT SAYS.
OKAY YOU BEHAVE YOURSELF WHILE
BEING INCARCERATED WILL LET YOU
OUT EARLY AND CONTINUE TO SEE IF
YOU BEHAVE YOURSELF. HOWEVER
MANY TIMES HIGH RISK PAROLEES DO
NOT BEHAVE THEMSELVES
UNFORTUNATELY THERE IS A VERY
DEFICIENT STRUCTURE TO HOLD THEM
ACCOUNTABLE WHEN THEY
INTENTIONALLY VIOLATE THEIR
PAROLE. AND THIS IS EVEN MORE
APPARENT IF THE PAROLE THE
HAPPENS TO BE TRANSIENT. K.
TIBBETTS ACT WOULD REQUIRE
TRANSIENT HIGH RISK PAROLEES TO
WEAR AN ANKLE MONITORING DEVICE
SO THAT IF AND WHEN THEY VIOLATE
PAROLE CONDITIONS THEY CAN
SIMPLY BE LOCATED. HAD THE
TRANSIENT PAROLEES WHO KILLED
KATE BEEN REQUIRED TO HAVE THIS
MONITORING DEVICE HER SENSELESS
AND BRUTAL MURDER LIKELY WOULD
HAVE BEEN AVOIDED. THERE ARE
SOME WHO SAY THAT THIS VIOLATES
THE CIVIL RIGHTS OF THE VIOLENT
PAROLEES MY COUNTER TO THEM IS
TWO FOLD FIRST THESE VIOLENT
CONT THAT CONTACTS FORFEITED
SOME OF THEIR RIGHTS WHEN THEY
COMMITTED THEIR CRIMES THAT LED
TO THEIR INCARCERATION IN THE
FIRST PLACE. AND SECOND WHAT
ABOUT THE CIVIL RIGHTS OF
VICTIMS LIKE KATE. ARE WE AS A
SOCIETY PUTTING THE FORFEITED
RIGHTS OF CONVICTED FELONS THE
HEAD OF THE RIGHTS OF LAW
ABIDING CITIZENS TAXPAYERS AND
CONSTITUENTS OF THE STATE.
THEREFORE I STRONGLY URGE YOU TO
SUPPORT THE CAPE TIBBETTS ACT
AND A VOTE FOR THIS BILL THANK
YOU FOR YOUR CONSIDERATION.
THANK YOU SIR. YES WE CAN SO WE
CAN HEAR YOU. YOU CAN PUT
CLOSER. NOT TO TOUCH IT. WELL
MISTER. THANK YOU FOR HAVING US
HERE TODAY MY NAME IS ANSWERED
ACCESS AND I'M TESTIFYING IN
SUPPORT OF AB EIGHTEEN TWENTY
SEVEN. I WOULD LIKE TO GIVE YOU
A LITTLE BACKGROUND AS TO WHY.
AB EIGHTEEN TWENTY SEVEN IS
NAMED AFTER IN HONOR OF KATE
TIBBETTS I MET KATE IN NINETEEN
SEVENTY NINE WHEN WE ARE BOTH
BUSINESS STUDENTS AT CAL STATE
SACRAMENTO. WE QUICKLY BUILT A
CLOSE FRIENDSHIP AND THE NEXT
ACADEMIC YEAR BECAME ROOMMATES
OVER THE COURSE OF THE NEXT
TWELVE YEARS KATE AND I WOULD
SHARE FOUR DIFFERENT HOMES IN
SACRAMENTO AND THE EAST BAY WITH
ONLY A FEW SHORT BREAKS DUE TO
EDUCATION OR EMPLOYMENT. AS KATE
AND I EACH BECAME HOMEOWNERS WE
LIVE SEPARATELY BUT CONTINUE OUR
CLOSE RELATIONSHIP IN FACT I
REFERRED TO KATE AS MY SECOND
SISTER INSTEAD OF A BEST FRIEND
OF WHICH KATE HAD TOO MANY TO
COUNT. OVER THE PAST FORTY THREE
YEARS KATE CELEBRATED MY
SUCCESSES AND SUPPORTED ME
THROUGH DIFFICULT TIMES
INCLUDING THE DEATH OF MY BLOOD
RELATED SISTER FROM CANCER FIVE
YEARS AGO. WHEN KATE ABOUT HER
LAN PER COMMON TWO THOUSAND
FOURTEEN I WAS HAPPY THAT SHE
WAS MOVING TO A SAFER
NEIGHBORHOOD THEN- PRIOR HOUSE
NOW I KNOW BETTER NO
NEIGHBORHOOD IS SAFE IN
SACRAMENTO OR EVEN CALIFORNIA.
ON THE NIGHT OF SEPTEMBER THIRD
KAY WAS BRUTALLY MURDERED AFTER
TREY DAVIS A VIOLENT OFFENDER
BROKE INTO HER HOME DAVIS HAD
PREVIOUSLY BEEN RELEASED FROM
CUSTODY ON TO THE STREETS OF
SACRAMENTO WITH NO PLACE TO
LIVE. AND IN FACT DAVIS HAVE
BEEN RECORDED PERFORMING SEXUAL
ACTS ON INDOOR SECURITY CAMERA
EARLIER THAT DAY. A CONCERN LAND
PARK RESIDENT CONTACTED THE
POLICE WHO PUT A HELICOPTER IN
THE AIR LOOKING FOR DAVIS LAW
ENFORCEMENT WAS FORCED TO
SUSPEND THE SEARCH WHEN DAVIS
COULD NOT BE LOCATED. IN MY
OPINION WE HAVE NOT GIVEN OUR
LAW ENFORCEMENT OFFICERS ENOUGH
TOOLS TO DO THEIR JOB HAD THE
PROVISIONS OF EIGHTEEN TWENTY
SEVEN THE KATE TIPPETT'S ACT
BEEN IN PLACE DAVIS COULD NOT
COULD HAVE BEEN LOCATED AND KATE
SENSELESS MURDER COULD HAVE BEEN
PREVENTED. IT IS SIMPLY NOT OKAY
FOR A LOT OF. WOMEN LIVING ALONE
TO PUT AT RISK IN FAVOR OF
VIOLENT OFFENDERS RIGHTS. WHEN A
VIOLENT OR SEXUAL OFFENDERS
RELEASED FROM PRISON A
MONITORING DEVICE SEEMS LIKE A
SIMPLE SOLUTION FOR THOSE
RELEASED WITH OUR- AND ESTABLISH
A- IT ALLOWS. WHO HAVE EARNED
EARLY RELEASE CREDITS TO RE.
SOCIETY WITH AN APPROPRIATE
MECHANISM AND MAINTAINING
CONTACT WITH THEIR PAROLE
AGENTS. AND WITH OTHER SUPPORT
SYSTEMS FOCUS ON TRUE
REHABILITATION WHILE ENSURING
PUBLIC SAFETY. AB EIGHT TWENTY
SEVEN ENCOURAGES CONTINUED
COMPLIANCE PROVIDE. BY PROVIDING
CONSEQUENCES FOR REPEAT
OFFENDERS. PLEASE VOTE THIS
PLEASE VOTE FOR THIS BILL OR LET
THE PUBLIC KNOW HOW THIS
COMMITTEE CHARGED WITH
PROTECTING PUBLIC SAFETY PLANS
TO ACTUALLY PROTECT PUBLIC
SAFETY. THE CURRENT LAW LET KATE
DOWN HOW MANY MORE KIDS ARE OUT
THERE THANK YOU. THANK YOU. IN
OUR HEAR FROM WITNESSES IN
SUPPORT. OF IN SUPPORT OF THE
BILL MAY COME TO THE MICROPHONE
YOUR NAME ORGANIZATION AND-%
BETTER IN SUPPORT OF THE BILL.
MAY COME TO THE MIKE NOW. IT'S
RIGHT THERE. THANK YOU CANNOT
STONE A FRIEND OF THE TO HIS
FAMILY IN A GROUP WITH KATE NEW
OVER WELL THIS NEVER SHOULD HAVE
HAPPENED. IN YOUR IN SUPPORT
THANK YOU I'M SUPPORT THANK YOU
SIR. C. NOTED- YES SIR MY NAME
IS GEORGE TIBBITT SKATES OLDEST
BROTHER I ALSO WANT TO SPEAK IN
SUPPORT OF THE ACT- IMPLORED THE
COMMITTEE ON PUBLIC SAFETY TO
TAKE THE SIMPLE STEP TO PROVIDE
MORE PUBLIC SAFETY FOR THE
CITIZENS OF CALIFORNIA. THANK
YOU SIR. I'M FLORI TIBBETTS HI
MA'AM KATE'S SISTER IN LAW AND
I'M IN SUPPORT OF THIS BILL.
THANK YOU. MY NAME IS SARAH
SCHULTZ- ALLEN PARK RESIDENT AND
I AM IN SUPPORT OF THIS BILL.
THANK YOU. MY NAME IS KATIE
HARRELSON AND I LIVE IN THE
GREEN HAVEN AREA AND STOOD
OUTSIDE KATE'S HOUSE ON
SEPTEMBER THIRD THINKING A FIRE
BROKE OUT ONLY TO FIND OUT. THAT
SHE DIED FROM SUCH A VIOLENT
CRIME AND AS A SINGLE WIDOW I
TOTALLY SUPPORT THIS BILL. THANK
YOU MA'AM. I'M JOANNE KALILA
REGISTERED DEMOCRATS LIVING IN
SACRAMENTO M. AND HAVE BEEN A
FORTY YEAR FRIEND OF KATE
TIBBETTS AND SINGLE WOMAN LIVING
ALONE AND IT'S TERRIFYING THAT
THERE WAS NO MORE PROTECTION FOR
HER THAN THIS. THANK YOU. ANY
OTHER WITNESSES IN A ROW. BUT
NOW GO TO THE AT&T OPERATOR
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT. THANK YOU-
PLEASE IF YOU HAVE ANY COMMENTS
IN SUPPORT OF AB EIGHTEEN TWENTY
SEVEN PLEASE PRESS ONE THEN ZERO
NOW. SINCE WE HAD SOMEONE IN THE
HALL AND THAT WAS IN SUPPORT TO
. THAT I SUPPORT. AB EIGHTEEN
TWENTY SEVEN THANK YOU SIR. YOU
MAY BEGIN NOW EIGHTEEN T.
OPERATOR IN SUPPORT THANK YOU
FIRST WE HAVE LINE NUMBER
NINETEEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. HELLO GONNA HELLO
MY NAME IS THE LADY SANDERS AND
CALLING ON BEHALF OF LEGAL
SERVICES FOR CALIFORNIANS
INTERESTED TOWN DENIZENS OF FOR
US SB. ELEVEN SEVENTY EIGHT
THANK YOU. THANK YOU. THANK YOU
AND NEXT WE HAVE BLIND THREE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. YES DAVID KING
T'CHALLA WITH THE CALIFORNIA
BAIL AGENTS ASSOCIATION IN
STRONG SUPPORT THIS MEASURE.
REYES DISASSEMBLE THIS IS COOPER
BILL ITEM NUMBER. NUMBER FOUR A.
B. EIGHTEEN TWENTY SEVEN. COOPER. THANK YOU LIKE WE HAVE LINE
NUMBER NINETY TWO. YOUR LINE IS
OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. HELLO
COMMITTEE ON AND I'M IN SUPPORT
OF THE BILL. THANK YOU THANK YOU
. NEXT HEADLINE NUMBER EIGHTY
SIX PLEASE GO AHEAD. IT IS THE
RESULT IN THE CRIME VICTIMS
UNITED ON BEHALF OF UNIVERSAL
ARE NO GOSPEL MAN AND HERIOT'S
LEARNER WE ARE IN SUPPORT. OF AB
EIGHTEEN TWENTY SEVEN. THANK YOU. AND THAT IS ALL I HAVE BEEN
HERE. THANK YOU WE NOW HEAR
WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION. THANK
YOU FOR YOUR TESTIMONY IT
DEPICTS THANK YOU.
EIGHTEEN TWENTY SEVEN AB
EIGHTEEN TWENTY SEVEN. YOU HAVE
FIVE MINUTES TO MINISTER PIECE
WHICHEVER WAY YOU WANT TO SPLIT
. I'LL GO FIRST AND I'LL MAKE IT
QUICK MY NAME'S ANDREW AND I'M
THE CEO OF THE INSIDE CARD
PROGRAM WE PROVIDE-
REHABILITATIVE. SERVICES TO
CURRENTLY IN PREVIOUS
INCARCERATED PEOPLE INCLUDING
THOSE WHO ARE IN RE ENTRY- IS
BILLS- THAT SEEKS TO PLACE LIKE
TOM MINERS ON PEOPLE WHO ARE
CONSIDERED HIGH RISK FRAWLEY'S
AND HELPLESS- WE KNOW THAT IN
CALIFORNIA WE HAVE A HOUSE THIS
THIS PROBLEM IS SYSTEMIC. IT
IMPACTS MANY PEOPLE FROM MANY
DEMOGRAPHICS ACROSS CALIFORNIA-
D. D. BEING HOUSES I'M SORRY
ADDITIONALLY PEOPLE WITHOUT
HOMES HAVE A DIFFICULT TIME
ACCESSING PLACES RIGHT LET
TRICITY THAT'S SETTING AT
SETTING THEM UP FOR NON CRIMINAL
VIOLATIONS- ADD THAT. THERE'S
LITTLE DIFFERENCE FROM HIGH
RISKS AND HIGH NEEDS PEOPLE ON
PAROLE AS SOMEBODY WHO WORKS
WITH PEOPLE EVERY SINGLE DAY IN
THIS FIELD. A LITTLE DIFFERENCE
IN HOW WE DO THAT ASSESSMENT- AT
HOUSELESS PEOPLE- FOR ALREADY
FACE A MERE READ A SYSTEMIC
CHALLENGES AND MORE BARRIERS TO
THE NON SUSTAINABLE SOLUTION
ONLY COMPOUNDS IN EXISTING ISSUE
- THE CURRENT MONITORING AS A
FORM ELECTRONIC INCARCERATION A
CONTINUES AT THE PRISON SYSTEM
LONG AFTER PERSONS RELEASED- AND
I'LL ADD THAT THERE'S ALREADY
PROVISIONS WITHIN WITH WITHIN
THIS LAW THAT I A AND THAT'S
RARELY AVAILABLE- TO BE PLACED
PEOPLE WANDER ELECTRONIC
MONITORING BY AT THE BORDER PRO
HEARINGS. THE COURT AND
INCLUDING THE SUPERVISING- PRO
AGENTS- AND SO WHAT THIS WOULD
DO IS JUST MAKE A BLANKET I'M
BILL THAT WOULD PUT EVERYBODY
WHO IS CONSIDERED HIGH RISK FOR
ALL ON ELECTRONIC MONITORING
WHEN THEY BECOME HOUSE THIS- AND
I'LL FINISH IT WOULD WANT ONE
MORE THING- WHEN I PAROLED IN
TWO THOUSAND NINE. THIS BILL
WOULD. ME THE SHORT. GOOD
MORNING THANK YOU- MY NAME IS
MARCO GEORGIAN I'M HERE TODAY ON
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA PUBLIC
DEFENDERS ASSOCIATION IN
OPPOSITION TO A. B. EIGHTEEN
TWENTY SEVEN- FIRST I WANT TO
SAY TO THE FAMILY AND FRIENDS OF
KATE I'M REALLY SORRY FOR YOUR
LOSS MY HEART GOES OUT TO YOU-
BUT AB TWENTY. EIGHTEEN TWENTY
SEVEN IS NOT A SOLUTION TO
PAROLEES BEING HOMELESS OR RE
OFFENDING. INSTEAD IT'S A JOB
CREATION PROGRAM FOR MORE PAROLE
OFFICERS AND MORE LAWYERS PUBLIC
DEFENDERS AND DISTRICT ATTORNEYS
. FIRST ON AS- THE OTHER SPEAKER
POINTED OUT HIGH RISK SEX
OFFENDER PAROLEES ARE ALREADY ON
GPS MONITORING- AND I JUST WANT
TO HIGHLIGHT A COUPLE OF FACTS
IN THE ANALYSIS- ACCORDING TO
THE ANALYSIS THERE ARE
APPROXIMATELY SIX THOUSAND
PAROLEES WHO WOULD BE REQUIRED
TO SUBMIT TO GPS MONITORING
UNDER. THIS PROPOSED BILL. ONE
STUDY TOUTING GPS SAID THAT-
OPTIMUM CASELOADS FOR PAROLE
OFFICERS MONITORING GPS PAROLEES
WAS TWENTY PAROLEES CURRENTLY-
THERE ARE ABOUT FIFTY PAROLEES
WHO ARE NOT ON GPS MONITORING TO
EACH PAROLE OFFICERS CASELOAD.
SO THAT MEANS THAT YOU WOULD
MULTIPLY- SIX THOUSAND AND DO
THE MATH AND YOU HAVE TO HIRE
MORE PAROLE OFFICERS- THE
CALIFORNIA OFFICER INSPECTOR
GENERAL- FOUND THAT ANY
ADVANTAGES OR GPS MONITORING
CAME AT THE EXPENSE OF DIVERTING
AGENTS. SO THAT THEY WERE BUSY
REVIEWING THE GPS TRACKS BECAUSE
THEY ARE REQUIRED TO. TO REVIEW
THE TRACKS DALY A LOT OF THE
TRACKING REVIEWS AND THEN
RESPOND TO ALERTS AND IN SOME
CASES THERE WERE UP TO A
THOUSAND ALERTS A DAY AND THOSE
WERE ALERTS FROM THINGS LIKE THE
BATTERY GOING OUT- SOMEBODY
BEING UNDER A BRIDGE AND IT NOT
WORKING- YOU KNOW JUST THINGS
THAT WERE LIKE FALSE ALARMS. AND
THIS TROUBLE IS NOT LIMITED TO
CALIFORNIA ALREADY ON THE STATES
THAT DO HAVE SIMILAR PROVISIONS
NEW YORK AND FLORIDA THE AGENTS
WERE SO OVERWHELMED WITH NONSTOP
ALERTS. THAT THEY WERE UNABLE TO
PROPERLY SUPERVISE THE PAROLEES
AND SOME OF THEM WENT ON TO
COMMIT NEW VIOLENT CRIMES AND Q.
CONCLUDING AND ONE SPEC IF YOU.
OKAY HE CONCLUDED OKAY SO THAT
AND CLOSING I WOULD JUST SAY THE
SOLUTION IS TO PROVIDE HOUSING
IT'S CHEAPER IT'S MORE EFFECTIVE
AND IT WORKS TO KEEP PEOPLE FROM
RE OFFENDING WE RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR YOUR NO VOTE ON A. B.
EIGHTEEN TWENTY SEVEN. THE NOW
HEAR FROM WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION- TO THE BILL A. B.
EIGHTEEN TWENTY SEVEN NAME AT
ORGANIZATION. ERIC ME ON BEHALF
OF THE NASHIK JUSTICE AND
RESPECT FOR OPPOSITION THANK YOU
. EMILY HARRIS OF ELEVATOR
CENTER FOR HUMAN RIGHTS IN
OPPOSITION. FRED WILLIAMS ACLU
CAL ACTION IN OPPOSITION. THANK
YOU. OTHER ANY ANYONE OUTSIDE IN
. OPPOSITION. THEY WILL GO TO
THE EIGHTEENTH TEE OPERATOR
PHONELINE. OPERATOR PHONE LINE.
THANK YOU LADIES AND GENTLEMEN
TO SPEAK IN OPPOSITION OF AB
EIGHTEEN TWENTY SEVEN PLEASE
PRESS ONE THEN ZERO AT THIS TIME
. AND FIRST WE HAVE LINE NUMBER
NINETY EIGHT PLEASE GO AHEAD.
OUR CHAIR THAT'S UNDERNEATH THAT
THE ANTI RECIDIVISM COALITION
OPPOSE THIS BILL THANK YOU THANK
YOU. NEXT WE HAVE LINE NUMBER
NINETY SIX PLEASE GO AHEAD. THE
MORNING YOGA JOHNSON WITH TIME
THERE A STRONG OPPOSITION THANK
YOU. THANK YOU THANKS WE HAVE
CLIMBED NUMBER SEVENTY EIGHT
PLEASE GO AHEAD. NINE SEVEN
EIGHT YOUR LINE IS OPEN. HELLO
HELLO YOUR LINE IS OPEN. MY
BUDDY HENRY OPHTHALMOL SCHOOL
COMMUNITY MEMBERS LED
UNFORTUNATE FOR THE STORY THAT I
WAS SHARED BY I WAS KNOW WHAT'S
WITH THOSE I HAVE BEEN A AYE OR
AGAINST WHAT OKAY NEXT WE HAVE
MY NUMBER NINETY ONE. PLEASE GO
AHEAD. THE MINIMUM MARVIN- FROM
DIESEL SERVICES PRISONERS WITH
CHILDREN AND I OPPOSED A. B.
EIGHTEEN TWENTY SEVEN. H. NEXT
WE HAVE MY NUMBER NINETY FIVE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI MY NAME IS A
LITTLE MORE FROM L. IF YOU SEE
ALL OF THE CAN NINE OAKLAND AND
I OPPOSE. EIGHTEEN TWENTY SEVEN.
AND I SAVE MY NUMBER NINETY NINE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. HELLO GOOD
MORNING. MY NAME IS BELLA
MARGINAL ENVIRONMENT STRONG
OPPOSITION. TO EIGHTEEN
EIGHTEEN. TWENTY SEVEN ON BEHALF
OF COMMUNITY THROUGH HOPE THANK
YOU. AND WE HAVE NO ONE ELSE
THANK YOU. THANK YOU AND I'LL
BRING IT BACK TO COMMITTEE FOR
QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS MISTER
CORK. ARM I'LL JUST HAVE A
COMMENT AND THEN I'VE GOT A CO
PRESENTER BELL BUT MY MAIN
CONCERN WITH THIS APPROACH IS I
DON'T THINK IT'S PRACTICAL. UP
YOU HAVE TO CHARGE THESE BINDERS
STANDING IS TWICE A DAY FOR AN
HOUR- EACH TIME AND THAT. I
DON'T KNOW HOW THEY DO IT AT
NIGHT DURING THE DAY THEY COULD
GET TO THE PAROLE OFFICERS-
OFFICE AND DO IT THERE. AND
THEN- YOU KNOW IF IT LOSES ITS
CHARGE YOU'RE NOT GONNA BE ABLE
TO TRACK THEM. OF WHICH SEEMS A
LIKELY- EVENT AND THEN YOU'RE NO
BETTER OFF THAN YOU WERE UNDER
THE CURRENT SYSTEM SO THAT IS MY
CONCERN AND- I HAVE TO GO
PRESENTED BILL BUT- I'M SORRY.
ON THAT ISSUE I WILL SAY THAT
THEY DO CHARGE YOUR CELLPHONE
THAT. I DON'T KNOW IF THAT WAS A
QUESTION BUT THANK YOU FOR YOUR
COMMENT TO. ANY OTHERS. SENILE
YOU MAY CLOSE MISS COOPER THANK
YOU MISTER SPEAKER- JUST SOUTH
BECAUSE NOT SPEAKER- DON'T START
ANY MISTER CHAIR. HE COULD BE
SPEAKER IF YOU WANT. MISTER
CHAIR- IT'S INTERESTING I LISTEN
TO THE COMMISSION SPEAKERS AND
THE LADY REPRESENT THE PUBLIC
DEFENDER'S SYNCING SHOULD WORRY
ABOUT PUBLIC DOLLARS OVER SAVING
LIVES- YOU KNOW ONE THING TO
TALK ABOUT AS WE KNOW THAT
VOLUNTARILY WE WILL HAVE A LOT
OF PROBABLY. REFUSES TO MEET THE
STIPULATIONS OF THEIR PAROLE ARE
CAN BE LOCATED TO FULFILL
PROGRAMS TO HELP THEM BETTER
THEMSELVES IT IN FOR THE
REHABILITATION THE FACT THEY CAN
BE FOUND OR HELD ACCOUNTABLE.
DENIES THEM THE HELP THEY NEED
TO GET BACK INTO SOCIETY IS IN
FACT PART OF PEARLS
REHABILITATION. AND WITH THE BIG
ISSUES WITH A LOT OF FOLKS
AROUND PRO RIGHT NOW THAT.
AREN'T GOING TO. VIOLENCE
PREVENTION ANGER MANAGEMENT.
DRUG REHAB. ALCOHOL REHAB-
PAIRING ISSUES A BUNCH OF THINGS
AND NOTHING HAPPENS RIGHT NOW
THE LANGUAGE OUT THERE THE
OPPOSITION ADMITS THERE'S A
PROBLEM OF HOMELESSNESS AND PULL
THESE BILLS NOT OF KNOWLEDGE
THAT BALLING THE PAROLE IS A
PROBLEM WITH THAT THIS PROBABLY
SHOULD BE HELD ACCOUNTABLE IN
SACRAMENTO COUNTY RIGHT NOW AS
WE SPEAK THERE TWENTY TWO APRIL
THESE THROUGH THEIR SEVEN YEAR
HOMELESS AND NOT ALL ARE
HOMELESS SUMMER HOMELESS BECAUSE
- THEY SAY THEIR HOMES BECAUSE
THEY DON'T WANT THEIR- RESIDENTS
SEARCH BY LAW ENFORCEMENT SO. W.
DO HAVE SOME THAT ARE TRULY
HOMELESS. NOW THE OPPOSITION
MENTION KATE TO THE SEXUAL
ASSAULT. AND VIOLENT MURDER. FOR
THE NUMEROUS OTHER VICTIMS THAT
KEEP STACKING UP. NO I CONCERN
IS FOR THE PRO LEAGUE VICE
IGNITIONS OF HIS PAROLE. IS IT
LEARNING TO BE RESPONSIBLE AND
ABIDING BY THEIR PAROLE
STIPULATIONS. PART OF
REHABILITATION INTO SOCIETY. I
HAVE TO CONCLUDE THAT THE
OPPOSITION BELIEVE THAT KATE WAS
JUST COLLATERAL DAMAGE. BUT IT'S
MORE IMPORTANT TO ALLOW VIOLENT
COOLEY TO ROAM FREE AND TO NOT
BE THE SIMPLEST CONDITIONS OF
HIS PAROLE. I WANT TO REITERATE
THE GOAL OF EIGHT A. B. EIGHTEEN
TWENTY SEVEN IS PROTECT WOMEN
LIKE KATE FROM VIOLENT SEXUAL
PREDATORS WHO VOLUNTARILY
REFUSED TO SIMPLY COMPLY WITH A
BROKEN DITIONS IRIS PRO HE'S
FULLY COMPLY WITH THE PRO ARE
NOT VICTIMS. K. TIBBETTSIN ME
LIKE HER ARE THE VICTIMS. WHILE
THE FENDERS WE SERVE AT HIGHER
RATE HE NONVIOLENT OFFENDERS.
OVER SIXTY PERCENT. AT SIXTY
THREE POINT 8% OF THE VOTE
OFFENDERS **** BY BEING
REARRESTED. THIS COMPARES TO
LESS THAN FORTY PERCNT. THIRTY
NINE POINT EIGHT PERCENT. OF
NONVIOLENT OFFENDERS WHO REAR
VIEW WHO WERE REARRESTED. THIS
IS FOR THE US SENTENCING
COMMISSION- ONE OF OUR STAFFERS
HERE LOT OF OUR CATHOLIC
COMMUNITY LIVING LAND PARKER THE
SOUTHLAND PARK AREA THIS IS A
TRAGIC INCIDENT. IT KEEPS COMING
UP IN UP AGAIN. ROMPER ALL THESE
PEOPLE ARE BACK LARGELY WANT TO
HELP THEM SUCCEED BUT THE BOTTOM
LINE THE KNOX EXCEEDING IF NOT
GET THE HELP THEY NEED. AND IF
YOU'RE NOT GETTING IT A LOT I
PUT THE BLAME SQUARELY ON CDC
ARE NOT DOING THEIR JOB NOT THE
PRO AGENTS THOSE MEN WOMEN DO A
GREAT JOB DAY IN AND DAY OUT
IT'S A TOUGH JOB. THEIR
CASELOADS OVERWHELMING BUT CVC
ARE ON THEIR POLICIES ON WE WANT
TO HELP THESE FOLKS THE HOMELESS
THE STATE SHOULD HOUSE THEM
BOTTOM LINE SHOULD BE
HOMELESSNESS STREET SPECIAL WITH
THESE FOLKS IT'S A DIFFERENT
TYPE OF THING. WE THROWN OVER
FIFTEEN BILLION DOLLARS A
HOMELESSNESS ALMOST THIS IS
GOTTEN WORSE SO I CAN UP. ALL
PAROLEES WERE TALKING TO
INFINITE NUMBER OF PAROLEES THAT
IS MANAGEABLE THERE'S HALF WE
HOUSING C. R. C. C. C. R. CAN DO
THAT THEY HAVE NOT DONE THAT- SO
IT SOME POINT WE'VE GOT TO
CHANGE THE NARRATIVE WITH THIS-
THOSE. THE SHOOTING SECOND TO
LAST WEEK. CDCR PAROLE. WITH
THEIR FOR VIOLENT CRIME THE
VIOLENCE SO A DEADLY WEAPON SO
KEEP COMING BACK TO THAT SO- AT
SOME POINT WE GOT IS SOMETHING
TO ADDRESS THIS OTHERWISE IT
LANGUISHES AND- I RESPECTFULLY
ASK RIVAL. THANK YOU AND- AND I
THINK OTHER MEMBERS HAVE SAID-
TO THE TIBBETTS FAMILY YOUR YOUR
YOUR STORIES TOUCHES ALL- IT IS
A TRAGIC INCIDENT OCCURRED WITH
WITHOUT A DOUBT AND NO ONE-
POLICY COMMITTEE FOR NO ONE- IS
LEGISLATURE WORLD. WE'LL SAY
ANYTHING DIFFERENT- AND WE OF
COURSE GRIEVE WITH YOU AND
THERE'S PROBABLY NOTHING WE CAN
SAY- THAT CAN TRULY HELP- THERE
WAS A FAILURE. OF COMMUNICATIONS
BETWEEN LAW ENFORCEMENT AGENCIES
WITHOUT A DOUBT- NOT NECESSARILY
A FAILURE TO PAROLE
CLASSIFICATION BUT DEFINITELY-
THE COMMUNICATIONS TO ENSURE THE
CDC ART DID THEIR JOB TO ENSURE.
THAT THESE TRAGEDIES DON'T
HAPPEN. DID NOT HAPPEN AND- WE
AND WHEN I SAY WE THE STATE WE
BECAUSE WE ARE CDC ARE NEED TO
HELP CDC ARE DO A MUCH BETTER
JOB ENSURING THAT THE PUBLIC.
THAT THE PUBLIC IS NOT IN
DANGER- AS THEY MAKE THESE
DECISIONS DESERT AS AS MY STEAM
COPLEY FROM ELK GROVE HAS SAID
THESE ARE TOUGH DECISIONS THAT
WE PLACED ON TTC ART TO MAKE BUT
WE ALSO- HOPEFUL- AND
UNFORTUNATELY IT'S PRESENTED OF
FEAR IN THIS COMMUNITY THAT
THEY'RE NOT DOING AN ADEQUATE
JOB WHICH NOW. HAS PLACED A FEAR
OF PEOPLE BEING ALLOWED OUT ON
THE STREET WHICH IS EXACERBATING
THE CRIME PROBLEM AND SO I
BELIEVE WE NEED TO WORK
VIGOROUSLY. HELLO ALL OF US
TOGETHER TO ENSURE THAT NO ONE
GETS LEFT OUT- WORKER RECREATE
THIS TRAGEDY BUT MOST IMPORTANT.
THAT WE HAVE A SYSTEM THAT IF
SOMEONE IS EVEN. REMOTELY NOT
ABIDING BY THE PAROLE
OBLIGATIONS WE IMMEDIATELY TAKE
CARE WE DON'T LET IT LANGUISH WE
DON'T FINGER POINT- AND I'M NOT
TRYING TO FINGER POINT BETWEEN
ONE AGENCY D. OTHER I JUST WANT
TO. FIX IT. JUST FIX IT SO THIS
NEVER HAPPENS AGAIN-
UNFORTUNATELY I DON'T THINK THIS
IS THE SOLUTION. BUT I'M GLAD
YOU BROUGHT IT FORWARD BECAUSE
WE HAVE TO FIND A SOLUTION-
RESTORES OUR COLLEAGUE FROM ELK
GROVE HAS SAID THAT WE NEED TO
DO SOMETHING. AND UNFORTUNATELY
THIS IS THIS IS THE WAY. BUT WE
NEED TO CONTINUE TO FIND A WAY
TO MAKE SURE THIS NEVER HAPPENS
AGAIN. THE BILL. SECOND WAS BEEN
MOVED IMPROPERLY SECOND MAY CALL
THE ROLL. I'M AB HIT ME ON AB
EIGHTEEN TWENTY SEVEN BY SEVEN
MEMBER COOPER THE MOTION IS TO
PASS TO THE APPROPRIATIONS
COMMITTEE JONES SAWYER FORTUNATE
ENOUGH JONES SAWYER NO LACKEY
COURSE YES LACKEY I BONTA.
FONTANELLE BRIAN BRIAN NO CORK
SANTIAGO SEYARTO YEAH THEY ARE
TELL I. UNFORTUNATE MEASURE
FAILS THANK YOU OKAY THANK YOU
MISTER COOPER THANK YOU FAMILY
AND WITNESSES. MISTER GIBSON.
WHEN EVER YOU'RE READY MISTER
GIBSON THANK YOU VERY MUCH MR
CHAIRMAN AND MEMBERS. THANK YOU
FOR ALLOWING ME TO PRESENT.
ASSEMBLY BILL SIXTEEN AWAY WITH
SIX TO SEPARATE THE CORONER'S
OFFICE FROM SHERIFF DEPARTMENT.
IN COUNTIES ACROSS THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA. CALIFORNIA IS
CURRENTLY ONE OF ONLY THREE
STATES THAT STILL ALLOW COUNTIES
TO COMBINE THE OFFICE OF THE
CORNER AND THIS YEAR. FOR YEARS
WE HAVE WITNESSES WE HAVE WE
HAVE WITNESSES FAR WITNESS FAR
TOO MANY TRAGEDIES AND PATTERNS
OF INCONSISTENCIES BETWEEN THE
SHERIFF'S. ARE ALLOWING TO
OVERSEE. THE CAUSE OF DEATH
RULING. THIS HAS RESULTED IN
BIAS MEDICAL INVESTIGATIONS TIME
AND TIME AGAIN. A. B. SIXTEEN OH
EIGHT WE'LL PUT CALIFORNIA IN
LINE WITH THE REST OF THE STATES
THAT HAVE ALREADY ADVANCED A
SIMILAR PIECE OF LEGISLATION
LIKE ASSEMBLY BILL SIXTEEN OH
EIGHT CALLOW IN CALIFORNIA TEN
COUNTIES. ARE ALREADY DOING WHAT
ASSEMBLY BILL SIXTEEN OH EIGHT
SEEKS TO ACCOMPLISH I AM PROUD
TO SAY. THAT THE- THAT LOS
ANGELES AND SAN FRANCISCO
COUNTIES. ARE PROUD SUPPORTERS
OF THIS PIECE OF LEGISLATION.
BOTH OF THESE COUNTIES ALSO HAVE
SUCCESSFUL INDEPENDENT FUNCTIONS
CURRENT LAW CURRENT STATE LAW
DOES NOT REQUIRE NO ONE
UNDERSCORE DOES NOT REQUIRE A
SHERIFF TO HAVE ANY MEDICAL
BACKGROUND. OR CERTIFICATION TO
ASSUME THE DUTIES AND
RESPONSIBILITY OF A CORNER. AS A
RESULT IT HAS CAUSED MANY TO
QUESTION WHETHER AND MEDICAL
DIAGNOSIS IS BALLOT NGUYEN THERE
IS ALL OFFICER INVOLVED DEATH.
IN DECEMBER OF LAST YEAR ANGELO
CANTLE. THE UNITED STATES NAVY
VETERAN NORTHERN CALIFORNIA WAS
TRAGICALLY KILLED. BY POLICE.
ANGELO KATO'S CASE EIGHT MONTHS
AFTER THE DEATH THE CARD R.
COSTA COUNTY CORONER'S OFFICE
ISSUED A REPORT B. FOR THE
AUTOPSY. BEFORE THE AUTOPSY. AND
RULED THAT THE DEATH OF AN ACT
OF DEATH AND ACCIDENTS AND
LISTED THE CAUSE OF DEATH AS
EXCITED DELIRIUM. I WANT YOU TO
PONDER ON THAT FOR A MOMENT WHAT
DOES EXCITED DELIRIUM ACTUALLY
MEANS. THE TERM EXCITED DELIRIUM
HAS BEEN REJECTED. I SAID
REJECTED BY THE AMERICAN MEDICAL
ASSOCIATION THE WORLD HEALTH
ORGANIZATION AND THE AMERICAN
PSYCHIATRIC ASSOCIATION THIS
TERM HAS BEEN REJECTED BY
MEDICAL COMMUNITIES YET IT IS
STILL USED BY LAW ENFORCEMENT TO
EXPLAIN CERTAIN DEATHS OCCURRED
. IN POLICE CUSTODY THE SAN
JOAQUIN COUNTY IT TOOK A VERY
PUBLIC EMBARRASSING RESIGNATION
FROM THE CHIEF MEDICAL EXAMINER
AND OTHER MEDICAL EXAMINERS ON
STAFF OF FOR THAT- THAT
PARTICULAR COUNTY. OVER NINE
MONTHS OVER NINE MONTHS PERIOD
THE CHEAPEST MEDICAL EXAMINERS
DOCUMENTS CALCULUS EXAMPLES OF
AUTOPSIES THEY PERFORMED THIS
DOCUMENTATION INCLUDES.
INSTANCES WHERE THE SHERIFF
CHANGED THE CALLS OF DEATH
BINDINGS. ACCORDING TO THE
DOCUMENTATION IN SOME CASES THEY
FELT PRESSURED BY THIS YEAR TO
REPORT SOMETHING DIFFERENT IN
ORANGE COUNTY CHRISTOPHER
EISINGER DIED AFTER BEING TAKEN
OFF LIFE SUPPORT EIGHT DAYS
AFTER BEING TRANSPORTED BY
AMBULANCE TO THE HOSPITAL SIX
PEOPLE ATTENDED THE AUTOPSY
INCLUDING FOR MEMBERS OF THE
SHERIFF'S DEPARTMENT AND TWO
OFFICERS FROM THE SENATE FROM.
ANAHEIM POLICE DEPARTMENT THE
PATH OLOGY THIS CONCLUDES THAT
THE CAUSE OF DEATH WAS SUDDEN
CARDIAC ARREST. THREE YEARS
AFTER HIS DEATH A JURY FOUND THE
OFFICERS WERE NEGLIGENT. AND
LARGELY RESPONSIBLE FOR
CHRISTOPHER'S DEATH AND AWARDED
THE FAMILY ONE POINT EIGHT
MILLION DOLLARS IN DAMAGES. KERN
COUNTY DAVID SILVA DIED FROM A
OF A- POSITIONAL TO CONFUSE ME-
A FIX THE- DURING AN ENCOUNTER
WHEN SEVERAL KERN COUNTY
SHERIFF'S DEPUTIES AND TWO HIGH
PATROL OFFICERS THE KERN COUNTY-
CORNERS DECLARED THE DEATH
ACCIDENTAL AND HEART DISEASE
RELATED. THE PROSECUTOR THE
PROSECUTION DID NOT FILE
CRIMINAL CHARGES AGAINST KERN
COUNTY SHERIFF'S DEPUTIES OR
CALIFORNIA HIGH PATROL YET
CALIFORNIA'S CURRENT COUNTY
ENDED UP SETTLING A THREE POINT
FOUR MILLION DOLLAR CIVIL
LAWSUIT. THESE ARE ONLY A FEW
EXAMPLES WHERE COUNTIES HAVE
SPENT LARGE SUMS OF MONEY TO
SETTLE. POSSIBILITY TO QUESTION
WHAT DOES NOT MAKE SENSE AND
THIS DOES NOT MAKE SENSE.
JOINING ME TO PROVIDE SUPPORTING
TESTIMONY IN SUPPORT OF SIXTEEN
OH EIGHT IS THE CHIEF MEDICAL
EXAMINER OF- EXAMINE OFFICER
FROM WASHINGTON DC WHO ALSO
CONDUCTED THE TWO THOUSAND
EIGHTEEN AUDIT OF THE SAN
JOAQUIN COUNTY. IN ADDITION- WE
ALSO HAVE JOINING ME US IN
PERSON IS- CENTER KETO COLLINS
THE MOTHER AND JOKING SO BELLA-
CANTIL SISTER UP AND LOOKING TO
AND ROBERT COLLINS THE
STEPFATHER OF ANGELO KING TO.
THANK YOU HAVE FIVE MINUTES TWO
MINUTES APIECE OR WHATEVER WE
ONLY MOVED TO THE TO THE DOCTOR
DOCTOR MITCHELL. OKAY HE'S ON
THE LINE OKAY A FIVE MINUTES ALL
TOGETHER SO OKAY THE DOCTOR
MITCHELL MET TO TAKE UP TOO MUCH
TIME- IT IS LOOK OKAY. GO AHEAD
. IS IT. IS ONLINE OKAY EIGHTEEN
T. OPERATOR OPEN UP LIKE A
DOCTOR MITCHELL.
AT&T OPERATOR. THE WORD EIGHTY
NINE HE HAS I DO NOT SEE A NAME
LISTED IF HE COULD PLEASE PRESS
ZERO THEN ONE TO TAG KIDS LINE.
OKAY WHILE THE FIND A DOCTOR
MITCHELL WE CAN GO TO AND DOES
MOM CENTER CAN TELL SURE. GOOD
MORNING WHENEVER YOU'RE READY.
GOOD MORNING MY NAME I COUNTY
PULLED THE MIKE A LITTLE CLOSER. GOOD MORNING MY NAME IS
CASSANDRA KING TO COLLINS THIS
IS BELLA AND ROBERT. WE ARE THE
FAMILY OF FANS ARE LOOKING. MY
SON ANGELES KILLED IN DECEMBER
OF TWENTY TWENTY BY ANTIOCH
POLICE OFFICERS. IN FRONT OF ME
ON MY BEDROOM FOR. HE WAS
EXPERIENCING A MENTAL HEALTH
CRISIS THAT MIGHT. BUT HE WAS
NOT VIOLENT. DID NOT HAVE ANY
WEAPONS AND WAS NOT UNDER THE
INFLUENCE OF ANY. COMMON
SUBSTANCES OF ABUSE. DESPITE THE
OFFICERS ACKNOWLEDGING ALL OF
THESE THE PLACE THE MONEY
STOMACH WUNDERGROUND HANDCUFFED
HIM PUSHED HIS CROSSED LEGS.
AGAINST HIS BACK AND BEYOND THE
BACK BUSINESS. I REMEMBER DEEP
THEM STAYING. SOMETHING LIKE
THIS IS WHAT WE DO TO CALM THEM
DOWN. DURING AT LEAST FOUR AND A
HALF MINUTES OF THIS RESTRAINT
HE WAS COMPLETELY. UNRESPONSIVE. THANK YOU I. SO AFTER HIS
DEATH WE EXPERIENCED A LOT OF
DECEIT FROM LAW ENFORCEMENT AND-
WHEN WE FIRST MET ARE LAWYERS
THEY TOLD US THAT HIS DEATH
WOULD BE BLAMED ON EXCITED
DELIRIUM DESPITE WHAT EVIDENCE
WAS COLLECTED EARLY ON- AND SO
WE GOT A PRIVATE PATHOLOGIST TO
DO OUR- EXAMINATION. BECAUSE WE
DO NOT TRUST THAT THERE WOULD BE
AN UNBIASED INVESTIGATION AND-
AUTOPSY AND ACTIVITY CORONER'S
INQUEST WHICH DETERMINES IN ALL
MANNER OF DEATH FOR AN
INDIVIDUAL- WE WITNESSED FIRST
HAND THE DECEIT AND- THE. THE
LACK OF TRANSPARENCY THAT GOES
ON BETWEEN THE SHERIFF'S AND
CORONER'S IN THIS INESTIGATION
THAT IS SUPPOSED TO BE
INDEPENDENT- THEY DID NOT NAME
WITNESSES THEY WITHHELD EVIDENCE
THEY LEAD WITNESSES THAT THEY
DID NAME- TO CERTAIN CONCLUSIONS
THAT THEY HAD ALL CREATED
TOGETHER. AND THEY COMPLETELY-
NICK NORD MEDICAL RECORDS- THANK
YOU SO THANK YOU FOR ALLOWING US
TO SPEAK WITH YOU TODAY THIS
MORNING S. N. MEMBERS WHAT WE'RE
ASKING FOR AN AB SIXTY NO EIGHT
IS A COMMONSENSE REFORMS THAT
INCREASES TRANSPARENCY
ACCOUNTABILITY- AND OBJECTIVITY
IN THE PROCESS OF DETERMINING A
DEATH. THAT IS QUESTIONABLE.
THAT IS A PROCESS THAT SHOULD BE
DETERMINED BY A MEDICAL
PROFESSIONAL AND NOT AN ELECTED
OFFICIAL THAT HAS NO MEDICAL
TRAINING. THIS IS REALLY
IMPORTANT AT A TIME WHEN WE- WE
CERTAINLY HAD QUESTIONS AS SOON
AS OUR LAWYER TOLD US THAT WE
SHOULD GET AN INDEPENDENT
PATHOLOGIST. BUT I THINK IN THIS
SOCIETY IN GENERAL YOU'RE SEEING
THAT EVERYONE WANTS AN
INDEPENDENT PATHOLOGIST BECAUSE
THERE'S NO TRUST IN CALIFORNIA.
A. N. INTO THAT SEPARATION IN
THAT OBJECTIVITY BECAUSE THE
SHERIFF OVERSEAS IN FORTY EIGHT
COUNTIES. WHAT THE OP WHAT THE
CORNER CONFINED AND SO THIS IS
REALLY A COMMONSENSE REFORM WHAT
WE'RE ASKING FOR IS SOMETHING
THAT INCREASES ACCOUNTABILITY
TRANSPARENCY AND OBJECTIVITY
AND- AND IT'S A GOOD GOVERNMENT
INITIATIVE IT BASICALLY SAYS WE
CAN TRUST THE GOVERNMENT BECAUSE
THE- YOU KNOW LAW ENFORCEMENT
DOES NOT. SHOULD NOT INVESTIGATE
ITSELF WHEN THERE'S SOMETHING AT
ISSUE SO WHAT WE'RE ASKING FOR
IS REALLY I THINK I COMMONSENSE
REFORM IT JUST TAKES OUT WHO IS
THE TOP PERSON THAT'S MAKING
THAT DETERMINATION. AND IN
INSTEAD IT IT JUST MEANS THAT
SOMEBODY WOULD AS SCIENTIFIC
TRAINING AND THAT OF A
PATHOLOGIST THE DOCTOR IS GOING
TO MAKE THAT ULTIMATE
DETERMINATION AND NOT BE
OVERRIDDEN BY A SHERIFF. THANK
YOU SO MUCH. THANK YOU- AT&T
OPERATOR REVILLA PINE THAT COULD
DOCTOR. I AM SORRY NOW- THE BILL
. SECOND THANK YOU HE WAS ON THE
LINE HE WASN'T ABLE TO GET AND
FOR SOME REASON THEY'RE NOT
ALLOWING ARDOCH IMAGE WILL WILL
GO TO ROOM FOR ANY WITNESSES IN
SUPPORT. GOOD MORNING TURN
MEMBERS CAITLIN DEAN ACLU
CALIFORNIA ACTION PROUD CO
SPONSOR OF THE BILL THANK YOU
SIR THANK YOU. MARCO GEORGE FOR
CALIFORNIA PUBLIC DEFENDERS
ASSOCIATION IN SUPPORT THANK YOU
THANK YOU. THE KAMARCK- BRITNEY
BAR SIDE FOR THE CALIFORNIA NEWS
PUBLISHERS IN STRONG SUPPORT
THANK YOU. KATRINA BAPTISTE
RESIDENT OF ALAMEDA COUNTY HERE
IN SUPPORT OF AB SIXTEEN ZERO
EIGHT THANK YOU. APRIL GRAYSON
YOUNG MUSLIM CENTRE IN STRONG
SUPPORT F AB SIXTEEN AWAY THANK
YOU. GOOD MORNING GOING BACK AS
THE ELLA BAKER CENTER FOR HUMAN
RIGHTS IN SUPPORT. THANK YOU. WE
WILL GO TO IT OPPOSITION BUT IF
DR- MITCHELL DOES COME THROUGH
WILL LEAD A MAN SO THAT ANY
WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION. COULD
THE GIFT OF THEM YES THANK YOU I
THANK YOU FOR YOUR TESTIMONY.
GOOD MORNING MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS
WHO SHALL MATURE ON BEHALF OF
THE CALIFORNIA STATE SHERIFFS
ASSOCIATION ON BEHALF OF THAT I.
CALIFORNIA STATE CORONERS
ASSOCIATION RESPECTFULLY IN
OPPOSITION TO SIXTEEN OH EIGHT-
THE CURRENT SHERIFF CORNER
APPROACHUTILIZED BY CHOICE- BY
A VAST MAJORITY OF CALIFORNIA-
COUNTIES. ENJOYS THE BENEFIT OF
OPERATIONAL AND BUDGETARY
EFFICIENCY- SEPARATING THIS
OFFICES WILL REMOVE
INVESTIGATIVE EFFICIENCIES AND
DRASTICALLY INCREASE COUNTY
COSTS. UNNECESSARILY BY
REQUIRING FORTY EIGHT COUNTIES
TO STAND UP SEPARATE CORNER
OFFICES. ARE FROM A GOVERNANCE
PERSPECTIVE THIS BILL IS HEAVY
HANDED AND DISREGARDS LOCAL
CONTROL. EXISTING LAW ALREADY
PERMITS COUNTIES TO PURSUE
MULTIPLE MODELS OF COUNTY OFFICE
CONSOLIDATION OR SEPARATION HI
THIS IS A DECISION BEST LEFT TO
THIS SOUND DISCRETION OF LOCAL
OFFICIALS WHO HAVE BUDGET
AUTHORITY AND RELEVANT LOCAL
EXPERIENCE. AT THIS BILL
INCLUDES NO FUNDING FOR COUNTIES
TO SEPARATE THE OFFICES OF
CORNER AND SHERIFF THAT DEMANDS
THAT IT BE DONE WITHOUT REGARD
TO THE MASSIVE COST THIS WILL
CREATE. EVEN IF FUNDING WERE
PROVIDED THIS BILL DISREGARDS
LOCAL CONTROL AND A DECISION
MADE OVER BY THE YEARS BY PAT BY
VAST MAJORITY OF STATES
COUNTIES. COUNTIES HAVE ADOPTED
PROCEDURES TO ADDRESS PERCEIVED
CONFLICTS WITH HOW DEATH
INVESTIGATIONS ARE UNDERTAKEN.
IN ORDER TO APPARENTLY FURTHER
ENGAGING IN THIS IRINA WE
BELIEVE AB SIXTY NO EIGHT
IMPOSES THEIR- WE INCENTIVE
SEISMIC SHIFT IN HOW LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS CHOOSE TO ORGANIZE
YOUR FUNCTIONS AND FOR THESE
REASONS WE RESPECTFULLY OPPOSE
THANK YOU. THANK YOU. IN THE WE
HAVE DOCTOR MITCHELL ON THE
LINE- GREAT DR MITCHELL WHEN
EVERY YEAR READY TO BEGIN. YOU
HAVE A COUPLE MINUTES CAN YOU
HEAR ME IT. CAN YOU HEAR ME OK
YES WE CAN. OKAY ARE NOT GOING
TO TAKE MUCH OF YOUR TIME
CHAIRMAN AND MEMBERS OF PUBLIC
SAFETY AGAIN I'M DOCTOR ROGER
MITCHELL I'VE SERVED AS A
FORENSIC PATHOLOGIST SINCE TWO
THOUSAND AND SEVEN. ASSISTANT
DEPUTY CHIEF IN HOUSTON
ASSISTANT MEDICAL STATE OUR
STATE MEDICAL EXAMINER IN CHARGE
IN NEW JERSEY I SPENT THE TWENTY
FOURTEEN TO TWENTY TWENTY ONE AS
THE CHIEF MEDICAL EXAMINER OF
WASHINGTON DC- IN THE ONLY
FORENSIC PATHOLOGIST TO SERVE AS
THE DEPUTY MAYOR OF WASHINGTON
DC AND PUBLIC SAFETY. OVER TWO
THOUSAND AUTOPSIES IN MY CAREER
AND YOU HEARD THAT I WAS PART OF
THE TRANSITION FROM THE SAN
JOAQUIN SHERIFF'S CORONER'S
OFFICE TO A MEDICAL EXAMINER
SYSTEM. THIS BILL GOES A LONG
WAY TO INSTILLING PUBLIC
CONFIDENCE IN DEPTH
INVESTIGATION PARTICULARLY THOSE
DEATHS THAT OCCUR IN CONNECTION
WITH THE CRIMINAL LEGAL SYSTEM.
ONLY THAT BUT PROPERLY STAFFED
AND TRAINED MEDICAL LEGAL DEATH
INVESTIGATION SYSTEM FOR
CALIFORNIANS. THAT ALLOW THEM TO
RELY ON NOT JUST FOR DEATHS IN
CUSTODY BUT FOR SUDDEN
UNEXPECTED NATURAL DEATHS DEATHS
OF MOMS WHO DIE DURING
CHILDBIRTH DOMESTIC VIOLENCE
CHILD ABUSE DEATHS DUE TO COLD
BIT AND EVEN IN THE RECENT
HISTORY MASS FATALITY EVENTS. IN
TWO THOUSAND AND NINE THE
NATIONAL ACADEMIES OF SCIENCE
HAVE CALLED FOR THE
STRENGTHENING OF THE MEDICAL
LEGAL DEATH INVESTIGATION.
SYSTEM NATIONWIDE. BY REMOVE THE
SHOW CORONER SYSTEM. NOW LET ME
BE CLEAR BOTH CALLED AND MANNER
OF DEATH SHOULD BE CONSIDERED
THE PRACTICE OF MEDICINE AT THE
OFFICIAL RECORD OF DEATH IS THE
DEATH CERTIFICATE WHICH IS USED
AS A PUBLIC HEALTH MODEL. THIS
DOESN'T SHOW A DISTRICT SUPPORT
FOR SHERIFF'S BUT ACTUALLY
SUPPORT SHERIFF'S BY SEPARATING
THIS RESPONSIBILITY BECAUSE OF
THE LACK OF QUALIFICATIONS THAT
A SHERIFF HAS IN ESTABLISHING
MANNER OF DEATH- THIS IS AN
ATTEMPT TO IMPROVE THIS SYSTEM
IN THIS IS HAPPENED. SINCE THE
COLONIAL INVASION OF THIS
COUNTRY AS WELL AS SINCE THE
INCEPTION OF THE MEDICAL LEGAL
DEATH INVESTIGATION SYSTEM AB
SIXTEEN OH EIGHT WITH A SMALL
BUT NECESSARY STEP. TOWARDS
GIVING CLOSURE TO FAMILIES THANK
CREATING A RELIABLE RECOUP
REPRODUCIBLE TIMELY AND ACCURATE
DEATH INVESTIGATION SYSTEM I'M
PROUD OF THIS AUSPICIOUS BODY
FOR YOUR WILLINGNESS TO MAKE
THIS CHANGE AND HOW CALIFORNIA
CONTINUE TO BE THE LEADER. THAT
IT IS PLEASE SEPARATE THE
SHERIFF'S AND CORONER'S OFFICES
AND I'M HERE FOR ANY QUESTIONS
THAT YOU MAY HAVE. THANK YOU
WILL NOW GO TO WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION THEY WERE IN A ROW.
WHEN MR MEMBERS RYAN SHERMAN
WITH THE RIVERSIDE SHERIFF'S
ASSOCIATION AND STRONG BUT
RESPECTFUL OPPOSITION TO THE
BILL THANK YOU THANK YOU- I
BELIEVE WE HAD SOME PEOPLE THAT
WERE SUPPORT THAT DID GET A
CHANCE TO SPEAK SO YOU MAY HAVE
. NAME AN ORGANIZATION. GIVE ME
GOOD MORNING CHAIRMAN EMBERS-
DARCHINYAN BIRD ON BEHALF OF THE
AMERICAN FEDERATION FOR STATE
COUNTY AND MUNICIPAL EMPLOYEES-
IN BEHALF I'M SORRY- IN STRONG
SUPPORT OF SIX EIGHTY SIX YOU
KNOW IT. THANK YOU THANK. GOOD
AFTERNOON THANK YOU- GOOD
MORNING THANK YOU CHAIR
COMMITTEE MEMBERS AND STAFF RUN
MORE MUNY ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA STATE ASSOCIATION OF
COUNTIES. AND RESPECTFUL
OPPOSITION AB SIXTY NO EIGHT AS
IT REMOVES EXISTING LOCAL
AUTHORITY OF OUR COUNTY BOARD OF
SUPERVISORS. AND WOULD IMPOSE
SIGNIFICANT COST INCREASES
SHOULD THE FORTY EIGHT OF THE
FIFTY EIGHT COUNTIES BE REQUIRED
TO SEPARATE THE SHARP CORNER
OFFICES THANK YOU. THANK YOU.
ALSO STRUGGLING SUPPORT JACKIE
GONZALEZ IMMIGRANT DEFENSE
ADVOCATES- IN STRONG SUPPORT
THANK YOU. THANK YOU. I HEARD
NOW WILL BRING IT BACK TO
COMMITTEE MEMBERS MR BY. I THE
ONLY THING THE OPPOSITION ON THE
PHONE I'M SORRY I THINK I MISSED
OPPOSITION ON THE PHONE. AT&T
OPERATOR OPEN UP LINE OPPOSITION
ON THE PHONE. THANK YOU FOR IT
TO SPEAK IN OPPOSITION OF THIS
BILL PLEASE PRESS ONE THEN ZERO.
AND FIRST WE HAVE LINE NUMBER
EIGHTY FIVE. YES GO AHEAD. HI
THANK YOU FOR THE FOR THE SPORT
- BUT I DON'T KNOW THAT IT
DIVERT ALL. OKAY NAME
ORGANIZATIONS SUPPORT GO AHEAD
WOULD DO BOTH- I LIKE YOU'VE GOT
ROAD DIRECTOR GOVERNMENT AFFAIRS
FOR THE CALIFORNIA IMMIGRANT
POLICY CENTER IN STRONG SUPPORT.
OKAY NEXT WE HAVE MY NUMBER
SEVENTY ONE PLEASE GO AHEAD.
NINE SEVENTY ONE YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. THANKS WE HAVE LINE NUMBER
FIFTY SEVEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
HELLO I'M ALSO CALLING IN
SUPPORT- JOHNSON GO- NATIONAL
ASSOCIATION OF SOCIAL WORKERS
CALIFORNIA CHAPTER IN STRONG
SUPPORT OF AB SIXTEEN OH EIGHT.
OKAY ANYONE THAT HAS A COMMON
HANDLER AGAINST MINE BECAUSE- A.
B. DO YOU KNOW A- THANKS NINE
NUMBER TWENTY SIX PLEASE GO
AHEAD. GOOD MORNING MY NAME IS
MARK CURTIS I'M HERE ON BEHALF
OF THE CONFERENCE CALIFORNIA BAR
ASSOCIATIONS WE- TOOK UP THIS
ISSUE FOUR YEARS AGO IN TWENTY
EIGHTEEN AND WE THOUGHT THIS WAS
AN EXCELLENT IDEA THEN AND WE
CONTINUE TO HOLD FOR IT. WE ARE
IN STRONG SUPPORT THE STOCK NO
RECORD HAS CALLED DIFFICULT
STANDARD WE HAVE A THANK THANK
YOU NEXT WE HAVE PLAN NUMBER ONE
SIXTEEN. PLEASE GO AHEAD. BRIAN
HOPE FOR ON BEHALF OF CO
SPONSORS SECURE JUSTICE HERE IN
SUPPORT ADDITIONAL SUPPORT FROM
INDIVISIBLE SACRAMENTO
CALIFORNIA COALITION FOR WOMEN
PRISONERS. CONFERENCE OF
CALIFORNIA BAR ASSOCIATION'S
AMERICAN FRIENDS SERVICE
COMMITTEE LEGAL SERVICES FOR
PRISONERS WITH CHILDREN ALL OF
US HERE NINE INITIATE JUSTICE
CALIFORNIA IMMIGRANT POLICY
CENTER SHAKEN. THE STATE SPEND
THE ARCTIC AREA HUMAN IMPACT
PARTNERS INTERFAITH MOVEMENT FOR
HUMAN INTEGRITY NEXTGEN
CALIFORNIA ALLIANCE SAN DIEGO
WELLSTONE DEMOCRATIC RENEWAL
CLUB CALIFORNIANS FOR SAFETY AND
JUSTICE. THANK YOU THANK YOU.
HEY MAX NINE ONE HALF EIGHTEEN
THAT'S ONE ONE EIGHT PLEASE GO
AHEAD. HI DENNIS GROSS AMERO
CROWD CO SPONSOR WITH THE
CALIFORNIA MEDICAL ASSOCIATION
AND STRONG SUPPORTER. FIXING
THEIR- THANK YOU. MAX NINE ONE
ZERO NINE PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD
MORNING DONNA THANKS FOR
PRESENTING A LOS ANGELES COUNTY
BOARD OF SUPERVISORS IN SUPPORT
OF AB SIXTEEN OH EIGHT THANK YOU. NEXT HEADLINE SEVENTY TWO
PLEASE GO AHEAD. THIRTY CALL ON
BEHALF OF THE RURAL COUNTY
REPRESENTATIVES OF CALIFORNIA
AND RESPECTFUL OPPOSITION AND
WHAT MADE IT A WITH THE MINUTE
OUR AMENDMENT TO THE COMMITTEE
AND AUTHOR WE LOOK FORWARD TO
CONTINUED CONVERSATION THANK
YOU. THANK YOU. THANKS NINE ONE
ZERO TWO PLEASE GO AHEAD. WE
SHARE MEMBERS READY PERRY WITH
RESPECT ON BEHALF OF POOR ATKINS
IN OPPOSITION. THANK YOU. THANKS
NINE ONE TWO FIVE PLEASE GO
AHEAD. HELLO MY NAME IS VERONICA
BENJAMIN WHAT COUNTRY CONTRA
COSTA AS WELL AS A MEMBER OF THE
REIMAGINE PUBLIC SAFETY CONTRA
COSTA GROUP AND I'M CALLING IN
STRONG SUPPORT OF AB SIXTY NO IT
. THANK YOU. XF NINE ONE TWENTY
NINE PLEASE GO AHEAD. KATHY
LEONARD I'M CALLING ON BEHALF OF
THE COALITION FOR POLICE
ACCOUNTABILITY IN OAKLAND
NEIGHBORS FOR EQUITY IN OAKLAND
CALIFORNIA I'M CALLING IN TO
SUPPORT TO EXPRESS MY SUPPORT
FOR A BI TWO FIVE FIVE SEVEN WE
NEED ACCOUNTABILITY I TO
SHERIFF'S OFFICE. THANK YOU SO
MUCH. ALL RIGHT. WE ARE ON A. B.
SIXTEEN ZERO EIGHT NEXT WE HAVE
LINE SIXTY ONE PLEASE GO AHEAD.
THE MORNING AND ONLY THREE WITH
THE STORAGE WE DON'T COALITION
IN SUPPORT OF AB SIXTY NINE IF
YOU KNOW IT. NEXT HEADLINE ONE
HUNDRED PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI JADI
WITH OAKLAND PRIVACY IN SUPPORT
OF AB SIXTEEN OH EIGHT. AND LINE
ONE HUNDRED TWENTY PLEASE GO
AHEAD. GOOD MORNING JEWELERS
CHRISTIAN REPRESENTING THE
SALMON SALMON THE COMMISSION'S
DEPARTMENT IN OPPOSITION OF AB
SIXTY NO WAY. NEXT HEADLINE ONE
SEVENTEEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. KERN
MEMBERS BARBARA COMBAT FOR THE
CALIFORNIA PSYCHOLOGIST IN
SUPPORT OF THE SIXTEEN OH EIGHT
THANK YOU. NINE NINETY SEVEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. LOCAL BOBBY X.
OUR FOUNDER OF CALIFORNIA UNITED
SUGGESTED UNCLE OF OSCAR GRANT-
WE ARE CLOSE FOR TO THIS BILL
AND WE SPENT A STRONG SUPPORT OF
AB. SIXTY EIGHT. SH ANNEX HAVE
LINE SEVENTY EIGHT PLEASE GO
AHEAD. IT. I'M SEVENTY EIGHT
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. HELLO HELLO.
HELLO YES THIS IS MY LIFE. OKAY. WELL YES MY NAME IS HENRY FROM
WITH ALL OF US IN STRONG SUPPORT
SACRAMENTO. ANNEX ONE NINETY SIX
PLEASE GO AHEAD. I NINETY SIX
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. WE HAVE ONE
MORE LINE WITH THE OPERATOR ONE
MOMENT. WE HAVE LINE. NUMBER ONE
THIRTY THREE PLEASE GO AHEAD.
YEAH BERMAN WAS LAMAR GLEN I'M
CALLING ON BEHALF OF THE LEGAL
SERVICES FOR CALIFORNIANS FOR
SAFETY AND JUSTICE- TIME DONE IN
SUPPORT OF US SENATE BILL ELEVEN
SEVENTY EIGHT THANK YOU. RIGHT.
AND I HAVE NO ONE ELSE THANK YOU
OKAY THANK YOU- WE NOW BRING IT
BACK TO COMMITTEE MEMBERS ANY
QUESTIONS COMMENTS. WITH BY A
THIRD MISTER BRYANT FOR.
MCCULLOUGH I JUST WANT TO THANK
THE AUTHOR FOR BRINGING THIS
BILL- YOU MENTIONED AND LOOKING
TO- AND THAT'S AN INCREDIBLY
IMPORTANT CASE- WHEN YOU HAVE
OFFICER INVOLVED SHOOTINGS WERE
IN CUSTODY DEATHS- THERE'S AN
INHERENT CONFLICT BETWEEN THE
SHERIFF. WHO OFFICE PARTICIPATED
IN THE TRAGIC OUTCOME ALSO THAN
INVESTIGATING THE CORONER'S
OFFICE I ALSO THINK OF JOHN
HORTON. WHOSE DEATH WAS RULED. A
SUICIDE ONE BECAUSE YOU KNOW
THEY COUNTY JAIL ONLY TO THEN BE
OVERTURNED AFTER BEING
INDEPENDENTLY INVESTIGATE I
THINK OF ANDREAS WE DATO. IN LOS
ANGELES AS WELL. WHICH IS WHY I
BELIEVE THE LOS ANGELES COUNTY
BOARD OF SUPERVISORS IN SUPPORT
OF THIS BILL WE'VE SEEN. THAT
THIS IS A PROBLEM AND IT'S A
PROBLEM THAT NEEDS TO BE
REMEDIED AND I. APPRECIATE YOU
BRINGING THAT REMEDY IF YOU ARE
IN NEED OF CO AUTHORS I'M HAPPY
TO JOIN YOU. THANK YOU. REALLY
NOTED. DESPITE THE THANK YOU
MISTER GIBSON FOR BRINGING THIS
BILL FORWARD AS WELL AND I WOULD
LIKE TO BE CONSIDERED AS A CO
AUTHOR AS WELL I JUST WANTED TO
PARTICULARLY THANK THE KEY TO
FAMILY ANGELA KEEP OF STANLEY
FOR BEING HERE- THEY ARE A PART
OF A TRIBE THAT THEY SHOULD NOT
EXIST AND FOLLOW ALONG AND-
WE'RE BRAVE ENOUGH TO BE ABLE
TO. SPEAK TO THE CIRCUMSTANCES
OF ANGELES STUFF TODAY- BUT I
KNOW THAT THEY TRAVEL WITH MANY
OTHERS WHO HAVE SHARE SIMILAR
STORIES- WHERE WE KNOW THAT WE
NEED TO HAVE A SEPARATION OF THE
CORNER FROM FROM FROM THE
SHERIFF IN THOSE INVESTIGATIONS
AS THEY CONTINUE TO GO ON SO FOR
THOSE REASONS I WILL BE
SUPPORTIVE OF THIS BILL AND
THANK YOU FOR ALWAYS COMING TO
SHARE YOUR STORY AND TO SHARE
ANGELA WITH THIS. THANK YOU. THE
OTHER COMMENT YEAH. YES SORRY I
SOMEONE NEEDS TO TEMPER SO IN
THIS DISCUSSION A LITTLE BIT-
I'D LIKE TO JUST NOTE THAT- BACK
IN TWENTY SIXTEEN SENATE BILL
ELEVEN EIGHTY NINE. IT WAS ABOUT
FOUR BY- PAM IN JACKSON SENATORS
PAM JACKSON. OF WHICH FOLLOWED A
HIGH PROFILE CASE IN VENTURA
COUNTY- THEY JOINTLY AUTHORED
THE LEGISLATION WHICH INCREASE
THE INDEPENDENCE OF THE FORENSIC
PATHOLOGIST WORKING FOR THE
SHERIFF'S CORNER BY DEFINING
AUTOPSIES AS A MEDICAL PROCEDURE
THAT MAY BE FORMED ONLY BY A
LICENSED PHYSICIAN AND SURGEON.
MOREOVER THE BILL PROVIDED. THAT
WHERE AN INDIVIDUAL DIES AS A
RESULT OF LAW ENFORCEMENT
ACTIVITY APART THE PROHIBITS LAW
ENFORCEMENT INVOLVED. IN THE
DEATH FROM ENTERING THE AUTOPSY.
OR HAVING ANY INVOLVEMENT IN THE
EXAMINATION SO I BELIEVE THAT
THAT SEPARATION ALREADY EXISTS.
AND I BELIEVE THAT THIS BILL
HARMS AND INTERFERES WITH SELF
DETERMINATION ON THE ISSUE WITH
THE COUNTIES. YOU'VE ALREADY
HEARD ABOUT POSITION THERE AND
LOCAL GOVERNMENT AND- SO
UNFORTUNATE I THINK YOUR YOUR
BILL IS WELL INTENTIONED BUT I
REALLY. THINK THAT- THIS PROBLEM
HAS ALREADY BEEN ADDRESSED AND I
THINK THE COUNTY SHOULD HAVE THE
ABILITY TO MAKE THE
DETERMINATION. ON HOW THIS
PARTNERSHIP SHOULD- EXIST IT'S
VERY VERY COSTLY. TO DO WHAT
YOU'RE ASKING THEM TO DO ALSO
AND I DON'T SEE A FUNDING
MECHANISM TO HELP THAT. SO I
WON'T BE ABLE TO SUPPORT YOUR
BILL SORRY. ANY OTHER COMMENTS.
QUESTIONS YOU MAY CLOSE. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH MR CHAIRMAN
MEMBERS AND THANK YOU FOR THE
ROBUST CONVERSATION WANT TO
THANK THE KANTO FAMILY DOCTOR-
MICHEAUX AND THOSE WHO. VOICE
THEIR- AYE VOTES OR SUPPORT FOR
SYMBOL BILL SIXTEEN OH EIGHT.
THIS BILL IS ABOUT TRANSPARENCY.
I'M NOT ONLY DOES IT. GIVE A
PIECE OF MINE. TWO OF THE FAMILY
WHO LOST A LOVED ONE- WEATHER'S
INVOLVES- INVOLVED SHOOTING OR
AN OFFICER. IN OF SOMEONE
PASSING AWAY IN CUSTODY. IT ALSO
PROVIDES TRANSPARENCY FOR LAW
ENFORCEMENT- TWO ONE I HAVE A-
AUTOPSY- IN A RULING- THEY
EITHER. THAT EITHER CLEARS A
OFFICER. OF WHAT POTENTIALLY
COULD BE UPSET- BUT ALSO GIVES
THE FAMILY. THE PEACE OF MIND TO
ACTUALLY KNOW THE CAUSE OF
DEATH- I'VE MADE MENTION IN MY
OPENING COMMENTS. ABOUT THE
COSTS. I KNOW IT'S BEEN. SAID
TIME AND TIME AGAIN IN THIS
HEARING. HOW EXPENSIVE IT WOULD
BE FOR COUNTIES TO SEPARATE.
WITH THE COUNTY BOARD OF
SUPERVISORS. EXPAND OR PASSED
MONEY TO THE SHERIFF. TO OVERSEE
THE COUNTING. WHAT DID STAND FOR
THE COUNT FOR THE COUNTY BOARD
OF SUPERVISORS TO GIVE THE MONEY
DIRECTLY TO THE CORONER'S OFFICE
AFTER IT'S BEEN BIFURCATED AND
SEPARATED SO THEY CAN DO
INDEPENDENT AUTOPSIES WITHOUT
ANY POTENTIAL INFLUENCE- BY A
SHARED THE OVERSEAS SUCH OF
RESPONSIBILITIES. ALSO
INDICATED- THAT WANT TO GIVE A
FAMILY THE KIND OF PEACE OF MIND
BUT ALSO THE COUNTY. I MADE
MENTION THAT COUNTIES HAVE TO
PAY OUT WRONGFUL DEATH OF- IS
LARGE SUMS OF MONEY. AND SO
THOSE LARGE SUMS OF MONEY- COULD
BE REDUCED BY SEPARATING- THE
TWO DEPARTMENTS- OF THE SHARE
STANDING ALONE AND THE COUNTY
CORONER'S OFFICE STANDING ALONG
AS WELL- MEMBERS I HAVE ALSO
TALKED ABOUT EXCITED DELIRIUM
AND ALSO GIVEN. OTHER
INDICATIONS OF WHERE COUNTIES
HAD TO PAY OUT MONIES- BASED ON
THEIR RULING. WE HAD IN SAN
JOAQUIN A MEDICAL EXAMINER
OFFICE WHO RESIGNED UNDER
EMBARRASSMENT WE WANT TO MAKE
SURE THIS DOESN'T HAPPEN MOVING
FORWARD AND WE BELIEVE THAT THIS
BILL SIXTEEN OH EIGHT. PROVIDE
THE KIND OF TRANSPARENCY AND THE
PEACE OF MIND THAT FAMILIES
ABSOLUTELY DEMAND AND ABSOLUTELY
NEED MEMBERS ARE RESPECTFULLY
ASK BUT I VOTE FOR THE FAMILY
MEMBERS TO KEEP YOUR FAMILY AND
THOSE. WHO HAVE ALREADY- I SPOKE
UP IN MY OPENING COMMENTS THANK
YOU VERY MUCH IN A DECADE I
WOULD TAKE YOU FOR BRINGING THIS
FORWARD I WILL ALSO OFFER MY
CITIZENS AS SOMEONE WHO SITS ON
BUDGET SUB BY PUBLIC SAFETY
BUDGET. UP TO HELP YOU FIND THE
FUNDING IF NEEDED. I DON'T THINK
IT'S NEEDED BUT IF IT'S NEEDED
WE SHOULD ADDRESS IT AND FIND
THE FUNDING PORT PORT DIRECTOR
TO MAKE THIS MOVE FORWARD AND
ULTIMATELY- MAKE SURE THAT IS
IMPLEMENTED. IN EVERY COUNTY AND
IN THE STATE THE CHURCH
RECOMMENDED AYE VOTE. THANK YOU
ON AB SIXTEEN OH EIGHT BY SEVEN
MEMBER GIPSON THE MOTION IS TO
PASS JONES SAWYER JONES SAWYER
HI LACKEY. LACKEY NEL BONTA
BONTA HI BRIAN. BRIAN HIGH COURT
. SANTIAGO THEY ARE. C. R.
TURNER. THAT MEASURES ARE CALLED
. THE NEW NEED TO MORE ABOUT
THANK VERY MUCH SIR RENOWNED
YOUR NECK ITEM. I DON'T HAVE A
SEVEN. AB SIXTEEN TWENTY ONE
GIPSON FIREARMS AND SERIALIZED
BYRON'S. THANK YOU AGAIN MISTER
CHAIRMAN AND MEMBERS THANK YOU
FOR ALLOWING ME TO PRESENT
ASSEMBLY BILL SIXTEEN TWENTY ONE
WHICH SEEKS TO BAN GHOST GUNS
WHICH CAN BE BUILT PIECE BY
PIECE USING A DO IT YOURSELF KIT
AT HOME OR BY A THREE D. PRINTER
IN THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA- THIS
BILL IS PART OF A LEGISLATIVE
PACKAGE SUPPORTED BY GOVERNOR
GAVIN NEWSOM TO STRENGTHEN. OUR
GUN LAWS AND PROTECT
CALIFORNIA'S SEVEN STATES HAVE
ALREADY PASSED LAWS SIMILAR. TO
THIS POLICY IS ONLY BE- SIXTEEN
TWENTY ONE AB SIXTEEN TWENTY ONE
IS ALSO IN LOCKSTEP WITH THE
FEDERAL ACTION LAST MONDAY BY
THE BY THE ADMINISTRATION TO
REGULATE GHOST GUNS PARTS BY
TREATING THEM AS FAR ARMS LET ME
BE CLEAR. THIS BILL IS ABOUT
TAKING AWAY IS NOT ABOUT TAKING
AWAY THE RIGHTS OF LEGAL GUN
OWNERS IT'S NOT ABOUT THAT.
ASSEMBLY BILL SIXTEEN TWENTY ONE
ENSURES THAT THESE DANGEROUS AND
UNTRACEABLE WEAPONS ARE
ERADICATED GHOST GUN PARTS AND
KITS CAN BE ORDERED ONLINE IN
STORES OR AT A GUN SHOW WITHOUT
UNDERSCORE WITHOUT A BACKGROUND.
CHECK AND THEY CAN BE PUT
TOGETHER. TO FORM A FULLY
FUNCTIONING FAR AREN'T UNDER A
HALF AN HOUR. LESS THAN THIRTY
MINUTES. IT CAN BE PUT TOGETHER
MEMBERS FOR THE MOMENT FOR THE
AMOUNT OF TIME OR LESS NEEDED TO
DISCUSS THIS BILL TODAY SOMEONE
COULD HAVE BUILT A GHOST GUN AND
IT IS EVEN LESS TIME THAT IT
TOOK THEM TO BUILD THAT GUN THAT
THEY COULD USE THAT GUN AND TAKE
SOMEONE'S LIFE AWAY. AND ALMOST
EVERYONE. CAN AND ANYONE CAN
ORDER THESE KIDS IN A VIDEO THAT
MY STAFF HAS SAID EACH AND
EVERYONE OF YOU IN YOUR INBOX A
SEPARATE SURE IT WAS STILL A
SEVENTEEN YEAR OLD. YOUNG MALE-
PURCHASE A KIT ONLINE FOR ONE
HUNDRED AND FORTY NINE DOLLARS
AND NINETY NINE CENTS AND SHIP-
TO HIS HOME. WITHIN A COUPLE
DAYS. ED ALSO WENT TO THE YOU
TO. AND WAS ABLE TO ASSEMBLE
THAT WEAPON OF MASS DESTRUCTION
LUCKILY THIS CHILD ONLY ORDERED
THE GHOST GUN KIT TO SHOW HOW
SIMPLE IT WAS TO OBTAIN AGAIN HE
ORDERED THIS SEVENTEEN YEARS OLD
WAS SENT TO HIS HOME. BUT THIS
LACK OF REGULATION CHAU ALARM
EACH AND EVERYONE OF US IN THIS
ROOM AND THOSE WATCHING AT HOME
FOR ALL THE REASONS I HAVE
STATED AND MORE GHOST GUNS HAVE
CONTINUE TO LEAD. THE WILDFIRE
OF GUN VIOLENCE IN NOT ONLY MY
COMMUNITY BUT ACROSS THE UNITED
STATES AND IT'S SPECIALLY HERE
IN THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA IN
LOS ANGELES ALONE DURING JUST
THE FIRST HALF OF TWO THOUSAND
AND TWENTY ONE. POLICE
CONFISCATED EIGHT HUNDRED AND
SIXTY THREE GHOST GUNS THIS WAS
A 4100% INCREASE FROM THE PERIOD
PRIOR YEAR. IN THAT SAME TIME
PERIOD THESE WEAPONS OF MASS
DESTRUCTION AS LINKED TO TWENTY
FOUR KILLINGS. EIGHT ATTEMPTED
HOMICIDES ED A DOZEN ASSAULTS
AND ARMED ROBBERS JEFF IN LOS
ANGELES ALONE IN ADDITION TO THE
CALMUS INDIVIDUALS OF ALL
INDIVIDUAL HOMICIDES GHOST GUNS
ARE BEING USED IN MASS
SHOOTINGS. FOR EXAMPLES. DAVID
MORA. SINCE APRIL OF TWO
THOUSAND TWENTY ONE MORE WAS
UNDER A RESTRAINING ORDER THAT
BARRED HIM FROM POSSESSING A
FIREARM AND AUTHORITIES DO NOT
KNOW HOW HE OBTAINED ONE. WE
HAVE TO STOP THE KILLING AND
START THE HEALING PROCESS IN
THIS STATE. LOSING LOVED ONES
DUE TO GUN VIOLENCE. THIS BILL
WILL PROVIDE. AND BRING US ONE
STEP CLOSER TO JUSTICE ASSEMBLY
BILL SIXTEEN TWENTY ONE SEEKS TO
HALT THE SALE OF FIREARMS
PRECURSOR PARTS WHICH ARE
UNFINISHED PARTS AND ON
TRACEABLE GUN PARTS UNTIL. UNTIL
AND SUCH TIME THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT REGULATES THEM I
PASSING THIS BILL WOULD GO INTO
EFFECT ON JANUARY THE FIRST TWO
THOUSAND AND TWENTY THREE AND
EVERYONE IN POSSESSION OF A UN
SERIALIZED BAR ON WOULD HAVE SIX
MONTHS FROM THAT DATE TO
STERILIZE THOSE PARTICULAR FAR
ARMS. HOBBYISTS GUN ENTHUSIASTS
CAN STILL BUILD AT HOME FOR
PERSONAL USE BUT ONLY USE FRAMES
AND RECEIVERS THAT ARE ALREADY
SUBJECT TO FEDERAL GUN SAFETY
LAWS JOINING ME. TO PROVIDE
SUPPORTING TESTIMONIES WILL BE A
REPRESENTATIVE AND I BELIEVE
HE'S ON THE LINE FROM AND WITH
THE GIPPER LAWCENTER ALSO
JOINING ME UP ON THE PHONE WILL
BE A REPRESENTATIVE WHO SURVIVED
UNDERSCORE SURVIVED HER NAME IS
MIA SHE'S A YOUNG LADY WHO'S IN
SCHOOL- IN TWO THOUSAND
NINETEEN- SAUGUS HIGH SCHOOL SHE
WAS THERE IN SENATE SENATE
CARITA. IN CALIFORNIA WHERE A
GHOST GUN WAS USE THESE GHOST
GUNS TOOK KNOWING HER FRIENDS
BUT ALSO KILLED HER BEST FRIENDS
MIA WAS ALSO. INTRODUCED IN
JOINT PRESIDENT JOE BIDE AT THE
WHITE HOUSE PRESS CONFERENCE TO
ANNOUNCE FEDERAL ACTION TO
ERADICATE GHOST GUNS IN THIS.
STATE AND IN THIS COUNTRY. SO
WE- BEEN. EIGHTEEN EACH OPERATOR
OPEN TO LINE FOR R. E. RELLIK-
FROM THE GIFFORDS LW CENTER.
AND I GUESS MISTER GIBSON FILES
OR NAY MEDIA TRETTER. FOR A-
DOES THE TODAY. GOOD MORNING MY
NAME IS ALREADY FILED AGAINST
THE POLICY DIRECTIVE OF
DIFFERENCE THE CONSULTANT AN
ORGANIZATION LED BY FORMER
CONGRESSWOMAN GUN OWNER AND
AMOUNTS MARTIN DADDY GET PRE
WARE IN STRONG SUPPORT OF THIS
BILL. READ THE REPORT BY THE
GUARDIAN I'M GOING WELL TO TELL
FOR YOUR STARTED WITH THIS QUOTE
. WHEN BY MUHAMMAD A PROGRAM
MANAGER ALTERNATE YOU LOOKING.
AS DISTRICT YEAR OLD BOY I DON'T
GETTING GUNS IS THE ANSWER BE A
NEED STATE. SEN THE KEY NATIONAL
THE PLAY. WHO WOULD WAIT TIME
GOING TO YOU CAN CHECK THEM IN
THE- MEMBERS WE ARE IN THE MIDST
OF THE BANK CRAZY PEOPLE IN
SMALL POT BUT THE- BLOOD OF
GREAT GUNS THAT WAS COMMUNITIES
ACROSS OUR STATE. YOU THE SELF
ASSEMBLED- ACCOUNTED FOR ONE OF
ALL WERE CUT BY THE- AND
INVESTING OF ACT LAST YEAR. AND
44% FIFTY HOMICIDE CASES. I
UNDERSTAND WHERE THIS DOES
INCOME STARTED WE HAVE TO BUILD
IN QATAR. YOU CAN LISTEN TO THE
WHOLE AFTER. YOU'RE A LITTLE
MUFFLED LOOK. THAT'S A NICE WAY
ABOUT THAT IS THAT ANY CLEAR
NOW. HELLO THE TECHNICIAN THIS
DEVASTATING SO WITH TO BUILD
INTO SOME JORDAN. BECAUSE THE
STEMS FROM AN ANTI EFFORT TO.
OUR LOW BASED THAT THE OF THE
WORD FOR. ITSELF THE FOR
RECEIVER OF A GUN AT SUCH A
INTEGRAL PART OF THE WEAPON THE
PULL BACK. FEDERAL LAW IN MOST.
LAWS THAT IMPOSE SAME OF. OTHERS
SAY TO THE AND THEN. FRIEDMAN
PEOPLE A COMPLETE GUN. THAT'S
ABOUT TO BE DEFINING WORD. TO
INCLUDE. WILL RECEIVE OF THE WEB
TO. SO IT'S IMPORTANT TO NOTE
LAW HOBBY HAVE ALWAYS BEEN ABLE
TO BUILD THEIR OWN GUY FROM
REGULATED COME. THANK YOU CAN
GET SALAS WITH. ARE YOU. THAT'S
OUR ARE YOU ARE YOU KNOW ABLE TO
HEAR ME. I IT IS WHAT YOU SAID
I'M SORRY. ARE YOU DONE BY SIR I
WOULD NOT FINISHED BY THE IF YOU
HAVEN'T COME HEARING AT THE
STRUGGLE TO- OUT TRY AGAIN. IT
IS SO YOU CAN PLEASE TESTIMONY
CAN I ASSUME THAT. CLOSE ARE YOU
ABLE TO HEAR ME NOW BETTER. YES
EVERY FINISH YOUR TESTIMONY. NO
SIR A I'M SORRY IF YOU'RE NOT
ABLE TO HEAR ME AT ALL TO ALL
CLOSED QUICKLY AND JUST SAYING
TO BE CLEAR AT ALL TIMES THE
BILL WOULD CONTINUE TO AUTHORIZE
UNLICENSED GUN MAKERS TO SELL
MORE GUNS FOR PERSONAL USE FROM
COMPLETED FRAMES AND RECEIVERS
WHICH ALREADY SUBJECT TO
CRITICAL CALIFORNIA AND FEDERAL
GUN LAWS. BUT AS LONG AS THE
FEDERAL RULED INFORMATION AFFECT
UNLICENSED GUN MAKERS COULD ALSO
SAMPLE GUNS UNFINISHED RANGERS
USE THAT A SERIAL SUBJECT TO FOR
BACK ON CHECKS THIS IS A TOUGH
PRIORITY FOR CONDITION WHICH
ONLY URGE SUPPORT. THANK YOU.
SIR YOU HEAR FROM IT TRETTER.
HELLO MY NAME IS MIA TREACY HEAR
ME YES WE HEAD. RIGHT ON
NOVEMBER FOURTEENTH TWENTY
NINETEEN A REFRESHMENT FARGAS
HIGH SCHOOL AND MY BIGGEST WORRY
ABOUT J. WITH THE SPANISH. WHEN
I GOT THE CALL I MADE A BEELINE
TO THE QUAD WITH MY BEST FRIEND
DOWN THE BLOCK FROM. OUR TYPICAL
MORNING LAUGHING SESSION WAS
INTERRUPTED BY THE SOUND OF A
GUNSHOT. BOB I THINK MORE. ONE
SHOT HIT ME IN THE STOMACH. I
WAS AIRLIFTED FROM SCHOOL TO
EMERGENCY SURGERY TO REMOVE A
BULLET BUT WAS MILLIMETERS AWAY
FROM KILLING ME. I WOKE UP TO A
NEW REALITY. ONE WHERE DOMINIC
AND ANOTHER CLASSMATE OF MINE
BRACEY ANNUAL BURGER COULD NO
LONGER LIVE. I LATER LEARNED
THAT WE HAD BEEN SHOT BY A
SIXTEEN YEAR OLD FOGGY STUDENT.
THE BIRTH FATHER GRANTED COOL A
FIREARM I WOULD COME TO
EVENTUALLY KNOW THE DOCTOR. I
WOULD QUICKLY LEARNED THAT THE
UNMARKED UNTRACEABLE BUILD IT
YOURSELF FIRE ARMS WITH THE
FASTEST GROWING PUBLIC SAFETY
THREATEN OUR COUNTRY. ANYONE
WITH A CREDIT CARD SKILL TO
BUILD IKEA FURNITURE AND THEIR
TIME TO MAKE THE SAME GUN THAT
TOOK THE LIVES OF TWO OF MY
CLASSMATES AND CHANGE MINE
FOREVER. BECAUSE OF THAT THESE
WEAPONS WERE ONCE SEEN AS THE
WEAPON OF CHOICE FOR TERRORISTS
AND CRIMINALS. BUT NOW HAVE
STARTED TO SHOW UP IN THE HANDS
OF CHILDREN AND TEENS AND SCHOOL
SHOOTINGS LIKE MINE. THE RISING
GO CAN HAS DEVASTATED
COMMUNITIES AND FAMILIES.
ACCORDING TO THE DEPARTMENT OF
JUSTICE LAW ENFORCEMENT HAS
RECOVERED NEARLY TWENTY THOUSAND
SUSPECTED GO SPENT LAST YEAR
ALONE. OUR STATE HAS
UNFORTUNATELY BECOME AN
EPICENTER FOR THESE TYPES OF
GUNS IN LOS ANGELES THE NUMBER
OF GHOSTS AND RECOVERED FROM
CRIME SCENE HAS RISEN
APPROXIMATELY FOUR HUNDRED
PERCENT. SINCE TWENTY SEVENTEEN.
LAST WEEK PRESIDENT BY THE
MINISTRATION FINALIZED A RULE TO
REGULATE THOSE GUNS. THAT WILL
AMONG OTHER THINGS ENSURE THAT
THE WEAPON IF IT LOOKS LIKE A
GUN SHIP LIKE A GUN AND KILLED
LIKE A GUN. IT WILL BE TREATED
LIKE A GUN. WELL THE ROLE OF A
MAJOR STEP FORWARD IN CUTTING
OFF THE STREAM OF UNTRACEABLE
GUNS IN OUR SCHOOLS AND
COMMUNITIES. THIS IS ONLY THE
BEGINNING. WE NEED COMPREHENSIVE
ACTION ON BOTH GUNS AND EVERY
LEVEL. PREVENT MORE TRAGEDIES
LIKE THE ONE I EXPERIENCED.
EIGHTEEN TWENTY ONE. FOR BIG
GROWTH COMES WITHOUT REALIZATION
AND ENSURE THAT THOSE ALREADY IN
CIRCULATION IN OUR PROPERLY
SERIALIZE. WE DESERVE TO LIVE IN
A STATE THAT PRIORITIZES THE R.
SIXTY. LET AS YOU CAN AND MUST
SAFE MODE YES ON EIGHTY SIXTEEN
TWENTY ONE THANK YOU THANK YOU.
WE NOW GO TO ROME AS- IN SUPPORT. AND IN THE HALLWAY SUPPORT.
GOOD MORNING TERM MEMBERS NICOLE
CAN UNITS ON BEHALF OF EVERY
TOWN FOR GUN SAFETY IN STRONG
SUPPORT OF AB SIXTEEN TWENTY ONE
THANK YOU THANK YOU ANYONE ELSE
IN THE ROOM IN SUPPORT. KNOW
WHAT OUTSIDE. EIGHTEEN T.
OPERATE WE NOW GO TO THE PHONE
LINE BEGIN FOR WITNESSES IN
SUPPORT. THANK YOU WITNESSES IN
SUPPORT OF AB SIXTEEN TWENTY ONE
ORGANIZATIONS ONE THEN. CERO AND
WILL START WITH NINE SIXTY FOUR
PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD MORNING
JIM LINDBERG ON BEHALF OF THE
FRIENDS COMMITTEE ON LEGISLATION
TO CALIFORNIA IN SUPPORT. AND
ACTION DECLINED ONE FIFTY PLEASE
GO AHEAD. LUCIEN ON BEHALF OF
THE LOS ANGELES POLICE
PROTECTIVE LEAGUE IN STRONG
SUPPORT. I HAVE ONE MORE LINE
WITH THE OPERATOR. MY NUMBER
FIFTEEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI MY
NAME IS CASSANDRA WENT DOWN AND
I LIVE IN FULL SUN I'M A
VOLUNTEER WITH MOMS DEMAND
ACTION AND I'M CALLING IN
SUPPORT OF AB SIXTEEN TWENTY ONE
THANK YOU. THANK YOU. AND THAT
IS ALL I HAVE IN QUEUE RIGHT
NOW. OKAY WE NOW HEAR FROM
WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION I DIDN'T
RECOGNIZE YOU. THE AGENT. OPERAS
EVER. AND I APPRECIATE. A GERMAN
MAN TO SAMPLE RIP GUN CAL. AND
WE'RE HERE TO RESPECTFULLY
OPPOSE AB SIXTEEN TWENTY ONE
WHICH MAKES SEEKS TO CHANGE THE
DEFINITION OF SO CALLED
PRECURSOR PARTS BANS THE SALE OF
ANY UN SERIALIZED FRAME OR
RECEIVER AND PROHIBITS THE SALE
OF COMPUTER NUMERICALLY
CONTROLLED MACHINES WAS PRIMARY
PURPOSES PRECURSOR PART
MANUFACTURING. WITHOUT QUESTION
THE RECENT ESCALATION IN CRIME
THROUGHOUT THE NATION IS CAUSE
FOR CONCERN HOWEVER PRIVATELY
MADE FIREARMS HAVE BECOME AN
UNFORTUNATE SCAPEGOAT ALTHOUGH
THE NUMBER OF GHOST GUNS HAVE
INCREASED IN POPULARITY QUOTE
UNQUOTE GHOST GUNS THERE IS
SIMPLY NO EVIDENCE THAT THEY ARE
THE CAUSE FOR THE SURGE IN
VIOLENT CRIME ACCORDING TO THE
BUREAU OF ALCOHOL TOBACCO
FIREARMS AND EXPLOSIVES.
RECENTLY REPORTED BY THE MEDIA
GOES GUNS HAVE BEEN TIED TO
THREE HUNDRED AND TWENTY ONE
HOMICIDES OR ATTEMPTED HOMICIDES
NATIONWIDE SINCE TWENTY SIXTEEN
NOT OUR NUMBERS ATF WHICH IS
ZERO POINT 36% OF ACTUAL
HOMICIDES FURTHER OF THE GUNS
RECOVERED IN THE OFT REPORTED
STATISTICS FROM L. A. COUNTY
ELLIE CITY THERE IS A LITTLE
DATA THAT INDICATES HOW MANY
WERE USED. IN THE ACTUAL-
COMMISSION OF GUN VIOLENCE
FINALLY ONE POINT THAT IS
SIGNIFICANTLY OVERLOOKED IS THE
FACT THAT WHENEVER A FIREARM IS
SEIZED AND THE SERIAL NUMBER HAS
BEEN REMOVED AS IN FILED OFF OR
A PUBLIC RATED WHICH IS A COMMON
THING AMONG CRIMINAL USE GUNS IT
NOW FITS THE DEFINITION AND IS
STATISTICALLY COUNTED AS A GHOST
GUN THIS IS MISLEADING THIS HAS
BEEN HAPPENING SINCE GUNS WERE
MADE. AND SEVERAL NUMBERS WERE
ADDED TO THEM. THE OF THIS BILL
THAT BANS THE SALE OF COMPUTER
NUMERICALLY CONTROLLED MACHINES
THAT ARE DESIGNED FOR THE
PURPOSE OF MANUFACTURING ON
SERIALIZE FRAMES AND RECEIVERS
AS TROUBLING AS WELL. GIVEN THAT
IT DISCOURAGED REGARDS THE FACT
THAT CNC MACHINES NO MATTER WHAT
TYPE OR WHAT SIZE CAN BE USED TO
MANUFACTURE PARTS MADE OF METAL
PLASTIC OR EVEN WOOD. ALL OF
WHICH- COULD BE. AND IN MOST
CASES ARE UNRELATED TO FIREARMS
. WE HAVE A CRIMINAL PROBLEM NOT
A GUN PROBLEM IN CALIFORNIA
UNTIL WE PASS STRINGENT
PENALTIES FOR THE CRIMINAL USE
OF FIREARMS THERE WILL BE LITTLE
TO NO IMPACT ON GUN VIOLENCE IT
IS FOR THESE REASONS THESE
REASONS WE OPPOSE AB SIXTEEN
TWENTY ONE AND THANK YOU FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY TO. TESTIFY IN
PERSON. THANK YOU AND ANY OTHER
WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION. IN THE
ROOM OR IN THE HALLWAY. WHO WAS
SUPPOSED TO BE ANOTHER ON THE
PHONE- I'M SORRY I DID I DON'T
HAVE ANY. REGRET IS THERE ANYONE
. ON THE PHONE WE I WOULD LIKE
TO TESTIFY IN OPPOSITION. IN
MOSCOW IF YOU HAVE A- COMMENT
PLEASE PRESS ONE THEN ZERO WE'LL
GO TO LINE ONE FORTY SIX. MISTER
CHAIRMAN ASSEMBLY MEMBERS FOR
THE RECORD WE'RE TRAVIS DIRECTOR
OF DEVELOPMENT CALIFORNIA RIGHT
BOTH SUBDIVISION SPEAKING TODAY
IN STRONG OPPOSITION TO ASSEMBLY
BILL SIXTEEN TWENTY ONE. THE
FELLAS YET ANOTHER STEP IN THE
PROCESS OF BRINGING THE LEGAL
AND LAWFUL AFTER FIFTY DOUBLE
FIREARMS BUDGET AMERICANS HAVE
ENJOYED OUR NATION FOUNDED. THE
PAST EIGHTY THREE TWENTY ONE
WILL THOUGHT AND I'M THAT THE-
AND LAWSUITS AND HOW THE
CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT JUSTICE
WOULD EVEN MORE UNNECESSARY TIME
. NOW EVENT I'M- IS ON COM. ALL
DOES NOT GOING THE- NO AGAIN AND
HE OF THE WITH WOULD BE REQUIRED
TO THE DEPARTMENT OF. THE CARD
RESPONSIBLE INCLUDE THE TRACK
ALL FOR. REGISTRY OF ALL PER
HAVE BEEN PURCHASED BACKGROUND
CHECKS AND WE WILL. NUMBER NOW
BUT I AM THERE'S PURCHASE AND
PURCHASE A ALREADY WHEN. EIGHT
EIGHT NINE. AND TWENTY FIVE
ISRAEL JERRY BE PASSED BETWEEN
THE STAGGERING NUMBERS. THE
FINAL BUT MADE A FULL DOES A
PART NOW THAT'S TO RESPOND ABOUT
THE SPECIAL GUNS ALL OF CAL BUT.
CONSTITUTIONAL RIGHTS THE BILL
INTO LAW BOND ABOUT FINANCES
FAMILY ENJOY THE PRESIDENT OF
THE BOARD YOU THOUGHT THE
CALIFORNIA OFFICE OF THE VISION
AND THE THOUSANDS OF MEMBERS
DOWN SHOP STRONG OPPOSITION TO
AB SIXTEEN TWENTY ONE AND URGE
YOU TO VOTE NO ON THIS MISGUIDED
LEGISLATION THANK YOU. FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY TO SPEAK OPPOSITION.
THANK YOU. IN ORDER TO LINE ONE
FORTY FIVE PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI
GOOD MORNING- THANK YOU FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY TO SPEAK THIS
MORNING MY NAME IS KAREN BUT
WELL I AM A MEMBER. OF THE RIFLE
AND PISTOL ASSOCIATION AND IN
ORDER TO CALIFORNIA AND I- I'M
CALLING TO VOICE MY STRONG
OPPOSITION FOR A. B. SIXTEEN
TWENTY ONE. THANK YOU AGAIN.
THANK YOU SIR. IT WILL ALIGN ONE
FIFTY ONE PLEASE GO AHEAD. HELLO
MY NAME'S JACK MARSHALL AND FIRM
NEVADO CALIFORNIA I'M A DISABLED
VETERAN AND I STRONGLY OPPOSE
THIS BILL I CAN'T BELIEVE IT'S
EVEN BROUGHT FORWARD THERE'S SO
MANY PEOPLE HAVE BROUGHT
INFORMATION HONESTLY. CAN'T
BELIEVE THIS YOUR SIX
CONSIDERING. THANK YOU. IT WILL
GO TO LINE ONE SIXTY ONE PLEASE
GO AHEAD. YES GOOD MORNING MY
NAME IS MIKE KELLY ASM FROM
VENTURA COUNTY I'M A MEMBER OF
THE VENTURA COUNTY GUN OWNERS
AND CALIFORNIA RIFLE PISTOL
ASSOCIATION I STRONGLY OPPOSE AB
ONE SIXTY ONE. THANK YOU THANK
YOU SIR. OVER A LINE ONCE PARDON
ME FORTY SIX LINE FORTY SIX.
MISTER CARE MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE FOR THE RECORD AND
READ WHAT'S A REGIONAL DIRECTOR
OF THE NATIONAL RIFLE
ASSOCIATION FROM OPPOSITION.
THANK YOU. OVERLYING SIXTY
EIGHT. RESEARCHERS ESTIMATE
GRANT ARMATURE OF THE SOUTH
SACRAMENTO CHAPTER OF THE
CALIFORNIA RIFLE AND PISTOL
ASSOCIATION AN NRA MEMBER AND
STRONG OPPOSITION. THANK YOU SIR. NUMBER ONE LINE ONE FORTY
SEVEN. MY NAME IS JAMES O'BRIEN
LIFELONG RESIDENT CALIFORNIA
LIFE BY MEMBERS OF THE NRA
MEMBER OF THE CALIFORNIA
LIFELINE CHRISTMASES SHE SHOULD
HAVE BEEN STRONG OPPOSITION OF
AB SIXTEEN TWENTY ONE THANK YOU.
THANK YOU. WHAT ARE SIXTEEN LINE. SIXTEEN GOOD MORNING THIS IS
JOHN EGGMAN I AM THE CHAIRMAN OF
THE NEVADA COUNTY GUN OWNERS
RESIDENT GRASS VALLEY IN NEVADA
COUNTY CALIFORNIA AND IN
REPRESENTATION OF THE MEMBERSHIP
WE ARE IN STRONG OPPOSITION TO
THIS LEGISLATION. WE'LL GO TO
LINE ONE FIFTY THREE. THANK YOU
MY NAME IS CARLENE ELLIS I'M A
OF THE CALIFORNIA RIFLE AND-
ASIAN. CALIFORNIA AND- THE PHONE
. AND I MISTER OTHER. AB SIXTEEN
TWENTY ONE THANK YOU. OVER LINE
ONE FIFTY TWO. HI MONETARISM I'M
AN NRA MEMBER AND SHE APPEARED
MEMBER ALIGNMENTS OPPOSITION OF
IT M. SIXTEEN TWENTY ONE. THANK
YOU. I WILL GO TO LINE ONE FIFTY
FIVE. MODILLIONED SECRETARY
RESIDENT I AM IN OPPOSITION AS
MEASURED. AND ONE MOMENT. NO
MATTER. M. ABOUT ALIGNING ONE
FIFTY THREE. AT THE TIME THERE
ARE NO FURTHER. THANK YOU MARK
HAS BEEN THANK YOU THANK YOU
BRING ABOUT COMMITTEE- ANY
QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS. ONE
RESPOND TO IT IN MR. I'LL MOVE
THE BILL BUT ALSO WANTED TO
THANK AT THE AUTHOR FOR BRINGING
FORWARD THIS LEGISLATION I DID
HAVE THE OPPORTUNITY TO VISIT
WITH YOU IN YOUR DISTRICT- AND
WAS ABLE TO SEE THE COMPONENT
PARTS. OF THAT OF OUR SO CALLED.
YOU HAVE OTHER USES BUT CLEARLY
DO NOT HAVE ANY OTHER USE BUT
THEN TO BE A PART OF. THE
COMPONENT OF A GUN- AND THOSE
PARTS ARE UN SERIALIZED THE FACT
THAT THEIR- SERIALIZED BECAUSE
GREAT CAUSES GREAT HARM- AT
BECAUSE THEY'RE NOT TRACEABLE
ARE NOT ABLE TO BE PUT TOGETHER-
FOR ANY OTHER REASON THAN TO BE
A GUN THAT CAN BE USED. TO CAUSE
HARM SO I THANK YOU FOR THE BILL
AND- AND FOR THOSE REASONS I
WILL BE PUTTING I. THINK
SELECTED. YEAH FOR OF ALL LET ME
SAY THAT- I YOU'RE INTO ARE
NOBLE ADMIRABLE BECAUSE I THINK
WE ALL HATE THE- THE VIOLENT
OUTCOMES THAT ARE- BEING
DISPLAYED. AND UP ON OCCASION
USING THESE THESE TYPES OF
WEAPONS CALLED GHOST GUNS NO ONE
LIKES GHOST GUNS NO ONE. AS A
MATTER OF FACT- IT'S ALREADY
ILLEGAL TO MANUFACTURE FIREARM
WITHOUT NOTIFYING. THE
DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE WE'RE
GETTING A SERIAL NUMBER FOR THE
FIREARM. AND THERE'S ALSO A
PROHIBITION AGAINST SELLING ONE
ALREADY- FIRE PARTS DON'T KILL
PEOPLE. BEHAVIOR KILLS PEOPLE
AND THAT'S WHAT I WISHED ARE
FOCUS WOULD BE MORE DIRECTED
TOWARDS THE- THE VIOLENT
BEHAVIOR ISSUES WITH ANY WEAPON
NO MATTER WHAT IT IS AND- I JUST
FEEL LIKE THIS IS CHASING THE
WRONG THING SO I WON'T BE ABLE
TO SUPPORT IT. SORRY THANK YOU
ANY OTHER COMMENT. SANTIAGO YEAH
I THINK IT WAS DIFFERENT
TYPICALLY DON'T WANT TO SEE A
LOT OF WORDS ON SOMETHING THAT I
SUPPORT BUT I THINK THIS IS THIS
IS INCREDIBLY IMPORTANT I CAN
APPRECIATE THE OPPOSITION HAVE
AN OPPOSING VIEW I DON'T SHARE
THAT VIEW BUT BUT I'VE LEARNED
OVER THE YEARS RESPECT FACTOR
YOU COMING HERE UNDERSTANDING
WHAT YOU'RE UP AGAINST- AND I
HAD TO SAY THAT BUT I DON'T
AGREE BECAUSE- THESE GUNS HAVE
NO PLACE ON THE STREETS.
SOMEBODY'S GUNS WERE BUILT. THE
MASS DESTROYS SOMEBODY'S GUNS
WERE AT THE CONCEPT OF CREATING
PARTS THAT ARE UNDETECTABLE SO
THAT THEY CAN BE PUT TOGETHER IN
A DIFFERENT LOCATION STILL UNDER
INTACT THE BOWL. TO MAKE A GUN
THAT UNDETECTABLE. THAT IS BUILT
WITH THE IF IT WOULD WITH THE
INTENT OF MASS DESTRUCTION TO ME
MAKES NO SENSE FOR US TONIGHT I
MEAN LET LET ALONE HAVE A BUT WE
CAN HAVE THAT DEBATE DOWN THE
LINE FOR THEM TO EXIST FOR THEM
TO HAVE THEM FOR THE AVERAGE
CITIZEN TO BE WALK AROUND THE
STREET OWNING ONE OF THESE GUNS.
FOR MASS DESTRUCTION OF WE'VE
DONE A LOT IN CALIFORNIA BUT BUT
THE RIVER THE REALITY WE REMAINS
AND UNLESS WE GET COMPREHENSIVE.
GUN CONTROL MEASURES AT THE
NATIONAL LEVEL PEOPLE CAN STILL
GO OUT OF STATE GET ONE BRING IT
BACK AGAIN. IT MAKES NO SENSE TO
ME TO HAVE A GUN LIKE THAT OR
WHY SOMEBODY WOULD WANT TO HAVE
ONE W. AS IT MAY THE CONCEPT
ALONE OF HAVING A GUN LIKE THIS
IT IS UNTRACEABLE. IT IS
UNCONSCIONABLE TO ME THAT WE
WILL EVEN HAVE. A DEBATE ABOUT
TRACING A GUN. L. A. N. I
UNDERSTAND THE CONCEPT ABOUT YOU
KNOW WE SHOULD FOCUS ON. ON
PEOPLE NOT GUNS BUT A PERSON IS
NOT GOING TO GET UP AND SHOOT
SOMEBODY WITH A GUN. SO OF
COURSE WE HAVE TO FOCUS ON THE
GUY YOU WANT ELIMINATE A LARGE
PORTION OF THE EQUATION OF WHAT
KILLED SOMEBODY WITH A GUN YOU
HAVE TO LIMIT THE GUN WE EAT WE
CAN VIEW IT DIFFERENTLY BUT THE
OTHER AT THE END OF THE DAY. THE
LOGIC STILL STANDS. YOU DON'T
GET UP TO SHOOT SOMEBODY WITH A
GUN AND HURT THEM UNLESS THE GUN
IS PRESENT. GIVEN THE JUST NO
SHOT THAT'S THE LOGIC. SO WE CAN
DO. SO WE COULD BE THERE ALL DAY
LONG BUT THE END OF THE DAY WE
NEED. THE STRONGEST CONTROL
CONTROL MEASURES. ON THE STREETS
TO PREVENT. PEOPLE FROM GETTING
SHOT OR PEOPLE FROM SHOOTING.
THAT'S THE BOTTOM LINE. SO I
WANT TO THANK YOU FOR YOUR FOR
YOUR HARD WORK AT THE GIVEN
MODEST IN YOUR EFFORTS. ITBUT I
THINK THIS IS ONE OF THE MOST
IMPORTANT ISSUES THAT WE'RE
GONNA BE FACING AND YOU HAVE.
BEEN DOGGED ON THIS OVER A
NUMBER OF YEARS I WANT TO THANK
YOU AND- AND WE HOPE TO ALLOW ME
TO JOIN YOUR PARTS OF IN ALREADY
CO AUTHORED IT. I THINK IT'S
IMPORTANT INCREDIBLE IN POINT
THAT THIS GETS SIGNED I THINK
IT'S INCREDIBLY IMPORTANT THAT
WE- HAVE A WAY TO DETECT A GUN
TO THE BILL THE MURDER PEOPLE-
AND IT'S- IT'S JUST UNIMAGINABLE
TO ME THAT WE EAT. OR EVEN
HAVING A DEBATE ABOUT
IDENTIFYING UNDETECTABLE WEAPON
MADE FOR MASS DESTRUCTION. THANK
YOU THANK YOU ANYMORE COMMENT.
SEEING NONE YOU MAY CLOSE THANK
YOU VERY MUCH MR CHAIRMAN AND
MEMBERS- THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR
THE ROBUST CONVERSATION I JUST
WANT TO CALL TO YOUR ATTENTION
WHAT TRANSPIRED IN SACRAMENTO I
MADE MENTION OF MY OPENING
REMARKS ABOUT DAVID MORE. DAVID
MORA HE- HAD THERE WAS A
REGISTERED GUN OWNER- HE WAS
RICHARD GUN OWNER BECAUSE THE
WORK THAT THIS PUBLIC SAFETY AND
MY COLLEAGUE DONE. BECAUSE OF
THE DOMESTIC VIOLENCE THAT EXIST
AT GOMEZ TAKEN AWAY AND TAKEN
OUT AT HOME. BUT DAVID MOORE
ALSO HAD SUPERVISED VISITATION
RIGHTS. TO SEE HIS THREE
DAUGHTERS. WELL DAVID- MATE A.
K. FORTY SEVEN. I WENT TO GO
VISIT HIS THREE DAUGHTERS. AT
CHURCH A PLACE OF WORSHIP HERE
IN SACRAMENTO. HE TOOK THAT A.
K. FORTY SEVEN IS A R. FIFTEEN I
APOLOGIZE. ANY KILLED HIS THREE
DAUGHTERS AT CHURCH. HE KILLED
THE SOCIAL WORKER AND THEN HE
TURNED HIS GUN ON HIMSELF. HE
WAS PROHIBITED FROM HAVING A GUN
AT ALL. WHAT WE'VE SEEN IN TV ON
TV TIME AND TIME AGAIN IS MASS
SHOOTINGS NEW YORK CHICAGO. LOS
ANGELES SACRAMENTO. WE KNOW THAT
CALIFORNIA PROVIDES OF GREAT
LEADERSHIP AS RELATES TO PUBLIC
SAFETY IN THIS SPACE AND OTHER
STATES FOLLOW CALIFORNIA BUT IT
MAKES NO DIFFERENCE UNLESS THE
FEDERAL GOVERNMENT INTERVENE I
AM SO EXCITED THAT PRESIDENT JOE
BIDEN. ANNOUNCED HIS WAR ON
GHOST GUNS IN THIS COUNTRY WE
NEED FEDERAL INTERVENTION WE
NEED FEDERAL LEGISLATION AND I'M
HOPEFUL THAT WE'RE GOING TO HAVE
IT WITH HIS EXECUTIVE ORDER. I'M
VERY EXCITED ABOUT OUR GOVERNOR
WANT AS A FATHER AS A HUSBAND TO
UNDERSTAND THAT NONE OF US. ARE
EXEMPT FROM BEING AT A CHURCH A
CLUB- WALKING DOWN OUR STREETS
BEING EXEMPT FROM GUN VIOLENCE-
COMING AND KNOCKING ON OUR DOORS
THIS IS A VERY THOUGHTFUL
MEASURE. WE HAVE TO STAND UP FOR
FAMILIES WHO STILL MOURN THE
LOSS OF A LOVED ONE WE HAVE TO
STAND UP FOR MOTHERS WHO STILL
WEEP BECAUSE THEIR CHILD HAS
JUST BEEN DONE DOWN WE JUST
HEARD FROM LITTLE MIA WHO'S AT
SCHOOL RIGHT NOW WHO HAD TO SAY
GOODBYE BECAUSE SHE THEY WERE IN
SAUGUS- AND- HER FRIENDS THAT
OTHERS WERE TAKEN AWAY DUE TO
NON VIOLENCE AND A GHOST GUNS.
WHEN IS ENOUGH IS ENOUGH THIS
BILL IS A THOUGHTFUL MEASURE-
AND WE BELIEVE WE'RE GOING TO
THE RIGHT DIRECTION- WE HAVE THE
POWER TO CHANGE THE SUBJECT TO
WRITE A NEW NARRATIVE FOR
CALIFORNIA BUT FOR THE UNITED
STATES OF AMERICA AND TODAY I
ASKED FOR THAT OPPORTUNITY TO DO
SO WITH A STRONG AYE VOTE. ON
SIXTEEN- EIGHT TWENTY ONE SEASON
I HAVE TOO MANY SIXTEEN. THANK
YOU OF THE BILL THANK YOU. JUDGE
RECOMMENDED THE AGUINALDO STAR
MISTER CHAIRMAN APOLOGIZE WE
HAVE FOUR THOUSAND SIGNATURES-
THREE HUNDRED TWENTY SEVEN PAGES
OF PEOPLE SIGNING SUPPORT OF
SIXTEEN TWENTY ONE THAT I WAS
GOING TO LIBERTY OFFICES BUT AS
WITH THE SHOW YOU. THANK YOU
IT'S GOOD TO SHOW THERE'S NO
NEED TO KILL A TREE. WHAT THAT'S
AN AB SIXTEEN TWENTY ONE BY
SEVEN OVER GIPSON THE MOTION IS
TO PASS TO THE APPROPRIATIONS
COMMITTEE JONES SAWYER HI JONES
SAWYER HI LACKEY. LACKEY NEL
BONTA. BONTA HI BRIAN. BRIAN I
WORK. SANTIAGO SANTIAGO I
SEYARTO SEE OUR TURN NOW. IT
MEASURES OR CALL NEEDS ONE MORE
THANK YOU VERY MUCH THANK
EVERYBODY. NOW MR HOLDEN YOU
HAVE TO BILLS THANK YOU FOR YOUR
PATIENCE ITEM NUMBER EIGHTY
NINE. AB TWENTY EIGHTY FIVE
HOLDEN CRIMES MANDATED REPORTERS
. BUT ITEM NUMBER NINE AB TWENTY
SIX THIRTY TWO HOLDEN.
SEGREGATED CONFIDE.
WHENEVER YOU'RE READY TO GET
THANK YOU MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS AB
TWENTY FIVE WILL ADDRESS THE
OVER SURVEILLANCE AND OVER
REPRESENT OVER REPRESENTATION OF
FAMILIES OF COLOR IN THE CHILD
WELFARE SYSTEM BY REFORMING
MANDATED REPORTING REQUIREMENTS
. MANDATED REPORTING LAWS WERE
ORIGINALLY CREATED TO MANDATE
PHYSICIANS TO REPORT PHYSICAL
ABUSE. AND OVER THE YEARS THESE
REPORTING LAWS HAVE EXPANDED THE
DEFINITION OF REPORTABLE CHILD
ABUSE AND PERSONS REQUIRED TO
REPORT. ALTHOUGH WE ALL INTENDED
DATA SHOWS THAT MANDATED
REPORTING LAWS DO NOT PREVENT
CHILDREN FROM EXPERIENCING
ABUSE. AND THE HIGH VOLUME OF
CALLS THAT THE CHILD WELFARE
HOTLINE RECEIVES HAS CREATED
UNIMAGINABLE CASELOADS FOR
SOCIAL WORKERS. THE HIGHEST RATE
OF CALLS THAT COME INTO THE
CHILD PROTECTION HOTLINE OR THE
CATCH ALL CATEGORY OF GENERAL
NEGLECT IN THIS CATEGORY
PRIMARILY CAPTURES CASES OF
POVERTY AND ECONOMIC
DISADVANTAGE THEY CANNOT BE
EFFECTIVELY RESOLVED BY THE
DIRECT SERVICES OFFERED BY CHILD
PROTECTIVE SERVICES. CHILDREN OF
COLOR ARE SIGNIFICANTLY MORE
LIKELY TO BE REPORTED FOR
ALLEGATIONS OF ABUSE AND NEGLECT
DESPITE THE MAJORITY OF
ALLEGATIONS GOING
UNSUBSTANTIATED. NOT ONLY DOES
THIS RESULT IN UNNECESSARY OVER
SURVEILLANCE OF FAMILIES WHO
CARE FOR THEIR CHILDREN BUT LACK
RELIABLE ACCESS TO CONCRETE
RESOURCES IT ALSO BURDENS TO AN
ALREADY OVERWHELM SYSTEM.
ADDITIONALLY FAMILIES ENTERING
AND INTERACTING WITH CPS RESULTS
IN UNDUE TRAUMA TO PARENTS AND
CHILDREN OFTEN CAUSING NEGLECT
NEGATIVE HEALTH OUTCOMES. I HAVE
ENGAGE WITH STAKEHOLDERS AND
HAVE AMENDED THE BILL TO DO THE
FOLLOWING. RETAIN CURRENT
REPORTING REQUIREMENTS FOR
GENERAL NEGLECT AND ABUSE.
RETAIN EXISTING DEFINITIONS OF
IMMINENT HARM AND REASONABLE
SUSPICIONS. THEREFORE THIS BILL
WILL SIMPLY AMEND THE CHILD
ABUSE AND NEGLECT REPORTING ACT
TO CLARIFY THAT PARENTS ECONOMIC
DISADVANTAGE DOES NOT TRIGGER
GENERAL NEGLECT REPORTING
REQUIREMENTS. THIS BILL INSTEAD
DIRECTS MANDATED REPORTERS TO
USE THEIR DISCRETION AND
TRAINING TO DETERMINE WHETHER
FAMILIES NEED TO BE REPORTED TO
CHILD WELFARE SERVICES OR IF
THEY SIMPLY NEED TO BE CONNECTED
WITH COMMUNITY BASED SERVICES.
BY DOING SO FAMILIES ON THE
VERGE OF BEING CHILD WELFARE
CASES CAN AVOID BEING SUBJECTED
TO SURVEILLANCE BY CPS WHILE
RECEIVING FAMILY STABILIZATION
RESOURCES IN A MORE TIMELY AND
APPROPRIATE MANNER. THESE
CHANGES PROVIDE MANDATED
REPORTERS WITH CLEAR GUIDELINES
FOR REPORTING CASES THAT ARE
LEGITIMATELY IN NEED OF CHILD
WELFARE INTERVENTION WHILE
REDUCING TRAUMA IN FAMILIES AND
UTILIZING MORE APPROPRIATE
RESOURCES TO MEET FAMILY NEEDS.
ON THE PHONE TO TESTIFY IN
SUPPORT OF THIS BILL ARE CHELSEA
REUSS A USE NEGATIVELY IMPACTED
BY OVER REPORTING AND DR KELLY
FONG AT A SO THE SYSTEM
PROFESSOR SOCIOLOGY WITH THE
GEORGIA INSTITUTE. OF TECHNOLOGY
WHOSE RESEARCH FOCUSES ON CHILD
PROTECTIVE SERVICES LIKE TO
THANK THE COMMITTEE AND I
RESPECTFULLY ASK RIVAL. OKAY
THANK YOU AT&T OPERATOR- WOULD
LIKE TO. LIKE TO LISTEN TO THE
SUPPORT WITNESS IF THEY'RE ON
THE LINE. IF YOU HAVE A COMMENT-
PRESS ONE THEN ZERO AND WE'LL GO
TO LINE THIRTY THREE. HI GOOD
MORNING NICOLE MORTAL MAN ON
BEHALF OF THE CHILDREN'S
PARTNERSHIP IN SUPPORT. THANK
YOU WILL GO TO ONE FORTY EIGHT
PLEASE GO AHEAD. PARDON ME THEY
DROPPED OUT AND. THAT'S IT SO
FAR. THIS ORDER. THE ROUTE THIS
YEAR. KELLY FONG IN HERE AS WELL
. WE'LL GO TO LINE. SEVENTY
THREE. WELL. EIGHT GOOD
AFTERNOON MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS OF
THE AFTER BUT THE COUNTY WELFARE
DIRECTORS ASSOCIATION
SIGNIFICANT CONCERN AB TWENTY
EIGHTY FIVE WE SUBMITTED A
LETTER WITH A CONCERNED LOOK
FORWARD TO CONTINUED DISCUSSION
BUT THE AUTHORS OFFER AND STAFF.
THANK YOU. AND THERE ARE NO MORE
COMMENTS AT THIS TIME. THANK YOU
I'M SORRY APPARENTLY YOU HAVE A
WITNESS HERE THAT WOULD LIKE TO
SPEAK TO MAKE PROCEED I'M THE
PRIMARY WITNESSES ACTUALLY ON
THE PHONE. WE ASKED FOR THAT
BUT- EIGHTEEN T. OPERATOR DO WE
HAVE ANYOTHER WITNESSES
SPECIFIC PRIMARY WITNESSES THAT
WOULD LIKE TO SPEAK TO THIS-
BILL. AND WE'LL GO TO LINE ONE
OH FIVE. HI MY NAME IS JENNY
PEARLMAN I'M WITH AN
ORGANIZATION AND FAITH AND FOUND
WHICH IS CHILD ABUSE PREVENTION
ORGANIZATION IN SAN FRANCISCO
AND WE ARE THE CHILD ABUSE
PREVENTION COUNCIL FOR SAN
FRANCISCO. I'M I'M SPEAKING IN
OPPOSITION OF THE BALLOT
CURRENTLY RIGHT ABSOLUTELY THE
PORT THE BILL'S INTENT TO REDUCE
THE OVER REPORTING OVER
SURVEILLANCE RELATED TO ISSUES
OF POVERTY- WHICH IS NOT A
REPORTABLE ISSUE HERE- TO CHILD
WELFARE WHAT WE SHOULD BE
CONCERNED ABOUT IS THE SAFETY OF
THE CHILD- BUT AS YOU'VE WRITTEN
THE LANGUAGE THAT. PROVIDES AN
EXCEPTION TO THIS ALLOWING-
SAYING THAT IT IS A GROUP
MANDATED REPORT IF THERE IS-ARE
THERE ARE SERVICES AVAILABLE AND
THE FAMILY REFUSES SERVICES. WE
ALL KNOW THAT FAMILIES DO NOT
SEEK SERVICES MULTIPLE REASONS
INCLUDING THEIR- IMMIGRATION
STATUS THEIR PRIOR NEGATIVE
EXPERIENCES WITH SERVICES. OVER
SURVEILLANCE BE RACISM. THAT
EXIST. I'M FOR- AND SO. AS
WRITTEN THE KERN BILL ACT HAVE
THE- EFFECT AND- IN REPORT BY.
SERVICE PROVIDERS IN INSTANCES
WHERE WHAT THE NEEDS IS SUPPORT
- AND FELT AS CURRENTLY RIGHT- I
SUPPOSE. THANK YOU. MISTER
MISTER CHAIRMAN WE HAVE TO BE
WOULDN'T. AND IT'S MY THAT THERE
ARE THE PHONE. WHY BY. CHELSEA
AND K. SO WE'RE- WELL WE HAD WE
DIDN'T EVEN GET TO THE PRIMARY
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT. ASIA NO
THE OPERATOR AT THE START WITH
WHAT YEAH IT WAS ALL OUT OF
ORDER. YEAH. NAMES ARE ALL WHEEL
DRIVE RIGHT YEAH. THEY THEY-
IT'S UNDERSTANDING THAT THERE ON
THE LINE I'VE BEEN GIVEN A NOTE
THAT THERE ON THE LINE. FOR YES
THERE MY WITNESSES.
WE DO HAVE TWO LINES THAT ARE IN
Q. WOULD YOU LIKE TO TAKE THEM.
ALL RIGHT WE'LL GO. TO ONE
SEVENTY SIX- HELLO MY NAME IS
WHAT TO BE HONEST FEDERAL WHICH
UP. HI THIS IS JANICE WEBER WOOD
CHILDREN'S LAWCENTER OF
CALIFORNIA AS BOND COPONSORED
THE BILL IN STRONG SUPPORT THANK
YOU. SO EIGHTEEN TOTAL LINE ONE
SEVENTY SEVEN. CAN STONE OF
STONE ADVOCACY ON BEHALF THE
CALIFORNIA DISTRICT ATTORNEYS
ASSOCIATION WITH THE AMENDMENTS
WE ARE MOVING OUR OPPOSITION.
THANK YOU WE STILL HAVE TWO
WITNESSES TO SUPPOSED TO TESTIFY
ON THE PHONE IN SUPPORT ONE'S
NAME KELLY FONG WHEN DAVE
CHELSEA BRUCE. AT&T OPERATE DO
YOU HAVE THEM. KELSEY IF YOU ARE
ON THE LINE PLEASE PRESS ONE AND
THEN ZERO AT THIS TIME. AND ALSO
KELLY KELLY YES THIS IS KELLY
FONG CAN YOU HEAR ME YES WE CAN
HEAR YOU. GO AHEAD DO YOU HAVE A
WONDERFUL YEAH SORRY ABOUT THAT
AND THANK YOU ALL FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY TO SPEAK WITH YOU%
TODAY SO. MY NAME IS KELLY FONG
I'M AN ASSISTANT PROFESSOR AT
THE THEOLOGY AND CHURCH ATTACK
AND I SUPPORT AB TWENTY FIVE
TWENTY EIGHTY FIVE AS AMENDED
BECAUSE BASED ON MY EXTENSIVE
RESEARCH ON THE CHILD WELFARE
SYSTEM. I THINK THIS LEGISLATION
AS A WAY TO IMPROVE CHILD WELL
BEING IN CALIFORNIA PARTICULARLY
FOR CHILDREN OF COLOR AND LOW
INCOME CHILDREN. SO OUR GOAL
SHOULD BE ENSURING CHILDREN'S
SAFETY RATHER THAN CREATING PDF
REPORTS FOR THE SAKE OF CREATING
REPORT. IN MY RESEARCH SUGGESTS
THAT EXCLUDING SITUATIONS OF
POVERTY FROM REPORTING MANDATE.
ACTUALLY MAKES CHILDREN
WORKSPACE AND BEFORE I GET INTO
HOW THE LEGISLATION WILL DO
THAT. IT'S IMPORTANT TO NOTE
THAT MANDATED REPORTERS. CAN
STILL REPORT ANY SITUATION THEY
FEEL ARE CONCERNING. INTEREST
LEGISLATION SIMPLY CLARIFIED
THAT THEY CAN USE THEIR
PROFESSIONAL JUDGMENT IN
SITUATIONS RELATED TO POVERTY.
SO THEY CAN BRING CONCERNS IT'S
- ATTENTION. AND WHAT BUDGET AND
CAN IN REDUCE AND- REPORT. HOW
DOES THAT HELP CHILDREN THE
FIRST AS A MEMBER HOLDEN
INDICATED. IT CAN REDUCE FAMILY
STRESS SO AS MOTHERS I
INTERVIEWED SHARED WITH ME. AT
THE REALLY CARE AND- IN
THEMSELVES EVEN WHEN THEY'RE
PROMPTLY CLOSED- SECOND AS THE
PARTY STATED AS WELL HIS WORKERS
ARE ALREADY FRIENDS. AND SO
REDUCING UNNECESSARY REPORT CAN
FOCUSED FOR HER ATTENTION ON
HIGHER RISK CASES. AND THIRD
REDUCING UNNECESSARY REPORTS CAN
ENCOURAGE AND MAINTAIN FAMILY
CONNECTIONS WITH NEEDED
RESOURCES. CHOI INTERVIEWED MANY
PARENTS WHO REPORTED BY MANDATED
REPORTER AND OVER HALF OF THEM
DESCRIBE NEGATIVE CONSEQUENCES
FOR THEY WERE THEIR RELATIONSHIP
WITH THE SUPPORTERS EVEN WHEN
PPL DID NOT IDENTIFY THE KEY
CONCERNS. SO AFTER REPORTS MON
WHICH DOCTORS THEY CANCELED
SOCIAL SERVICE PROGRAMS THAT
CHANGE SCHOOL. EVEN PROACTIVELY
ANTICIPATING POTENTIAL REPORTS
FROM MANDATED REPORTERS THEY HAD
THE DATA TO SHARE THINGS LIKE
HOMELESSNESS AND MENTAL HEALTH
IN. THE DENSELY CUTTING OFF
CRITICAL SOURCES OF SUPPORT FOR
CHILDREN AND I PROVIDED SOME
EXAMPLES IN THE LETTER OF
SUPPORT THAT I SUBMITTED. SO AND
I HOPE YOU WILL SUPPORT EIGHTY
TWENTY EIGHTY FIVE AS AMENDED TO
PROMOTE THE SAFETY AND WELL
BEING OF CALIFORNIA'S CHILDREN
THANKS SO MUCH FOR YOUR
CONSIDERATION. THANK YOU IN
EIGHTEEN T. OPERATE DO YOU HAVE
CHELSEA. REUSS. WE'LL GO TO LINE
ONE SEVENTY NINE. YES I'M HERE.
THIS CHELSEA WAS RUTH YES YEAH
MAYBE GET. OKAY HELLO EVERYBODY
GOOD MORNING MY NAME IS CHELSEA
ROUTE MY SON'S NAME IS
BACKGROUND THAT BEING WITHDRAWN
ON DECEMBER TWENTIETH TWO
THOUSAND FOURTEEN AND GOVERNMENT
BOTH TODAY. WHEN I WAS PREGNANT
WITH ZACH I WAS SEVENTEEN YEARS
OLD AND DOCTOR HOME AND LIVING
IN A GROUP HOME FOR EXPECTING
PARENTS THINK BOCKIUS UNLOCKED
ANGELES. IF THAT COULD BORE I
HAVE BEEN DOING WELL. I WAS ON
TRACK TO GROW HIGH WITH ALL. AND
I HAD ONE AWARD FROM BEHAVIOR AT
THE GROUP HOME. ALTHOUGH NONE OF
THIS I WAS EXCITED TO BE A MOM
BUT AFTER THAT COULD BORN THINGS
CHANGED. DURING SIX MONTHS
BETWEEN BACK BIRTH AND WHEN I
VOLUNTARILY LEFT THE GROUPON.
GROUPON STAFF AND ALL MANDATED
REPORTERS. CALLED IN NINE CHILD
ABUSE REPORT AGAINST ME. MY
THERAPIST MADE A REPORT WHEN I
TOLD HER THAT I WAS NERVOUS
BEATING BACK BECAUSE HE WAS SO
SMALL AT THE VERY. THE GROUP
HOME FAX QUALITY REPORT
TRANSACTION FELL ASLEEP ON MY
CHEST IN THE BAND. AND THEY CALL
BECAUSE THEY. THOUGHT I WOULD
BACKING BACK TO HARD. I HOPE OUT
. MAY BE RECORDED. ME BECAUSE
THE LAW REQUIRES THEM TO. IN THE
CASE MY THERAPIST THAT SHE ME
THAT SHE CAN WNT TO REPORT BUT
WAS A PART TWO. ONE OF THE
REPORTERS HELP ME I DID NOT GET
HELP ON BAKER MY SON OR GUIDANCE
ON HOW TO BIRD M. OR SUPPORT
PAKISTAN TRACK WITH SCHOOL AND
PARENTS. IN FACT NAY REPORT
ALLEGED AYE BERMAN BONTA ON ARCH
HE WAS FORCED TO UNDERGO A FULL
BODY X. BRING. WHEN IF BROWN'S
HAD NO. THE REPORT WITH CLOSE. I
KNOW POINT TO ANYBODY NOT THE
RECORDER RECORDER FOR OR THE
POST MARKET CONTENT THE GATED IT
STAYED DOWN WITH ME AND SHOW ME
PROJECTION CONVERT. AFTER SIX
MONTHS OF THIS I WAS TERRIFIED.
I DID NOT THINK I COULD TRUST
ANY SERVICE PROVIDER AND I DID
ALL MY FRONT END UP IN FOSTER
CARE SYSTEM THAT I HAD
EXPERIENCED MYSELF. SO I AGREED
TO LET MY FRIENDS TO LIVE WITH
HIS. PATERNAL GRANDPARENTS AND
THEN I BECAME HOMELESS I WAS
ABLE TO STABILIZE MY LIFE AFTER
A FEW MONTHS BUT I WAS HORRIFIED
TO LEARN EXACT PATERNAL
GRANDPARENTS WERE GRANTED
GUARDIANSHIP IN A PRIVATE
CUSTODY PROCEEDING I USED OTHER
PORT MADE AGAINST ME EVEN THOUGH
ALL WERE UNFOUNDED ACT PROVED
THAT I COULD NOT CARE FOR MY
SON. IT WOULD NOT HAVE HAPPENED
IF I HAD RECEIVED SUPPORT IN NOT
REPORT. WHEN I NEEDED IT. I WAS
EXPECTED TO PAY MY BILL LIKE I
HAVE ALL THE HOW AND WE- IN THE-
IN REALITY I WAS PLEASED TO
AGREE COMPANY NO HELP OR SUPPORT
EVEN FROM THE PEOPLE. TO PROVIDE. ASSEMBLY BILL TWO ZERO EIGHT.
WOULD ME REPORTERS BECAUSE- NEW
DEBATE EVERYTHING THAT OF OUR-
BENEFITS. HE RESTARTED SET OF AN
HOWEVER AND FACE PAPA OF SEPT
FROM THE CHILDREN FOR THE REASON
I AM MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE TO
SUPPORT THIS BILL THANK YOU.
THANK NOW. EIGHTEEN T. DO WE
FROM ALL THE WHICH- IN. THE OF
THE EIGHTEEN T. LINE. WE HAVE
ONE LINE LINE ONE SEVENTY NINE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. BY NUMBER
SEVENTY THREE PLEASE GO AHEAD.%
MY NUMBER SEVENTY THREE YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. I GUESS WE HAVE NO
ONE IN Q. OKAY AND I DON'T KNOW
WHERE WE ARE DO WE DO IN
OPPOSITION ON INSIDE THE ROOM.
WE DO SUPPORT INSIDE THE ROOM.
WHAT SUPPORT INSIDE THE ROOM. I
THOUGHT WE DID SUPPORT INSIDE
THE ROOM OKAY SUPPORT INSIDE THE
ROOM BAKER KRAMER MATTER ON
BEHALF OF A CELL YOU CALIFORNIA
ACTION IN STRONG SUPPORT THANK
YOU COULD ANY OTHER SUPPORT
INSIDE THE ROOM. ANY OPPOSITION. CNN ANY OPPOSITION ALL WAY. AT
EIGHT EIGHTEEN T. OPERATOR OPEN
UP THE LINE FOR OPPOSITION.
MAYBE WE'VE ALREADY HEARD IT BUT
I JUST WANNA MAKE SURE W DON'T
LEAVE ANYBODY OUT. THANK YOU IF
YOU HAVE ANY OPPOSITION TO THE
BILL PLEASE PRESS ONE THEN ZERO
AND FIRST WE HAVE NINE SEVENTY
THREE. PLEASE GO AHEAD WHAT.
SUPPORT HERE. NINE THREE HEREBY
AND SO. YOU CAN CLEAR. RIGHT I'M
- HELLO OUR USER OPPOSITION. AND
FOR THANK YOU AND WHO ARE YOU
AND WHAT ORGANIZATION. GOOD
MORNING HELLO MY NAME IS. AND I
AM CALLING ON. WE LOOK VERY GOOD
FOR PREGNANT WHEN SHE AND COURT
A YOU. A ARE IN. OKAY WE HAVE
WHY EIGHTY PLEASE GO. HELLO NAME
IS JOHN MOORLACH APOLOGY I WITH
LEGAL FOR PRISONERS WITH
CHILDREN COMMON IN SUPPORT OF AB
TWO ZERO EIGHT FIVE THANK YOU.
YOU. AND NEXT WE HAVE NINE ONE
SEVEN EIGHT PLEASE GO AHEAD.
THREE ONE SEVEN EIGHT YOUR LINE
IS OPEN OKAY HELLO MY NAME IS
GENERAL SOME WITH ALL OF US ARE
NOT SACRAMENTO. IN SUPPORT. WELL
IN THIS BILL THANK. AND I HAVE
NO ONE ELSE THANK YOU THANK YOU
BRING ABOUT TO COMMITTEE FOR
QUESTION MISTER CORK- POVERTY
SHOULD NOT BE A CHRONIC. AND
WITH THE VERY CAREFUL AMENDMENTS
THAT YOU'VE THAT YOU'VE PUT A
AND YOU HAVE THE SUPPORT OF FOR
EXAMPLE THE CATHOLIC CONFERENCE
- AND THIS IS AN ORGANIZATION
THAT REALLY CARES ABOUT KIDS
THERE IS NO QUESTION IN MY MIND
AND- THEIR SUPPORT AND YOUR
AMENDMENT HAS CONVINCED ME THAT
THIS IS A VERY GOOD BILL. THANK
YOU. THANK YOU. BONTA DID YOU DO
YOU HAVE A COMMENT STYLE.
SELECCI YEAH I RESPECTFULLY I
MUST- OPPOSES BILL I APPRECIATE
THAT THERE'S MUCH WORK TO BE
DONE REGARD MAKING OUR SYSTEM
SEE THE STRENGTHS OF FAMILIES
ACROSS CULTURES AND
CIRCUMSTANCE. FURTHER I AGREE
THAT WE NEED IN OUR GREAT
COMMUNITY BASED ORGANIZATIONS.
TO ALLEVIATE DESPERATION RELATED
TO POVERTY. UNFORTUNATELY I
DISAGREE WITH THE APPROACH TO.
RELIEVE THESE COMMUNITIES FOR
SCRUTINY. ARE MANDATED REPORTERS
SHOULD BE EMPOWERED TO SAY
SOMETHING WHEN THEY SEE
SOMETHING. THIS POLICY ADDS
LAYERS OF PROCESS WHICH ARE
COMMONPLACE FOR SOCIAL WORKER
WOULD NOT BE COMPLETED BY A
TEACHER OR COACH. IN MY
COMMUNITY WE'VE LOST THREE BOYS
TO SEVERE CHILD ABUSE. GABER
FERNANDES NOR. ANTHONY OF LOS. I
LOOK CLOSELY AT THEIR CASES AND
ALL OF THESE REPORTS PROVIDED
THE CONTEXT FOR WHAT WENT WRONG
ON A SYSTEMATIC LEVEL. IT'S ONLY
WITH THAT INFORMATION THAT WE
CONSERVE OUR CHILDREN BETTER SO
FORTUNATE WILL BE ABLE TO
SUPPORT. THANK YOU ANY MORE
COMMON YOU MAY CLOSE. WELL FIRST
OF ALL I THINK THE COMMITTEE-
FOR. ARE YOUR REVIEW AND YOUR
ANALYSIS ON THE BILL- AS DR
COWORKERS POINTED OUT ONCE AGAIN
WE TRY VERY HARD TO ADDRESS WHAT
WE BELIEVE OUR CONCERNS I WOULD
APPRECIATE THE VICE CHAIR OR
ANYONE ELSE WHO HAS SPECIFIC
IDEAS ON HOW WE MIGHT INTEGRATE
THEIR THOUGHTS THE TAKEN FROM. I
CAN'T SUPPORT TO ADDRESS IT IN A
MAYBE A POSITIVE WAY OF HOW WE
CUT YOU CAN. OF BECAUSE WE ARE
TRYING TO ADDRESS THE SITUATION
RIGHT NOW CHILDREN ARE FINE AND
FAMILIES ARE FINDING THEMSELVES-
IN A DESPERATE SET OF SITUATIONS
WHERE THEY CAN BE. PUT ON A PATH
WHERE THE CHILDREN ARE GETTING
THE RIGHT KIND OF SUPPORT THAT
THEY NEED BUT THEY'RE GETTING
CAUGHT UP IN A SYSTEM THAT THEY
DON'T NECESSARILY NEED TO BE A-
AND WOULD LIKE TO THINK THAT-
THIS BILL. WILL DO SOME
IMPORTANT- CAREFULLY THOUGHT OUT
THOUGHTFUL REFORMS THAT ALLOW US
TO MOVE FRWARD IN A PRODUCTIVE
MORE PRODUCIVE WAY SO I
RESPECTFULLY ASK HER I. YES WE
NEED A MOTION AND A SECOND SHOW
MOVED BACK. GROUP CALDERON AN
EIGHTY TWENTY EIGHTY FIVE BY
SEVEN MEMBER HOLDEN THE MOTION
IS TO PASS TO THE APPROPRIATIONS
COMMITTEE JONES SAWYER HI JONES
SAWYER HI LACKEY LACKEY KNOLL
BONTA HI BONTA HI BRIAN BRIAN I
WORK I WORK HI SAN DIEGO.
SEYARTO THE OUR TURN NOW. A
MEASURE CALLED NEEDS ONE MORE
NOW GO TO A. B. NUMBER ITEM
NUMBER NINE AB TWENTY SIX THIRTY
TWO. SEGREGATED COMBINED. THANK
COMMITTEE FOR THE OPPORTUNITY
PRESENTED AB TWENTY SIX THIRTY
TWO THE CALIFORNIA MENDELL ACT
ON SOLITARY CONFINEMENT DESPITE
THE VOLUMES OF RESEARCH THAT
SHOWS HOW SOLITARY CONFINEMENT
CAUSES DEEP PSYCHOLOGICAL AND
PHYSICAL HARM IT REMAINS COMMON
IN JAILS PRISONS DETENTION
CENTERS AND FACILITIES ACROSS.
CALIFORNIA IN FACT THE CURRENT
CONSENSUS AMONG MENTAL HEALTH
EXPERTS HUMAN RIGHTS
ORGANIZATIONS THE UNITED NATIONS
IS THAT PROLONGED SOLITARY
CONFINEMENT AMOUNTS TO TORTURE.
IN TWO THOUSAND SIXTEEN THE
NATIONAL COMMISSION ON
CORRECTIONAL HEALTH CARE STATED
THAT A PERIOD OF CONFINEMENT
BEYOND FIFTEEN CONSECUTIVE DAYS
IS INHUMANE. DEGRADING TREATMENT
AND HARMFUL TO INDIVIDUALS
HEALTH. THE LACK OF HUMAN
CONTACT AND ENLISTMENT MARC
MONOTONY CAUSES DEEP DEPRESSION
PARANOIA AND SOME EVEN SUFFER
HALLUCINATIONS OTHERS EXPERIENCE
LARGE FLUCTUATIONS IN WEIGHT AND
CHRONIC PAIN AND DUE TO ITS
EXTREME EXTREMELY RESTRICTIVE
CONDITIONS CHRONIC HEALTH
CONDITIONS EITHER GO UNTREATED
OR ARE MISTREATED. AB TWENTY SIX
THIRTY TWO PROVIDES A CLEAR
DEFINITION OF WHAT CONSTITUTES
SOLITARY CONFINEMENT ACROSS ALL
FACILITIES IN CALIFORNIA AND
IMPOSES STRICT LIMITS ON HOW IT
CAN BE USED. ADDITIONALLY THIS
BILL WILL PROHIBIT THE USE OF
SOLITARY CONFINEMENT FOR AUDIBLE
POPULATIONS SUCH AS PREGNANT
WOMEN AND THOSE WITH
INTELLECTUAL DISABILITIES. TO
STATE THE OBVIOUS PEOPLE WHO
NEED SPECIALIZED CARE SHOULD NOT
BE LOCKED IN A ROOM THE SIZE OF
A KING SIZE BED WITHOUT ACCESS
TO THE SERVICES THEY NEED. AB
TWENTY SIX THIRTY TWO PER ALSO
PROVIDES IMPORTANT PROTECTIONS
FOR THOSE PLACED IN SOLITARY
CONFINEMENT. AN EXAMPLE. CURRENT
REGULATIONS ALLOW THE USE OF
FOOD AND NUTRITION AS AN
ADDITIONAL LEVER OF PUNISHMENT
FOR CONFINED INDIVIDUALS THIS
BILL DISALLOWS THAT. MANY TIMES
WE LIKE TO BOAST THE CALIFORNIA
THAT AS CALIFORNIA GOES SO GOES
THE NATION BUT WE ARE BEHIND IN
SETTING CLEAR STANDARDS ON THE
USE OF SOLITARY CONFINEMENT.
SEVERAL STATES INCLUDING NEW
YORK AND COLORADO HAVE ALREADY
TAKEN THIS CRITICAL STEP.
CALIFORNIA'S JOIN THE STATE'S IN
THE INTERNATIONAL COMMUNITY TO
SET CLEAR STANDARDS AND LIMITS
ON THE USE OF SOLITARY
CONFINEMENT. THIS BEGINS BY
RECOGNIZING THAT PROLONGED
SOLITARY CONFINEMENT IS TORTURE
AND SETTING UNIFORM AND
CONSISTENT LIMITS ON HOW
SOLITARY CONFINEMENT ISSUES IS
AN ALL DETENTION FACILITIES.
HERE WITH ME TO TESTIFY IN
SUPPORT OF AB SIX TWENTY SIX
THIRTY TWO IS ERIC HARRIS WITH
DISABILITY RIGHTS CALIFORNIA AND
KEVIN MCCARTY WHO WILL SPEAK TO
THE IMPACT SOLITARY CONFINEMENT
HAS HAD ON HIS LIFE. AHMED YAZAN
IS ALSO HERE TO ANSWER TECHNICAL
QUESTIONS ON THE BILL I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR I.
BOATS. GETTING GENERALLY GET
FIVE MINUTES AND WHERE WERE YOU
GOING TO BREAK IT UP IS FINE.
THANK YOU. GOOD MORNING TURN
MEMBERS. MY NAME IS ERIC HARRIS
AND I AM THE DIRECTOR OF PUBLIC
POLICY AT DISABILITY RIGHTS
CALIFORNIA. A STATEWIDE
NONPROFIT PROTECTION ADVOCACY
ORGANIZATION THAT ADVOCATES ON
BEHALF OF ALL PEOPLE WITH
DISABILITIES IN THE STATE. WE
ARE PART OF A COALITION OF PROUD
CO SPONSORS OF AB TWENTY SIX
THIRTY TWO. WE WORK IN JAILS
JUVENILE FACILITIES AND
DETENTION CENTERS TO IMPROVE
CONDITIONS ELIMINATE UNNECESSARY
ISOLATION AND SEGREGATION AND
SECURE ADEQUATE MEDICAL AND
MENTAL HEALTH TREATMENT FOR
THOSE WHO ARE INCARCERATED.
SOLITARY CONFINEMENT IS TORTURE
AND A PRIORITY ISSUE FOR DRC
BECAUSE OF ITS HARMFUL IMPACT ON
DISABLED PEOPLE WHO AS A GROUP
ARE DISPROPORTIONATELY SUBJECT
TO ITS USE. WE'VE LITIGATED
OBTAIN CONSENT DECREES WITH
JAILS AND AGO SHARED WITH
IMMIGRATION DETENTION OPERATORS
TO LIMIT ITS USE. MOST RECENTLY
WE SERVED ON THE EXECUTIVE
STEERING STEERING COMMITTEE AND
WORKING GROUPS OF THE BOARD AND
STATE COMMUNITY CORRECTIONS FOR
THE TITLE FIFTEEN JAILS
REGULATION REVISION TO LIMIT
SOLITARY CONFINEMENT. BUT WERE
UNABLE TO GET THE NECESSARY
REFORMS THROUGH THAT PROCESS WE
HAVE CONCLUDED THAT CALIFORNIA
NEEDS A STATEWIDE COMPREHENSIVE
LEGISLATIVE SOLUTION TO END THE
SOLITARY CONFINEMENT OF PEOPLE
WITH DISABILITIES IN JAILS
PRISONS AND IMMIGRATION
DETENTION CENTERS. SOLITARY
CONFINEMENT IS A PRACTICE THAT
DOES NOT REHABILITATE BUT CAUSES
HARM ESPECIALLY TO VULNERABLE
POPULATIONS. SOLITARY
CONFINEMENT IS NOT AN EFFECTIVE
TOOL TO MANAGE VIOLENCE IN A IN
CORSO. AND CARCERAL SETTINGS.
RATHER SOLITARY CONFINEMENT
EXACERBATES THESE ISSUES
RESEARCH SHOWS THE SOLITARY
CONFINEMENT DOES NOT MAKE JAILS
OR PRISONS SAFER NOR DOES IT
IMPROVE PUBLIC SAFETY OUTCOMES
BECAUSE EXPOSURE TO SOLITARY
CONFINEMENT HAS BEEN PROVEN TO
INCREASE RECIDIVISM IN SOME
CASES. THE CO SPONSORS OF THIS
BILL ALSO VIEW SOLITARY
CONFINEMENT AS A RACIAL JUSTICE
ISSUE. SOLITARY CONFINEMENT IS
MOST OFTEN USED AGAINST PEOPLE
OF COLOR ESPECIALLY BLACK AND
LATIN NEXT PEOPLE. ALTHOUGH THE
STATISTICS ARE NOT RELEASE TO
THE PUBLIC RESEARCHERS ESTIMATE
THAT BETWEEN EIGHTY FIVE AND 90%
OF PEOPLE IN SOLITARY
CONFINEMENT ARE PEOPLE OF COLOR
. WE NEED AB TWENTY SIX THIRTY
TWO A BILL THAT WOULD BAN
SOLITARY CONFINEMENT FOR
VULNERABLE POPULATIONS SUCH AS
INDIVIDUALS WITH DISABILITIES
PREGNANT WOMEN YOUTH AND THE
ELDERLY. PROHIBIT LONG TERM
SOLITARY SEGREGATED CONFINEMENT
BY LIMITING THE TIME SPENT IN
CONFINEMENT TO NOT MORE THAN
FIFTEEN DAYS CONSECUTIVE DAYS OR
FORTY DAYS AND ONE HUNDRED AND
EIGHTY DAY PERIOD. AND REQUIRE
FACILITIES TO KEEP CLEAR RECORDS
OF THE USE OF SOLITARY
CONFINEMENT IN ORDER TO PROVIDE
PUBLIC TRANSPARENCY AND
ACCOUNTABILITY. THE CO SPONSORS
OF THIS BILL HAVE HAD
CONVERSATIONS WITH LAW
ENFORCEMENT AND BELIEVE THAT WE
CAN COME TO A COMMON GROUND ON
THIS BILL. CALIFORNIA WOULD JOIN
OTHER STATES LIKE NEW YORK AND
COLORADO WHICH HAVE PASSED
SIMILAR BILLS. AB TWENTY SIX
THIRTY TWO WOULD HELP CALIFORNIA
SET CLEAR STANDARDS AND LIMITS
ON THE USE OF SOLITARY
CONFINEMENT IN JAILS PRISONS AND
DETENTION CENTERS. THANK YOU AND
WE REQUEST YOUR AYE VOTE. THANK
YOU GOOD. GREETINGS HONORABLE
CHAIR MEMBERS MY NAME IS KEVIN
MCCARTHY I'M AN UNDERGRADUATE OF
LEGAL STUDIES AND A MEMBER OF
THE UNDERGROUND SCHOLARS AT UC
BERKELEY I SPENT A TOTAL OF
TWENTY TWO YEARS INCARCERATED
AND ROUGHLY TWELVE YEARS IN
SOLITARY CONFINEMENT INCLUDING
TWO YEARS IN SOLITARY
CONFINEMENT AS A JUVENILE. MY
FIRST EXPERIENCE OF SOLITARY
CONFINEMENT TOOK PLACE WHEN I
WAS SENT TO THE CALIFORNIA YOUTH
AUTHORITY. I NEED TREATMENT FOR
ADDICTION BUT INSTEAD WAS GIVEN
SOLITARY CONFINEMENT. ONCE A
WEEK WE WERE GIVEN ONE NOVEL
FIVE PIECES OF PAPER AND A
PENCIL. TALKING TO OUR NEIGHBORS
WHILE IN OURSELVES WAS
PROHIBITED WE CAN ONLY TALK TO
OTHER PEOPLE WHEN WE WERE GIVEN
ONE HOUR OUTSIDE IN THE EXERCISE
CAGE. USUALLY I FINISH MY WEEKLY
NOVEL IN A COUPLE OF DAYS AND
BECAME SO DESPERATE TO TALKING
HERE SOUND. THAT WOULD ASK
MYSELF QUESTIONS AND THEN
RESPOND OUT LOUD. I WOULD ALSO
RECITE EVERY MEMORY THAT I COULD
REMEMBER SENSE BIRTH JUST AS A
WAY TO GET MY MIND TO DO
SOMETHING. SOMETIMES I WOULD
JUST SIT THERE AND CRY OUT OF
FRUSTRATION. ALL GOING TO SPEND
A TOTAL OF TWENTY THREE MONTHS
IN SOLITARY CONFINEMENT BEFORE I
WAS PAROLED. BUT NOT BEFORE I
SAW TWO PEOPLE COMMIT SUICIDE IN
SOLITARY IN MANY OTHERS MAKE
SUICIDE ATTEMPTS. ONCE I WAS OUT
I FELT SO MUCH ANGER AND
ANIMOSITY ESPECIALLY TOWARDS
FIGURES OF AUTHORITY. I AVOIDED
PEOPLE AND DID NOT LIKE TALKING
TO ANYONE. SOLITARY CONFINEMENT
IS A VICIOUS ASSAULT UPON ONE'S
PSYCHE AND SOUL. IT IS A FORM OF
SPIRITUAL EMOTIONAL AND
PSYCHOLOGICAL TORTURE. HOW CAN
WE PROHIBIT PHYSICAL VIOLENCE
UNDER THE EIGHTH AMENDMENT BUT
NOT STOP VIOLENCE AGAINST THE
MINE. I WOULD HAVE PREFERRED A
PHYSICAL BEATING IN LIEU OF
SOLITARY CONFINEMENT. BRUISES
AND CUTS ON MY BODY HEAL BUT THE
ONES IN MY MIND AND SOUL HAVE
ONLY BECOME INFECTED AND
CONTINUE TO HARM ME. WHEN I WAS
IN SOLITARY THE GUARD'S FAVORITE
RESPONSE WAS THEY DON'T MAKE THE
LAW THEY JUST FOLLOW IT. THIS
LEGISLATURE MAKES THE LAW AND
HAS THE OPPORTUNITY TO STOP
TORTURE. AND SAVE LIVES THROUGH
THIS BILL I STAND BEFORE YOU
TODAY HAS A TESTAMENT TO THE
HORSS SOLITARY CONFINEMENT AND
ALSO AS PROOF THAT PEOPLE CAN
CHANGE THEIR LIVES. THERE IS
NOTHING THAT THE STATE CAN DO TO
RESTORE ME AND OTHER VICTIMS OF
SOLITARY CONFINEMENT. BUT THIS
LEGISLATURE CAN PROTECT FUTURE
GENERATIONS FROM EXPERIENCING
THIS PERMANENT HARM RGS
COMMITTEE TO GIVE A YES VOTE
THANK YOU. THANK YOU. ARE THERE
ANY OTHER WITNESSES IN SUPER
COURT NAME AN ORGANIZATION.
MARCO GEORGE ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA PUBLIC DEFENDERS
ASSOCIATION AND SUPPORT. KAREN
MEMBER SALLY HANDED ON WITH WHAT
I MEAN TO REPRESENT NEXT IN
CALIFORNIA PROUD SPONSORS IN
SUPPORT THANK YOU. THAT HASHEM
IS YOUR FIRST MY DRESSES
CALIFORNIA STRONG SUPPORT THANK
YOU. JACKIE GONZALEZ IMMIGRANT
DEFENSE ADVOCATES A PROUD CO
SPONSOR ALSO HERE IN SUPPORT OF
CALIFORNIA IMMIGRANT POLICY
CENTER AND CALIFORNIA
INDIVISIBLE STAYED STRONG THANK
YOU. SERIK ME ON BEHALF OF
INITIATE JUSTICE A PROUD CO
SPONSOR IN STRONG SUPPORT.
MARGOT MENDELSON WITH PRISON LAW
OFFICE A PROUD CO SPONSOR IN
SUPPORT. GLENN BACKUS ELLA BAKER
CENTER FOR HUMAN RIGHTS IN
STRONG SUPPORT. FRED WILLIAMS
ACLU CONTACTS IN IN SUPPORT.
THANK YOU NOW WE HAVE WITNESSES
IN OPPOSITION. A WITNESS
OPPOSITION ROOM AT JENNIFER
COULD YOU MAKE ROOM SO THEY CAN
. THE THREAT. BUT. THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIR AND COMMITTEE
MEMBERS MY NAME IS MATTHEW
EASILY RIP SINGING CALIFORNIA
CORRECTIONAL PEACE OFFICERS
ASSOCIATION IN OPPOSITION TO AB
TWENTY SIX THIRTY TWO. THE
REGARDING SEGREGATED
CONFINEMENT. CCPOA HAS MAJOR
ISSUES WITH THE LIMITATIONS ON
SEGREGATED CONFINEMENT THAT ARE
CONTAINED IN AB TWENTY SIX
THIRTY TWO. THESE LIMITATIONS
MAY CREATE SERIOUS SAFETY ISSUES
FOR OUR OFFICERS AND THE INMATES
WITHIN THE PRISON SYSTEM. MOST
OF THE INVOLUNTARY PLACEMENTS IN
WHAT IS CURRENTLY REFERRED TO AS
ADMINISTRATIVE SEGREGATION OR
SECURITY HOUSING UNITS ARE
INMATES WHO HAVE COMMITTED NEW
SERIOUS INFRACTIONS WHICH ARE
TYPICALLY VIOLENT CRIMES SUCH AS
ASSAULT MURDER RAPE OR ATTEMPT
THEREOF. WELL INCARCERATED.
FORCING THE DEPARTMENT TO
RELEASE THESE INDIVIDUALS FROM
SEGREGATED CONFINEMENT AFTER
ONLY FIFTEEN DAYS. COULD PLACE
OUR OFFICERS AND OTHER INMATES
AT SERIOUS RISK OF HARM. THAT
POTENTIAL RISK ONLY INCREASES
WITH THE BILL MAXIMIZING ITS USE
TO NO MORE THAN FORTY FIVE DAYS
WITHIN A ONE HUNDRED EIGHTY DAY
PERIOD. THE BILL GOES FAR BEYOND
TARGETED REFORMS TO ADDRESS ANY
MISUSES OF SEGREGATED
CONFINEMENT. AND THROWS OUT ANY
EFFECTIVE USE NO MATTER THE
REASON FOR PLACEMENT. WHEN
INMATE SHOWS A PROPENSITY FOR
CONTINUED VIOLENCE AGAINST OTHER
INMATES FORCING THEM BACK INTO
THE GENERAL POPULATION TOO
EARLY. WILL ONLY RESULT IN
FURTHER A FURTHER VIOLENCE
PERPETRATED ON INMATES AND
CORRECTIONAL OFFICERS. INMATES
WHO HAVE ATTEMPTED OR SUCCEEDED
IN MURDERING THEIR CELLMATES
WOULD HAVE TO BE PLACED BACK
INTO THE POPULATION TO WHICH
THEY POSE A RISK. AS FAR AS OUR
OFFICERS ARE CONCERNED EVEN WHEN
TACK ATTACKS ARE NOT DIRECTED AT
THE OFFICERS. ANY VIOLENCE
WITHIN A PRISON FACILITY POSES A
DANGER TO THEM WHEN THEY
INTERVENE. IT STANDS TO REASON
THAT REMOVING EXCEPTIONALLY
DANGEROUS INDIVIDUALS FROM
ACCESS TO THEIR POTENTIAL
VICTIMS. PROMOTES A MORE
GENERALLY STABLE ENVIRONMENT FOR
EVERYONE ELSE INMATES AND
OFFICERS ALIKE. ANOTHER
TROUBLING RESULT OF AB TWENTY
SIX THIRTY TWO IS THE INABILITY
OF CDCR TO VOLUNTARILY PLACE AN
INMATE AND SEGREGATED
CONFINEMENT FOR THEIR PROTECTION
AGAINST KNOWN THREATS TO THEIR
LIVES. THE BILL ONLY ALLOWS FOR
PLACEMENT INTO ANOTHER UNIT OR
AREA OF THE FACILITY. THIS MAY
BE FOR THAT SUFFICIENT IN SOME
CASES BUT IF AN INMATE HAS BEEN
DESIGNATED BY PRESENTING TO BE
KILLED. MOVING INTO ANOTHER AREA
OF THE PRISON IS FAR FROM A
GUARANTEE OF PROTECTION.
UNFORTUNATELY THE REGION
INFLUENCE OF SOME PRISON GNGS
WILL CONTINUE TO PLACE THE
PERSON AT RISK. IT WILL NOT TAKE
LONG FOR THE ORDER TO SPREAD
THROUGHOUT THE PRISON IN IN MANY
CIRCUMSTANCES SEGREGATED
CONFINEMENT IS THE ONLY WAY TO
ENSURE THEIR PROTECTION. IN THIS
BILL WOULD PROHIBIT THAT EVEN AT
THE REQUEST OF THE INMATES. THE
NEW AN OVERLY BROAD DEFINITION
OF SEGREGATED CONFINEMENT.
INCLUDES THE CONFINEMENT OF AN
INDIVIDUAL AND A CELL OR
SIMILARLY SIMILARLY CONFINED
HOLDING OR LIVING SPACE ALONE OR
WITH OTHER INDIVIDUALS. WITH
SEVERELY RESTRICTED ACTIVITY
MOVEMENT OR SOCIAL INTERACTION.
IN THIS GOES WAY BEYOND WHAT IS
CURRENTLY CONSIDERED AS
ADMINISTRATIVE SEGREGATION. OR
SECURITY HOUSING UNITS OR ANY OF
THE OTHER. I THINK WHAT WE'RE
TALKING ABOUT TODAY WITH
SOLITARY CONFINEMENT- AND IT
ALSO INCLUDES INMATES SUFFERING
FROM SEVERE MENTAL ILLNESSES
THAT ARE PLACED IN SHORT AND
LONG TERM MENTAL HEALTH CRISIS
BEDS. SO I KNOW IT'S NOT THE
AUTHOR'S INTENT THAT THE BILL
COULD POTENTIALLY ALSO SEVERELY
LIMIT THE TYPE OF CARE THAT THEY
CAN RECEIVE. WOULD WOULD FORCE
THE DEPARTMENT TO PLACE THEM
BACK INTO A LESS RESTRICTIVE
ENVIRONMENT WHERE SOME INMATES
MAY BE A GREATER. DANGER TO
THEMSELVES OR OTHERS. AND I'VE
SEEN SOME OF THE PROPOSED
AMENDMENTS THEY DO MAKE SOME
IMPROVEMENTS TO THE BILL BUT IT
DOESN'T CHANGE OUR POSITION. AND
THE AUTHOR IN HIS OFFICE HAVE
BEEN VERY COMMUNICATIVE THE-
WITH- OUR ASSOCIATION SO
DEFINITELY DO APPRECIATE THAT.
WE DO HAVE A PRETTY DIFFICULT
HURDLE TO OVERCOME WITH THE
BASELINE ABSOLUTE CONSTRAINTS ON
THE DURATION OF SEGREGATED
CONFINEMENT IN ALL
CIRCUMSTANCES. BUT DID
PROVISIONS FOR NOW OF TWENTY SIX
THIRTY TWO ARE FAR TOO
RESTRICTIVE AND LIMIT THE
ABILITY OF STAFF AND MANAGEMENT
TO ENSURE THE SAFETY OF OFFICERS
AND INMATES AND FOR THESE
REASONS CCPOA. IS A POST THANK
YOU. THANK YOU. YOU MAY BEGIN
GOOD MORNING MR CHAIRMAN
RESOLUTION MUCH FOR ON BEHALF OF
THE CALIFORNIA STATE SHERIFFS
ASSOCIATION. I RESPECTFULLY AND
OPPOSITION TO AB TWENTY SIX
THIRTY TWO. AS A GENERAL MATTER
WE ARE VERY CONCERNED ABOUT
IMPOSING ON THE SIGNIFICANT
MANDATES AND STATUTE. S. CENTRAL
ROLE OF THE BOARD OF THE ESTATE
AND COMMITTEE CORRECTIONS IS TO
SET MINIMUM STANDARDS FOR.
CUSTODIAL FACILITIES ADOPTING
AND REVISING THESE MINIMUM
STANDARDS IS AN ONGOING PROCESS.
THAT INVOLVES STAKEHOLDERS FROM
ALL PERSPECTIVES AND ALLOWS
FOREIGN FOR EVOLUTION AND
REFINEMENT OF REQUIREMENTS AND
PROCESSES. WITHOUT THE BURDEN OF
HAVING TO AMEND STATUTE. EVERY
TIME IT CHANGES NEEDED. THE B.
S. C. AND THE PRACTITIONERS WHO
ARE RESPONSIBLE FOR SUPERVISION.
HOUSING AND REHABILITATION OF
INCARCERATED PERSONS ARE BEST
SITUATED TO MAKE DECISIONS ABOUT
BEST PRACTICES AND FACILITY
STANDARDS. WHAT SPECIFICALLY THE
RESTRICTIONS IN THIS BILL WOULD
PRECLUDE MANY IF NOT MOST
OFFENDERS FROM BEING CONFINED IN
A WAY THAT MEETS THE BILL'S
DEFINITION. THE TERM SPECIAL
POPULATION WHICH IS THE TRIGGER
FOR THE GENERAL PROHIBITS XIN ON
THE USE OF SEGREGATED
CONFINEMENT INCLUDES PERSONS
UNDER TWENTY SEVEN YEARS OF AGE
OR OLDER THAN FORTY NINE- PRECHT
AN AMPLE SUPPORT PARDON PERSONS
AS ALREADY MENTIONED LGBT Q.
PLUS PERSONS OR PERSONS WHO
EXPERIENCED CHILDHOOD TRAUMA OR
TRAUMA THAT OTHERWISE
CONTRIBUTED TO THEIR ARREST.
CONVICTION OR DETENTION BEYOND
THAT THE BILL'S ADDITIONAL
RESTRICTIONS AND REPORTING
REQUIREMENTS WILL PARTICULAR.
PRACTICALLY ELIMINATE ANY USE
ARE SEGREGATED CONFINEMENT
INCLUDING WHEN SUCH PLACEMENT IS
NECESSARY AS ALREADY MENTIONED.
FOR THE SAFETY OF THE FACILITY
OR INDIVIDUAL AND MAKES
THEMSELVES. FINALLY THE BILL
REQUIRES ALL FACILITIES TO PLACE
INDIVIDUALS IN THE LEAST
RESTRICTIVE HOUSING POSSIBLE
THIS MANDATE WILL ABSOLUTELY
RESULT IN PLACEMENTS THAT ARE
UNSAFE TO OTHER INMATES AND
STAFF AND ECLIPSE ALL OF THE
OTHER CLASSIFICATION DECISIONS
THAT MUST BE MADE WHEN DECIDING
HOW TO USE BECAUSE STILL THE
RESOURCES. FOR THESE REASONS WE
RESPECTFULLY OPPOSE THANK YOU.
WHEN I BRING IT BACK. DO NOT
HERE FOR OTHER WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION IN A ROOM AND OUTSIDE
IN THE HALLWAY. THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIRMAN RYAN SHERMAN WITH THE
RIVERSIDE SHERIFF'S ASSOCIATION
ALL IN OUR COMMENTS WITH THE
REPRESENTS FROM STATE SHARES AND
CCPOA THANK YOU. THANK YOU. I
SEE NO WITNESSES IN THE OUTSIDER
IN CHAMBER WILL GO TO THE
FOLLOWING WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION. AB TWENTY SIX
THIRTEEN. THANK YOU IN
OPPOSITION PLEASE PRESS ONE THEN
ZERO AND FIRST WE HAVE LINED
FIFTY SEVEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI
THIS IS JOHN TO GO I DON'T THINK
YOU GUYS CALLED THE SUPPORT BUT
I'M ACTUALLY CALLING TO REPORT
IS AB TWENTY SIX THIRTY TWO I'M
WITH THE NATIONAL ASSOCIATION OF
SOCIAL WORKERS CALIFORNIA AFTER
THANK YOU. THANK YOU. AND NEXT
WE HAVE LINED ONE NINETY PLEASE
GO AHEAD. HI THIS IS JIM
LINDBERG ON BEHALF OF THE
FRIENDS COMMITTEE ON LEGISLATION
THAT CALIFORNIA ALSO CALLING IN
SUPPORT OF THIS BILL THANK YOU.
YOU'RE A GUEST READER BOTH. AND
LINE ONE EIGHTY ONE PLEASE GO
AHEAD. I'M SORRY THEY REMOVED
THEMSELVES LINE ONE SEVENTY
EIGHT PLEASE GO AHEAD. HELLO YES
I'M CALLING AT THE PORT ALSO I'M
WITH ALL OF A SUDDEN MY NAME IS
GERRY ORTIZ. FOR ALL OF US IN A
SECOND ON THE LIST. THANK YOU.
AND NEXT WE HAVE LINED ONE
NINETY FOUR PLEASE GO AHEAD.
HELLO BUT IT WAS CRISTINA
INTEGRIS A RIVER THAT ALL OF US
AND THEN SACRAMENTO CHAPTER AS
WELL AS KEY DEALERS AND AS A
MOTHER ON BEHALF OF MY TWO
TEENAGE DAUGHTERS- WE ARE IN
SUPPORT. THANK YOU. NEXT WE HAVE
LINED ONE NINETY FIVE PLEASE GO
AHEAD. NINE ONE NINETY FIVE YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. NINE ONE EIGHTY
PLEASE GO. HI OLIVIA CAMPBELL
RESIDENT OF SACRAMENTO IN STRONG
SUPPORT THANK YOU. WE HAVE LINE
ONE TWENTY ONE PLEASE GO AHEAD.
HI GOOD MORNING MY NAME IS EDWIN
CAN ENGAGEMENT DIRECTOR WITH THE
CALIFORNIA COLLABORATIVE
AMERICAN JUSTICE WHERE PROUD
SPONSOR OF AB TWENTY SIX THIRTY
TWO AM CALLING IN FULL SUPPORT
OF THE CALIFORNIA MENTAL ACT. ON
SUCH A CONFINEMENT THANK YOU.
AND NOW WE HAVE LINE SIXTY ONE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. HELLO HELLO
HERE LINE IS OPEN. APART AND
ONLY THIRTY THE YOUNG WOMAN'S
FREEDOM CENTER IN STRONG SUPPORT
AS WELL. THANK YOU NEXT WE HAVE
LINED ONE OH SEVEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. HI GOOD MORNING THIS IS
THE INTERVIEW STRUCTURE WITH THE
LEAGUE OF WOMEN VOTERS OF
CALIFORNIA ORANGE SUPPORT AT
THIS BILL. LINE ONE EIGHTY ONE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. HELLO MY NAME
IS ARGHA MARGIELA CALLING ON
BEHALF OF LEGAL SERVICES FOR
PRISONERS WITH CHILDREN COLIN IN
STRONG SUPPORT OF AB TWENTY SIX
THIRTY TWO THANK YOU. SHE.
NINE POINT EIGHTY NINE PLEASE GO
AHEAD. HI MY NAME IS MARTIN
PROGRAM IS FROM LEGAL SERVICES
FOR PRISONERS WITH CHILDREN AND
I'M CALLING IN STRONG SUPPORT OF
AB. TWENTY SIX THIRTY TWO. DO
YOU. THINK CANALI NUMBER NINETY
EIGHT PLEASE GO AHEAD. NINETY
EIGHT YOUR LINE IS OPEN. MEMBERS
OF THE COMMITTEE AT FUNDING AS
WITH THE ANTI RECIDIVISM
COALITION STRONG SUPPORT THANK
YOU. NEXT LINE ONE HUNDRED
PLEASE GO AHEAD. NINE ONE
HUNDRED. HI CAN YOU HEAR ME. YES
HI JADI WITH OPEN PRIVATE IN
SUPPORT AB TWENTY SIX THIRTY TWO
. AND NEXT NINE ONE NINETY FIVE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI MY NINETY
FIVE YEAR LINE IS OPEN. THANK
YOU.
NEXT WE HAVE BLIND ONE NINETY
EIGHT PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD
MORNING MY NAME IS KELLY WALTERS
I'M A STAFF ATTORNEY WITH LEGAL
SERVICES FOR PRISONERS WITH
CHILDREN AND I'M CALLING IN
STRONG SUPPORT OF AB. TWENTY SIX
THIRTY TWO. AND THAT WAS OUR
LAST LINE IN Q. OKAY THANK YOU
IT WILL BRING BRING IT BACK TO
COMMITTEE MEMBERS. MR LACKEY.
YEAH MY REMARKS ARE DIRECTED
TOWARDS A WITNESS MISTER-
MCCARTY THERE THAT I WOULD LIKE
TO SAY CONGRATULATIONS. AND-
GIVE YOU KUDOS FOR THAT- VERY
COMPELLING TESTIMONY- IT HASN'T
BROUGHT ME TO YES ON THIS BILL
BUT WHAT IT HAS DONE IS BECAUSE
ME TO EVALUATE AND THINK. SO MY
PERSPECTIVES SO- THANK YOU FOR
THE VERY COMPELLING TESTIMONY.
THANK YOU ANYONE ELSE. SEEING
NONE YOU MAY CLOSE. THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIR- I'D ALSO LIKE TO
RECOGNIZE MR MCCARTY ARTIST
CORPORATE YA- I DID HAVE A
QUESTION I'M SORRY I MISSED
TALKING TO YOU LOOK I THINK YOUR
BILL AND ALL SPORTING A TODAY IS
GREAT FOR THE VAST MAJORITY. BUT
THERE'S A FEW INDIVIDUALS WHO I
THINK. YOU KNOW PEOPLE OF KILTER
CELLMATE OUR PEOPLE ARE GENERAL
AND DE DANGER OF GENERAL
POPULATION WHERE- HEY. THERE'S I
THINK THEY HAVE TO HAVE SPECIAL
COULD. AND WALLET IN THEORY THAT
CAN BE DONE IN YOUR BILL BY
EXTENDING THE FIFTEEN DAYS
REPEATEDLY I DON'T KNOW THAT
THAT'S A GOOD WAY. TO DO THIS
AND I DON'T KNOW THAT THE
CRITERIA FOR THIS- I'D JUST LIKE
TO SEE SOME MORE SPECIFICITY ON
WHAT YOU DO WITH PEOPLE WHO
REALLY CAN'T BE RELEASED AND IT
MAY BE ONLY YOU KNOW ONCE A YEAR
THIS HAS TO BE LOOKED AT HER.
HOPEFULLY NEVER BUT I DO THINK
THAT REQUIRES A BIT MORE WORK
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. I
APPRECIATE THAT GOOD THE NEW
MAKE CLOTHES NOW THANK YOU-
FIRST ALLIED TO YOUR POINT- YOU
KNOW WE'RE THIS IS A VERY
IMPORTANT COMMITTEE AND WE
APPRECIATE THE COMMITTEES- INPUT
AND WE APPRECIATE AND THAT'S WHY
THESE HEARINGS OR PART OF THE
PROCESS SO THAT WE CAN AS WE ARE
MOVING THE BILL FORWARD OR IN A
PLACE WHERE WE'RE TRYING TO
CONTINUE TO UNDERSTAND HOW WE
CAN. MAKE IT EVEN BETTER- YOUR
COMMENTS ARE LOST I THINK THAT
IT'S IMPORTANT TO NOTE THAT.
MIGHTY AND I THINK WE'VE ALSO
BEEN MADE AN OFFER TO THE
COMMITTEE THAT WILL BE VISITING
NEW FOLSOM ON WEDNESDAY FOR THE
PURPOSE OF ACTUALLY SEEING-
WE'VE HEARD A LOT OF TESTIMONY
AND APPRECIATE MR MCCARTY'S- A
PICTURE IN OF. PARTICULAR
ENCOUNTER- IT IS THE IT IS THE
UNDERPINNING OF WHY THIS BILL IS
IN FRONT OF THIS COMMITTEE. ARE
YET TO FIND A PERFECT BILL. AND
I'VE SENT THE IN ALL THE YEARS
I'VE BEEN HERE- BUT- THERE IS A
REAL PROBLEM HERE. THERE'S A
DYSFUNCTIONAL SYSTEM. THAT
PEOPLE ARE FINDING THEMSELVES
TRAPPED IN AND I'M NOT. SAYING
THAT THIS BILL IS SOME BECAUSE
WE EVEN HAVE IN IT THERE WERE
LEAST RESTRICTIVE HOUSING.
POSSIBLE HAS BEEN STRICKEN FROM
THE BILL SO EVEN THOUGH IT WAS
SUGGESTED THAT IT DOES NOT IT
HAS BEEN. SO WE ARE TRYING TO
FIGURE THIS OUT. AND WE WANT. OF
THOSE WHO WERE GUARDS. WHO WERE
IN HIS PRESENCE TO BE SAFE WE
WANT. IN MAYES OTHER INMATES IN
THE PRISON AND STAFF. TO BE SAFE
AND WE HAVE TRIED TO ADDRESS A
LOT OF THOSE CONCERNS IN THOSE
ISSUES. BUT AT THE SAME TIME
WE'RE JUST TRYING TO ALSO MIRROR
. A GENERAL POLICY STATEMENT HAS
BEEN ESTABLISHED BY THE
INTERNATIONAL COMMUNITY. SO
WE'RE NOT EVEN. TRYING TO CREATE
SOMETHING SUPER BRAND NEW HERE.
WE'RE RECOGNIZING. LEADERSHIP
AROUND THE RECORD. ESALA CONFINE
BEING TO. AND WE'RE TRYING TO
CREATE POLICIES THAT ARE FAIR-
AND RESPONSIVE TO THAT REAL
ISSUE. AND THE TRAUMA THAT IT
CREATES ISRAEL. I HAD A STORY
THAT I WAS GOING TO CLOSE WITH
AND ENSURING WITH YOU BUT I
THINK MR MCCARTY STORY. IS OF IS
. COMPLETELY COMPELLING AND I
WANT THAT TO BE MY LAST WORD. WE
WILL CONTINUE IN THIS PROCESS.
WE HOPE THAT THOSE OF YOU HAVE
ARE OPEN TO VISITING WITH US AND
THERE'S A NEW FOLSOM. OF SO WE
ALL SEE TOGETHER MANY OF YOU
PROBABLY ALREADY HAVE. BUT WE
ARE TRYING TO TALK TO FOLKS
THERE TO TRY TO GET CLARITY ON
HOW WE CAN. MAKE SURE THAT. ALL
INTERESTED PARTIES A CONCERNS
ARE BEST REPRESENTED. THE BOTTOM
LINE IS FOLKS WHO ARE BEING
SUBJECTED TO THIS KIND OF WHAT
WE WILL CALL IN HUMANE TREATMENT
- NEEDS TO BE CORRECTED. THIS
DOES NOT ELIMINATED. BUT IT PUTS
WE THINK SOME APPROPRIATE
STANDARDS IN PLACE THAT MAYOR
COLORADO NEW YORK NEW JERSEY AND
THE INTERNATIONAL. COMMUNITY SO
WITH THAT I RESPECTFULLY ASK
YOUR IPHONE THE BILL. THANK
MOTION AND SECOND- BUT I WANT TO
THANK YOU FOR BRINGING THIS
FORWARD- I TRULY BELIEVE THAT
THAT THE REAL PROBLEM. IT IS NOT
REALLY SOLITARY CONFINEMENT. IS
THE ABUSE OF SOLITARY
CONFINEMENT BY BOTH THE PRISON
GUARDS. NCDC ARE MANAGEMENT
WHICH DOESN'T TAKE EFFECT. THE
LONG STANDING. HARM BED IT DOES
TO PRISONERS. BECAUSE I DON'T
THINK THEY CARE. AND WHEN THEY
DECIDED TO GO TO PUT SOMEBODY IN
SOLITARY CONFINEMENT. FORD
INDEFINITE PERIOD OF TIME IT'S
BECAUSE THEY DON'T WANT TO DEAL
WITH THAT PRISONER AND THEY JUST
. ANY USE JUST TORTURES METHOD
TO KEEP CONTROL OF THE INMATE
THERE. AND IT'S GOTTEN OUT OF
CONTROL- I THINK WHAT YOU'RE
DOING IS PUTTING IN SOME
BATTERIES SAFEGUARDS BUT COMING
UP WITH SOME. METHODOLOGY FOR
WHY YOU DO IT OR WHY YOU DON'T
DO IT- AS OPPOSED TO JUST
LEAVING IT UP TO THE WHIMS OF
THE INDIVIDUALS THAT ARE
SUPPOSED TO BE PROTECTING. THESE
INDIVIDUALS THAT ARE
INCARCERATED AND SO- I'M-
RECOMMENDED I BOTH. YEAH ON AB
TWENTY SIX THIRTY TWO BY THE
MEMBER HOLDEN THE MOTION IS TO
PASS TO THE APPROPRIATIONS
COMMITTEE JONES SAWYER JONES
SAWYER HI LACKEY LACKEY NEL
BONTA BONTA HI BRIAN HI BRIAN
HIGH COURT. QUIRK I SANTIAGO
THEY ARE TOO SEE OUR TURN NOW.
THAT MEASURE CALL NEEDS ONE MORE
THANK YOU. SO WE'LL GIVE A TRY
MISTER KALRA GO AHEAD AND JUST
GO FOR IT. I BELIEVE YOU WANT TO
DO- YOUR SECOND ITEM FIRST AB
TWENTY FOUR EIGHTEEN ITEM NUMBER
ELEVEN. THANK YOU SO MUCH I'M
SURE MEMBERS LIKE TO START BY
THANKING YOU THE COMMITTEE
STAFFER WORKING MY OFFICE I'LL
GLADLY ACCEPT- THE COMMITTEE
MEMBERS THIS IS ON AB TWENTY
FOUR EIGHTEEN ALSO KNOWN AS THE
JUSTICE DATA ACCOUNTABILITY AND
TRANSPARENCY ACT WHICH REQUIRED
ATTORNEYS TO COLLECT AND REPORT.
BASIC CASE INFORMATION UP WITH
DATA BEING HOUSE UNDER THE
CRIMINAL JUSTICE SYSTEM CENTER
WITHIN THE DEPARTMENT OF
JUSTICE. DISTRICT ATTORNEYS PLAY
A CENTRAL ROLE THROUGHOUT OUR
CRIMINAL JUSTICE SYSTEM. NOT
ONLY DO THEY DETERMINE THE CRIME
SOMEONE IS CHARGED WITH BUT ALSO
WILL BE DETAINED OR RELEASED PRE
TRIAL WHETHER THEY'RE CONVICTED
OF THE CRIMES HAVE BEEN CHARGED
WITH AND HOW SOMEONE SCHOOL
HISTORY MAY IMPACT THEIR
TREATMENT JUST TO NAME A FEW
EXAMPLES. YET DESPITE THIS GREAT
AMOUNT OF INFLUENCE VERY FEW
JEEZ PUBLICLY REPORT MUCH ABOUT
THEIR CHARGING RATIONALE THE
LENGTH OF TIME IT TAKES THE CASE
MOVED TO THE PROCESS AND THE
NUMBER OF CERTAIN CRIMES THAT
HAVE BEEN CHARGE. THIS LACK OF
INFORMATION TRANSPARENCY IS ONLY
ENABLED RACIAL BIAS PROLIFERATE
WITHIN OUR CRIMINAL JUSTICE A
CRIMINAL LEGAL SYSTEM OF PEOPLE
OF COLOR VASTLY OVER REPRESENTED
IN CALIFORNIA'S PRISON AND JAIL
POPULATIONS. HOWEVER THE
MOVEMENT TOWARD YOU TRANSPARENCY
IS NOT NEW AND IN FACT IS BEING
LED IN TANDEM WITH APRS BY
CRIMINAL JUSTICE ORGANIZATIONS
AND DISTRICT ATTORNEYS
THEMSELVES. IN TWO THOUSAND
EIGHTEEN SAN FRANCISCO DAB
DELIGHT LAUNCH PUBLIC DATA
DASHBOARDS ON A RESPITE
PRESENTED CASES PROSECUTED AND
TRIALS TO GIVE A COMPREHENSIVE
OVERVIEW OF THE CRIMINAL JUSTICE
PROCESS AND SAM CISCO. THIS PART
THE PRACTICE WAS. QUICK FOLLOWED
BY YOUR COUNTY DA REESING WHO
LAUNCHED A PUBLIC A PUBLICLY
ACCESSIBLE WEBSITE. OFFERING
VITAL DEMOGRAPHIC DATA ON YOLO
COUNTY CRIMINAL CASES IN TWENTY
TWENTY ONE. AND LOS ANGELES
COUNTY DA OF A GAS GOING TO
TWENTY TWENTY TWO SHARING OFFICE
CHARGE RATES IN REAL TIME. AB
TWENTY FOUR EIGHTEEN. NOT ONLY
BUILD UPON THIS WORK TO ENABLE
BETTER ACCOUNTABILITY OF
CRIMINAL PROSECUTIONS BUT IT
ALSO ENSURES YOU'LL BE EQUIPPED
WITH THE DATA WE NEED TO MAKE
MUCH NEEDED WELL INFORMED POLICY
REFORMS MOVING FORWARD. THIS
BILL IS SPONSORED BY ACLU
CALIFORNIA ACTION THE YOLO
COUNTY DISTRICT ATTORNEY THE SAN
FRANCISCO DISTRICT ATTORNEY AND
THE PROSECUTORS LINES OF
CALIFORNIA. HERE TO TESTIFY IN
SUPPORT OR YOU'LL COUNTY
DISTRICT ATTORNEY JEFF RESYNC
AND YOU'LL HALEY HALEY CRIMINAL
JUSTICE PROGRAM DIRECTOR WITH
THE ACLU OF NORTHERN CALIFORNIA.
AND PROVIDE TECHNICAL SUPPORT R.
MICHAEL MICHAEL DR OFF WITH ACLU
OF NORTHERN CALIFORNIA AND RYAN
COUSINS WITHIN THE YELLOW COUNTY
DA'S OFFICE THANK YOU. THANK YOU
. FIVE MINUTES. A GOOD MORNING
I'M JEFF REISIG THE DISTRICT
ATTORNEY OF YOLO COUNTY WE LIVE
IN THE GREATEST STATE IN THE
NATION AND WE HAVE SOME OF THE
GREATEST INNOVATIONS IN THE
WORLD EMERGING FROM PLACES LIKE
SILICON VALLEY YET IN THE REALM
OF CRIMINAL JUSTICE WE ARE ALL
TOO OFTEN MAKING POLICY
DECISIONS IN AN OLD SCHOOL DATA
VACUUM AT THE SAME TIME THE
PUBLIC IS DENIED ON GOING ACCESS
TO COMPREHENSIVE AND RELIABLE
DATA FROM THE JUSTICE SYSTEM. IT
IS TIME FOR CALIFORNIA TO ENSURE
THAT ALL OF US HAVE THOROUGH AND
ACCURATE DATA ON EVERY ASPECT OF
THE CRIMINAL JUSTICE SYSTEM FOR
THESE REASONS I'M PROUD TO
SPONSOR AND SUPPORT AB TWENTY
FOUR EIGHTEEN WHAT TWENTY FOUR
EIGHTEEN SEEKS TO DO IS
EMINENTLY REASONABLE AND
ACHIEVABLE IN FACT IN APRIL OF
TWENTY TWENTY ONE MY OFFICE
PARTNERED WITH A THIRD PARTY
ORGANIZATION CALLED MEASURES FOR
JUSTICE TO BECOME THE FIRST DA
IN THE NATION. TO MAKE ALL OF
OUR DATA THE BALLOT AVAILABLE
ONLINE TO THE PUBLIC THROUGH A
TRUSTED THIRD PARTY TRANSPARENCY
PORTAL NOW IN YOLO COUNTY
MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC
POLICYMAKERS AND THE MEDIA CAN
SIMPLY LOG ON TO OUR
TRANSPARENCY PORTAL AND EXAMINE
ALMOST EVERY ASPECT OF OUR WORK
IN THE DA'S OFFICE AND DISSECTED
BY RACE BY AGE BY GENDER IT'S
CETERA. AT THE SAME TIME WE'RE
USING THE DATA INTERNALLY TO
HELP ALLOCATE RESOURCES GUIDE
PRIORITIES AND SHAPE EVERYTHING
FROM OUR INTERNAL DIVERSION
POLICIES TO IDENTIFY IDENTIFY
AND RACIAL DISPARITIES BETWEEN
POLICE AGENCIES TO SAY THAT THIS
TRANSPARENCY TOOL HAS BEEN A
GAME CHANGER FOR US IS AN
UNDERSTATEMENT AB TWENTY FOUR
EIGHTEEN COMES TO YOU TODAY AS A
PRODUCT OF A COLLABORATION
BETWEEN PROSECUTORS THE ACLU AND
MANY OTHERS WHO ARE COMMITTED TO
THE IDEA THAT ACCOUNTABILITY AND
TRANSPARENCY IN THE CRIMINAL
JUSTICE SYSTEM START. WITH GOOD
DATA I URGE YOUR SUPPORT. THANK
YOU. GOOD MORNING MISTER CHAIR
AND MEMBERS MY NAME IS JOE OUT
HIGHLANDER DIRECTOR OF TACOMA
JUSTICE PROGRAM FOR THE ACLU. ON
BEHALF OF ACLU CALIFORNIA ACTION
WE ARE PROUD SPONSORS OF AB
TWENTY FOUR EIGHTEEN. THEY SELL
YOU HAS BEEN ENGAGED IN
PROSECUTORIAL ACCOUNTABILITY
WORK HERE IN CALIFORNIA AND
ACROSS THE NATION FOR OVER A
DECADE. IN CALIFORNIA WE ARE
PART OF A STATEWIDE COALITION OF
COMMUNITY ORGANIZATIONS WORKING
TO HOLD DISTRICT ATTORNEY'S
ACCOUNTABLE. THROUGH DEEP
PARTNERSHIP WITH THESE GROUPS
WHO ARE MOSTLY LED BY SYSTEM
IMPACTED BLACK AND BROWN LEADERS
WE HAVE PUBLISHED REPORTS
DETAILING PROSECUTORIAL
PRACTICES IN SIX COUNTIES AND
SUCCESSFULLY PUSHED FOR VARIOUS
POLICY AND PRACTICE CHANGES
ACROSS MANY COUNTIES. AS YOU LL
MAY KNOW DAYS ARE THE MOST
POWERFUL ACTORS IN THE CRIMINAL
LEGAL SYSTEM. THEY NOT ONLY
DETERMINE WHAT CHARGES TO BRING
BUT ALSO PLAY A CENTRAL ROLE ON
WHETHER PEOPLE ARE DETAINED PRE
TRIAL WHAT CHARGES PEOPLE ARE
ULTIMATELY CONVICTED OF WHAT
SENTENCES PEOPLE RECEIVE. AND
HOW PEOPLE PRIOR INVOLVEMENT IN
THE CRIMINAL LEGAL SYSTEM.
IMPACTS DEREK CURRENT TREATMENT
WITHIN. ALL OF THE DECISION
POINTS PROSECUTORS HAVE ENDED
DISCRETION THE EXERCISE WITHIN
THE CRIMINAL CASES LIFE. HAVE
SIGNIFICANTLY CONTRIBUTED TO THE
CREATION AND SUSTENANCE OF THE
CRISIS OF MASS INCARCERATION AND
THE DEEP RACISM WITHIN THE
CRIMINAL LEGAL SYSTEM. I'M DOING
THE HARMS OF MASS INCARCERATION
REQUIRES TRANSPARENCY. DESPITE
BEING PUBLICLY ELECTED DAYS ARE
NOT CURRENTLY REQUIRED TO REPORT
MUCH PUBLIC DATA. MORE
IMPORTANTLY PROSECUTOR DATA CAN
HELP INFORM BETTER POLICY MAKING
AND STRENGTHEN OUR COMMUNITIES.
ADDITIONAL DATA WILL INFORM
COMMUNITY MEMBERS THE
LEGISLATURE AND ENGAGE
THEMSELVES AS WE COLLECTIVELY
PURSUE SOLUTIONS THAT CREATE
COMMUNITY SAFETY AND ADDRESS THE
ROOT CAUSES OF HARM.
PROSECUTORIAL TRANSPARENCY IS A
CRITICAL STEP IN ENDING MASS
INCARCERATION CURBING RACIAL
INJUSTICE AND DEVELOPING
STRATEGIES TO PREVENT AND
ADDRESS TALK. WE BELIEVE THAT AB
TWENTY FOUR EIGHTEEN WILL BE AN
IMPORTANT STEP TOWARDS CREATING
A LEGAL SYSTEM THAT TRULY SEEKS
HEALING AND JUSTICE WE THANK YOU
AND WE ARE WE URGE FOR YOUR AYE
SUPPORT ON THIS BILL. THANK YOU
VERY ANY OTHER WITNESSES IN. IN
SUPPORT IN A ROOM NAME AN
ORGANIZATION. MARCO GEORGIA
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA PUBLIC
DEFENDERS ASSOCIATION IN SUPPORT
THANK YOU THANK YOU. HI NATASHA
MINSKER ON BEHALF OF THE
PROSECUTORS ALLIANCE OF
CALIFORNIA PROUD CO SPONSOR ALSO
ON BEHALF OF SMART JUSTICE
CALIFORNIANS STRONG SUPPORT
THANK YOU. SERIK ME ON BEHALF OF
INITIATE JUSTICE IN STRONG
SUPPORT THANK YOU. EMILY HARRIS
OF ELEVATOR CENTER IN STRONG
SUPPORT THANK YOU- ANY WITNESSES
IN OVER GO TO PAUL LIGHT A
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT EIGHTEEN T.
OPERATOR OPEN UP THE PHONE LINES
. YES IN SUPPORT CENTER ONE THEN
ZERO AND FIRST WE HAVE LINE
NUMBER FIFTY SEVEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. HELLO JONATHAN GO
NATIONAL ASSOCIATION OF SOCIAL
WORKERS CALLING IN STRONG
SUPPORT OF AB TWENTY FOUR
EIGHTEEN THANK YOU SO MUCH. AND
WE HAVE ONE MORE IN LINE WITH
THE OPERATOR. ONE MOMENT.
EIGHTEEN OPERATE. WE HAVE NINE
TWO ZERO FOUR PLEASE GO AHEAD.
HELLO THIS IS JOHN C. SMITH A
SENIOR MANAGER OF CRIMINAL
JUSTICE WITH ADVANCEMENT PROJECT
CALIFORNIA CALLING AND STRONG
SUPPORT. THANK YOU. AND I HAVE
NO ONE ELSE IN Q. THANK YOU NOW
AFTER WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION
THAT ARE IN A ROW COULD YOU MAKE
ROOM FOR A WITNESSES AND
OPPOSITION THANK YOU. IT MIGHT
BE AFTERNOON ALREADY BAD ON. THE
GOOD AFTERNOON MR CHAIRMAN
VERSES SHOW MUCH OR- ON BEHALF
OF THE CALIFORNIA LAW
ENFORCEMENT ASSOCIATION OF
RECORD SUPERVISORS I
RESPECTFULLY IN OPPOSITION TO
TWENTY FOUR EIGHTEEN- AS IT WAS
AMENDED ON MARCH THIRTY FIRST SO
ON THIS LETTER IS BASED ON THAT-
AS WE BELIEVE THIS STATED GOALS
OF THIS AND- PROPOSAL. WHICH IS
TRANCE AND- ARE ALREADY
ACCOMPLISHED UNDER EXISTING LAW-
WHICH REQUIRES LOCAL CRIMINAL
CRIMINAL JUSTICE AGENCIES TO
COLLECT A CORE SET OF DATA
ELEMENTS
THE SINGLE CENTRALIZED DATA
REPOSITORY IN THE DOJ AS STATED
IN THE ANALYSIS FURTHERMORE
SHOULD ILLEGALITY DECIDE THAT
THE CURRENT REPOSITORIES OF
SHARED LAW ENFORCEMENT DATA IS
INADEQUATE. ON NOTHING IN LAW
PREVENTS A LAW ENFORCEMENT
AGENCY IN COLLABORATION WITH THE
DISTRICT ATTORNEY TO CREATE A
PUBLICLY ACCESSIBLE WEBSITE- FOR
THE BENEFIT BENEFIT OF THE
COMMUNITY AS MR REISIG HAS
ALREADY DONE SO. IT'S NOT CLEAR
WHAT RELEVANT USEFUL AND COMPARE
A BULL CRIMINAL JUSTICE DATA
WOULD BE GATHERED BY DIS HEAVY
HANDED MANDATE THAT WOULD RESULT
IN A MORE EFFECTIVELAW
ENFORCEMENT PRACTICES AND
IMPROVE TRANSPARENCY AND
ACCOUNTABILITY- MISSTATED- THIS
IS BASED ON THAT- AMENDMENTS AS
TAKEN ON MARCH THIRTY FIRST-
HAVING SAID THAT WE ARE IN THE
PROCESS OF REVIEWING THAT- THE
PROPOSED AMENDMENTS- BUT WE DO
WANT OUT WE UNDERSTAND THIS IS
NOT THE BUDGET COMMITTEE BUT WE
DO WANT TO STRONGLY. URGE THE
MEMBERS TO PLEASE ACT CONSIDERED
THE BUDGETARY- AT REALITIES OF
THIS PROPOSAL- AND THAT RELIEF
THIS PROPOSAL NEEDS TO GO HAND
IN HAND WITH WHAT IS IN THE
BUDGET AND AS A MEMBER WHO
SYSTEM BUT JUST SOUTH FIVE WE
REALLY HOPE THAT DISCUSSION
TAKES PLACE TOGETHER- SO THAT WE
CAN TAKE OUR OPPOSITION OFF AND
BE NEUTRAL ON THIS LEGISLATION.
THANK YOU THANK YOU. OTHER ANY
OTHER. REMEMBER LIKE TO SPEND
OTHER PEOPLE ROLEX UP AS- ROUTES
THE ROOM. WHAT THE NUMBER THE
PHONE LINES ANY. AT&T OPERATORS-
BUT THE PHONE LINES FOR
OPPOSITION. ANYONE IN OPPOSITION
OF AB TWENTY FOUR EIGHTEEN
PLEASE PRESS ONE AND ZERO. AGAIN
OPPOSITION PLEASE PRESS ONE NINE
ZERO. AND I HAVE NO ONE IN Q.
THANK YOU BRING IT BACK TO
COMMITTEE FOR ANY QUESTIONS YES
OF COURSE YES SO ARMAND. AND
THAT'S THE PLACE TO TAKE THIS
OP. BUT WE BOTH AUTHOR AND I
COMPLETELY AGREE WITH YOU ON
THIS OP WHAT WILL HAPPEN IS THAT
THEY WILL GIVE AN ESTIMATE OF
THE COST AND THE TIME. THEY
BETTER BE ASKING YOU WHAT IT'S
GOING TO BE. SO AGAIN WITH
RESPECT TO- THE OPPOSITION I
THINK WE WILL TAKE CARE OF THAT
IF WE DON'T THEN THE BILL IS
GOING TO BE ABLE TO BECOME LAW
SO. I REGION AYE VOTE HAS BEEN
IN MOTION YET. SO ON MOVE THE
BILL. THAT COULD. QUESTIONS YOU
MAY CLOSE THANK YOU VERY MUCH
MEASURE INTO SUMMER COURSE
POINT- NOT ONLY OF THE CERTAINLY
THERE'S A RECOGNITION OF
DIFFERENT COUNTIES HAVE
DIFFERENT LEVELS OF RESOURCES
AVAILABLE AS WELL SO AS WE MOVE
FORWARD WELL CERTAINLY
INCORPORATE HERE INFORMATION
IMPLEMENTATION DATES AND ONE
CONVERSATION WITH THE DOJ
ATTORNEY AND- BUT WILL BE
WORKABLE BECAUSE WE DO RECOGNIZE
THAT NOT YOU'LL YOU'LL COUNTY
SAM SCOTT MAY HAVE RESOURCES
THAT SOME OF THE OTHER
JURISDICTIONS. SIMPLY DON'T HAVE
OR DON'T HAVE ALTHOUGH THE DATA
BEING ASKED WHERE IS READILY
COLLECTED DATA BUT STILL WE DO
ONE OF RECOGNIZE CERTAINLY ANY
RESOURCE ISSUES NIGHT OF REALLY
WANT TO THANK A DISK ATTORNEY
REISIG UP FOR HIS LEADERSHIP AS
ALWAYS IT SHOWS BOLD LEADERSHIP
WHEN YOU'RE ONE OF THE FIRST OUT
ON INITIAL LIKE THIS BUT I THINK
AS HE SAID- IT'S ALREADY
PROVING. TO BE A GAME CHANGER IN
THE ABILITY FOR HIM AND HIS
STAFF IN HIS OFFICE TO DO A
BETTER JOB IN IN EXECUTING
JUSTICE AND WITH. THAT I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE
VOTE. THANK YOU- AND- WE'VE BEEN
MOVING SECONDED- THERE ACTUALLY
TWO MEMBERS OF BUDGET SO FIVE
THAT ARE HERE THAT WILL
DEFINITELY LOOK INTO THE
FINANCIAL ASPECTS OF IT AS A
BOOK AND YOU HAVE A MEMBER OF
APPROPRIATIONS SO- I THINK YOU
WILL COVER TO BE ON ON THAT-
PERSPECTIVE- SO- JEFF RECOMMEND
I GO CALL THE ROLL. ON AB TWENTY
FOUR EIGHTEEN BY SOME MEMBER
KALRA THE MEN DO PASSED AS
AMENDED TO THE APPROPRIATIONS
COMMITTEE. JONES SAWYER HI JONES
SAWYER IRAQI STATE BLACKIE
ABSTAIN BONTA HI BONTA HI BRIAN.
BRIAN I WORK HARD WORK HI
SANTIAGO. SEYARTO THE BILL'S
LOCAL THANK YOU SO WE'VE BEEN.
CITED OR SOME MEMBERS THAT MAY
NEED TO GO TO A MEETING OF
MEMBERS OF. MY SIDE OF THE AISLE
WE'VE BEEN EXCUSE WE CAN'T STAY
IN CONTINUE. OKAY AND THERE'S-
IF YOU NEED TO. YOU NEED TO EAT
YOU CAN GO ACROSS THE HALL
THERE'S AN ACROSS. IN THE END-
WE CAN FLY OKAY A BUT WE WILL
CAN. FOR WHAT WOULD YOU IN A AT
THE MISTER KILEY CERROS. ALL
RIGHT THANK YOU VERY MUCH MISS
AS OF YOUR PAY- THERE TO PRESENT
ON AB TWENTY. SIXTIES A. TWENTY
ONE SIXTY SEVEN ENCOURAGES
RESTRAINT IN THE OVER RELIANCE
ON INCARCERATION BY REQUIRING
COURTS TO CONSIDER OTHER
ALTERNATIVES IN SENTENCING
DECISIONS. WHILE EXISTING LAW
CONTAINS NUMEROUS EXAMPLES OF
MANDATORY MINIMUM SENTENCES VERY
FEW SECTIONS NEITHER LIMIT NOR
DISCOURAGE INCARCERATION AS
NOTED IN THE COMMITTEE ON
REVISION OF THE PENAL CODE
TWENTY TWENTY ONE REPORT. THE
LACK OF THIS LACK OF DIRECTION
AS PER CALIFORNIA BEHIND STATES
SUCH AS ALABAMA ARKANSAS
MINNESOTA TENNESSEE AND NEW YORK
ALL OF WHICH ALREADY REQUIRE
SENTENCES TO BE THE LEAST
RESTRICTIVE MEANS POSSIBLE OR
THE CASE IN NEW YORK. EXPLICITLY
STATED THE MINIMAL AMOUNT OF
CONFINEMENT SHOULD BE IMPOSED.
SUCH PRACTICES ARE IN LINE WITH
SEVERAL CASE STUDIES AT
APPOINTED TOWARDS EVIDENCE OF
DIVERSION BEING EFFECTIVE METHOD
AND DISK TO CREASING FUTURE
CONVICTIONS. FURTHERMORE
ALTERNATIVES TO INCARCERATION OF
BEEN SHOWN TO LEAD TO REDUCE
PRISON AND JAIL COSTS LOWER
RECIDIVISM RATES ARE ONE WAY TO
ADDRESS HARMFUL RACIAL
DISPARITIES COME A JUSTICE
SYSTEM I SAW THIS FIRST HAND. IN
MY LIVING YEARS W. PUBLIC
DEFENDER HALF WHICH I SPENT IN
DRUG COURT AND ACTUALLY SAW THE
POSITIVE OUTCOMES OF CHOOSING
REHABILITATION AND RESTORATIVE
JUSTICE OVER SIMPLY
INCARCERATING INDIVIDUALS.
OVERALL BY REQUIRING COURTS
PRESIDING OVER A COUPLE MATTER
TO CONSIDER ALTERNATIVES
INCARCERATION. AB TWENTY ONE
SIXTY SEVEN SHIPS CALIFORNIA
AWAY FROM AN OVERLY PUNITIVE
SYSTEM. THAT DISPROPORTIONATELY
IMPACTS MARGINALIZED COMMUNITIES
WAS RE TOWARDS REHABILITATION
APRS RESTORATIVE JUSTICE AND
OTHER DIVERSION PROGRAMS. THIS
BILL IS SPONSORED BY THE FRIENDS
COMMITTEE ON LEGISLATION
INITIATE JUSTICE AND THE
NATIONAL. OF SOCIAL WORKERS HERE
TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT OUR AGE
ANA GRIFFITH ON BEHALF OF
INITIATE JUSTICE AND AS A
TECHNICAL WITNESS RICK OWENS
SENIOR STAFF ATTORNEY WITH
COMMITTEE ON REVISION. OF THE
PENAL CODE. YEAH THANK YOU. FIVE
MINUTES OR BOTH WITNESSES. IN
MORNING GOOD MORNING CHAIR AND
COMMITTEE MEMBERS IT'S A
PLEASURE TO SEE YOU ALL AGAIN.
MY NAME IS ADRIANA GRIFFITH AND
I AM PLEASED TO SPEAK TODAY IN
SUPPORT OF AB TWENTY ONE SIXTY
SEVEN. I AM SUPPORTIVE OF THIS
BILL BECAUSE NOT ONLY AM I
DIRECTLY IMPACTED BY
INCARCERATION BUT ALSO BECAUSE
OF THE WORK THAT I DO EVERY DAY
IS ROOTED IN RESTORATIVE AND
TRANSFORMATIVE JUSTICE. AB
TWENTY ONE SIXTY SEVEN IS A MUCH
NEEDED ADDITION TO CALIFORNIA'S
PENAL CODE. AND ENCOURAGING
ALTERNATIVES TO INCARCERATION
WILL NOT ONLY SAVE THE STATE
MILLIONS OF DOLLARS BUT ALSO
PROVIDE THE PEOPLE OF CALIFORNIA
WITH BETTER OUTCOMES WHEN IT
COMES TO PUBLIC SAFETY. IN BOTH
MY PROFESSIONAL LIVED EXPERIENCE
I'VE SEEN THE POWERFUL EFFECT
THE DIVERSION AND RESTORATIVE
JUSTICE PROGRAMS HAVE ON
INDIVIDUALS. AS AN EXAMPLE AND
SAN JOAQUIN COUNTY WE CREATED A
DIVERSION PROGRAM IN
COLLABORATION WITH THE DISTRICT
ATTORNEY'S OFFICE. THE WOMEN'S
CENTER YOUTH AND FAMILY SERVICES
AND OTHER COMMUNITY BASED
ORGANIZATIONS FOR PEOPLE WHO
HAVE BEEN ARRESTED FOR
PROSTITUTION RELATED OFFENSES.
THIS PROGRAM OFFERS INDIVIDUALS
A WAY TO LEARN ABOUT THE IMPACT
OF HARMS CAUSED BY SEXUAL
EXPLOITATION TRAFFICKING BUT
MOST IMPORTANTLY. PROGRAM OFFERS
A WAY TO ALLOW THE M. THE HARMS
CAUSED EXPLOITATION. IN THE
OFFERS THE WAY TO LEARN FROM THE
AND MAKE MEANINGFUL CHANGES
MOVING FORWARD. INDIVIDUALS
PARTICIPATING IN THE PROGRAM ARE
OFFERED RESOURCES TO ASSIST THEM
WITH BASIC NEEDS AS WELL AS
CONTINUED PEER SUPPORT AND
REFERRALS FOR ADDITIONAL
COUNSELING AND THERAPY SERVICES.
MORE RECENTLY SAID KING COUNTY
HAS ALSO IMPLEMENTED A
RESTORATIVE JUSTICE PROGRAM FOR
LOW LEVEL DOMESTIC VIOLENCE
CASES ALSO IN COLLABORATION WITH
THE DISTRICT ATTORNEY'S OFFICE
AND WHICH I HAVE THE PLEASURE OF
BEING ONE OF THE CASE MANAGERS
IN THAT. GRAHAM THE PAST FORTY
YEARS HAVE SHOWN THE IN CARS
ASIAN IS NOT ALWAYS THE BEST OR
MOST EFFECTIVE TOOL TO DEAL WITH
HARM. WE MUST CONSIDER AND
INVEST IN ALTERNATIVES TO
INCARCERATION IF WE WANT TO
BREAK OUT OF THE HARMFUL CYCLES
OF MASS INCARCERATION AND
DISRUPT CYCLES OF VIOLENCE AND
HARM. FINALLY I WOULD LIKE TO
THANK THE AUTHOR FOR BRINGING
THIS IMPORTANT MEASURE FORWARD
AND I RESPECTFULLY URGE THIS
COMMITTEE TO PASS AB TWENTY ONE
SIXTY SEVEN TODAY. THANK YOU
THANK YOU YOU MAY BEGIN SIR.
GOOD AFTERNOON CHAIRMAN. MEMBERS
OF THE COMMITTEE MY NAME IS
RICK- AND I'M A SENIOR STAFF
ATTORNEY FOR THE BE ON REVISION
OF THE PENAL CODE. THE COMMITTEE
RISEN CODE WAS CREATED BY THE
LEGISLATURE AND HAS BEEN IN
EXISTENCE. TWENTY TWELVE. IT
MANDATE IS TO RIGOROUSLY STUDY
THE EXISTING CRIMINAL LEGAL
SYSTEM AND TO MAKE
RECOMMENDATIONS TO SIMPLIFY AND
RATIONALISE THE LAW. OKAY
RECOMMENDATION. THIS IS. THE
TWENTY ONE SIXTY IS ABOUT GIVING
JUDGES GUIDANCE ON WHEN TO
IMPOSE A SENTENCE OF
INCARCERATION OR WENT TO OPPOSE
AN ALTERNATIVE TO INCARCERATION.
COMMUNITY BASED SOLUTIONS HAVE
BEEN SHOWN TO LEAD TO BETTER
RESULTS OF INCARCERATION IN MANY
CASES AND ALSO HAVE SIGNIFICANT
COST SAVINGS WHILE THE PENAL
CODE HAS A NUMBER OF SECTIONS
THAT REQUIRE JUDGES TO
INCARCERATE IT DOES NOT GIVE
MUCH GUIDANCE WHEN ALTERNATIVES
SERRATION. THERE IS A- HM AND
INCARCERATION RATES THROUGHOUT
THE STATE. OF DATA ANALYSIS
PERFORMED BY THE COMMITTEE
SHOWED THAT THE RATE OF
INCARCERATION PER ONE HUNDRED
THOUSAND PEOPLE RANGE FROM AS
LOW AS UNDER TWO HUNDRED PEOPLE
PER ONE HUNDRED THOUSAND IN SOME
COUNTIES. TO NEARLY FIVE TIMES
THAT AMOUNT IN OTHER COUNTIES
AND IN EVERY COUNTY EVEN THOSE
THAT HAD LOWER INCARCERATION
RATES THERE WERE- SIGNIFICANT
RACIAL DISPARITIES IN THE RATES
OF INCARCERATION WITH BLACK
PEOPLE VASTLY OVER REPRESENTED
IN THEIR CARS RATED POPULATION.
UP CALIFORNIA CAN ENCOURAGE THE
USE OF ALTERNATIVES TO
INCARCERATION BY IMPLEMENTING A
STATEMENT OF RESTRAINT INTO THE
PENAL CODE THAT GIVES JUDGES
GUIDANCE ON WHEN INCARCERATED IT
IS APPROPRIATE. SUCH STATEMENTS
ARE WELL ESTABLISHED- THE
NATIONAL RESEARCH COUNCIL WELL
AS WELL AS THE MODEL PENAL CODE
HAVE RECOMMENDED ST STE A LOT.
AND STILL JURIST INCLUDING NEW
YORK AND THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT
HAVE SUCH LAWS INCORPORATE INTO
IT. A LEGAL TERM THE LOCAL
COMMITTEE CONCLUDED THAT THIS
RECOMMENDATION COULD REDUCE
INCARCERATION IN THE STATE WHILE
NOT IMPACTING PUBLIC SAFETY
AFTER LEAVING JUDGES WITH THE
DISCRETION TO INCARCERATE WHEN
NECESSARY. THANK YOU AND I'M
HAPPY TO ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS
YOU MAY HAVE. THANK YOU ARE ANY
WITNESS INTO. IN A ROW. OR
OUTSIDE. NATASHA MINSKER SMARTER
SAYS CALIFORNIANS SUPPORT. MARK
OF GEORGE CALIFORNIA PUBLIC
DEFENDERS ASSOCIATION IN SUPPORT
THANK YOU. EMILY HARRIS ELLA
BAKER CENTER FOR HUMAN RIGHTS IN
SUPPORT. SERIK ME ON BEHALF OF
INITIATE JUSTICE OF PROPER
SPONSOR IN SUPPORT. THANK YOU
NEVER MOVED TO WITNESSES AND
UNDER BONE THAT ARE IN SUPPORT.
EIGHTEEN T. OPERATORS OPEN UP
THE LINES. THANK YOU CAN SPEAK
IN SUPPORT PLEASE PRESS ONE THEN
ZERO AND FIRST WE'LL GO TO LINE
TWO ZERO TWO PLEASE GO AHEAD.
THEY WERE LINE RUSHES HERE
PLEASE RESTART THANK YOU. HI
THIS IS JIM LINDBERG ON BEHALF
OF THE FRIENDS COMMITTEE ON
LEGISLATION OF CALIFORNIA PROUD
CO SPONSOR OF EIGHTY TWO ONE SIX
SEVEN AND I'D LIKE TO URGE AN
AYE VOTE THANK YOU. THANK YOU.
NINE TWO ZERO NINE PLEASE GO
AHEAD. BRIAN HOPE FOR ON BEHALF
OF SECURE JUSTICE HERE IN
SUPPORT. AND NINE FIFTY SEVEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. HELLO JONATHAN
GO NATIONAL ASSOCIATION OF
SOCIAL WORKERS CALIFORNIA
CHAPTER OF PROUD CO SPONSOR OF
AB TWENTY ONE SIXTY SEVEN URGING
YOUR AYE VOTE THANK YOU SO MUCH
. NINE ONE SEVENTY EIGHT PLEASE
GO AHEAD. HELLO HELLO HELLO YES
THIS IS A GREAT- WITH ME AGAIN-
HE'S A COMMUNITY SHOOTERS IN
SUPPORT. THANK YOU OF MINE ONE
NINETY FIVE PLEASE GO AHEAD.
JEFFREY BROWN. THREE YEAH. NINE
ONE NINETY FIVE YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. A LOT OF THE- WHAT. WE
APPLYING TO A HEAVY PLEASE GO
AHEAD. THE MOBILE GAME WITH AT
JEFF GROUP AND- THANK YOU. AND
THAT HAVE LINE TRY PLACE GO
AHEAD. HELLO WELL YES S. OPEN-
NEED ARE YOU FOR- DAVID
ORGANIZATION ARE A LITTLE. AS
CRISTINA BEEN AGGRESSIVE WITH
COMMUNITY HILLARD AND WITH I'M
DONE AND I AM IN SUPPORT THANK
YOU. LSF NINE ONE EIGHTY EIGHT
PLEASE GO AHEAD. I WILL BE A
PANEL IN STRONG SUPPORT THANK
YOU. THANK YOU. I DID GET ONE
MORE LINE NUMBER ONE NINETY FIVE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. WHAT. AT AND I
HAVE NO NO THANK YOU ALL RIGHT
THANK YOU- NOW WE HEAR FROM UP.
ANYONE IN THE ROOM IT OPPOSITION
. STEEM NONE- WILL GO LIVE
OPPOSITION ONLINE. EIGHTEEN T.
OPERATOR OPEN APPLIED FOR
OPPOSITION. FOUR EIGHT AND
PARALYMPIC SEVEN. PLEASE PRESS
ONE AND ZERO. AND WE HAVE LINE
ONE NINETY FIVE YOUR LINE IS
OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. AND THEY
REMOVED THEMSELVES. I HAVE NO
ONE ELSE IN Q. THANK YOU BRING
ABOUT TO COMMITTEE. ANY
QUESTIONS CONCERNS. THE BILL
SECOND. AND UP YOU MAY CLOSE
ACROSS FROM ABOUT IT TEARS
RECOMMENDED AYE VOTE WE HAVE THE
FIRST STEP YOU MAY CALL THE ROLL
ON AB TWENTY ONE SIXTY SEVEN BY
THE MEMBER KALRA THE MOTION IS
DUE PATH JONES SAWYER HI
CONSIDER IRAQI. BONTA BRIAN WORK. PORK I SANTIAGO SEYARTO LOCAL
MEASURES ARE CALLED LEAST THREE
MORE. THANK YOU. AND NOW WE HAVE. MISTER JAMESON HIS WAY. IT
WILL TAKE MISTER KING UP NEXT
BECAUSE HE HAD. IT IS A PRIOR
COMMITMENT HE NEEDS TO COME AND
TESTIFY SO WE CAN GET HIM ON HIS
WAY. THE BELIEVE YOU PETER AND
HE SAID. BUT. BRITAIN. PEOPLE
WHO HAVE BEEN DOING THAT COLD
WATER YEAH A GREAT DEAL.
YEAH. YOU'RE COMING OUT OF.
ONE OF.
I WANT ONE FIFTEEN TOMORROW IS
GOING TO. COPYRIGHT GIVEN THE
LATTER IF YOU CHANGE IT YEAH. IS
THAT YOUR STAFF.
HELLO.
TAKE ADVANTAGE WHILE YOU CAN
YEAH. I CAN'T. YOU CAN GO WHAT'S
NEXT WHAT'S ACROSS SMALL.
SURCHARGE KNOCKED THE BALL AS
MUCH. ALL OF THE CALLS BECAUSE
THERE'S MANY PEOPLE THE TEAM
FROM DISTRICT. WHEN I GOT. THE
COMMISSION YEAH THANK. ALL RIGHT
. WITH MEMBERS- OVER THE- I'M
NOT SURE. OKAY.
I WOULD. GET A BATTERY AND
HEAVILY IT TAKE THAT THING OFF
TO CURRENT TRIP SHE FALLS. THE
WORKERS COMP CLAIM RIGHT NOW
HAPPEN SANDWICH ROAST BEEF
TURKEY HAM OR A CERTAIN SALAS
AND CHIPS- TURKEY. WITH A BUNCH
OF STUFF. FOR EVERYBODY.
YEAH.
OVERSHOOTING MISTER CHAIR YOU'RE
RIGHT NOW TO SUBCOMMITTEE OF ONE
. THE MOST IMPORTANT ONE. SO
WHATEVER YOU'RE READY I KNOW YOU
HAVE SOME TIME CONSTRUCTING AQ
SO MUCH. SO AB TWENTY FOUR
SEVENTEEN ESTABLISHES THE YOUTH
BILL OF RIGHTS FOR INCARCERATED
YOUTH THEY'RE CURRENTLY EXISTS A
YOUTHFUL RIGHT UNDER THE
DIVISION OF JUVENILE JUSTICE
HOWEVER DJS CLOSURE NEXT YEAR-
WITH DETAILS CLOSER NEXT YEAR
THE BILL I USED BILL OF RIGHTS
WILL NO LONGER EXIST. WHAT THIS
BILL DOES IS JUST PROVIDING CARS
FOR USE WITH UNDERSTANDING OF
THEIR BASIC HUMAN RIGHTS THAT
ALREADY EXISTED LAW SUCH AS
ACCESS TO CLEAN CLOTHES WATER IN
EDUCATION IT ALSO ENSURES YOUTH.
ARE PROVIDED A DOCUMENT WITH
THEIR RIGHTS IN THAT A LIST OF
THE RIGHTS ARE PASTED- AT EACH
FACILITY. BE INCARCERATED AS A
YOUNG PERSON VERY DISCIPLINED
DIFFICULT AND OBVIOUSLY
EXACERBATES ANY EXISTING TRAUMA
THE BILL CREATES EQUITY ACROSS
ALL JUVENILE JUSTICE FACILITIES
IN THE STATE. ESTABLISH A
UNIFORM REQUIREMENTS FOR
NOTIFYING YOU OF THE RIGHTS SO
THEY CAN GET THE CARE THEY
DESERVE I HALF OF. TWO WITNESSES
ON THE PHONE HOPEFULLY OKAY.
AT&T OPERATOR COULD YOU OPEN UP.
TO HEAR FROM THE TWO WITNESSES.
HELLO. HELLO OKAY HELLO DURING
COMMITTEE MEMBERS MY NAME IS
SABRINA A BOND AND I AM A
RESIDENT OF MERCED COUNTY AND A
MEMBER OF THE WAY THE CALIFORNIA
CONNECTION IF YOU ADVOCACY
ORGANIZATION WITH A MEMBERSHIP
OF CURRENT AND FORMER FOSTER
YOUTH I AM HERE IN SUPPORT OF
YOU ALL RIGHT FOR YOU ARE
INCARCERATED I AM A FORMER
FOSTER LIKE MEANING YOU I WAS
ALSO A GIVEN OBJECT SYSTEM AND
AT AGE THIRTEEN I WAS LOCKED AND
YOUR FACILITY IT REALLY HARD ONE
OF OUR THINGS ALONG. WELL I WILL
TALK TO I'M NOT A CONTACT MY OR
OTHER FAMILY I DON'T KNOW WHAT
AT THE TIME BUT I HAD THE RIGHT
TWELVE LAW YOU HAVE REGULAR THAT
WAS NOT THROUGH TELEPHONE CALLS
MAIL THAT BARELY MURDER RIGHT
MADE IT VERY TRYING YOU KNOW
WHAT FOR ME OKAY I NOT YOU MY
FEAR IN THE JUVENILE JUSTICE
EXPERIENCE BEING THE NIGHT TO
REST THEY'RE NOT ACCESS TO STATE
CLEAN DRINKING. OR IF YOU'RE ON
. WHICH FROM BOTTOM FLUID AND
OTHER. WHAT WANT TO UNDER
PREVIOUS.
I WOULD THINK INTO FOSTER CARE
GROUP HOME WHEN I ARRIVED I WAS
HANDED A COPY OF MY FOSTER YOUTH
BILL RIGHT. I WONDER WHY IT
WASN'T IN MY RIGHT WONDER WHEN
WHILE I WAS OFF THAT THERE'S NO
RATIONAL REASON. I WOULD THINK
YOU WOULD THINK RIGHT M. NEEDED
PROTECTION IT MADE ME FEEL
UNSAFE AND UNPROTECTED THE FACT
IS THAT IN BOTH SYSTEMS DRAMATIC
YOU CAN HAPPEN BEHIND CLOSED
DOORS AND IN THE SHADOWS. MY
LIFE WOULD HAVE BEEN DIFFERENT
IF I HAD NO MY RIGHT WHEN I
WALKED UP I WOULD HAVE BEEN ABLE
TO SEE MY FAMILY I GET THE
SUPPORT I NEEDED AND DESERVE. I
SUPPORT AB TWENTY FOUR SEVENTEEN
BECAUSE IT WOULD CONSOLIDATE ALL
RIGHT IN THE COMING LOCATION.
LET YOUNG PEOPLE KNOW THEIR
RIGHTS AND HOW TO CALL THEM BACK
THEN. BUT MOST IMPORTANTLY AB
TWENTY FOUR SEVENTEEN WILL
COMMUNICATE THAT WE ARE NOT
ALONE AB TWENTY FOUR SEVENTEEN
CALIFORNIA CHRISTMAS THEM I DO
NOT THE- ALL OF US IN THERE. AND
RESPECT FOR RIGHTS TELL LAW I
REQUEST YOUR. FOR YES ON THIS
MATTER THANK YOU. THANK YOU.
NEXT WITNESS. HELLO GERMAN JONES
SAWYER AND COMMITTEE MEMBER
THANK I AM OLD BIT CAL THE AND I
IN THE TO RIGHT DIVISION OF
HUMAN RIGHTS WATCH WE INVEST
RIGHT ABUSE IN SOME ONE HUNDRED
COUNTRIES SHE PLEASED TO CO
SPONSOR EIGHTY TWO FOURTH ONE
THAT YOU BILL OF. IN TWO
THOUSAND TWENTY FOUR JUST SET IN
MY- ON. TRANSFORMATION OF YOUTH
JUSTICE. SHIFTING THE FOCUS OF
THE SYSTEM FROM A CORRECTIONAL
ONE TO A PUBLIC HEALTH APPROACH.
TO IMPORTANT ELEMENTS INCLUDE
CLOSURE OF DJJ THE STATE'S
JUVENILE PRISONS AND GOING
FORWARD INCARCERATION OF YOU
WILL HAPPEN ONLY AT THE COUNTY
LEVEL. AND SECOND THE CREATION
OF THE FIRST STATE OMBUDSPERSON
WHOSE JOB IT IS TO RESPOND TO
COMPLAINTS FROM INCARCERATED YOU
IN COUNTY FACILITIES. TO BE
SUCCESSFUL BIG SYSTEM CHANGES
OFTEN REQUIRE SEVERAL YEARS OF
FOLLOW UP AN ADJUSTMENT TO
RELATED LAWS AND THIS BILL IS
ONE OF THOSE NEEDED ADJUSTMENTS
. THERE IS A CURRENT LAW ARE YOU
BILL OF RIGHTS FOR YOUTH WHO ARE
LOCKED UP AT DJJ BUT WE DJJ
CLOSES IN TWO THOUSAND TWENTY
THREE AND BOTH YOU ARE SENT TO
THE COUNTIES THERE WILL BE NO
BILL OF RIGHTS. AB TWENTY FOUR
SEVENTEEN FILLS THAT GAP
INSURING THE INCARCERATED YOU
CAN LEARN WHAT THEIR RIGHTS ARE
IT REQUIRES COUNTIES TO INFORM
YOU ABOUT THE NEW OMBUDSPERSON
AND INSURERS UNIFORMITY ACROSS
ACROSS FIFTY EIGHT COUNTIES. AB
TWENTY FOUR SEVENTEEN DOES NOT
CREATE NEW RIGHT EXISTING STATE
AND FEDERAL LAW ALREADY REQUIRED
COUNTIES TO PROVIDE PROTECTION
FOR YOUTH WHO ARE INCARCERATED
RANGING FROM THE RIGHT TO ENOUGH
FOOD TO ACCESS TO EDUCATION.
THIS BILL TAKES THOSE
PROTECTIONS THAT ARE ALREADY
EXISTING ACROSS COMPLEX AND
CONFUSING CODES AND PUT THEM IN
ONE PLACE WITH CLARIFYING
LANGUAGE THAT YOUNG PEOPLE CAN
UNDERSTAND. CHANGES TO THE
ORIGINAL BILL OF RIGHTS REFLECT
NEW LAWS THAT HAVE BEEN ENACTED
SINCE THE ENACTMENT OF THAT LAW.
AND INPUT FROM YOU IN FOCUS
GROUPS GROUPS FROM ACROSS THE
STATE YOU TOO HAD EXPERIENCE
WITH JUVENILE FACILITIES. YOU'RE
IN FOSTER CARE HAVE A BILL OF
RIGHTS. ELDERLY PEOPLE IN
RESIDENTIAL CARE HAVE A BILL OF
RIGHTS THE BODY WAS RECENTLY
CONSIDERING A BILL OF RIGHTS FOR
DOGS AND CATS IN SHELTERS. BEING
INCARCERATED MEANS BEING BEHIND
CLOSED AND LOCKED DOORS OUT OF
THE EYE OF THE PUBLIC AND AWAY
FROM FAMILY AND FRIENDS WE URGE
AN AYE VOTE PLEASE ENSURE THAT
YOU COREY CARCERI DID KNOW THEIR
RIGHTS. AND KNOW ABOUT THE NEW
OMBUDSPERSON THANK YOU. THANK
YOU NOW ANY WITNESSES IN THE ROW
IN SUPPORT NAME AN ORGANIZATION. THANK YOU. AT. APRIL GRAYSON
POLICY ASSOCIATE CENTER PROUD CO
SPONSOR OF THIS BILL THANK YOU.
BAKLEY WITH ASIAN AMERICANS
ADVANCING JUSTICE CALIFORNIA
OVER IN SUPPORT THANK YOU. EMILY
HARRIS ELLA BAKER CENTER FOR
HUMAN RIGHTS IN STRONG SUPPORT.
THANK YOU. MARCO GEORGIA
CALIFORNIA PUBLIC DEFENDERS
ASSOCIATION IN SUPPORT THANK YOU
THANK YOU. GREGORY FELT INITIATE
JUSTICE STRONG SUPPORT THANK YOU
. ALISA OR WITH ANTI RECIDIVISM
COALITION STRONG SUPPORT THANK
YOU. ADRIANA GRIFFITH FORMALLY
INCARCERATED SURVIVOR IN STRONG
SUPPORT THINKING THANK YOU. NOW
WE'RE HERE WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION. SEEING NONE OF SAM
ONE. GOOD MORNING MISTER TURNER
MEMBERS DANIEL SANCHEZ ON BEHALF
OF THE CHEAP PROBATION OFFICERS
OF CALIFORNIA I WANT TO FIRST
CLARIFY WE DO NOT HAVE A
POSITION UNFORTUNATELY WITH
THERE BEING NO- LINE FOR NOT
HAVING A POSITION I WANTED TO
TAKE JUST A FEW BRIEF MOMENTS I
FIRST WANT TO THANK
ASSEMBLYMEMBER TING FOR REACHING
OUT TO US VERY EARLY TO ENGAGE
US ON THIS VERY IMPORTANT TOPIC
ON HOW WE CAN COLLECTIVELY
INVEST ON MAKE SURE AGAIN THAT
WERE- DELIVERING THESE IMPORTANT
SERVICES AND SUPPORT. TO YOU-
WITH THERE BEING SUCH EXTENSIVE
US STATUTORY- REQUIREMENTS-
PERTAINING TO THE DELIVERY OF
SERVICES FOR YOUTH AND ALSO OF
COURSE- THE JUVENILE TITLE
FIFTEEN REGULATIONS WE REALLY
WANT TO MAKE SURE THAT IS
CONVERSATIONS COULD NOT PROCEED
ON THAT WE ARE LOOKING AT HOW TO
BRING THOSE THINGS INTO AN
ALIGNMENT- FROM AN OPERATIONAL
PERSPECTIVE I THINK IT WAS WAS
PREVIOUSLY STATED THE IMPORTANCE
OF HAVING CLARITY AND THEN
LOOKING AT AGAIN HOW WE ALIGN
ALL OF THOSE DIFFERENT- POLICIES
AND REGULATIONS TO MAKE SURE
THAT THEY CAN TRULY BE
EFFECTUATED AND OPERATIONALIZE-
IN A MEANINGFUL WAY SO. WE LOOK
FORWARD TO CONTINUING TO WORK
WITH ASSEMBLYMEMBER TING- ON
THIS AND SO APPRECIATE THE
OPPORTUNITY- EVEN THOUGH WE
DON'T HAVE A POSITION AT THIS
TIME AND LOOK FORWARD TO THAT.
THANK YOU. THANK THANK YOU. ANY
OTHER. ANYONE ELSE IN THE ROOM
IN OPPOSITION. THEN WE WILL GO
TO THE PHONE LINES- EIGHTEEN T.
OPERATOR I'M SHOOTING ANY. PARTY
IN OPPOSITION TO AB TWENTY FOUR
SEVENTEEN. YOU DID NOT DO IN
FAVOR DO YOU WANT TO DO BOTH.
YES LET'S GET RIGHT ANY COMMENT
ON AB TWENTY FOUR SEVENTEEN THIS
PRESS ONE THEN ZERO FIRST WE
HAVE LINE TO THIRTEEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON PICK ME
BAN ON BEHALF CALIFORNIA COURT
APPOINTED SPECIAL ADVOCATE A
TRADITIONAL CAL COSTA INTO COURT
AT AT- EIGHTY TWO POINT SEVEN
THANK YOU. AND THEN NINE TO
SEVENTEEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. TONY
MARTIN ON BEHALF OF EQUALITY
CALIFORNIA PROUD CO SPONSOR OF
THE BILL I'VE ALSO BEEN ASKED TO
REGISTER SUPPORT FROM THE
FOLLOWING ORGANIZATIONS HUMAN
RIGHTS WATCH HUMBOLDT COUNTY
TRANSITION AGE YOUTH
COLLABORATION SO SHE'D LARIO.
JUSTICE FOR JOSIAH ALLEY W.
PROJECT OF LOS ANGELES NATIONAL
INSTITUTE FOR CRIMINAL JUSTICE
REFORM THAT'S A BIG JUVENILE
DEFENDER CENTER ROSENBERG LAW
OFFICES URBAN PEACE MOVEMENT W.
HAYWOOD BURNS IN Q. AND USE
ALIVE THANK YOU. THANK YOU. NINE
TO EIGHTEEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
GOOD AFTERNOON THIS IS JIM
LINDBERG ON BEHALF OF THE FRENCH
COMMITTEE ON LEGISLATION THE
CALIFORNIA IN SUPPORT THANK YOU
. NINE FIFTY SEVEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. HELLO JONATHAN GO
NATIONAL ASSOCIATION OF SOCIAL
WORKERS CALIFORNIA CHAPTER
CALLING IN SUPPORT OF AB TWENTY
FOUR SEVENTEEN THANK YOU SO MUCH
. AT NINE TWENTY THREE PLEASE GO
AHEAD. HELLO THIS IS JORDAN TOOK
A CALLING ON BEHALF OF
CALIFORNIA YOUTH CONNECTION HOW
CLOSE CONTRA COSTA DEL AND IN
SUPPORT THANK YOU. NINE SIXTY
ONE PLEASE GO AHEAD. AFTERNOON
ANALLY THE REPORT YOUNG WOMAN'S
FREEDOM CENTER APPROXIMATE BONTA
THEY'LL ALSO IN SUPPORT ANTI
RECIDIVISM COALITION CALIFORNIA
COALITION FOR WOMEN PRISONERS
CARE FOR CALIFORNIA COALITION
COMMUNITY TONIGHT STARTED YOU
CATHOLIC KENNEDY KILLER ALL OF
BAKER CENTER. THANK ALL RIGHT
YOU'LL NEED A- YOU'LL FAMILIES
AND OUR- YOU THROUGH OUR YEARS
WE DON'T. AS WELL NINE OTHER.
THANK YOU. NINE TWO NINE. PLEASE
GO AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON ANY
AVAILABLE WITH THE COUNTY
BEHAVIORAL HEALTH DIRECTORS
ASSOCIATION IN SUPPORT OF AB
TWENTY FOUR SEVENTEEN THANK YOU
. NINE TWO TWO ZERO PLEASE GO
AHEAD. THEY REMOVED THEMSELVES
FLYING TWO TO THREE PLEASE GO
AHEAD. THANK YOU FOR MORE WITH A
CALIFORNIA CATHOLIC COALITION
CALLING IN SUPPORT OF AB. TWENTY
FOUR SEVENTEEN. THANK YOU AND I
HAVE NO ONE ELSE IN Q. HELLO
OKAY THERE WILL BRING YOU BACK
TO COMMITTEE MEMBERS WITH ANY
QUESTIONS MR CORK. AS BUDGET
CHAIR OF ACCESS TO SECOND TO
POST SECONDARY EDUCATION IS
GOING TO COST MONEY ARE THEY
HAVE YOU PUT MONEY IN THE BUDGET
FOR IT. SO THIS DOES NOT GIVE
ANY ADDITIONAL RIGHTS- THAN THEY
ALREADY HAVE THAT JUST LETS THEM
KNOW WHAT THEIR RIGHTS ARE. SO
THE RIGHTS TO. POST SECONDARY
EDUCATION CURRENTLY EXIST IN
STATUTE- THIS IS JUST MAKING
SURE THAT WE ARE INFORMING-
FOLKS AT THEY'VE MOVED OUT OF
DJJ INTO THE COUNTIES WHAT THEIR
RIGHTS ARE. STILL IT'S GOING TO
COST MONEY JUST SAID HAHA IT'S
NOT GONNA COST ANY ADDITIONAL
MONEY. YES BUT IS THERE REALLY
THE STRUCTURE AND- SUCH IN PLACE
AND HOW IS IT REALLY GOING TO
HAPPEN EIGHTY EIGHT YEAH WE I
MEAN THERE'S NO THERE'S NO
QUESTION WE HAVE TO DO A MUCH
MUCH BETTER JOB OF- DOING
REHABILITATION. PERIOD WHETHER
IT'S OUR YOUTH WITH OUR DOLLS
RIGHT- PART OF THE FOCUS AS
WE'VE BEEN WORKING IN BUDGET
COMMITTEE IS TO ENSURE THAT
THERE IS. A GREATER FOCUS ON
REHABILITATION SO THAT THERE'S
NO QUESTION THAT THERE NEEDS TO
BE SIGNIFICANT ROOM FOR
IMPROVEMENT BELT AT THE ADULT IN
AT THE YOUTH LEVEL THERE'S NO
ARGUMENT THAT THAT'S NOT WHAT
THIS BILL IS DUE OKAY. FOR A
TOTAL OF THE BILL. TICKETS
ANYMORE YOU MAY CLOSE JUST
RESPECTFULLY ASK PRIVATE. JURORS
RECOMMEND I VOTE REQUIRED TO
PROTECT YOUR- I'M AB TWENTY FOUR
SEVENTEEN BY THE MEMBER CHIANG
THE MOTION IS TO PASS TO THE
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE JONES
SAWYER HI JONES SAWYER IRAQI.
BONTA BRIAN HI BRIAN I WORK I
WORK I SANTIAGO. SEYARTO THE
MEASURE ON CALL THANK YOU MORE.
MR MCCARTY ATTEMPT YOUR NEXT.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR YOU KNOW
THIS COMMITTEE IN THE
LEGISLATURE IS IN A LOT LAST FEW
YEARS ON- POLICE ACCOUNTABILITY
AND- TRANSPARENCY AS FAR AS
INFORMATION THIS THIS ISSUE KIND
OF THAT TACKLES BOTH THESE
THINGS RELATED DEATHS IN CUSTODY
- WE DON'T ALWAYS HAVE A-
TRANSPARENT PROCESS TO FIND OUT
WHEN SOMEBODY DIES. AT THE HANDS
OF LAW ENFORCEMENT WHILE IN
CUSTODY SINCE THE L. A. COUNTY
JAIL. AS WELL AS DEATH
CERTIFICATES- ARE THE PRIMARY
DATA SOURCE USED BY GOVERNMENT
AGENCIES TO TRACK MORTALITIES IN
THE NOT ALWAYS. ACCURATE WITH
THESE INDICATIONS SO THIS WOULD
MAKE SURE THAT- CURRENT LAW
CLARIFIES THIS AND WE DON'T HAVE
A HOTCH POTCH- SYSTEM THROUGHOUT
CALIFORNIA. I KNOW OUR
OPPOSITION SAYS THIS IS
DUPLICATIVE AND SO IF IT IS I
GUESS WHAT THE PROBLEM AND BUT
MORE IMPORTANTLY THIS MAKE SURE
WITH THIS MAKE SURE THAT ALL
FIFTY EIGHT COUNTIES HAVE A
UNIFORM. A POLICY WITH FOCUSING
ON- TRANSPARENCY INFORMATION
FOR- FAMILIES WITH SOMEBODY DOES
DIE IN CUSTODY. AS WELL AS JUST
GOOD GOVERNMENT IN GENERAL I
WITH ME TODAY ARE TWO
REPRESENTATIVES FROM THE- YOUNG
WOMEN'S FREEDOM CENTER AND THE
ANTI RECIDIVISM COALITION. THANK
YOU FOR GOOD AFTERNOON FAIR
MEMBERS. MY NAME IS APRIL
GRAYSON A POLICY ASSOCIATE FOR
THE YOUNG ONES FREEDOM CENTER
AND A POLICY FELLOW WITH THE
WOMEN'S FOUNDATION OF CALIFORNIA
SO LEAST POLICY INSTITUTE BOTH
SPONSORS OF AB TWENTY SEVEN
SIXTY ONE. A TWENTY. AB TWENTY
SEVEN SIXTY ONE REQUIRE A DEATH
CERTIFICATE TO INCLUDE IN THE
FIELD THAT INDICATES WHEN
SOMEONE DIES WHILE IN CUSTODY AT
THE LAW ENFORCEMENT INVOLVEMENT
. AND REQUIRES CARCERAL
FACILITIES TO DISCLOSE TO THE
PUBLIC WITH SOMEONE DIES WHILE
IN CUSTODY. A. TWENTY TWENTY
REPORT TWENTY TWENTY ONE SKEWS
ME REPORT BY THE PUBLIC POLICY
INSTITUTE OF CALIFORNIA. FOUND
THAT APPROXIMATELY A HUNDRED
NINETY FIVE PEOPLE ARE KILLED BY
LAW ENFORCEMENT IN CALIFORNIA
EACH YEAR. HOWEVER AND TWENTY
EIGHTEEN THE CALIFORNIA
DEPARTMENT OF PUBLIC HEALTH ONLY
REPORTED EIGHTY NINE DEATHS
OCCURRED WHILE LAW ENFORCEMENT
INVOLVEMENT. NATIONALLY
ACCORDING TO RESEARCH PERFORMED
BY THE UNIVERSITY OF WASHINGTON
FOUND THAT MORE THAN HALF OF
OFFICER INVOLVED DEATHS WERE
UNDERCOUNTED OR MISLABELED. THE
DEATH CERTIFICATE IS AN
IMPORTANT TOOL FOR MANAGING
MORTALITY TRENDS PROVIDING
OUTCOME DATA FOR RESEARCH
STUDIES AFTER SETTLING. PART OR
IS FOR HEALTH RELATED FUNDING
RESEARCH AND INTERVENTIONS.
INFORMATION ON THE DEATH
CERTIFICATE IS ENTERED INTO THE
CALIFORNIA ELECTRONIC DEATH
REGISTRATION SYSTEM. THIS DATA
IS THEN USED TO FORMULATE PUBLIC
HEALTH AND SAFETY POLICIES TO
IMPROVE THE LIVES OF ALL
CALIFORNIANS. THE DEATH
CERTIFICATE CURRENTLY. DOES NOT
CURRENTLY CAPTURE WHETHER DEATHS
ARE OFFICER INVOLVED BUT WHEN
THE DEATH OCCURRED WHILE IN
CUSTODY. THE PROCESS FOR CUTTING
THAT RELIED ON THE MEDICAL
EXAMINER OR CORONER TO INCLUDE
THIS INFORMATION. BUT IT'S UP TO
THE DISCRETION. WHAT OFTEN GETS
SUBMITTED. FURTHERMORE THE
PUBLIC CURRENTLY DOES NOT HAVE A
TIMELY ACCESS TO DATA ON DEATHS
THAT OCCUR WHILE IN THE CUSTODY
OF STATE OR LOCAL CORRECTIONAL
FACILITIES. WHILE EXISTING LAW
REQUIRES LAW ENFORCEMENT
AGENCIES A CORRECTIONAL
FACILITIES TO REPORT DEATHS IN
CUSTODY FOR THE CALIFORNIA
DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE. IT DOES
NOT REQUIRE THE AGENCIES TO SET
THIS INFORMATION WITH THE PUBLIC
OR UPDATE THE POSTING WITHIN
THIRTY DAYS AFTER THEY CHANGED
INFORMATION. OR DETAILS BEING
REPORTED. GREATER TRANSPARENCY
IS NEEDED. BY IMPROVING
CALIFORNIA'S DATA COLLECTION
PRACTICES THE TRANSPARENCY
PRACTICES THIS BILL WILL ENHANCE
COMMUNITIES REST ASSURE ALL
DEATHS ARE COUNTING. IT BECAUSE
THE DEATHS ARE REPORTED. OR
COVER THE POLICY MAKERS WON'T
HAVE AN ACCURATE SENSE OF THE
NUMBERS OF DEATHS ARE HAPPY MAKE
IT DIFFICULT TO DETERMINE
ASSOCIATED PROBLEMS. I WOULDN'T
BE ABLE TO EFFECTIVELY RESPOND
TO PUBLIC POLICY CRISIS. THIS
ENTIRE BILL IS ABOUT ENSURING
TRANSPARENCY AND THAT
CALIFORNIA'S THAT IT'S ACCURATE
IS NOT. ABOUT CULPABILITY. WE
ARE HERE FOR CHECKBOXES THE
NOTIFICATIONS I RESPECTFULLY
REQUEST YOUR AYE VOTE ON AB
TWENTY SEVEN SIXTY ONE THANK YOU
. THANK. OKAY JOB- ALL RIGHT
THAT ON THE MORNING- THAT'S A
GOOD IDEA YEAH IT'S IS TO ME
WHEN THE MICROPHONES ON ARM SO
ARE THERE OTHER WITNESSES IN
SUPPORT THAT ARE IN THE BUILDING. EMILY HARRIS ELEVATOR CENTER
FOR HUMAN RIGHTS AND SUPPORT.
FARKO GEORGE CALIFORNIA PUBLIC
DEFENDERS ASSOCIATION IN SUPPORT
THANK YOU. GREGORY FOR THAT
WOULD INITIATE JUSTICE SUPPORT.
K. WINDY IN ACLU CALIFORNIA
ACTION- IN SUPPORT. BRITNEY BA
SITE GENERAL OR COUNSEL FOR THE
CALIFORNIA NEWS PUBLISHERS AND
SUPPORT. GOOD AFTERNOON ASSEMBLY
CHAIR JONES SAWYER AND MEMBERS
OF THE COMMITTEE MY NAME IS
KATRINA HILL BAPTIST I LIVE IN
ALAMEDA COUNTY AND I AM A TWENTY
TWENTY TWO SOULS POLICY
INSTITUTE LEGISLATIVE FELLOW I
AM HERE TO GIVE MY ME TOO IN
STRONG SUPPORT AND OF AB TWENTY
SEVEN SIXTY ONE ALONG WITH THE
SOULS PASTI INSTITUTE. STABLE
SECURE AND STRONG AND INITIATE
JUSTICE THANK YOU THANK YOU. ALL
RIGHT- NOW I'D LIKE TO PRIMARY
WITNESS IN OPPOSITION.
GOOD AFTERNOON MR CHAIRMAN
MEMBERS WHO SHALL MUCH THERE ON
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA STATE
SHERIFFS ASSOCIATION I
RESPECTFULLY IN OPPOSITION TO AB
TWENTY SEVEN SIXTY ONE- THE
RECORDS FROM AT THAT
INVESTIGATION ATTENDANT
DISCIPLINARY INVESTIGATION ANY
POTENTIAL CRIMINAL MATTER AND
EXISTING REQUIREMENT THAT IN
CUSTODY DEBTS BE REPORTED TO THE
ATTORNEY GENERAL DEMONSTRATE.
THE INFORMATION THAT A PEERS TO
BE SOUGHT BY THE PROPONENT
PROPONENTS OF THE BILL CAN
ALREADY BE ACCESSED FURTHER
REQUIRING THIS INFORMATION TO BE
INCLUDED IN THE DEATH
CERTIFICATE COULD SLOW THE
COMPLETION OF THAT DOCUMENT AND
TIMELY RELEASE OF THE DEATH
CERTIFICATE IS A PARAMOUNT GOAL
FOR DEBT INVESTIGATORS. WE NOTE
THAT NO DEATHS INVOLVING OTHER
PROFESSIONS WOULD TRIGGER AN
ANALOGOUS INCLUSION INVESTOR
DIFFICULT. ADDITIONALLY THE
BILL'S REQUIREMENT TO POST
CERTAIN FACTS ABOUT AN IN
CUSTODY DEATH ON THE AGENCY'S
WEBSITE IS DUPLICATIVE COSTLY
AND UNNECESSARY UNFUNDED MANDATE
THAT IS UNLIKELY TO PROVIDE ANY
INFORMATION THAT IS NT ALREADY
PUBLIC OR ATTAINABLE- WE DO
RECOGNIZE THAT THERE ARE
PROPOSED AMENDMENTS BUT- WE
RESPECTFULLY ASK CONTINUE TO-
OPPOSE. ALSO ON BEHALF OF THEIR-
CALIFORNIA CORNERS ASSOCIATION-
WE HAVE NOT- TAKEN A FORMAL
POSITION ON THE BILL THAT WE
UNDERSTAND THAT THE TEN DAY
REQUIREMENT HAS NOW BE HAS NOW
BEEN EXTENDED. TO THIRTY DAYS ON
BAD BAD GUIDELINE IS STILL
INSUFFICIENT- FOR- IN MOST CASES
DOES- DOES ON DEATH
INVESTIGATIONS DO TAKE FOUR TO
FIVE MONTHS TO COMPLETE- SO
THIRTY DAYS IS A VERY VERY- IT'S
NOT UP PROFICIENT SUFFICIENT
TIME FOR US TO BE ABLE TO
COMPLETE- WHAT THE AUTHOR NEEDS
NOW FOR THOSE REASONS WE
RESPECTFULLY ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA STATE SHERIFFS
ASSOCIATION. OPPOSED THANK YOU
BYE. ALL RIGHT THEN NOT. ANYONE
IN THE BUILDING WHO IS OPPOSED
NAME ORGANIZATION AND POSITION.
THERE BEING NONE WILL GO TO THE
PHONE LINES AND AGAIN THE BILL
WE'RE TALKING ABOUT IS. A. B.
TWO FIVE FIVE ONE. CHOOSE ME.
TWO SEVEN SIX ONE. SO THAT'S AB
TWO SEVEN SIX ONE MCCARTY DEATHS
WHILE IN LAW ENFORCEMENT CUSTODY
REPORTING- AND- THOSE WHO ARE IN
FAVOR OR AGAINST WHAT WE NEED IS
NAME POSITION. AND- AFFILIATION
IF ANY. MR OPERATOR COULD YOU
PLEASE PUT THOSE ON THE LINE
CONCERNED ABOUT AB TWENTY SEVEN
SIXTY ONE. YES THANK YOU TO
SPEAK PLEASE PRESS ONE THEN ZERO
AND FIRST WE HAVE LINE NUMBER
FIFTY SEVEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
HELLO THIS IS JOHN TO GO WITH
THE NATIONAL ASSOCIATION OF
SOCIAL WORKERS CALIFORNIA
CHAPTER CALLING IN STRONG
SUPPORT OF AB TWENTY SEVEN SIXTY
ONE THANK YOU SO MUCH. NINE
SIXTY ONE PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD
AFTERNOON NATALIE THEORIES WITH
YOUNG ONES FREEDOM CENTER
COSPONSORED AB TWENTY SEVEN
SIXTY ONE IN CONCORD I DON'T
LIKE TO- EXPRESSED SUPPORT ON
BEHALF OF DATABASES ARE WARRIORS
CHAPTER THANK YOU. NINETY EIGHT
PLEASE GO AHEAD. BRIAN HOPE FOR
ON BEHALF OF THE CARE JUSTICE
HERE IN SUPPORT. NINE TWO THIRTY
SEVEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. THEY
REMOVE THEMSELVES NINE TWO OH
EIGHT PLEASE GO AHEAD. SORRY
NINE TO THIRTY THREE PLEASE GO
AHEAD. HELLO MY NAME IS TONY
ABOUT YOUR LARA CALLING ON
BEHALF OF LEGAL SERVICES FOR
PRISONERS WITH CHILDREN
PUBLISHED ON SUPPORT OF AB
TWENTY SEVEN SIXTY ONE THANK YOU
. NINE TWO TWENTY TWO TWO TWO
TWO PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI THIS IS
EMILY WONDER CALLING ON BEHALF
OF THE SISTER WORRIES FREEDOM
COALITION IN STRONG SUPPORT
THANK YOU. NINE TWO THIRTY TWO
PLEASE GO AHEAD. WITH A MAKE
AMERICA YOUR SISTER WHERE YOU'RE
TREATING COALITION CONTRA COSTA
CHECK- INSTRUCT ALL PUBLIC FIFTY
ONE THANK YOU. NINE TWO THIRTY
ONE PLEASE GO AHEAD. VERY MUCH
AGAIN WITH ESSIE JUSTICE GROUP
IN SUPPORT THANK YOU. NINE TO
SIXTEEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD
AFTERNOON MY EARLIER OF
RESIDENTS OF LOS ANGELES IN
STRONG SUPPORT OF AB. TWENTY
SEVEN SIXTY ONE. NINE TO THIRTY
SIX PLEASE GO AHEAD. HELLO. YES
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. HELLO MY NAME
IS TRACKING ANALYST AND I AM
CALLING- YEAH. WE GOT EVERYTHING
SOME PRETTY MUCH AND SUPPORT
EIGHT TWENTY SECOND FIFTY ONE
EIGHT YEAH. NINE ONE EIGHT EIGHT
PLEASE AHEAD. ONE EIGHT EIGHT
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. A LIVIA
CAMPBELL IN STRONG SUPPORT THANK
YOU. NINE TWO THIRTY SEVEN YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. HELLO. HELLO HELLO
PLEASE GO AHEAD. YES EVERY WITH
ALL OF THE THIRTY NINE
SACRAMENTO SUNSPORT. THANK YOU
AND THAT ONCE EVERYONE I HAD IN
Q. LAWRENCE THANK YOU WE HAVE
ONE OF THE PRIMARY WITNESS IN
SUPPORT. YOU HAVE TWO MINUTES.
AT JERRY MEMBERS OF THAT
COMMITTEE MY NAME IS ESTEBAN
UNIONS AND I'M WITH THE ANTI
RECIDIVISM COALITION- WE
STRONGLY SUPPORT- A. B. AT
TWENTY SEVEN SIXTY ONE TWENTY
SEVEN SIXTY ONE IS REALLY ABOUT-
PROVIDING INSIGHT INTO
SOMEBODY'S DEATH BERSERK DEBT
CERTIFICATES REALLY- SHOW
BECAUSE OF EVENTS WHEN SOMEBODY
HAS HAS DIED- AND REALLY- OFTEN
TIMES WE SEE PEOPLE WHO HAVE
PASSED AWAY WHILE INCARCERATED-
DON'T NECESSARILY THEIR FAMILIES
DON'T NECESSARILY HAVE THAT SAME
KIND OF INSIGHT INTO PROMPTLY
MANNER- AND OFTENTIMES ARE
NOTIFIED IN A WAY IN A PROBABLY
MATTERED AND THEREFORE- BUT TRY
TO CALL THE PRESIDENT TRY TRY TO
DROUGHT WHAT'S GONE ON WITH
THEIR FAMILY MEMBER- AND REALLY
DEATH CERTIFICATES ARE USED IN A
MULTITUDE OF FUNDING MECHANISMS-
TO DETERMINE. YOU KNOW WHAT'S
WHAT WERE THE NEED REALLY IS
AND- WE DON'T PROVIDE ADEQUATE
INSIGHT INTO HOW WHAT WHAT THE
LEADING UP WHAT THE EVENTS
LEADING UP TO SOMEBODY'S DEATH
REALLY WERE AND THIS BILL REALLY
IS ABOUT PROVIDING THAT THAT
INSIGHT SO- WE STRONGLY SUPPORT
AB TWENTY SEVEN SIXTY ONE AN
ASSET THAT YOU ALL DO SO AS
WELL. THANK YOU. ARM SO WE'VE
HEARD NOW FROM ALL THE
OPPOSITION ON THE PHONE LINE IN
THE AREA AND WE'VE HEARD AGAIN
FROM THE SECOND- WITNESS FOR THE
SIDE SO NOW WE WILL GO TO THE
BILL'S TO BRIAN TO REMOVE THE
BILL ARE SECOND AT SO BOTH THE
CHAIR AND I ARE VOTING YES ON
THE BILL MY CONCERN I THINK YOU
SHOULD TAKE OUT THE PART. THAT
SAYS THAT THE DEATH WAS CAUSED
BY AN OFFICER AND HERE'S WHY.
THINGS LIKE THAT OFTEN GO OUR TO
COURT BEFORE THEY DECIDE I DON'T
THINK IN THIRTY DAYS YOU CAN
COME TO THAT NOW WHAT YOU
PROBABLY CAN SAY. ON A DEATH
CERTIFICATE IS THAT THE AREAS-
OFFICER FORCE WAS USED THE
PERSON WAS IN CUSTODY. I DON'T
THINK YOU CAN SAY WHETHER OR NOT
IN WELL. IN ALL CASES IN SOME
CASES PERHAPS YOU CAN DECIDE IN
THIRTY DAYS AND THE OTHERS YOU
CAN'T. AND I THINK YOUR BILL
SHOULD BE SHOULD RECOGNIZE THAT
. YEAH I DID NOT CLARIFY THE
BEGINNING THAT WE WILL BE
ACCEPTING THE COMMITTEE
AMENDMENTS AND I THINK THAT'S
OUR INTENT IS TO SPECIFY THE
DEATH IN CUSTODY. WHETHER IT'S A
SIMPLE FACT WHETHER YOU ARE IN A
CORRECTIONAL FACILITY AND YOU
DIED ARE YOU DID NOT OKAY THE
TIME OUT OF THE CASE ITSELF I'M
NOT SURE THAT THAT'S WHEN THE
MAN MANAGEMENT- I'M AN ACCORD
THAT THAT'S A DIRECTION ALL
RIGHT. SO THEY WON'T. I DON'T
THINK YOU CAN HAVE REQUIREMENT
SAYING THAT IT WAS CAUSED BY
THE- OFFICER IN A THIRTY DAY
TIME SPAN. MAYBE YOU COULD DO IN
A RARE CIRCUMSTANCE WHERE. BUT
YOU CERTAINLY CAN'T DO IT
ROUTINELY SO I'LL JUST ASK YOU
TO TAKE A LOOK AT THAT AS TIME
GOES ON. WE'LL GET. THE GLOBAL.
I LAST. SO WHAT YOU KNOW WE CAN
TALK ABOUT THIS LATER. WE'LL
JUST STEP WE HAVE A MOTION AND A
SECOND. AND MADAM SECRETARY WILL
CALL THE ROLL. YEAH I SEE THE
SECTION THAT WE'RE TALKING ABOUT
AND I THINK THAT WE CAN ADDRESS
THAT AND CLARIFY THAT SO AGAIN I
MEAN I'M NOT PERFECT. YEAH WELL
I HAD THE ADVICE OF STAFF ALSO.
THANK YOU ALL RIGHT MADAM
SECRETARY ON AB TWENTY SEVEN
SIXTY ONE BY SOME OF OUR MCCARTY-THE MISSION IS TO PASS AS
AMENDED TO THE APPROPRIATIONS
COMMITTEE JONES SAWYER. LACKEY
BONTA BRIAN BRIAN I WORK HARD
WORK I SANTIAGO. SEYARTO. OKAY A
TO VOTE SHE SAID YOU NEED THREE
MORE AND DOUBLE GET THOSE LATER
I'M SURE THANK YOU ALL RIGHT
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. ALL RIGHT
OUR NEXT- NEXT ON THE AGENDA.
WHICH. WE HAVE A MURATSUCHI BILL
THIS IS MISTER MURATSUCHI HERE.
HE'LL BE HERE IN A COUPLE
MINUTES SORRY- I DON'T IS THERE
ANY OTHER AUTHORS HERE. WHO
WOULD YOU LIKE WE NORMAL. BUT
PERHAPS IF THE IF SHE'S IN
HALLWAY PREPPY CAN GATHER NOW
OKAY.
HE HAD REACHED.
WELL. SO PETRIE-NORRIS IS NOT
HERE MURATSUCHI IS HAS A BILL
SOMEWHERE ELSE SIR. HOW IS ON
HIS WAY OKAY. ALL RIGHT.
TWENTY TWO NINETY FOUR PROGRAM.
FRAZIER MICHAEL YEAH. NO THANK
YOU MOVE THE BILL SHARE A
HUNDRED THAT AB TWENTY TWO
NINETY FOUR WHICH PROVIDES LAW
ENFORCEMENT THE ABILITY TO ACT
IN MEDIA LEE WHEN DEALING WITH
CRIMES DETERMINED TO BE
ORGANIZED IN NATURE I'M TWENTY
SEVENTEEN THE NATIONAL RETAIL
FEDERATION CONDUCTED THE
ORGANIZED RETAIL CRIME SURVEY
AND FOUND THAT ORGANIZED RETAIL
THEFT CONTINUED TO CONTINUE BE
PERVASIVE WITHIN THE INDUSTRY
THE SURVEY STATED THAT 95%
AMERICANS REPORTED HAVING BEEN A
VICTIM OF CONTINUE THEFT
RESULTING IN REVENUE LOSS IS
ESTIMATED THIRTY BILLION PER
YEAR. A RESPONSE I AUTHORED AB
TEN SIXTY FIVE AND TWENTY
EIGHTEEN WHICH CREATED THE CRIME
OF RETAIL ORGANIZED STAFFED IN
ESTABLISHED CHP CALIFORNIA
HIGHWAY PATROL PROPERTY CRIMES
TASK FORCE THAT LAW INCLUDED
PROVISIONS INTENDED TO REDUCE
DEATH RECIDIVISM SUCH AS
ALLOWING AUTHORIZING A PEACE
OFFICER TO TAKE INTO CUSTODY A
PERSON WHO HAS BEEN CITED
ARRESTED OR CONVICTED OF THAT IN
THE PAST SIX MONTHS AND ALLOWING
THE COURT TO ISSUE A BENCH
WARRANT IF SIMILAR FACTORS
SUPPLY AND INFINITE HAS FAILED
TO APPEAR IN COURT. BILL BEFORE
YOU TODAY. WILL RE. THESE
CRITICAL TOOLS IN ORDER TO
BALANCE THE ADDITIONAL POWERS TO
DETAIN PEOPLE FOR COMMITTING
THEFT OFFENSES. AB TWENTY TWO
NINETY FOUR. ALSO RENEWS LOCAL
AUTHORITY TO GREAT DIVERSION
PROGRAM FOR PEOPLE WHO COMMIT
THEFT OFFENSES AND BECAUSE THE
GOAL OF THESE PROGRAMS TO REDUCE
STAFF AND RECIDIVISM THIS BILL.
EXTENDS THEM TO INCLUDE FIRST
TIME OFFENDERS RATHER THAN JUST
REPEAT OFFENDERS. LASTLY AB
TWENTY TWO NINETY FOUR DIRECTS
FUNDING TO GREAT PROJECT THE
DEDICATED PROJECTS DEDICATED TO
REDUCING RECIDIVISM OF HIGH RISK
MISDEMEANOR PROBATIONERS UPON
APPROPRIATION BY THE
LEGISLATURE. SINCE THE ORIGINAL
BILL WAS CRAFTED TWENTY EIGHTEEN
THE CRIME ORGANIZED RETAIL THEFT
AND THE C. THREE TASK FORCE HAVE
BEEN VERY EFFECTIVE TOOLS AND
BUSTING RETAIL THEFT RINGS
THROUGHOUT THE STATE. AB TWENTY
TWO NINETY FOUR WILL ALLOW
CALIFORNIA TO CONTINUE. A
BALANCE BETWEEN TACKLING A
PERVASIVE ISSUE EMPEROR
PRESERVING THE PROCESS IT HAS
MADE A PUBLIC SAFETY REFORMS
THIS BILL ALLOWS US TO MAINTAIN.
A VITAL TOOLS THAT HAVE BEEN
EFFECTIVE IN HELPING US
COLLECTIVELY RECOVER MILLIONS OF
DOLLARS AND PUT A STOP TO THOSE.
ORGANIZED RETAIL GANGS. RESPECT
AS RIVAL ALL RIGHT DO YOU HAVE
WITNESSED PRIMARY WITNESSES IN
SUPPORT I THINK THAT WOULD BE ME
I JUST DID OKAY I LOVE IT. ALL
RIGHT- IS. IS THEREANYONE IN
THE ROOM. WHO WOULD LIKE TO
STATE THEIR NAME. AFFILIATION
AND SUPPORT. SO WITNESSES IN
SUPPORT. FOR TWENTY TWO NINETY
FOUR. THERE BEING NONE ARE THERE
ANY WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION
PRIMARY WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION. TO TWENTY TWO NINETY FOUR.
THERE ANYONE IN THE ROOM WHO
WANTS TO SPEAK IN OPPOSITION TO
TWENTY TWO NINETY FOUR NAME
AFFILIATION. AND POSITION. WE
WILL THEN GO TO THE CALL LIVE-
OPERATOR COULD YOU ASK THOSE WHO
ARE IN SUPPORT OR OPPOSITION OF
AB TWENTY TWO NINETY FOUR
DIVERSION FOR REPEAT RETAIL
THEFT CRIMES. OF IN SUPPORT OR
OPPOSITION TO STATE NAME
AFFILIATION AND POSITION. THANK
YOU TO SPEAK ON A B. TWENTY TWO
NINETY FOUR PLEASE PRESS ONE
THEN ZERO. AND FIRST WE HAVE
BLIND. TWO ZERO EIGHT.
TRANSPLANTED ZERO EIGHT PLEASE
GO AHEAD. WHICH CHAIR MEMBERS
RANDY PERRY ON BEHALF SUPPORT TO
SUPPORT. ANYONE ELSE TO SPEAK ON
AB. TWO TWO NINE FOUR. I HAVE NO
ONE ELSE IN Q. SO THAT'S WHY I
ASKED FOR TWENTY TWO NINETY FOUR
TO GO FIRST BECAUSE I FIGURED
YOU WOULDN'T HAVE TOO MANY
WITNESSES AND HE DIDN'T AND
MERIT MISTER MURATSUCHI COULD
COME UP NEXT- WE'VE HAD A MOTION
AND A SECOND MADAM SECRETARY
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. ON AB
TWENTY TWO NINETY FOUR BY SEVEN
MEMBER JONES SAWYER THE MOTION
IS TO PASS TO THE APPROPRIATIONS
COMMITTEE JONES SAWYER JONES
SAWYER I MACKEY. THE BRIAN BRIAN
HI WORK I WORK I SANTIAGO.
SEYARTO OKAY. WELL MERIT MISTER
MURATSUCHI. YOU MAY BEGIN. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH MR CHAIRMAN AND
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE. I'M
HERE TO PRESENT ASSEMBLY BILL
TWENTY FIVE FORTY FIVE. TO MAKE
KNOWINGLY BUYING OR RECEIVING
STOLEN FIREARM A MISDEMEANOR OR
A FELONY REGARDLESS OF THE VALUE
OF THE FIREARM. THE DATA IS
CLEAR. BY THEM VIA VIOLENT
CRIMES. INVOLVING FIREARMS HAVE
DRAMATICALLY INCREASED DURING
THE PANDEMIC. MANY OF THESE
CRIMES INVOLVED STOLEN FIREARMS
. THE RECENT MASS SHOOTING JUST
TWO BLOCKS AWAY FROM HERE FROM
THE STATE CAPITOL INVOLVED A
STOLEN FIREARM. CALIFORNIA HAS
SOME OF THE STRICTEST GUN LAWS
IN THE COUNTRY. BUT ALL THESE
LAWS THAT WERE PASSING ARE
MEANINGLESS UNLESS THERE ARE
MEANINGFUL CONSEQUENCES. I
BELIEVE THAT THIS IS A COMMON
SENSE PROPOSAL. TO KNOWINGLY BY
A RECEIVE A STOLEN FIREARM
KNOWING THAT IT'S A STOLEN FIRE
ARM REGARDLESS OF VALUE SHOULD
BE TREATED AS A SERIOUS CRIME.
MOST GET HAND GUNS YOU CAN CHECK
IT ON THE WEBSITE MOST HANDGUNS
ARE LESS THAN NINE HUNDRED FIFTY
DOLLARS IN VALUE. WE NEED TO
HAVE MEANINGFUL CONSEQUENCES. TO
FIGHT GUN TRAFFICKING. AND DEFY
THE SPIKE IN GUN VIOLENCE. HERE
TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT OF THE
BILL IS A SPONSOR. THE
CALIFORNIA STATE SHERIFFS
ASSOCIATION. YEAH HI GOOD
AFTERNOON MR CHAIRMAN VERSES
SHOW MUCH THERE ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA STATE SHERIFFS
ASSOCIATION WE ARE PLEASED TO BE
SPONSORS OF ASSEMBLY BILL TWENTY
FIVE FORTY FIVE AND WOULD LIKE
TO THANK ASSEMBLYMEMBER MATT SU
CHI FOR AUTHORING THIS
LEGISLATION TO RESTORE THE
WOBBLER FROM RECEIVING A STOLEN
FIREARM VALUED AT LESS THAN NINE
HUNDRED AND FIFTY DOLLARS- AS
YOU ALL WELL KNOW IN TWO
THOUSAND FOURTEEN PROPOSITION
FORTY SEVEN WAS APPROVED BY THE
VOTERS OF CALIFORNIA A
PROPOSITION FORTY SEVEN CHANGED
THE LAW REGARDING CERTAIN THEFT
DRUG RELATED CRIMES REDUCING
SOME NON VIOLENT CRIMES TO
MISDEMEANORS MISDEMEANORS.
INCLUDING THE THEFT OF A FIREARM
IF THE VALUE OF THE FIREARM IS
UNDER NINE HUNDRED FIFTY DOLLARS
. HOWEVER VOTERS REALIZE THAT
LOWERING THE THEFT OF A FIREARM
TO A MISDEMEANOR WAS NOT THEIR
INTENTION AND THAT'S WHY ON
NOVEMBER EIGHTH. TWO THOUSAND
SIXTEEN- DAY PASSED PROPOSITION
SIXTY THREE TO FIX ONE OF THE
FIREARM LOOPHOLES BY STATING
THAT ANY THEFT OF A FIREARM IS
NOW A FELONY REGARDLESS OF THE
VALUE OF THE FIREARM. EXCEPT
THERE IS STILL ONE MODEL
MODIFICATION LEFT ARE TO MAKE.
AND THAT IS THIS BILL WE NEED TO
CLOSE THE CURRENT LOOPHOLE IN
LOSS OF RECEIVING A FIRE ARM
WITH THE VALUE OF NINE HUNDRED
FIFTY DOLLARS OR LESS CAN BE
CHARGED AS A WOBBLER- SO WE DO
ASK THE COMMITTEE- TO. OUR
APPROVED THIS LEGISLATION WHICH
WAS SUBMITTED TO THE VOTERS THE
DECISION TO FIX FIRE ARM
LOOPHOLE. THIS MINOR BUT VITAL
MODIFICATION ONLY TAKES OF UPON
VOTER APPROVAL AT THE NEXT
GENERAL ELECTION. SO
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOU I FELT
THANK YOU THANK YOU.YES MISTER
MEMBERS RYAN SHERMAN WITH THE
RIVERSIDE SHERIFF'S ASSOCIATION-
THOUSANDS OF MEMBERS OF OUR
ASSOCIATION AND NUMEROUS OTHER
LOCAL LAW ENFORCEMENT GROUPS.
INCLUDING THE POLICE OFFICERS
ASSOCIATIONS OF CLAREMONT
CORONA. POMONA PALACE VERDES
NEWPORT BEACH BUSTER COUNTY
DEPUTY SHERIFFS ASSOCIATION.
UPLAND PO A SANTA ANA BURBANK
INGLEWOOD ARCADIA RIVERSIDE LA
SCHOOL POLICE FOURTEEN P. LA AND
CULVER CITY PO A ALL ORDERS
SUPPORT. OF ASSEMBLY BILL TWENTY
FIVE FORTY FIVE WHICH WOULD
RESTORE THE ALTERNATE OF
MISDEMEANOR FELONY PUNISHMENT
WOBBLER. FOR RECEIVING STOLEN
FIREARM REGARDLESS OF ITS VALUE.
RECEIVING STOLEN FIREARM VALUE
LESS NINE HUNDRED FIFTY DOLLARS
EXCEPT IN VERY LIMITED
CIRCUMSTANCES CAN ONLY BE
CHARGED AS A MISDEMEANOR WHICH
IS NOT REFLECT THE DANGEROUSNESS
OF THE CRIME. STONE FIREARMS ARE
FOR OFTEN FOUND IN UNDERGROUND
GUN MARKETS WERE THERE ILLEGALLY
SOLD TRADED. IN USED TO
FACILITATE VIOLENT CRIMES POSING
SIGNIFICANT RISK TO THE
COMMUNITY SAFETY. OUR
COMMUNITIES ARE EXPERIENCING
INCREASED VIOLENT CRIME MANY OF
WHICH INVOLVE FIREARMS WE URGE
THE COMMITTEE TO SUPPORT THIS
COMMONSENSE LEGISLATION
CALIFORNIA SOME OF THE TOUGHEST
GUN LAWS IN THE COUNTRY HOWEVER
<c.green>RIMINALS SEEM TO LARGELY IGNORE</c>
MANY OF THEM INCLUDING THE
ILLEGAL PURCHASE OF STOLEN
FIREARMS BECAUSE IN MANY
INSTANCES THEY KNOW THEY'LL
FACE. VERY FEW CONSEQUENCES FOR
THEIR ILLEGAL ACTS FOR THESE
REASONS WE SUPPORT AB TWENTY
FIVE FORTY FIVE RESPECTFULLY
REQUEST AN AYE VOTE IN THIS
COMMITTEE THANK YOU THANK YOU
SIR ARE THERE ANY OTHER
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT. THERE IN
THE ROOM RIGHT NOW OR OUTSIDE
THE- CHECKING NOW. OKAY WE NOW
GO TO THE PHONE LINES FOR
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT OF AB TWO
FIVE FOUR FIVE MURATSUCHI.
PLEASE PRESS ONE THEN ZERO TO
SPEAK IN SUPPORT AND FIRST WE
HAVE LINE TO FORTY SIX PLEASE GO
AHEAD. THANK YOU EMPFEHLEN OF
STONE ADVOCACY ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA DISTRICT ATTORNEYS
ASSOCIATION IN SUPPORT. THANK
YOU THE NEXT LINE TWO ZERO EIGHT
PLEASE GO AHEAD. NINE TWO ZERO
EIGHT YOUR LINE IS OPEN. ANNEX
WE HAVE LINE TO FORTY SEVEN.
LANE IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
GOOD AFTERNOON MR CHAIRMAN BIRDS
OF THE COMMITTEE BALKANS OFFICE
ON BEHALF OF THE CITY OF
TORRANCE AND STRONG SUPPORT
THANK YOU. THANK YOU SIR. AND
LINE TWO ZERO EIGHT YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. BUT ISRAELI PERRY ON THE
HAPLESS FOR ACTIVE SUPPORT OF
THE BILL. THANK YOU SIR. I HAVE
NO ONE ELSE THANK YOU. IT WILL
NOW MOVE TO WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION- I THINK I NEED
ANOTHER CHAIR AT THE THANK YOU
READ EVERY. THANK YOU RYAN.
OKAY. WITH EVERY RATED BEGIN
FIVE MINUTES. MY NAME IS MARCO
GEORGIAN I'M HERE TODAY ON
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA PUBLIC
DEFENDERS ASSOCIATION AGAIN IN
OPPOSITION TO TWENTY FIVE FORTY
FIVE- HI AB TWENTY FIVE FORTY
FIVE IS NOT NEEDED AS THE AUTHOR
AND SPONSOR OF THIS BILL NOPE
STOLEN GUNS WHEN YOU STARVE WHEN
USED OR FOR CRIMES IN WHICH THE
INDIVIDUAL WILL FACE MUCH MORE
SERIOUS CONSEQUENCES WHICH RANGE
FROM AN ADDITIONAL YEAR. TWO
TWENTY FIVE YEARS TO LIFE IN
STATE PRISON- MUCH MORE THAN THE
WOBBLER THIS BILL PROPOSES. THIS
BILL WILL NOT SEND THE MESSAGE
TO CRIMINALS. WHAT TWENTY FIVE
FORTY FIVE WILL DO. IS END UP
WITH MORE BLACK AND BROWN
CALIFORNIANS SENT TO JAIL OR
PRISON BECAUSE PROSECUTORSWILL
ELECT TO CHOOSE THEM WITH
FELONIES. IMPOVERISH THEIR
FAMILIES AND THEIR COMMUNITIES
PERMANENTLY LIMIT THOSE
INDIVIDUALS WHO HAVE SUFFERED
FELONY CONVICTIONS TO LOW PAYING
JOBS BECAUSE MANY EDUCATIONAL
OPPORTUNITIES AND BETTER PAYING
JOBS AREN'T OPEN TO FELONS.
WASTE TAXPAYER RESOURCES
IMPRISONING PEOPLE WALK
CALIFORNIA SCHOOLS HEALTH CARE
AND HOUSING. WANT TO GO WAIT
WANTING FOR ADEQUATE FUNDING. SO
WHAT WE URGE YOU INSTEAD TO DO
IS ADOPT A PUBLIC HEALTH
APPROACH TO GUNS AND GUN
VIOLENCE. IT WOULD BE MORE
EFFECTIVE IT WOULD BE MORE
HUMANE AND IT WOULD COST LESS.
WE HAVE ALREADY TRIED TOUGH ON
CRIME IT FAILS. CALIFORNIA HAS
REDUCED SMOKING BY IMPOSING
TAXES ON CIGARETTES FANS ON
SMOKING IN PUBLIC PLACES AND
EDUCATION SIMILARLY. DEATHS FROM
MOTOR VEHICLE ACCIDENTS ARE DOWN
BY 90% AND THAT ALSO- WAS THE
RESULT OF A PUBLIC HEALTH
APPROACH. SO WE RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR YOUR NO VOTE ON A B. TWENTY
FIVE FORTY FIVE THANK YOU. GOOD
AFTERNOON CHAMBERS FRED WILLIAMS
OF ACLU CALIFORNIA ACTION AC
CALIFORNIA ACTION IS A
COLLABORATION OF ACLU SOCAL
NORTHERN CALIFORNIA AND SAN
DIEGO WE MUST RESPECTFULLY
OPPOSE AB TWO FIVE FOUR FIVE.
THIS BILL WOULD INCREASE THE
PENALTY FOR ANYONE WHO BUYS
ARAMBULA GET TO BE STOLEN FROM A
MISDEMEANOR TO ALLOW THEIR
OFFENSE WE UNDERSTAND OTHERS
INTENT TO CURB THE STOLEN THE
STOLEN FIREARM SECONDARY MARKET.
AS WELL AS PREVENT GUN VIOLENCE
ISN'T ON THE FIRE HOWEVER
IMPRISONING MORE CALIFORNIANS
WITH LONGER SENTENCES IS NOT THE
SOLUTION. CURRENTLY POSSESSION
OF A STOLEN FIREARM IS ALREADY
COMMON IS THIS THING LAW IN THIS
TOPIC IS OFFICIALLY ADDRESSED IN
THE PENAL CODE. AND MY
COLLEAGUES THAT THEIR MERE A
MYRIAD OF PENALTIES AND
ENHANCEMENTS FOR AN INDIVIDUAL
WHO COMMITS AN OFFENCE WHILE
ARMED WITH A STOLEN FIREARM
USING A FIREARM. DURING THE
COMMISSION OF THE OFFENSE INDEED
THAT IS CORRECT FROM YEAR TO
TWENTY FIVE YEARS TO LIFE
DEPENDING ON THE SENATE THE
SERIOUSNESS OF THE OFFENSE WHEN
WE CHANGE MISDEMEANORS ALLOW THE
PENALTIES WILL WE DO IS WE-
AUGMENT THE CURRENT DISPARITIES
THAT ARE ALREADY PRESENT. WITHIN
OUR SENTENCING MOST ON BLACK AND
BROWN INDIVIDUALS MALL EVEN MORE
OFTENTIMES BLACK MAN AND BROWN
MAN INDIVIDUALS END UP BEING
TARRED WITH THE WOBBLER IS TO
THE MISDEMEANOR AS A WHITE- AS-
Y. INDIVIDUALS WHO COMMIT THE
SAME CRIMES. AND SO WHILE WE
UNDERSTAND THE BASIC BILL PLAN
AT OF THOSE BRUCE HE SAID HE OF
THESE BILLS CREATE A NEW CRIME.
USUALLY FINDING A NOVEL WAY TO
CHARACTERIZE AND CRIMINALIZE
CONDUCT THAT IS ALREADY
PROSCRIBED. IS MULTIPLICATION IN
PARTICULAR THEY XIN OF CRIMINAL
BEHAVIOR CREATES INCREASING
COMPLEXITY WITHOUT COMMENSURATE
BENEFITS. AND IT'S FOR THESE
REASONS WE RESPECTFULLY URGE A
NO VOTE ON TWO FIVE FOUR. FIVE
YOU. ARE ANY OTHER WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION IN ROW. OR OUTSIDE
THE ROOM THEY WILL GO TO THE
PHONE LINES EIGHTEEN T. OPERATOR
COULD YOU OPEN UP FOR WITNESSES
IN OPPOSITION TO AB TWENTY FIVE
POINT FIVE MURATSUCHI. YOU CAN
OPPOSITION PLEASE PRESS ONE AND
ZERO. PRESS ONE AND ZERO AT THIS
TIME. AND I HAVE NO ONE IN THE
PHONE QUEUE THANK YOU WILL BRING
IT BACK TO COMMITTEE FOR ANY
QUESTIONS MR QUIRK. SO MISTER
MURATSUCHI- YOU AND I ARE
TOGETHER A LOT OF THINGS WERE
NOT TOGETHER HERE BUT JUST TO
GIVE ONE EXAMPLE. THAT GUN THAT
WAS FOUND STOLEN GUN. UP FIRST
FOES COULD CONVERTED TO BE A
MACHINE GUN. WHICH IS HIGHLY
ILLEGAL I THOUGHT IF IT WAS USED
IN THE COMMISSION OF A CRIME
IT'S FELONY WHICH MAY WELL HAVE
I'M NOT GOING TO PREJUDGE IT BUT
IT MAY WELL HAVE. CARRIED IT IN
PUBLIC IS A FELONY AND HE WAS A
FELON SO HAVING THE GUN WAS A
FELONY THAT'S ENOUGH. WHAT THIS
BILL WOULD DO IT WOULD ALLOW. AN
ARBITRARY SEARCH. WELL SHE IS ME
IT WOULD ALLOW US LAW
ENFORCEMENT ATTACKED TO TARGET
GROUPS FIRST SEARCH AND THEN
FINDING THE GUN- ALLOWANCE TO
ALLOW THE DA TO SAY. LEAVE A
MISDEMEANOR FOR X. Y. OR C. OR
WE WILL CHARGE YOU WITH FELONY
AND I JUST DON'T AGREE WITH THAT
. SO YOU KNOW WE'RE GOOD FRIENDS
BUT WE'RE GOING TO HAVE TO DO
CREATED DISAGREE THANK YOU. AS
CHAIR MATT RESPOND HERE THANK
YOU UGH MR QUIRK I AGREE WHERE
WE ARE- FRIENDS AND- WE AGREE
MORE THAN WE DISAGREE- I WOULD
JUST SAY THE AND THAT AS A
FORMER- LOS ANGELES COUNTY
PROSECUTOR AS WELL AS A LOS
ANGELES COUNTY PUBLIC DEFENDER-
THAT NUMBER ONE THE ARGUMENTS
THAT THERE ARE OTHER CRIMES.
THAT CAN BE- CHARGED TO PUNISH
SOMEONE WHO KNOWINGLY RECEIVES
OR BUYS A STOLEN FIREARM THAT'S
IF THERE IS ANOTHER UNDERLYING
CRIME. BUT HERE I MEAN. IF WE
ARE TO AGREE AS THE COMEDIAN
ALSO POINTS OUT THAT ALL GUN
CRIMES SHOULD BE TREATED AS
SERIOUS THERE ARE SITUATIONS
WHERE THERE IS NO UNDERLYING
CRIME WHEN THEY WOULD KNOWINGLY
BUY OR RECEIVE A STOLEN FIREARM.
AND SO YOU KNOW I THINK IT'S I
MEAN I AGREE THAT. YOU KNOW I
I'M A JOINT AUTHORS ACTUALLY OF
A BILL THAT THAT MR GIPSON A
PRESENTED EARLIER ON THE ON THE-
BANNING MOST GUNS I BELIEVE THAT
THAT'S ANOTHER PROSE THAT WE
NEED TO TAKE I MAY DISAGREE WITH
SOME OF THE SUPPORTERS ALL. OF
THIS BILL ON THAT POINT BUT- YOU
KNOW I DO BELIEVE THAT IT COMES
DOWN TO YOU KNOW IF WE ARE TO
HAVE A STRONG ENFORCEMENT OF GUN
LAWS THERE NEED TO BE
CONSEQUENCES SO. YOU KNOW WE SAW
THERE WAS A RECENT LOS ANGELES
TIMES ARTICLE- STATING YOU KNOW
THE FACT THAT- THE NUMBER OF
MISDEMEANOR CRIMINAL CHARGES
FILED BY THE CURRENT DISTRICT
ATTORNEY IS HALF OF WHAT WAS
FILED UNDER THE PREVIOUS
DISTRICT ATTORNEY. YOU KNOW I IF
IT TALK ABOUT. ABOUT YOU KNOW
THE CRIMINAL PUNISHMENT APPROACH
FAILING YOU KNOW I THINK WE ALL
AGREE THAT- CRIMINAL STATISTICS
ARE ARE MORE COMPLICATED- IT'S
HARD TO DETERMINE CAUSE AND
EFFECT. YOU KNOW JUST LIK IT'S
HARD TO SAY. THE RECENT INCREASE
IN VIOLENT. CRIMES IS A
REFLECTION OF THE FAILURE OF
CRIMINAL JUSTICE REFORM I MEAN.
THE BALANCE YOU KNOW WE NEED TO
HAVE A BALANCED APPROACH WHERE.
AS I SUPPORT YOU KNOW WE NEED TO
ADDRESS THE ROOT CAUSES OF CRIME
WHERE IT'S APPROPRIATE. BUT I
THINK YOU KNOW WHERE WE'RE
TALKING ABOUT KNOWINGLY
RECEIVING STOLEN FIREARM.
STANDING IN AND OF ITSELF. THE
SHOULD AT LEAST HAVE THAT THE
OPTION. OF FILING AND YOU EITHER
AS A MISDEMEANOR OR FELONY. WELL
WE JUST AGREE TO DISAGREE. AND
PARTICULARLY BECAUSE I DO THINK
AS ONE OF THE- OPPOSITION PEOPLE
SAID IT'S- YOU KNOW. IF YOU'RE
WITH THE SON OF A- WHITE RICH
PERSON YOU'RE MUCH LESS LIKELY
TO. BE OUR- SEARCH MUCH LESS
LIKELY TO BE CHARGED ETCETERA
ETCETERA- I THINK OUR OUR LAWS
YOU KNOW WE'RE JUST GOING TO
DISAGREE SORRY THANKS. ANYMORE
COMMITTEE FOR. YOU MAY CLOSE
THANK YOU I AM A- LOOKING TO SEE
A YOU KNOW WHERE THE REPUBLICANS
WIN. AYE AYE AYE WHICH TO SAY
THAT- YOU KNOW I DO BELIEVE THAT
WE NEED TO. WE NEED TO DO MORE
OBVIOUSLY I THINK WE WANT ONE
THING THAT WE SHOULD BE OF THE
GREEN THAT AGREE ON IS THAT WE
NEED TO DO MORE TO FILE IT FILE
A FIGHT VIOLENT. YOU KNOW I IT'S
NAY NEEDLESS TO SAY ON MY PART
THAT- THAT THAT THE VICTIMS OF
VIOLENT ARE MORE OFTEN THAN NOT
BLACK AND BROWN VICTIMS- AND SO
- I THAT THIS IS A- YOU KNOW A
RATIONAL. PROPOSAL TO TRY TO
RESTORE SOME OF THE BALANCE IN
TERMS OF ADDRESSING- DRAMATICS
AND VIOLENT CRIMES IN OUR STATE
. AND I WILL RESPECT ME. AS YOUR
- SO I I'M I'M A GO AHEAD AND
MOVE THE BILL- BUT IT. I WILL
NOT VOTE FOR THE BILL BUT I WILL
RESPECT AND HOPEFULLY- WEEK ONE
OF MY COLLEAGUES WILL WILL
SECOND IT SALUTE AT LEAST VOTE-
VOTED UP OR DOWN- I AM NOT. I AM
NOT A- FORMER PROSECUTOR NORM A
FORMER DA. BUT PRESENTLY I'M AN
AFRICAN AMERICAN MALE. WHO KNOWS
WHAT IT'S LIKE. WHEN THE
CRIMINAL JUSTICE SYSTEM BY D.
A.'S LAW ENFORCEMENT WORKS
AGAINST YOU ADD THE PYLON AT
DECISIONAL. PROBLEMATIC LAWS
THAT WILL ADVERSELY IMPACT
AFRICAN AMERICANS AND LATINOS IT
IS A PROBLEM AND WE WENT TO THIS
LIKE THIRTY YEARS OF IT OF YOU
KNOW LET'S GET ON CRIME LET'S
AND USE THAT MEANT LET'S GET.
OFF ON PEOPLE OF COLOR. LET'S
LOCK UP AS MANY PEOPLE OF COLOR
BECAUSE WE ARE SO AFRAID OF THEM
WERE SCARED OF THEM WE NEED TO
DO MORE TO MORE TO LOCK THEM UP.
TO MAKE US. WHO DON'T LOOK LIKE
US I FEEL COMFORTABLE AND SAFE
AND BETTER- AND THAT'S WHY WE
PROBABLY HAVE A PLETHORA OF.
PEOPLE TRYING TO MAKE THAT
HAPPEN. I KNOW YOU GENERALLY
BELIEVE IN WHAT YOU BELIEVE
THAT'S WHY I'M GOING TO GIVE YOU
A GO AHEAD AND GIVE ME THE
COURTESY VOTE AGAIN I HOPE YOU
YOU YOU GET THAT BOAT BUT GET.
IT TO BE VOTED ON TO BE HEARD
BEING HURT- BUT BUT I HOPE THAT
WE CAN EVENTUALLY COME UP WITH-
A WAY THAT WE CAN BOTH HELP.
PEOPLE ARE AFRAID OF WHAT CRIME
AND WHAT'S GOING ON RIGHT NOW
BUT ALSO MAKE SURE THAT WE DON'T
. TERRORIZER COMMUNITY FOLK
BECAUSE IT'S JUST THE EASIEST-THING TO DO. AND SO- I THINK
YOU'RE GENUINE AND THAT I
HONESTLY BELIEVE THAT WE UNITE.
TO HAVE HAD OUR- DISCUSSIONS
ABOUT THIS- BUT I WOULD DO
BELIEVE YOU GENERALLY HAVE A
HEART IN THIS AND YOU GENERALLY.
BELIEVE IN IN PARTS OF
REHABILITATION CAN YOU BELIEVE
IN. THAT THERE ARE SOME THINGS
WE HAVE NOT DONE WELL WHICH I
WILL AGREE WITH YOU. AND ONCE WE
GET OUR MUCH WE ABLE TO DO THAT
PROVIDE HOUSING MENTAL HEALTH-
EDUCATION ONCE WE GET THAT ON
TRACK I THINK THE PUBLIC WILL.
SEE THE BENEFITS OF IT LONG
RANGE IT'S JUST THAT IT TAKES
TIME. LOCKING SOMEONE UP AND
THROWING AWAY THE KEY IS OUT.
IMMEDIATE AND YOU FEEL BETER
YOU WALK AWAY WHAT DOES IT DO TO
OUR COMMUNITY IT IS DOESN'T HELP
. SO- MANAGER MAY CALL THE ROLL
. ON AB TWENTY FIVE FORTY FIVE
BY SEVEN RUMORED TO G. THE
MOTION IS TO PASS TO THE
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE JONES
SAWYER. JONES SAWYER NILE LACKEY
BONTA BRIAN. BRIAN NOT VOTING
QUIRKNO WORK NOW SANTIAGO.
SEYARTO THE MEASURE FAILS THANK
YOU. THANK YOU THE. ONE ON OUR
SIDE. MY BACK UP AGAIN. I THINK
I'LL BACK UP AGAIN. WE HAVE DO
WE HAVE ON OFFER IN THE HOUSE.
MISTER TERRIFIC- WELL JONES
SAWYER OKAY.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS
ARE PESENT AB OF FORTY TWENTY
FORTY THREE RISK A LINE
CALIFORNIA WITH EIGHTEEN OTHER
STATES WITH REQUIRING BAIL
FUGITIVE RECOVERY AGENTS
COLLATERAL YOU KNOWN AS BOUND A
KNOWN AS BY HIS TO BECOME
LICENSED BY THE STATE. CURRENT
LAW ON BAIL FUGITIVE RECOVERY
AGENTS IS LIMITED TO EDUCATION
NOTICE AND CONDUCT STANDARD
WHICH IS UNVERIFIABLE
CONSIDERING THERE IS A LACK OF
IN HOUSE SUPERVISION FROM
INDUSTRY WHEN HIRING AND
MANAGING RECOVERY AGENTS FURTHER
POINT TO BAIL FUGITIVE RECOVERY
AGENT IS TERMINATED PRO FOR
VIOLATING CALIFORNIA LAW THERE
IS NO WAY TO TRACK SUCH
TERMINATION AT DUSTY'S
INDIVIDUALS CAN BE HIRED BY A
SEPARATE COMPANY. THE CURRENT
ISSUE WE FACE IS NO ENTITY IS
CHARGED WITH ENFORCEMENT OF
THESE RECOVERY AGENTS AND AS
SUCH THEY ARE ALL IN PORTSMOUTH
CAREERS AFTER THE FACT BECAUSE
THE RECOVERY AGENTS ARE
ASSOCIATED WITH THE BAIL BOND
TRANSACTIONS THE CALIFORNIA
DEPARTMENT OF INSURANCE CDI HAS
BECOME THEIR DE FACTO WATCHDOG.
DESPITE THE FACT THESE AGENTS
ARE NOT LICENSE I DO NOT PAY ANY
FEES TO CDI. BELL FUGITIVE
RECOVERY TO FOR INCENTIVE TO
MAKE ARRESTS OFTEN WITHOUT
WARRANTS COMBINED WITH THE
ABILITY TO SELF REGULATE FAILS
TO PROTECT THE PUBLIC FROM A
JOB. THAT SIMULATES LAW
ENFORCEMENT AND SUBJECTS THE
PUBLIC TOO DANGEROUS AND
DRAMATIC SITUATION. FOR EXAMPLE
IN APRIL. TWENTY TWENTY ONE A
PALM SPRINGS RESIDENT WAS SHOT
AND KILLED BY A BILL FUGITIVE
RECOVERY AGENT DESPITE NOTING
THAT NO WARRANTS HAD BEEN ISSUED
FOR THE RESIDENTS ARREST. AND
THE RESIDENT HAD NOT FAILED TO
APPEAR IN COURT TO MAKE MATTERS
WORSE THE RECOVERY AGENT SHOULD
NOT HAVE BEEN DOING RECOVERY
WORK NOR SHOULD HAVE BEEN IN
POSSESSION OF A FIREARM IN THE
FIRST PLACE DUE TO HIS. PRIOR
FELONY CONVICTIONS THIS TRAGIC
KILLING COULD HAVE BEEN
PREVENTED HAD THERE BEEN MORE
ASIAN AND PRE EMPLOYMENT
TRAINING FOR THOSE WHO HIRED
THIS RECOVERY AGENT AS WELL AS
HAD BEEN THERE AND IT HAD BEEN
AN ENTITY TO VERIFY WHO ALL IS
OPERATE IN OUR STATE. OTHER
TROUBLING SITUATIONS HAVE
INCLUDED SHOOTING OF A MILITARY
VETERAN WITH PTSD AFTER COVERING
AGENTS BROKE INTO THE VETERANS
RESIDENTS. THROUGH HIS WINDOW.
GIVE ME. S. AND SEPARATELY.
RECOVERY AGENTS BREAKING INTO AN
INNOCENT FAMILIES HOME WHO HAD
NO RETALIATION TO THE INDIVIDUAL
TO COVER AGENTS WERE TARGETING.
MEMBERS FOR. AN OCCUPATION THAT
IS GIVEN GREATER AUTHORITY THAN
LAW ENFORCEMENT BY NOT REQUIRING
A WARRANT TO ARREST AND ENTER
SOMEONE'S HOME ENHANCE STANDARDS
ARE CRITICAL. BY REQUIRING BAIL
FUGITIVE RECOVERY AGENTS BECOMES
LICENSE AB TWENTY FORTY THREE
WILL NOT ONLY PROVIDE LONG
OVERDUE OVERSIGHT OF ITS
ACTIVATION BUBBLE ALSO PROVIDE.
GREATER CONSUMER PROTECTIONS FOR
HARM MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC
ADDITIONALLY AB TWENTY FORTY
THREE WAS SYSTEM LOCAL AW
ENFORCEMENT IDENTIFYING WHO IS
OPERATING IN THEIR COMMUNITIES.
AND PROVIDE THEM WITH GREATER
INSIGHT WERE RESPONDING TO CALLS
AS WELL AS PROVIDE AN EXTRA TOOL
FOR PROSECUTORS TO HOLD
ACCOUNTABLE. ACCOUNTABLE THOSE
WHO BREAK CALIFORNIA LAW WITH ME
VIA THE TELECONFERENCE LAW TO
SPEAK OF. THOSE MONSTER IS
KENDRA ZOELLER DEPUTY LEAD
DIRECTOR OF THE INSURANCE
COMMISSIONER RICARDO LARA. GOOD
AFTERNOON HUNDRED DOLLAR HERE ON
BEHALF OF INSURANCE COMMISSIONER
RICARDO LARA AND THE CALIFORNIA
DEPARTMENT OF INSURANCE. AS THE
SPONSOR OF THE BILL WE WOULD
LIKE TO THANK ASSEMBLY MEMBER
JONES SAWYER FOR HIS LEADERSHIP
IN OFFERING THE MEASURE. AB FOUR
THREE WOULD CREATE THE FIRST
FAILED. RECOVERY AGENT LICENSE
IN CALIFORNIA THERE BY BRINGING
LONG OVERDUE REGULATORY
OVERSIGHT THAT THEY'LL FIND
INDUSTRY AND ALIGN OUR STATE
WITH EIGHTEEN OTHER STATES THAT
HAVE EXISTING MANDATORY.
LICENSURE IN PLACE BOUNTY HUNTER
DAY BECAUSE OF INSURANCE
REGULATE FAIL BONTA ON BAIL
AGENT. WE OFTEN RECEIVE
COMPLAINTS INVOLVING BALE
FUGITIVE RECOVERY PERSONS
HOWEVER SINCE WE ARE NOT THEIR
REGULATOR THERE IS LITTLE WE CAN
DO. A FEW RECENT AND TRAGIC
INCIDENT INVOLVING BOUNTY
HUNTERS TRYING TO ACKERMAN. AND
THOSE WHO JUMPED BAIL HAVE THE
NEED FOR MORE DEPARTMENT
OVERSIGHT AND FOUNDING. TO THE
PARK FIVE. WE HAVE NOT FOR YEARS
THAT ALLOWING THE INDUSTRY TO
SELF REGULATE IS UNACCEPTABLE
AND THE STATUS QUO HAS NEVER
BEEN ENOUGH. REQUIRING FUGITIVES
RECOVERY PERSONS TO FIRST OBTAIN
A LICENSE PRIOR TO CONDUCTING
BUSINESS IN THE STATE WOULD HELP
CURTAIL RECKLESS PURSUITS
APPREHENSION OF OUR MOST
VULNERABLE POPULATIONS. IN
ADDITION BAILED OF RECOVERY
AGENTS WOULD HAVE TO PASS A
BACKGROUND CHECKS DONE BY THE
CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE
AND THE FEDERAL BUREAU OF
INVESTIGATION PRIOR TO LICENSURE
AND THEY WOULD BE REQUIRED TO
CAROLINE KERRY LIABILITY
INSURANCE WHICH WOULD PROVIDE
HARM CONSUMERS AND CENTRAL
AVENUE TO COLLECT DAMAGES. AB
EIGHT ZERO FOUR THREE IS NEEDED
NOW TO RAISE THE STANDARD FOR
BAIL FUGITIVE RECOVERY PERSON TO
APPREHEND BAIL YOU DID IT AS
WELL AS SHINING. LIGHT ON THE
INDUSTRY IT WILL ALSO
STRENGTHENED THE DEPARTMENT'S
ABILITY TO PROTECT THE PUBLIC
AND PREVENT FUTURE VIOLATIONS OF
LAW THAT READY PUBLIC. I
RESPECTFULLY REQUEST YOUR AYE
THOSE. ON THE MEASURE THANK YOU
. OUR DO YOU HAVE ENOUGH PRIMARY
WITNESS THAT THAT THE WITH
THAT'S ALL ALL RIGHT THEY- IS
THERE ANYONE IN THE ROOM WHO
WOULD LIKE TO SPEAK TO THIS. A.
B. TWENTY FORTY THREE. ARE IN
SUPPORT. NAME AFFILIATION AND
POSITION. MARCO GEORGE ON BEHALF
OF THE CALIFORNIA PUBLIC
DEFENDER ASSOCIATION AND SUPPORT
THANK YOU. VERY GOOD. ALL RIGHT
OUR EYES SYRUP ARE IS ZERO
WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION WE A
PRIMARY WITNESS OKAY COME
FORWARD THEN. YOU HAVE TO TWO
MINUTES. THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE LIKE TO
THANK ASSEMBLYMAN JOHN SORRY FOR
STOPPING THIS IS ALWAYS ON THESE
ISSUES- ALTHOUGH WE SIGNED UP
OPPOSED I'D LIKE SAYS BILLS
PROBABLY 95% FOR MARCH
PERSPECTIVE WHERE IT NEEDS TO BE
WE HAVE ONE ISSUE WHICH I'LL
JUST TALK ABOUT BRIEFLY ALSO
LIKE TO THANK THE STAFF THIS IS
A REALLY GOOD- PROCESS IN TERMS
OF. THE BACK WITH THE DEPARTMENT
AND WOMEN STAFF TO GET TO WHAT I
BELIEVE IS A GOOD PRODUCT IF YOU
LOOK AT MOST THE AMENDMENTS
THOSE FOR ALL PRODUCTS
CONVERSATIONS WE HAD WITH THE
DEPARTMENT. FLAG ON THIS BILL IS
THAT- THE AGENCY RELATIONSHIP
BETWEEN A BAIL AGENT BAIL
RECOVERY AGENTS CREATED BY A
CONTRACT IT VERY SELDOM INVOLVES
AN INSURANCE COMPANY WHICH I
REPRESENT. SO THE AMEND WE WOULD
ASK FOR IS THAT THE PERSON THAT
APPOINTS THE BILL RECOVERY AGENT
FILES THE POINT WITH THE
DEPARTMENT SO THAT WE KNOW WHO'S
RESPONSIBLE. IN I SAID THE
AGENCY RELATIONSHIPIS CREATED
BY THE CONTRACT. BAIL AGENT
HIRED THE BILL RECOVERY AGENT
AND THAT'S THE ONLY THING WE
WOULD ASK ON THIS BILL IS TO
MAKE CLEAR TO THE PUBLIC AND THE
DEPARTMENT WHO'S ULTIMATELY
RESPONSIBLE FOR THE CONDUCT WHEN
THE HIGHER THE BILL RECOVERY
AGENT. OTHER THAN THAT I THINK
THIS IS A GOOD BILL I THINK IT'S
AS THE SOMEONE IN SAID
CONSISTENT WITH. A LEGISLATION
EIGHTEEN OTHER STATES MOST OF
WHICH I'VE WORKED ON- AND I CAN
TELL YOU THIS BILL FAIRLY
CONSISTENT- WITH THE PRACTICE
AND OTHER STATES HAVE CHOSEN TO
REGULATE FORTUNE MY HOME STATE
OF COLORADO HAS NOT SO GIVE HIM
A RING AND LET THEM KNOW- THAT
IT'S TIME BUT AGAIN LIKE
THINKING. THAT WOMEN FOR
STOPPING THIS AND- AND EVEN
THOUGH WE'RE OPPOSE I THINK
THERE'S A SMALL FIX AND UNITE I
SUPPOSE WE CAN LIVE WITH WITH IT
IF THAT THE DOES USUALLY CALL
OPPOSE LESS AMENDED. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU MISTER. THANK YOU
THANK YOU- VERY GOOD- LET'S SEE
SO IS THERE ANYONE IN THE ROOM
WHO WOULD LIKE TO SPEAK IN
OPPOSITION NAME FILIATION A
POSITION. ON TWENTY FORTY THREE
JONES SAWYER BAIL BONDS. DOESN'T
LOOK LIKE IT SO WE'RE GONNA GO
TO THE PHONE. AND- OPERATOR IF
YOU WOULD LIKE TO HEAR FROM
ANYONE IN SUPPORT OR OPPOSITION
FOR TO AB TWENTY FORTY THREE.
JONES SAWYER BAIL BONDS NAME
POSITION AND AFFILIATION IF ANY
ASSEMBLY. THANK YOU AGAIN TO
SPEAK ON AB TWENTY FORTY THREE
PLEASE PRESS ONE THEN ZERO. AND
FIRST WE HAVE LINED ONE EIGHTY
EIGHT PLEASE GO AHEAD. AND ONE
EIGHTY EIGHT YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
WE HAVE LINE TWO HUNDRED FIFTY
TWO FIVE ZERO PLEASE GO AHEAD. I
AM IN SUPPORT OF AB TWENTY FOUR
SEVENTEEN. MINOR IN THAT BOX AND
I WORK WITH CALIFORNIA CONNECT
AND THE LAST CHANCE THAT WEEKEND
AND ENCOUNTERING MANAGER I'M AT
THE PORT FOR EIGHTEEN TWENTY
FOUR SEVENTEEN THANK YOU YEAH
THAT'S THE WRONG BELL BUT- WE
APPRECIATE IT NOT THE TAPE CUT
WILL HELP. US OKAY YOU VERY.
THANK YOU AND NEXT WE LINE FIFTH
FOUR PLEASE GO AHEAD. NINE TWO
FIVE FOR YOUR LINE IS OPEN. SO
NEXT WE HAVE LINE TWO FOUR FOUR
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. YES THIS IS
AUBURN MARATHON HERE ON BEHALF
I'M SPEAKING ON BEHALF OF THOSE
STATE BAILEY DISASSOCIATION- WE
MUST OPPOSE THIS BILL UNLESS IT
IS AMENDED AS PACIFIC WE THE
INSURANCE REQUIREMENT IS ONE
WORKABLE AS IT'S CURRENTLY TRUCK
. BECAUSE FUGITIVE RECOVERY IS
DIFFICULT TO OBTAIN AND
PROHIBITIVE EXPENSIVE. HOWEVER
MUCH SAY THE ALL AND DO STAFF
AND THEAPART OF. HAS DONE A
VERY JOB OR WITH US AND THEY
HAVE COMMITTED TO WORK US ON THE
EDGE. ISSUE SO WE ARE BOTH THAT
MATTER COOPER IN THE CAN REMOVE
OFFICE. OKAY I THAT. IT WAS MORE
NAY AND POSITION. BOB BECAUSE IT
I THINK IT- EDUCATED US HERE SO
. I ANYONE ELSE DAY POSITION AND. AND THAT IS ALL THAT I HAD AND. THAT'S ALL THEN- WITH THE BILL
SECOND- ANY COMMENTS. ALL RIGHT
NO COMMENTS THEREFORE- I KNOW
THE CHAIR IS IN FAVOR OF THIS
BILL. AND SO MY PLEASE CLOSER OF
AND SO I AND I WANT TO THANK
EVERYBODY THAT'S BEEN WORKING ON
THIS AND- AND I PROBABLY WILL
NOT PROBABLY I WILL- INTERJECT
ONE MORE IN THIS THURSDAY I HAVE
A REPUBLICAN COLLEAGUE. THIS ON
INSURANCE WHO HAS SEVEN OR EIGHT
DIFFERENT ENSURE- LICENSE. AND
WE JUST BOTH OF THESE OPTION AND
HE HAS SOME VERY GOOD IN AND IF
THE THREE OF US COULD TOGETHER
WITH THE BAIL BONDSMAN IN AB BE
THE- MEMBER SANTEE- RANDY VOEPEL
. WHO CAN LIGHTEN ME UP THIS
THIS. AND HAS SOME REALLY INPUT
BUT I THINK WOULD BE VERY
HELPFUL ESPECIALLY AS THIS MOVES
TO THE INSURANCE. COMMITTEE
COMMITTEE- THAT WILL ALSO SHED
SOME LIGHT ON HIS PERFECT
PERSPECTIVE AND A LOT OF TIMES
OF MY SIDE OF THE AISLE DUTTON
IN LIST. SOME OR- FROM THE OTHER
SIDE OF THE HOUSE SO I WOULD I
WOULD BELIEVE THAT IT WOULD BE
VERY GOOD FOR US TO CONTINUE
THIS PROCESS. AND I THINK ONCE
WE ALL SIT DOWN WILL BE ABLE TO
COME UP WITH THE AN EQUITABLE
SOLUTION FOR. FOR BOTH THE
INSURANCE AND WHO. WHO NEEDS TO
BE REPORTED TO BUT INSURANCE
COMPANY OR THE BOND AGENCY
BECAUSE THESE CONTRACTS COULD
BE- WE JUST NEED TO LOOK AT THE
- I RESPECTFULLY ASK RIVAL ALL
RIGHT. LET'S SEE THAT EVERYTHING
BEING DONE THAT AND SECRETARY
PLEASE CALL LAUREL AND AB ON AB
TWENTY FORTY THREE BASS JOHNSON-
THE MOTION IS DUE PASSED TO THE
INSURANCE COMMITTEE JONES SAWYER
HI GENSER IRAQI STATE LACKEY
ABSTAINED BONTA I'VE BONTA HI
BRIAN. WORK HI WORK I SANTIAGO.
SEYARTO THE R. TEN NOT VOTING
THAT MEASURE. NEEDS TO WORK
THANK YOU. MISS PETRI NORRIS WHY
DON'T YOU COME FORWARD. YOU MAY
BEGIN. THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR
AND THAT GOOD AFTERNOON MEMBERS
I'M HERE TODAY TO PRESENT
ASSEMBLY BELT TWENTY TWO SIX. AB
TWO TWO FOUR SIX AIMS TO PREVENT
FEDERAL POISONING BY
STRENGTHENING PENALTIES FOR THE
TRAFFICKING OF THIS DEADLY DRUG
WITH A SPECIAL FOCUS FOR
ATTEMPTS TO SELL TO CHILDREN AND
ON SOCIAL MEDIA. THE JOURNAL IS
ONE OF THE MOST DANGEROUS AND
DEADLY SUBSTANCES IN THE WORLD
JUST TWO MILLIGRAMS TO
MILLIGRAMS OF FUNCTIONAL IS TWO
GRAINS OF SAND IS ENOUGH TO
KILL. AND KILL EIGHT IT
CERTAINLY HAS ACCORDING TO
CALIFORNIA'S DEPARTMENT OF
PUBLIC HEALTH FROM TWENTY
SIXTEEN TO TWENTY TWENTY
STATEWIDE FEDERAL DEBTS
INCREASED BY ONE THOUSAND FIVE
HUNDRED AND FIFTY ONE. I
1000510051% SYNTHETIC OPIOIDS
LIKE FENTANYL NOW ACCOUNT FOR
ONE AS HER TWO THIRDS OF
NATIONWIDE DRUG RELATED DEATHS
BUT TWO DISTURBING TRENDS REALLY
HAVE DRAMATICALLY ESCALATED THE
DANGERS OF FUNCTIONAL AT FIRST
THE DECEPTIVE USE OF FENTANYL IN
COUNTERFEIT PILLS. AND SECOND
THE USE OF SOCIAL MEDIA TRAFFIC
THESE SUBSTANCES AND THIS POISON
OUR CHILDREN INTO YOUNG PEOPLE.
FEDERAL IS EASY AND CHEAP TO
MANUFACTURE AND IT'S OFF MAST
AND MARKETED IN THE FORM OF
COUNTERFEIT PRESCRIPTION
MEDICINE THERE BEEN THOUSAND OF
REPORTS INDIVIDUALS WHO DIE OF A
FENCE IS. AFTER CONSUMING A THAT
THEY WERE MISLED TO BELIEVE WAS
SOMETHING ELSE ALTOGETHER. I IN
FACT THE DRUG ENFORCEMENT
ADMINISTRATION THE D. E. A.
RECENTLY RELEASED A WARNING ON
THE SHARP INCREASE IN FAKE
PRESCRIPTION DRUGS CONTAINING
FENTANYL. I THIS DRUG PRODUCED A
CRISIS IN OUR COMMUNITIES AND
IT'S INCUMBENT THAT WE ACT NOW
TO PROTECT OUR COMMUNITIES. AND
ESPECIALLY OUR KIDS FROM THIS
PRESENT. THESE ARE TO BE JOINED
TODAY BY TWO WITNESSES WHO WILL
SHARE THEIR STORIES AND THEIR
EXPERIENCE WITH FUNCTIONAL.
WE'RE JOINED BY AND AMY NOVEL
AND CHRISTY. HI MY NAME'S AMY
LEVEL. AND I'M HERE ON BEHALF OF
MY SON ALEXANDER NOBLE. HE ALEX
WITH ADOBE FOURTEEN YEAR OLD
FROM THE SUBURBS OF THE
SKATEBOARD AND A BRIGHT FUTURE.
HE DID MAKE THE DECISION NOT TO
MAKE TO PURCHASE A PILL VIA
SNAPCHAT AND HAD IT DELIVERED TO
OUR HOME JUST LIKE EASY AS
ORDERING A PIZZA. ALEXANDER DIED
SOMETIME IN THE NIGHT IN HIS
BEDROOM. FROM WHAT I SAW ON
SNAPCHAT AND ALEXANDER AND WHAT
I HEARD FROM ALEXANDER'S FRIEND
FRIENDS THIS DEALER OPENLY
DENIED ON SNAPCHAT WHAT WAS
PLAIN HIS PILLS CONTAINED
FENTANYL AND KILLED MY SON. THIS
IS THE SAME DEALER IS NOW
CONNECTED TO SEVERAL MORE DEATHS
BEFORE ALEXANDER'S DEATH AND
AFTER. I'M NOT A VINDICTIVE
PERSON BUT I DO BELIEVE THAT
MONSTERS LIKE HIM SHOULD NOT BE
ALLOWED TO ROAM FREELY ROAM OUR
NEIGHBORHOODS AND ONLINE. WE
SHOULD MAKE EFFORTS TO
INCARCERATE THOSE WHO KNOWINGLY
PEDDLE POISON AND DEADLY
AMOUNTS. I ASSURE YOU THAT FENCE
ALL IS A POISON. WITH COCAINE
AND HEROIN ONE HAS TO CONSUME
DISPROPORTIONATE AMOUNTS TO
OVERDOSE. TODAY FENCE NOT
REQUIRED NO MORE THAN A PENSION
TO KILL FOUR POPLE. THIS DRUG
KILLS AND WE NEED TO ACT LIKE
IT. FOR ALMOST TEN YEARS VINCE
ALWAYS BEEN GROWING AND
MULTIPLYING IN OUR DRUG STREAM
LIKE A VIRUS. IT IS NOW IN THE
MAJORITY OF ILLICIT DRUGS YET WE
CONTINUE TO BEHAVE THAT THE DRUG
CLIMATE IS THE SAME AS IT'S
ALWAYS BEEN. IT'S NOT TODAY
TODAY'S ILLICIT DRUG MARKET
RACKS UP OVER A HUNDRED THOUSAND
AMERICAN DRUG DEATHS A YEAR
DRIVEN LARGELY BY SENTINEL. THAT
NUMBER IS STILL GOING UP BECAUSE
COMMITTEES LIKE THIS STOP
HELPING DISTRICT ATTORNEY'S
SCHOOLS AND CLINICIANS WITH OUR
DRUG PROBLEM. LIKE IT OR NOT
AMERICANS WILL CONTINUE TO
EXPERIMENT AND CONSUME. DRUGS TO
GET HIGHER TO TREAT PAIN OR
WHATEVER REASON THEY HAVE. WE
NEED TO HELP PEOPLE BEFORE
DURING AND AFTER THEY USE THEM.
FOR DECADES WE WITNESSED THE WAR
THE OLD DRUG OR FAILURES WE SAW
PRISONS OVERFLOW FOCUSED UPON
MINORITY COMMUNITIES AND ARE NOW
SELF PARALYZED DUE TO OVER
CORRECTION. THIS SHOULD BE AT
THE TOP OF EVERYONE'S MIND HERE
WHEN CONSIDERING ENHANCING
PENALTIES. WE SHOULD FOLLOW THE
EXAMPLES IN PORTUGAL IN EUROPE
OR PENALTIES WERE RE EVALUATED
ACROSS THE BOARD. PUBLIC HEALTH
IS PRIORITIZE AND DRUG EDUCATION
IS REQUIRED AS PART OF HARM
REDUCTION. FOR THESE REASONS I
SAW THIS BILL AS A FIRST STEP.
THE TERMS OF THIS BILL WAY OUT
REASONABLE PENALTIES FOR
FENTANYL DISTRIBUTION. THIS BILL-FOCUSES UPON SPECIFIC METHODS OF
SALE THIS BILL IS FOCUSED UPON A
DRUG THAT LITERALLY KILLS PEOPLE
. CALIFORNIA NEEDS AB TWENTY TWO
FORTY SIX TO GO TO THE FLOOR FOR
DEBATE. YOU ARE AWARE OF THE
PROBLEM WITH INTERNAL NOW IT'S
TIME TO LET THE PUBLIC HAVE A
SAY BY LETTING THEIR
REPRESENTATIVES DISCUSSED IT AND
DECIDE THANK YOU. THANK YOU MIKE
WAS. WHENEVER YOU A TO DAY AFTER
CHRISTMAS IN TWENTY TWENTY I
FOUND MY SEVEN YEAR OLD SON ZACH
APPEARING TO BE ASLEEP ONLY TO
FIND HIM NOT BREATHING LOSING A
CHILD FROM A DANGER WE HAD NOT
HEARD OF BEFORE HAS BROUGHT
DEBILITATING TORMENT TO OUR
FAMILY. SACRAMENTO THE
COUNTERFEIT PRESCRIPTION PILLS
AND CHAD TO CONTAIN ONLY
FUNCTIONAL HI DESPITE HAVING NO
HISTORY OF DRUG USE. ZACH DIED
FROM FENTANYL POISONING. ZACH
WAS A SELF TAUGHT MUSICIAN
BONAFIDE STRAIGHT A STUDENT
ACCOMPLISH MULTI SPORT ATHLETE
LEAD ROLE IN A HIGH SCHOOL
MUSICAL AND ACTIVE IN SCOUTING.
SINCE HIS PASSING ZACH WAS
ACCEPTED INTO FIVE UC'S
INCLUDING UCLA. LIKE SO MANY
ZACH HAS DEMONSTRATED SUCCESS
AND SHOWED PROMISE TO BRING
INNOVATION AND PROGRESS TO OUR
WORLD IN A BEAUTIFUL WAY.
INSTEAD HE WAS ROBBED OF THAT
CHANCE CDC HAS REPORTED OVER ONE
HUNDRED TO FIVE THOUSAND LIVES
LOST IN OUR NATION FROM DRUGS IN
THE PAST TWELVE MONTH PERIOD.
AND ABOUT SEVENTY THOUSAND
ATTRIBUTED TO SYNTHETICS MOSTLY
FENSOM. THAT'S A FINAL DEATH
RATE ABOUT ONE EVERY SEVEN AND A
HALF MINUTES AND TWENTY TWENTY
ONE THE U. S. BECAUSE- ORDER
PROTECTION. AGENCY REPORTED OVER
ELEVEN THOUSAND POUNDS OF
FENTANYL THAT WERE CONFISCATED
AND YET ESTIMATE ONLY ONLY 5%
ARE ACTUALLY BEING SEIZED THE
RADICALLY THAT'S TWO HUNDRED AND
THIRTEEN THOUSAND POUNDS OF
FENTANYL. THAT ARE STILL ON OUR
STREETS TODAY FROM ONLY ONE YEAR
OF TRUCK TRAFFICKING. YET
DEALERS ARE KNOWINGLY AND
WILLINGLY WILLINGLY SELLING
ILLICIT PRODUCTS CONTAINING
FENTANYL TO UNSUSPECTING YOUNG
ADULTS ON SOCIAL MEDIA FOR AN
EASY PROFIT. CALIFORNIA IS A HOT
SPOT STATE ALONG THE BORDER AND
THIS EVIDENCE SHOWS THERE IS A
CLEAR PUBLIC SAFETY DANGER AND
IT IS ONLY WORSENING. IN THIS
BILL TO THE FLOOR WOULD SHOW A
LACK OF PRIORITY TO ENSURE
PUBLIC SAFETY. THE NATURE OF
THIS CRISIS SHOULD ALLOW THE
ENTIRE ASSEMBLY THE RIGHT AND
THE RESPONSIBILITY. TO STUDY AND
IMPLEMENT ACCOUNTABILITY
MEASURES TO STOP TRAFFICKERS
FROM VICTIMIZING THE PUBLIC WHO
ARE UNWITTINGLY INGESTING
FENTANYL AND DINE. THINK ABOUT
IT I FELT NO RELATED DEATH EVERY
SEVEN AND A HALF MINUTES PLEASE
SUPPORT AB TWENTY TWO FORTY SIX
STANNIS HOLIDAY ALREADY WITH US
WITH OUR FAMILY AND SO MANY
OTHER FAMILIES IN OUR NATION AND
HELP SAVE OUR NATION'S FUTURE
THANK. ARE THERE WITNESSES IN
SUPPORT IN THE ROOM MAKE TO NAME
AN ORGANIZATION GOOD AFTERNOON
MR CHAIRMAN RESOLUTION MUCH
THERE ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA STATE SHERIFFS
ASSOCIATION SUPPORT THANK YOU.
THANK YOU. MISTER CHAIRMAN RYAN
SHERMAN WITH THE RIVERSIDE
SHERIFF'S ASSOCIATION ALSO
REPRESENTING POLICE OFFICERS.
CLEAR CORONA POMONA PALACE
VERDES NEWPORT BEACH UPLAND
SANTA ANA BURBANK INGLEWOOD
ARCADIA RIVERSIDE FULLERTON IN
CULVER CITY ON SUPPORT THANK YOU
THANK YOU. OR ANY OTHER
WITNESSES IN ROME. OR OUTSIDE.
AT&T OPERATOR WE CAN NOW GO TO
THE PHONE LINES OPEN UP FOR
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT. AB TWENTY
TWO FORTY SIX PETRIE-NORRIS.
THANK YOU TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF
AB TWENTY TWO FORTY SIX PLEASE
PRESS ONE THEN ZERO. WE'LL START
WITH NINE ONE NINETY ONE PLEASE
GO AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON THE
COLD WAR LIMON ON BEHALF OF THE
ORANGE COUNTY BOARD OF
SUPERVISORS IN SUPPORT. THANK
YOU. NEXT WE HAVE LINE. ONE
MOMENT WHILE THEY'RE GETTING
THEIR MY NUMBERS FROM THE
OPERATORS WE HAVE FLIGHT NUMBER
TWO TWENTY EIGHT PLEASE GO AHEAD
. CARAMEL GOLO- MY PHONE WAS
POISONED BY FUNDS ALONE AND-
PASSED AWAY AND- I SUPPORT THE
BILL. THANK YOU. THANK YOU NEXT
FROM A LINE OF TWO TWENTY SIX
PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI MY NAME IS
LAURIE DID YEAR ANOTHER AS THE
FACTORY DID HERE IN- CALCUTTA.
FOR LEGISLATION. THANK YOU THANK
YOU EVERYONE TO SIXTY NINE
PLEASE GO AHEAD THIS IS JILL TO
DISSECT I SUPPORT AB TWENTY TWO
FORTY SIX THANK YOU. NEXT NINE
TO SEVENTY THREE PLEASE GO AHEAD
. MISTER CARE MEMBERS LIEUTENANT
BRANDON UP ON BEHALF OF THE LOS
ANGELES COUNTY SHERIFF IN
SUPPORT THANK YOU. THANK YOU
SIR. NINE TWO SEVENTY TWO PLEASE
GO AHEAD. HELLO YES YOUR LINE IS
OPEN YEAH I'M A MOTHER OF TWO
TEAMS WHO LOST A FAMILY MEMBER
TICKET NOW CUISINE AND I AM FOR
PART OF THE BILL AB. TWO TWO
FOUR SIX. CAN'T NINE FIFTY SEVEN
YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. HELLO MY NAME'S PATRICK
GREEN AND I LOST A NEPHEW TO
FENTANYL POISONING AND I AM IN
STRONG SUPPORT OF BILLS A. B.
TWO TWO FOUR SIX. THANK YOU. IN
LINE TO SIX PLEASE GO AHEAD.
HELLO MY NAME IS MERRIAM I'M
CALLING WITH ADVOCACY GROUP
PARENTS AGAINST AND SMALL
CALLING OUT OF SACRAMENTO
CALIFORNIA WERE MY ONLY CHILD
WITH SEVENTEEN WAS KILLED A
COUNTERFEIT PRESCRIPTION PILLS
BEING SOLD BY SOMEBODY WHO KNEW
THE SUBSTANCE COULD ACTUALLY BUT
MALL THERE FOR MURDERING MY SON
BY PUTTING HIM TO DEATH. I'M
CALLING IN STRONG SUPPORT OF
THIS BILL. THANK YOU. NINE ONE
EIGHTY FIVE PLEASE GO AHEAD. MY
NAME IS PEARL MENDOZA AN
EXECUTIVE BOARD MEMBER OF BOYS
EXAMS OF THE LISTED DRUG POINT
IS A CO SPONSOR OF EIGHTEEN
TWENTY TO FORTY SIX SO ON BEHALF
OF BOYS WE STRONGLY SUPPORT THE
BILL AND NOTHING WE WILL AS
WELL. THANK YOU. NINE SIX FIVE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. TWO SIXTY FIVE
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. WE'LL GO TO
LINE TWO SIXTY SIX PLEASE GO
AHEAD. HI MY NAME IS JESSICA
COMPUTER AND I IN SUPPORT OF. AB
TWO FOUR TWO TWO FOUR AND THE
HALF OF MY SEVENTEEN YEAR OLD
NEPHEW WHO PASSED AWAY FROM ONE
CELL. HELLO NINETEEN SIXTY SEVEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI MY NAME IS A
MARKET THAT I LAW WELL. ACTUALLY
YOU AND ALL UP FOR THAT. EIGHT
EIGHT EIGHT TWO TWO FOUR SIX.
TRYING TWO FIFTY SIX PLEASE GO
AHEAD. HELLO MY NAME IS ALL THE
MENTAL SIDE LAW I THANK SENT NOT
POISONING AND I'M IN SUPPORT OF.
SENATE BILL TWO TWO FOUR SIX
THANK YOU. NINE TWO SEVEN FIVE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI MY NAME IS
MERCY CAVALEIRO I'M CALLING ON
BEHALF OF ISAAC AND SALAS MY SON
WHO IS FIFTEEN AT THE END OF
SENTINEL AND I'M IN FULL SUPPORT. THE LAST LINE I HAD IN Q.
THANK YOU FOR NOW HEAR FROM
WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION TO- AB
TWENTY TWO FORTY SIX. A FAMILY
YOU COULD ALLOW THEM TO HAVE AT
THE SEE THANK. THE. GOOD
AFTERNOON CHAIR AND MEMBERS AND
I WANT TO START BY- OFFERING MY
CONDOLENCES TO ALL THE FAMILY
MEMBERS- OF PEOPLE WHO HAVE
OVERDOSED FROM SENTINEL MY NAME
IS JENNA HEY WHAT I'M THE
ASSOCIATE DIRECTOR OF COMMUNITY
MOBILIZATION AT THE NATIONAL
HARM REDUCTION COALITION WE ARE
A CAPACITY BUILDING AND ADVOCACY
ORGANIZATION WHO BUILDS BASED
STRATEGIES WITH AND FOR PEOPLE
WHO USE DRUGS OUR APPROACH IS
ROOTED IN THE FACT THAT MOST
DRUG RELATED HARMS ARE CAUSED BY
FAILED POLICY AND NOT ACTUAL
DRUG AND- I AM ALL HERE. AS A
FORMER INJECTS DRUG USE WHO IS
NOW IN RECOVERY RESPECTFULLY
OPPOSE AB ME TO FORTY. I DID JOB
IS AND BUILDING HARVARD PROGRAMS
THROUGHOUT CALIFORNIA I WORK%
WITH DOZENS OF DIRECT SERVICE
PROVIDERS AND PARTICIPANTS OF
HARM REDUCTION PROGRAMS AND ALL
OF US WANT TO AND OVERDOSE DEATH
AB TWENTY FORTY SIX IS NOT
CERTAIN OVER. AS I SAY DOWN AT
MY COMPUTER YES TO REPAIR MY
STATEMENT I OPENED IN A FROM A
MOTHER IN. SHE WANTED TO THANK
US FOR OUR WORK AND TELL US
ABOUT HOW SHE HAD RECENTLY LOST
HER HER SECOND SON TO OVERDOSE
HER AND HER SON ALLEN HAD
OVERDOSED IN THE BACK OF A
POLICE CAR UNDER CUSTODY ON
MARCH TWENTY THIRD TWENTY TWENTY
TWO. AND WAS DEAD FOR OVER AN
HOUR BEFORE OFFICERS OPENED THE
DOOR TO CHECK ON HIM. THIS IS
ONE OF HUNDREDS OF INSTANCES
WHERE POLICE INTERVENTION THAT
IS EXPECTED TO INCREASE SAFETY.
HAS INSTEAD ONLY CAUSE MORE
HARM. THE OVERDOSE CRISIS WILL
NOT BE SOLVED BY ENHANCED
SENTENCING FOR LOW LEVEL DRUG
SELLERS MANY OF WHOM ARE USING
THEMSELVES. THE REALITY IS THAT
NOW IS PART OF THE DRUG SUPPLY
NOW AND FOCUSING ON
CRIMINALIZING PEOPLE WHO SELL
DRUGS ON SOCIAL MEDIA IS NOT
GOING TO STOP DRUG USE OR DRUG
SALES. AND IT'S CERTAINLY NOT
GOING TO FIX THE DRUG SUPPLY.
PROHIBITION AND CRIMINALIZATION
HAVE LONG BEEN TACTICS IN THE
WAR ON DRUGS AND WE HAVE SEEN
THAT BAIL OVER OVER AGAIN. WHEN
OVER NINE THOUSAND FOUR HUNDRED
AND SIXTY TWO OVERDOSE DEATHS
BETWEEN JUNE TWENTY TWENTY AND
JUNE TWENTY TWENTY ONE. IN
CALIFORNIA. THE LEGISLATURE
URGENTLY NEEDS TO ACT WHAT WE
SEE ON THE GROUND IS THAT HARM
REDUCTION WORKS AND I DON'T JUST
MEAN IN TERMS OF DISEASE
PREVENTION. THE PRINCIPLES AND
PRACTICES OF HARM REDUCTION CAN
BE INCORPORATED INTO OUR
PREVENTION TREATMENT AND
RECOVERY EFFORTS. TO MEET PEOPLE
WHERE THEY ARE ON THE DRUG USE
CONTINUE- AND KEEP PEOPLE WHO
USE DRUGS ALIVE. WHETHER THEY'RE
HABITUAL USERS ARE YOUNG PEOPLE
EXPERIMENTING WITH DRUGS FOR THE
FIRST TIME. IT'S IMPERATIVE THAT
YOUNG PEOPLE HAVE ACCESS TO DRUG
EDUCATION THAT IS EVIDENCE BASED
AND DOESN'T ONLY ENCOURAGE THEM
TO AVOID DRUGS. IT MUST ALSO
PROVIDE INFORMATION ON HOW THEY
CAN REDUCE RISK. THEY NEED
SOMEONE THEY CAN BE HONEST ABOUT
WHAT'S GOING ON FOR THEM WHO CAN
PROVIDE STIGMA FREE SUPPORT. I
HAVE TWO SMALL CHILDREN AND
BELIEVE ME I DO NOT HOPE FOR
THEM TO END UP. DRUG DEPENDENT
THE WAY I WAS. I NOW UNDERSTAND
THE GUT WRENCHING WORRYMY MOM
HAD. FEARING THAT OUR CHILD
MIGHT DIE IN VIEW FEELING
POWERLESS. SHE ABSOLUTELY WOULD
HAVE WANTED THE FRIENDS THAT I
USE WITH LOCKED UP IF THAT MEANT
IT WOULD HAVE. MY TRUTH WHAT IT
WAS GOOD AND WHERE TO GET HIRED
A MATTER. I WOULD TO SEVEN CORE
OR DRUG PER THAT EIGHTY AND
TWENTY YEARS OLD AND THAT ONE OF
THEM STOPPED ME FROM USING I AM
LUCKY TO STAND HERE TODAY AND
TELL MY STORY OR SIT HERE TODAY
AND TELL MY STORY AND- A LOT OF
THAT HAS TO DO WITH THE
DIFFERENCES IN DRUG SUPPLY-
TWENTY YEARS AGO. BECAUSE I DID
NOT HAVE NALOXONE I MOSTLY USE
ALONE AND I HAD NO ONE TO TALK
HONESTLY WITH ABOUT MY USE. WELL
MANDATED TREATMENT RARELY WORKS
WE KNOW FROM BEING ON THE GROUND
WITH DIRECT SERVICE PROVIDERS
AND PEOPLE WHO USE DRUGS THAT
TREATMENT IS STILL NOT READILY
AVAILABLE FOR PEOPLE. WHO DO
WANT IT AS PART OF MY WORK IN
CALIFORNIA WE PROVIDED GRANT
FUNDING TO THIRTY SEVEN HARM
REDUCTION PROGRAMS TO EXPAND
STAFFING FOR NAVIGATION TO
TREATMENT. WE ADVOCATED FOR THIS
FUNDING ALONG WITH THE
CALIFORNIA SYRINGE EXCHANGE
PROGRAM COALITION. AFTER HEARING
FROM PROGRAM FOR. THAT THEY
COULD NOT ACCESS TREATMENT WHEN
THEY WANTED IT. TODAY TWO YEARS
AND REFERRALS AND LINKAGES TO
TREATMENT HAVE TRIPLED. HARM
REDUCTION APPROACHES LIKE THIS
INITIATIVE COULD BE SCALED UP TO
MEET THE NEEDS OF PEOPLE AT ANY
STAGE OF DRUG USE. WE ALSO KNOW
THAT WHILE CALIFORNIA HAS DONE A
LOT OF WORK TO MAKE NALOXONE
ACCESSIBLE WE HAVE A LONG WAY TO
GO TO A LINE WITH NALOXONE
DISTRIBUTION BEST PRACTICES.
RESEARCH SUGGESTS THAT COMMUNITY
SATURATION OF NALOXONE REDUCES
OVERDOSE DEATH. I WAS VISITING
SOME PROGRAMS IN SAN DIEGO LAST
WEEKEND PARTICIPANTS THERE
REPORTED HAVING TO USE MULTIPLE
DOSES OF NALOXONE TO REVERSE AN
OVERDOSE. DUE TO THE POTENCY OF
THE LOCAL DRUG SUPPLY. THESE
INDIVIDUALS WERE ABLE TO GET THE
SUPPLIES THEY NEEDED TO KEEP
THEMSELVES AND THEIR COMMUNITY
SAFE. BUT THIS IS NOT. IN EVERY
COUNTY AND EVEN IN COUNTY STROP
OVERDOSE PREVENTION AND
EDUCATION PROGRMS. THERE ARE
STILL MAJOR GAPS IN
AVAILABILITY. SOME THIS IS ABOUT
SUPPLY AND FUNDING BUT SOME OF
IT IS ABOUT MISINFORMATION AND
STIGMA. THE SAME DAY IN SAN
DIEGO I TALKED TO SOME PROVIDERS
WHO ARE MISINFORMED ABOUT THE
LAWS AROUND THE LOCKS OWN. AND
CONCERNED ABOUT PROVIDER
LIABILITY AND THEREFORE WE'RE
RESTRICTING HOW AND WHEN IT WAS
DISTRIBUTED TO CLIENTS AND
COMMUNITY MEMBERS. WE NEED ANTI
STICK. EDUCATION CAMPAIGNS
FOCUSED ON OVERDOSE PREVENTION
AND WE NEED TO SCALE UP NALOXONE
ACCESS. AND DISTRIBUTION TO
SATURATE EVERY COMMUNITY WITH
THIS LIFESAVING MEDICATION. TIME
IS A- GOOD. FINISH UP THE LAST
TIME I WENT TO DRUG TREATMENT I
WENT VOLUNTARILY TO A REHAB
PROGRAM IN ORANGE COUNTY. AND I
AM SO GRATEFUL FOR THAT PROGRAM
BECAUSE I'VE BEEN AND WE
BECAUSE- WE COVER EVER SINCE.
BUT THE REALITY FOR THE MAJORITY
OF THOSE WHO I WENT TO TREATMENT
WITH WAS THAT THEY WERE NOT
READY OR THE ABSTINENCE MODEL
DIDN'T WORK FOR THEM. A LOT OF
THEM GOT KICKED OUT OF TREATMENT
AND WENT OUT INTO A COMMUNITY
THAT HAD NO HARM REDUCTION
SERVICES THEY SHARED SYRINGES
THEY OVERDOSED AND DIED THEY GOT
TREATMENT TREATED TERRIBLY BY
POLICE AND EMTS WHEN THEY WERE
LUCKY ENOUGH TO GET REVIVED.
THEY HAD NO ACCESS TO NALOXONE
AND NO TO MEET THE WHERE THEYWERE WITH THEIR USE. THE REALITY
IS THAT WE DO KNOW STRATEGIES TO
CURB OVERDOSE TO OVERDOSE DEATHS
AND HARSHER SENTENCING IS NOT
ONE OF THEM. IT ONLY CONTRIBUTES
TO THE HARMS PEOPLE NAVIGATING
SYSTEMS FACE WITH AN UNREGULATED
DRUG SUPPLY INTERNALIZED AN
EXTERNAL STIGMA. AND A FRACTURED
MEDICAL CARE AND TREATMENT
SYSTEM RECOVERY JOURNEYS MAY
OCCASIONALLY START IN JAILS AND
WITH PLEASE AND OUR INTERACTIONS
BUT WE KNOW THAT IT'S MORE
LIKELY THAT GRIEF STORIES START
THERE THAT PEOPLE DIE IN CUSTODY
LIKE THE MOM GREETING HER CHILD
IN TENNESSEE TODAY. WE WILL
RECORDS DO NOT HELP PEOPLE
RECOVER NOT ONLY FROM STORIES
BUT FROM DECADES OF FAILED DRUG
POLICY. FOR THESE REASONS I
RESPECTFULLY URGE AND NOVO ON AB
TWENTY TWO FORTY SIX THANK YOU
THANK YOU TERRY ANY OTHER
WITNESSES IN A ROOM NAME AND
ORGANIZATION ONLY. MEMBERS DEREK
MORGAN WITH THE OTHER BAKER
CENTER FOR HUMAN RIGHTS
RESPECTFUL OPPOSITION. THANK YOU. MONNING ADRIANA GROWTH OF
MEMBER OF THOSE IN RECOVERY AND
STRONG OPPOSITION THANK YOU.
SERIK ME ON BEHALF OF INITIATE
JUSTICE AND AS AN INDIVIDUAL WHO
HAS PERSONALLY RESUSCITATED
THEIR LOVED ONE FROM FAT NOT
OVERDOSE WE ARE IN RESPECTFUL
OPPOSITION THANK YOU. POLICE IN
LEWIS ON BEHALF OF DRUG POLICY
ALLIANCE IN STRONG OPPOSITION.
FRED WAS ACLU CAL ACTION IN
OPPOSITION. HE MARCO GEORGE
CALIFORNIA PUBLIC DEFENDERS
ASSOCIATION AND OPPOSITION THANK
YOU THANK YOU. I WOULD NOW GO TO
THE PHONE LINES WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION AT&T OPERATOR OPEN UP
. FOR AB TWENTY TWO FORTY SIX P.
TAKEN UP OF AB TWENTY TWO SIX
PLEASE PRESS ONE THEN. ZERO SHE
AND ONE MOMENT WE ASSIGN MY
NUMBERS. GO TO THE LINE OF THE
NUMBER ONE EIGHTY EIGHT PLEASE
GO AHEAD. BOLIVIA CAMPBELL IN
OPPOSITION THANK YOU. NEXT WE
HAVE LINE SIXTY ONE PLEASE GO
AHEAD. FINALLY THIRTY VETERANS
FREEDOM CENTER AND RESPECTFUL
OPPOSITION OF THE BILL. NINE TO
NINETY ONE PLEASE GO AHEAD. MY
GOOD MORNING MY NAME IS ANITA
SIMONS AND I LIVE IN OCEANSIDE
CALIFORNIA AND I AM CALLING IN
STRONG OPPOSITION TO A. B. TWO
TWO FOUR SIX THANK YOU. AND TWO
EIGHTY THREE PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI
MY NAME IS IT IS BEING HIDDEN
UNDER. ON MY GRANDSON DIED FROM
FENTANYL SO I SUPPORT AB TWENTY
TWO FORTY SIX UNSYNCHRONIZED IF
NOT- BUT IT DOES IT FROM MIDDAY
. SO YOU WOULD OF THE- THANK YOU
THANK YOU AT. GO TO THE LINE OF
TO PLEASE GO AHEAD WHAT ABOUT
TOMORROW TO FROM HER OF
COMMITTEE- HOPE IN STRONG. TO AB
TWO TO FOUR SIX THANK YOU. THANK
YOU AN ACTIVE LINE TWO NINE ZERO
PLEASE GO AHEAD. MY NAME IS BILL
MATT AND I'M CALLING IN STRONG
OPPOSITION A. B. TWO TWO FOUR
SIX WE HAVE THE SIDEWALK PROJECT
THANK YOU. WE ARE BLIND EIGHT
TWO PLEASE GO AHEAD. HELLO MY
NAME IS CAROL NEW YORK AND I AM
CALLING IN STRONG OPPOSITION TO
EIGHTY TWO TWO FOUR THANK ON
BEHALF OF THE HARM REDUCTION AND
AN ORANGE COUNTY CALIFORNIA.
ANNEX WE HAVE NINE TWO NINE
THREE PLEASE GO AHEAD. THANK.
NINETY NINE THREE PLEASE GO
AHEAD. WILL BE GOOD TERRACE IN
STRONG SUPPORT. AB. TWO TWO FOUR
SIX. THANK YOU THANK YOU AN- ONE
SIX EIGHT PLEASE GO AHEAD. YEAH
HI MARK CAMPANELLA FROM HEALTH
CARE LOS ANGELES IN SUPER STRONG
OPPOSITION OF TWO TWO FOUR SIX
WE'VE GONE DOWN THIS PATH WE'VE
ELECTED PEOPLE OF COLOR WAY TOO
LONG. THANK YOU AND I HAVE NO
ONE ELSE IN Q. THANK YOU BRING
NOW BACK TO COMMITTEE FOR LIKE
TO SAY SOMETHING DIRECTLY. FIRST
OF ALL. LET ME SAY- I'M SO SORRY
FOR THE- WITNESSES WHO. ENTERED
UNCONSCIONABLE OF LOS AND-
SECONDLY I WOULD LIKE TO SAY
THAT. IT OFFENSIVE TO HEAR THE
SUB POISONING REFERRED TO AS
OVERDOSE. I DON'T THINK YOU
MEANT TO INSULT BUT I WILL TELL
YOU THAT IT IS AN INSULT BECAUSE
IT IS A POISONING THERE'S A
DIFFERENCE BETWEEN A POISONING
AND OVERDOSE. AND I JUST HAVING
A HARD TIME UNDERSTANDING. THE
OPPOSING VIEW THAT WANTS TO
PROTECT THE SELLER OF THIS
POISON. I'M JUST REALLY REALLY
HARD TRYING TO MY BEST TO
UNDERSTAND IT. BUT I WILL NEVER
AGREE WITH IT. AND I CLEARLY AND
THANKFULLY YOU BROUGHT THIS
FORWARD AND GIVE US THE
OPPORTUNITY TO DISCUSS. THIS
TRAVESTY OF WHAT'S HAPPENING.
AND IT'S HAPPENING AT SUCH AN
ALARMING RATE. YET WE DO'T HAVE
THE APPETITE TO GO AFTER THE
SELLER. I'M HAVING A HARD TIME
UNDERSTANDING THE OPPOSITION
BUT- KNOW THAT I'M CLEARLY IN
SUPPORT AND THANKFUL FOR USED TO
HELP THE CURRENT WHICH TO COME
HERE AND SHARE YOUR TRAGEDY
THANK YOU. THANK YOU. I'M JUST
HERE TO VISIBLE BILL BEEN MOVED
YET. I'M OF THE BILL. SO
FOLLOWING A LITTLE BIT UP MY
COLLEAGUES COMMENTS AND AS A-
PARAMEDIC IN THE NINETEEN
EIGHTIES AND HEROIN OVERDOSES
WERE VERY POPULAR- AT LEAST THEY
HAD A CHANCE- IF THEY TOOK A
LITTLE AND THEY'D BE OK- IF WE
GOT THERE WITHIN FOUR MINUTES
BABY OKAY. APARTMENT WAS BECAUSE
WE WERE ABLE TO ADMINISTER
RESPONSIBLY ADMINISTERED ARCANE
. I'LL TALK ABOUT NOR CAN LIKE
IT'S- MANAGER. IN A DAY WHEN
YOU'RE ON SCENE AND BRING
SOMEBODY BACK FROM NOT BREEDING
AN ALMOST DEAD IT IS ALMOST LIKE
MAGIC. BUT IF YOU'RE AN
UNTRAINED PERSON YOU ADMINISTER
THAT AND- SOME OF THE SIDE
EFFECTS OF BRINGING SOMEBODY
BACK FROM AN OVERDOSE LIKE THAT
- WELL INTO ABOUT HERE. AND AND
ALSO- SO CONSCIOUS TO- BEING
POISONED Y BY THIS. THE FOR
REACTION IS TO BUY. AND
ASPIRATION PNEUMONIA IS WHAT
FOLLOWS AND THAT PERSON DIES-
THE OTHER THING WITH THE NOR CAN
APPROACH IS AND THAT'S SOMETHING
THAT WE'RE GONNA TALK ABOUT THE
FUTURE IS IT YET MAY HAVE SOME
SPACE IT WITH THEIR BABY SOME.
THAT MIGHT BE PART OF THE
SOLUTION- THAT YOU KNOW. NOT
HERE NOR CAN LIKE I SAID IT HAS
TO BE ADMINISTERED BY PEOPLE
THAT KNOW WHAT THEY'RE DOING.
AND OTHERWISE YOU WILL
EXACERBATE THE SITUATION IT HAS
TO BE ADMINISTERED WITHIN FORTY
SIX MINUTES OF THE PERSON STOPS
READING. OTHERWISE THEIR BRAIN
IS DEAD. AND THERE'S NOTHING YOU
CAN DO. THESE POISONINGS. IF I
KNOW I KALRA POISONING IF I GAVE
SOMEBODY A CYANIDE PILL AND THEY
TOOK IT AND WENT OFF AND DIED
THAT I POISON THEM. THERE'S NO
TO BE TWO WAYS ABOUT IT- SAME
THING WITH ANNA FREEZE A LOT OF
PEOPLE- YOU KNOW WHEN THEY WANT
TO GET RID OF SOMEBODY THEY LIKE
FEET AMANDA FREEZE. UNTIL THEY
DIE. PLEASING THAT'S NOT
OVERDOSE OF ANNA FREEZE. SO
WE'RE NOT TALKING ABOUT OVERDOSE
HERE WE'RE TALKING ABOUT A
POISONING. OF A LETHAL SUBSTANCE
THAT HAS BEEN MANUFACTURED. FOR
THIS FOR THE SOLE PURPOSE OF
GETTING PEOPLE ADDICTED. TO
DRUGS SO THE PEOPLE THAT DEAL
DRUGS. CAN MAKE THE MONEY THAT
THEY WANT TO MAKE FOR THEIR
CRIMINAL ENTERPRISE. FOR US NOT
TO AT LEAST CONSIDER ESPECIALLY
BETWEEN NOW AND WHEN WE HAVE THE
BIGGER DISCUSSION OF WHAT'S THE
OVERALL PLAN FOR DEALING WITH
FENTANYL IN CALIFORNIA WHICH I
HOPE WE WILL HAVE. AN IN THE
NEAR FUTURE- WE NEED TO DO
SOMETHING TO SEND THE MESSAGE
AND ALLOW PEOPLE THAT SELL AND
KILLER KIDS AND THAT'S NOT JUST
KIDS AND ADULTS. KNOWINGLY
GIVING THEM SOMETHING THAT IS
GOING TO KILL THEM. WE NEED TO
HOLD THEM ACCOUNTABLE. AND
INSTEAD WHAT KIND OF SENDING THE
MESSAGE THAT IT'S NOT YOUR FAULT
THAT YOU'RE SELLING THEM. A
POISON PILL. THAT'S HARD FOR
PEOPLE OF LAST THEIR KIDS
THEY'RE GOOD KIDS. THEY MAY HAVE
THOUGHT THEY WERE BUYING
SOMETHING THEY'LL KEEP HIM AWAKE
SO THEY CAN DO THEIR HOMEWORK.
SO THEY CAN DO THEY REPORT TO
THEY CAN DO THEIR COLLEGE THESIS
. AND INSTEAD THEY RETREAT TO
THEIR ROOM THEY FALL ASLEEP AND
NEVER WAKE UP. SO IT IS HARD FOR
ME AS WELL- TO JUST TURNED A
BLIND EYE TO WHAT THIS IS. AND
NOT ALLOW- AT LEAST AS TO START
WORKING ON. ONE ASPECT OF IT
WHILE WE FIGURE OUT THE REST OF
THOSE ASPECTS OF WHAT WILL WHAT
WILL IT TAKE TO STOP THESE
DEATHS. BECAUSE THEY'RE GONNA
GET WORSE EXPONENTIAL. THEY'RE
GONNA GET WORSE. WE CAN'T JUST
STAND BY AND LET IT HAPPEN. SO
ANYWAY. I APPRECIATE YOUR BILL
VERY MUCH- I SEE IT IS MAYBE ONE
SLIVER OF PART OF A SOLUTION FOR
THE BIGGER PROBLEM- BUT WE CAN
CONTINUE TO WORK ON THIS BUT IN
THE MEANWHILE- JUST WHAT YOU'RE
ASKING US TO DO IS NOT
UNREASONABLE. SO THANK YOU.
THANK YOU. NEAR THE GOVERNMENT.
YOU MAY CLOSE. I THINK YOU
MISTER CHAIR AND DIVE. I DO IN
IT- IN MY CLOTHES JUST
ADDRESSING SOME OF THE POINT
SAID THAT THE OPPOSITION REYES
AND I THINK. MAKE A COUPLE
CLARIFYING POINTS- SO I DO AGREE
WITH MY COLLEAGUES I BELIEVE
THAT WHEN WE WHEN WE HEAR THESE
STORIES THESE ARE NOT OVERDOSE
DEATHS THESE ARE POISONING. I'M
AND I REALLY DO BELIEVE SENTINEL
IS DIFFERENT. TWO GRAINS OF SAND
TWO GRAINS OF SAND IS ENOUGH TO
KILL A CAT. WE'VE GOT TO TREAT
IT DIFFERENTLY WE'VE GOT TO
TREAT IT LIKE THE DEADLY AND
DANGEROUS POISON THAT IT IS.
THIS BILL IS NOT ABOUT. GOING
AFTER USERS IT'S NOT ABOUT GOING
AFTER LOW LEVEL DEALERS TRACKING
NOT TRAFFICKERS. TWO GRAMS
DOESN'T SOUND LIKE A LOT THAT'S
ONE THOUSAND ONE THOUSAND PEOPLE
TO SAYS THAT WE'RE TALKING
ABOUT. AND MEET MICHAEL REALLY
IS IT AND I THINK OUR STATE
SCHOOL NEEDS TO BE THAT WE NEED
TO STRIKE THE RIGHT BALANCE
BETWEEN. REHABILITATION AND CARE
FOR INDIVIDUALS WHO ARE
STRUGGLING WITH ADDICTION- BUT
FOR FIRM PENALTIES FIRM
PENALTIES FOR BAD ACT. AND
MEMBERS. I AND I BELIEVE THAT
THAT THIS BILL CAN COMPLEMENT
CALIFORNIA'S INCREASE INVESTMENT
IN TREATMENT AND REHABILITATION
AND I DO THINK WE NEED TO STRIKE
THAT BALANCE AS WE MOVE FORWARD.
IN ORDER TO ADDRESS THIS CRISIS-
AND LASTLY I'LL JUST SAY. I AM
THE MOM IS TWO TEENAGE BOYS I'VE
GOT A THIRTEEN YEAR OLD BOY AND
A FIFTEEN YEAR OLD BOY AND WHEN
I HEAR. STORIES LIKE SAKS STORY
AND ALEXANDER STORY. IT BREAKS
MY HEART AND I'LL BE HONEST IT'S
A MAMA. KEEPS ME AWAKE AT NIGHT
AND HE LEGISLATOR IT KEEPS ME
AWAKE AT NIGHT AND- WE KNOW.
THIS IS AN URGENT PUBLIC HEALTH
SAYS AND I HOPE LIKE ME IN YOUR
HEART YOU KNOW WE NEED TO ACT
WITH URGENCY. TO ADDRESS US AND
TOP WITH THAT I RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR AN AYE VOTE TODAY. KING AND
I AND I ALSO WANT TO THANK
ANNOUNCED WANNA THANK YOUR
WITNESSES. FOR HAVING THE
COURAGE TO COME HERE. AND- BRING
THIS STORY TO THIS COMMITTEE IS
NOT EASY- TO TELL THE WORLD
ABOUT A TRAGEDY IN YOUR IN YOUR
FAMILY IN YOUR LIFE AND- I
COMMEND YOU. FOR YOUR COURAGE
DEBATE BEFORE THIS DISC
COMMITTEE AND SPEAK YOUR TRUTH-
I TO HAVE A FRIEND. AFTER
AMERICAN FRIEND I WENT TO
COLLEGE WITH WHOSE NEPHEW-
WORKED HIS **** OFF TO GET INTO
THE MILITARY ACADEMY. I HAD
FEDERAL AND DIED WAS RECENTLY IN
THE STORIES THAT YOU HEARD ABOUT
THE MILITARY ACADEMY SOMEONE
DIED ONE OF WHICH AFTER AMERICAN
MALE IF YOU KNOW HOW HARD IT IS
. HAHAHA ARE YOU HAVE TO WORK
YOUR **** OFF TO GET INTO A
MILITARY ACADEMY. AND AS AN
AFRICAN AMERICAN MALE. IT IS
UNBELIEVABLY DIFFICULT AND HAVE
HIS LIFE SNUFFED OUT. IN AN
INSTANT WHEN HE WAS VERY CLOSE
TO GRADUATING- TO BE ABLE TO
SERVICE COUNTRY. AND- AND DO A
HIS LIFE- THAT COULD HAVE BEEN
EXTRAORDINARY THINGS AND SO I
BELIEVE THIS IS A CRISIS. I
BELIEVE THAT AB. SIXTEEN SEVENTY
THREE- THAT WE WILL PUT BEFORE I
GENUINE BELIEVE WE WILL PUT
BEFORE THIS BODY- EDGY MOVE
FORWARD WITH IT AND IT GOES
BEFORE ON THE FLOOR. AND WE
CREATE THIS THIS TASK FORCE THIS
CALIFORNIA BUT NO ABUSE TASK
FORCE TO LOOK AT THIS. AND I
URGE I INSIST AND I DEMAND THAT
THIS FAMILY- WORKS WITH THIS
TASK FORCE SO THEY KNOW THE
URGENCY. I HOPE I WISH MY DEMAND
THAT. THE ASSEMBLY WOMAN.
CONTINUES TO WORK WITH THIS TASK
FORCE BECAUSE AT THE END OF THE
DAY- IF THIS DOES NOT GET OUT OF
THIS COMMITTEE WE MAY END UP
WITH. DISSOLUTIONS YOU YOU'VE
IDENTIFIED. BUT WE'RE GONNA LOOK
AT EVERYTHING COMPREHENSIVELY.
AND COME UP WITH A COMPREHENSIVE
PLAN. BECAUSE WE'VE DONE
PIECEMEAL BEFORE AND IT DOESN'T
ALWAYS IF IT. YES WILL MAKE YOU
FEEL BETTER COULD YOU FELT LIKE
YOU DID SOME BUT IT DOESN'T
WE'RE NOW LOOKING AT THE TASK
FORCE THAT WILL. SOLVE HIGHER
PROBLEM AND GET A SPONSOR ROAD
TO ENDING THIS SCOURGE. YOU'RE
ABSOLUTELY RIGHT THIS IS A
SCOURGE BONTA. AND SO I. I AM
GOING TO NOT ONLY PUSH FOR THE
FINAL TASK FORCE TO MOVE FORWARD
BUT I MAKE SURE. THAT THE
INFORMATION YOU GAVE US TODAY
BECAUSE IF IT DOESN'T GET OUT
THIS COMMITTEE. BECOMES PART OF
THAT TASK FORCE TO BECOME A PART
OF THAT DISCUSSION. I THINK IT'S
IMPORTANT. THAT I THINK IS
ESSENTIAL AND I THINK THE
FAMILIES THAT ARE HERE TODAY.
NEED TO BE AN ESSENTIAL PART OF
THAT. URGENTLY I CAN'T SUPPORT
IT TODAY BUT I THINK THE TASK
FORCE MAY COME ACK AND SAY
ULTIMATELY. THIS IS. DESCRIPCI
THE ULTIMATE SOLUTION NOT JUST
PART OF THE SOLUTION INSIDE TO
SWEAR SURE WE LOOK AT ALL
ASPECTS OF IT BEFORE WE MOVE ON
- SO WITH THAT WE HAVE OF. FIRST
IN THE SECOND. WHAT MEANT SECTOR
CALL THE ROLL ON AB TWENTY TWO
FORTY SIX BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER
PETRIE-NORRIS THE MOTION IS TO
PASS TO THE APPROPRIATIONS
COMMITTEE JONES SAWYER REALLY NO
DANCER DAHLE LACKEY. BLACKIE I
BONA. BONTA NOT VOTING BRIAN
BRIAN NOT VOTING CORK CORK NOW
SANTIAGO SEYARTO HI THERE TÔI.
SO THE MEASURE FAILS THANK YOU
THANK YOU. NEXT I BELIEVE WE
HAVE A- MR KILEY. HI. THE ITEM
NUMBER TWELVE CHICAGO. AB
SEVENTEEN- EIGHT. I THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIR MISTER VICE CHAIR
FOR YOUR CONSIDERATION OF THIS
MEASURE TODAY- IT MY BILL- ASKS
US TO REASSESS- A SPECIFIC
POLICY CHANGE THAT WAS
INSTITUTED- IN TWENTY EIGHTEEN
FROM A BILL THAT PASSED IN
TWENTY SEVENTEEN IT WAS SB FIFTY
FOUR AUTHORED BY- THE FORMER-
PRESIDENT PRO TEM- OF. I THE
BILL THAT RATED A LOT OF.
CONTROVERSY AT THE TIME- IT WAS
KNOWN FORMALLY AS THE CALIFORNIA
VALUES ACT OFTEN CALLED THE
SANCTUARY STATE BILL- I WAS IN
MY FIRST YEAR IN THE LEGISLATURE
AT THE TIME- AND AT THE TIME AND
SINCE I'VE ALWAYS BEEN SORT OF
STRUCK BY THE DISCONNECT
BETWEEN. SORT OF THE- THE
POLITICAL SYMBOLISM OF THE BILL
OR THE RHETORIC ASSOCIATED WITH
THAT ON THE ONE HAND- AND THE
ACTUAL POLICY- THAT IT
IMPLEMENTS ON THE OTHER AS YOU
KNOW THE US THE AUTHOR AND THE
SUPPORTERS OF THE BILL. AT THE
TIME- SORT OF USED IT- SEND THE
MESSAGE THAT WOULD STICK.
WELCOME PLACE. I WAS DEAD SENATE
PASSAGE THAT WERE- YOU KNOW WHEN
IN FAVOR OF THE GRANT AND SO
FORTH- BUT WHAT WHAT THE BILL
ACTUALLY DID. I IT YOU KNOW
DOESN'T ACTUALLY DO ANYTHING FOR
THE VAST MAJORITY OF IMMIGRANTS
IT DOESN'T THING CERTAINLY FOR.
THE MET AND WE FUNDS WERE. OUR
AFTER STATING THAT THE DO ANY
EITHER- FOR- UNDER IMMIGRANTS-
SO LONG AS THEY HAVE NOT
VIOLATED OUR CRIMINAL LAWS IN
ADDITION TO- VIOLATING
IMMIGRATION LAW AND THEN ON TOP
OF THAT IT ACTUALLY HAS
MAINTAINED SOME CATEGORIES OF
PEOPLE WHO ARE IN THE COUNTRY-
ILLEGAL IT IS A CRIME- COMMITTEE
I'M THE BILL EXEMPTS- WHO IT
CARVES OUT SO IT WAS A VERY VERY
SPECIFIC- POLICY CHANGE- THAT
WAS USED TO MAKE THESE- BROAD
CLAIMS AND I THINK THAT THE
REASON FOR THAT IS CALIFORNIA IT
ALREADY GONE SO FAR IN ONE
DIRECTION WHEN IT CAME TO ALL.
MATT IT'S KIND OF. FIVE ARE TO
MAKE THE STATEMENT THAT- SOME
WANTED TO MAKE AT THAT TIME AND
THE REASON THAT THIS WAS LAST IS
THIS IS A LONG BEEN A VERY
BIPARTISAN- THREE PAST
ADMINISTRATIONS AT THE FEDERAL
LEVEL WHETHER IT'S PRESIDENT
OBAMA- PRESIDENT BUSH AND
PRESIDENT REAGAN OR PRESIDENT
CLINTON THERE'S ALWAYS BEEN A
CONSISTENT POLICY THAT
IMMIGRATION ENFORCEMENT FOCUSES
FIRST AND FOREMOST. ON THAT TO
HAVE A COME IN OFF IT WILL. THE
BIPARTISAN. EITHER THIS IS BILL
SB FIFTY FOUR I BENNETT AND
THERE WERE. A LOT OF ALARMS
RAISED AT THE TIME AS TO WHAT
THE PRACTICAL CONSEQUENCES
FORGET THE POLITICAL PART OF IT
BUT THE PRACTICAL CONSEQUENCES
OF THE ACTUAL POLICY CHANGE-
WOULD BE. I AM STATE SHERIFFS
ASSOCIATION AMONG OTHERS- WARNED
THAT THIS WOULD HAMPER THE
ABILITY OF LAW ENFORCEMENT- IN
THE IMMIGRATION AUTHORITIES TO
MAKE SURE THAT- THIS READ DANGER
PEOPLE. WERE NOT ABLE TO CAN YOU
TO COMMIT MS. IN OUR COMMUNITIES
AND ON PERSONAL THE PREDICTIONS
HAVE HAVE EMPLOYEE AND
TRAGICALLY. BORN OUT AND I'M NOT
GOING TO GO THROUGH ALL OF THAT
THE EXAMPLES THE BUT THERE IS
ONE. THAT IS. VERY AND- I HIS
ONE OF THE MOST HEINOUS CRIMES
I'VE EVER HEARD OF IT HAPPENED
VERY CLOSE TO HERE I JUST A FEW
MILES FROM THIS CAPITAL WHERE
THERE WAS A MAN. WHO WENT INTO A
CHURCH AND MURDERED HIS OWN
THREE DAUGHTERS THEIR CHAPERONE
AND THEN TOOK HIS OWN LIFE- AND
THIS WAS JUST A- COUPLE MONTHS
AGO ON FEBRUARY TWENTY EIGHTH
AND WHAT WE LEARNED SHORTLY
AFTER- THIS THIS HEINOUS CRIME.
IS THAT THIS INDIVIDUAL HAD IN
FACT BEEN IN POLICE CUSTODY JUST
FIVE DAYS EARLIER AND THE REASON
HE WAS IN POLICE CUSTODY WHILE
FOR ASSAULTING. A PEACE OFFICER
AND THIS DIMENSION SPECIFICALLY
IN TWO THOUSAND SEVENTEEN WITH
SB FIFTY FOUR PASSED THIS IS
MENTIONED SPECIFICALLY BY THE
STATE SHERIFF ASSOCIATION. IS
ONE OF MANY MANY. TIMES AT THAT
. THE RESTRICTION A NATION OF S.
BUT WHAT I BUT OUR ABILITY TO
DEAL WITH THIS. A POLICE OFFICER
THAT'S THIS SAID. IN THEIR
STATEMENT BOB TO THE A GOOD.
WHAT HERE. I THIS INDIVIDUAL IN
CUSTODY FOR ASSAULTING A PEACE
OFFICER IS IN THE COUNTRY
ILLEGALLY- THE IMMIGRATION
AUTHORITIES ASKED TO BE NOTIFIED
OF HIS RELEASE BUT BECAUSE OF
THIS SPECIFIC POLICY CHANGE THAT
SB FIFTY FOUR PUT INTO PLACE-
THAT THEY WERE NOT NOTIFIED. AND
THEN HE FIVE DAYS LATER WENT ON
TO COMMIT VERY. HEINOUS CRIME
AND SO- YOU KNOW I THINK IT CAN
REASONABLY BE INFERRED THAT IF
THIS LEGISLATURE HAD NOT MADE
THE POLICY CHANGE IF. GOVERNOR
BROWN NOT SIGNED THAT INTO LAW.
I THIS PERSON WOULD HAVE NOT
BEEN ABLE TO COMMIT. THAT CRIME
AND I THINK THAT YOU KNOW I
DON'T EXPECT THE MEMBERS AT
LEAST ALL OF THE MEMBERS OF THIS
COMMITTEE I TO ADOPT MY OWN
VIEWS ON ON IMMIGRATION
WHOLESALE- OR ON PUBLIC SAFETY.
DO. THINK WE HAVE. A CLIP. I'VE
HOW A PUBLIC THE- BOB HAS AN
ACTIVE I IS A PROXY CAUSE ARE
REALLY A BUT FOR CAUSE OF SUCH A
HORRIFIC TRAGEDY IT IS INCUMBENT
ON US TO REVISIT WHETHER THAT IS
SOUND POLICY- TO WEIGH COST
VERSUS BENEFITS FRANKLY I DON'T
REALLY SEE ANY BENEFITS TO THIS
LAW BUT EVEN IF YOU DO I THINK
THAT IT'S INCUMBENT TO WEIGH
THOSE BENEFITS AGAINST THE
CLEARLY. ESTABLISHED COSTS AND
SO THAT'S THE REASON I'M
PRESENTING THIS BILL TODAY- I
THINK THAT AT THE VERY LEAST IT
MERITS A DEBATE- BY THE FULL
ASSEMBLY AND SO I WOULD ASK FOR
A NIGHT OUT. THANK YOU. AND DO
YOU HAVE ANY WITNESSES I BELIEVE
WE HAVE ONE WITNESS ON THE LINE
. THERE WOULD BE. OKAY LISA
KNOWLTON- CRIME VICTIMS UNITED.
SO AT&T OPERATORS IS MISS
KNOWLTON ON THE LINE RIGHT NOW.
I DO NOT SEE HER NAME ON OUR
LINE IF SHE IS. SITTING IN THE
PARTICIPANTS IF SHE COULD
PLEASE. IT HAS TESTIFYING VIA
PHONE. WHAT WE CAN DO IS ASK FOR
. ANYONE IN THE AUDIENCE IF THEY
HAVE- IF THEY'RE IN SUPPORT IF
THEY WANT TO COME IN AND- NAME
AN ORGANIZATION. OR SPEAK TO THE
MATTER. SEEN NONE SO EIGHTEEN T.
OPERATOR CAN YOU LEAST OPEN UP
LIFE FOR PEOPLE WHO ARE IN
SUPPORT. IF YOU WISH TO SPEAK IN
SUPPORT OF AB SEVENTEEN OH EIGHT
PLEASE PRESS ONE THEN ZERO. AND
FIRST WE HAVE LINE THREE ZERO
SEVEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. I HOPE
FROM BEHALF OF SECURE JUSTICE
OPPOSED TO SEVEN CAN OPERATE.
BUT THIS IS FOR SUPPORT OKAY.
AND ONE MOMENT FOR OUR NEXT LINE. NEGATIVE ONE TWO NINE SEVEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. HELLO YES LISA
NELSON SPEAKING ON BEHALF OF
CRIME VICTIMS UNITED AND NINA
SOLARE DEL BERMAN. THE VOICE-
STRONG SUPPORT FOR A BI
SEVENTEEN OH EIGHT THANK YOU IF
YOU WANT TO SAY MORE YOU HAVE
MORE TIME RESULT IN. THEIR LOSER
I APPRECIATE THAT I'M SORRY I AM
SITTING IN CORNING A SOLANO
BAFFLEMENT AND- I GOT TO THE
LAST MINUTE SUBSTITUTION SO I
APOLOGIZE THAT I DON'T HAVE MORE
TO SAY OTHER THAN. MAYBE YOU ARE
JUST AS STRONG SUPPORT. FOR AB
SEVENTY NINE. THANK YOU. ANY
OTHER EIGHTEEN T. OPERATOR AREAS
IN SUPPORT. THAT IS ALL I HAVE
IN QUEUE RIGHT NOW- ANY
WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION I SEE
ACLU ADVOCATE TESTIFYING. IN
PERSON. I DON'T HAVE A NAME. YES
WHENEVER YOU'RE READY THANK YOU
GOOD AFTERNOON CHAIR JONES
SAWYER IS A MEMBERS MY NAME IS
FAITH LEE I'M WITH ASIAN
AMERICANS ADVANCING JUSTICE
CALIFORNIA- ALONG WITH OVER
FORTY CIVIL RIGHTS ORGANIZATIONS
ABOUT THE STATE WE OPPOSE AB
SEVENTEEN. WOULD APPEAL. HE
IMMIGRANT RIGHTS PROTECTIONS IN
CALIFORNIA BY REQUIRING LOCAL
LAW ENFORCEMENT TO HOLD
IMMIGRANT COMMUNITY MEMBERS FOR
EXTRA TIME. BEYOND THEIR
SCHEDULED RELEASE DATE. THIS
WOULD REQUIRE STATE GOVERNMENTS
TO WORK WITH I HAVE AN AGENCY
WITH A LONG RECORD OF SYSTEMIC
ABUSE TO FILL IMMIGRATION
DETENTION CENTERS. AND CARRY OUT
MASS DEPORTATION. A. B. AB
SEVENTY IT WOULD UNDERCUT THE
VALUES OF IMMIGRANT INCLUSION
AND RACIAL EQUITY THAT MOTIVATED
THIS LEGISLATURE TO PASS THE
EXISTING LAW THE CALIFORNIA.
VALUES ACT IT WOULD LEAD TO
THOUSANDS OF ADDITIONAL FAMILY
SEPARATIONS ACROSS THE STATE OR
PRO IMMIGRANT LAWS HELP PROTECT
CALIFORNIANS FROM RACIAL
PROFILING AND ABUSE. ENCOURAGE
VICTIMS AND WITNESSES TO COME
FORWARD TO GET THE HELP THAT
THEY NEED. IN CALIFORNIA WE
TRULY VALUE AND WELCOME
IMMIGRANTS WHO ARE PARENTS
GRANDPARENTS CO WORKERS NAME
BRANDS AND OURSELVES. THROUGH
LESSONS LEARNED FROM THE HATEFUL
ERA OF PROPOSITION ONE EIGHTY
SEVEN WE REJECT SENIOR PHOBIA
AND CALLS TO SUBJECT. CALLS TO
SUBJECT IMMIGRANTS TO TARGETING
AND CRUEL DOUBLE PUNISHMENTS
THAT'S WHY WE SHOULD CONTINUE
STRENGTHENING OUR STATE'S
PROTECTIONS NOT WEAKEN THEM I
URGE YOU NOT GO ON BUSINESS
BILL- AND CHAIR I ALSO HAVE A
LIST OF ORGANIZATIONS WHO WE GOT
PERMISSION FROM TO EITHER DROP
IT GEN AT THE APPROPRIATE TIME.
THANK YOU WHAT A NAME NOW- WE
CAN NOW YEAH. I'M OPPOSITE IS
NEED OUR WHEN BUT NO MIGRANT
LEGAL RESOURCE CENTER AND LUNCH
. FOR M. JUSTICE IDT P. S. C. A.
NATIONAL DAY LABORER ORGANIZING
ORGANIZING NETWORK SISTER
WORKERS FREEDOM COALITION SOUTH
BAY FULL POWER YOUNG WOMAN'S
FREEDOM CENTER SOCIAL JUST LEGAL
FOR. THROUGH SOLIDARITY. REYES
RIGHT AND EDUCATION. AS FORNEY
ACTION ALLIANCE DIEGO COMMUNITY
UNITED AGAINST VIOLENCE AND SAN
DIEGO IMMIGRANT RIGHTS
CONSORTIUM. THANK YOU THANK YOU
. THAT PROJECT ANY OTHER
WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION END OF
BETTER IN A ROW. MARCO GEORGIA
MY HALF OF THE CALIFORNIA PUBLIC
DEFENDERS ASSOCIATION IN
OPPOSITION THANK YOU THANK YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON DEREK MORGAN WITH
THE OTHER BAKER CENTER FOR HUMAN
RIGHTS RESPECTFULLY IN
OPPOSITION. THIRD ME ON BEHALF
OF INITIATE JUSTICE RESPECTFUL
AND THANK YOU THANK YOU. EIGHTY
TWO OPERATOR YOU'RE OPEN TO LINE
PRINTED WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION
. SPEAKING OPPOSITION OF AB.
SEVENTEEN ZERO EIGHT ONE NINE
ZERO WE'LL START WITH LINE THREE
ZERO NINE PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI
GOOD AFTERNOON MERRIAM- MORENO
OUR SYSTEM IMPACTED CALIFORNIA
CONSTITUENTS IN- STRONG
OPPOSITION TO- AB SEVENTEEN OH
EIGHT THANK YOU THANK YOU. NEXT
HEADLINE THREE TEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON JIM
LINDBERG ON BEHALF OF A FRIEND
COMMITTEE ON LEGISLATION OF
CALIFORNIA IN OPPOSITION. AND
NEXT LINE ONE HUNDRED PLEASE GO
AHEAD. YEAH YOU WITH OAKLAND
PRIVACY AND OPPOSITION OF AB
SEVENTEEN OH EIGHT. THANK YOU.
AND I HAVE NO ANNOUNCED IN Q.
THANK YOU NOW BRING IT BACK TO
COMMITTEE MEMBERS ANY QUESTIONS
COMMENTS. CONCERN YOU MAY CLOSE
THANK YOU VERY MUCH ASPIRIN I
BET THANK YOU I THINK PART OF IT
AND I KNOW YOU HAD JUST GOTTEN
HERE TO THE ASSEMBLY PART OF
THAT DISCUSSION- THAT WENT ON
DURING. THE IMMIGRATION
DISCUSSION WHAT ICE ITSELF AND I
SAID DOESN'T HAD. WHERE ABUSING
IMMIGRANTS AND- IT WAS NOT A LOT
OF TRUST. AMONG MEMBERS CERTAIN
MEMBERS OF THE ASSEMBLY AND HOW
IMMIGRANTS WERE TREATED. HOW
FAMILIES ARE BROKEN APART AND
HOW HAD A DEFINITE IMPACT AND
THAT WAS PART OF THE RATIONALE.
FOR IT- FOR US TO MOVE FORWARD
WITH. WITH WHAT WE GET BACK TO-
AND- I KNOW YOU HAD JUST GOTTEN
THERE AND YOU MAY HAVE HEARD
SOME OF THAT RHETORIC. BUT THAT
WAS KIND OF THE PUSH TO THERE
WASN'T A WHOLE LOT OF TRUST IN
LAW ENFORCEMENT IT WAS A WHOLE
LOT TRUST AND I. THAT THEY WOULD
DO THE RIGHT THING IN FACT-
PROBABLY BECAUSE OF THE
ADMINISTRATION AT THAT TIME.
THEY FELT THAT THEY WERE
OVERZEALOUS. IN THEIR REACTION
TOWARD IMMIGRANTS NOT JUST
LATINOS. BUT THE BUT BBI PHOTO.
AND SO- THAT'S THAT WAS THE
IMPETUS YOU YOU DON'T HAVE TO
AGREE WITH IT. BUT THAT WAS THE
IMPETUS OF HOW ALL OF THAT. THAT
THAT STARTED AND SO- I THINK WE
HAVE A- SOME OF THE BILL I THINK
WE HAVE A- SECOND. I JUST YOU
KNOW OUR TELEPATHIC THAT WAY.
YOU MAY CALL THE ROLL. ON AB
SEVENTEEN EL A BISA MEMBER KILEY
THE MOTION IS DUE PASSED TO THE
JUDICIARY COMMITTEE JONES SAWYER
JOHN SALERNO LACKEY LACKEY HI
BONTA. BONTA KNOW BRIAN. WORK NO
QUIRK KNOWS SANTIAGO SEYARTO
THEY ARE TOUGH I. SORRY THAT
MEASURE FAILS. IT DOESN'T IT
WITH ONE TO THE OTHER IT ENDS
TOMORROW AND YOU HAVE TO GET
YOUR STEP IN BY FIVE TODAY. IF
YOU WERE THE RESULT UNANIMOUS
CONSENT ON THAT EITHER- YOU
WOULDN'T RECEIVE UNANIMOUS CAN
THANK GOD HAS HUDDLED TOGETHER
OKAY. MISTER DAVID MISTER
RODRIGUEZ EUROPE. THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIRMAN RESULT TRY TO
MAKE THIS QUICK. THANK YOU FOR
ALLOWING ME TO PRESENT AB TWENTY
THREE FOR THE SIX WHICH ALLOW
COURTS TO AGGREGATE THEFT COUNTS
IN THE DEATH. WAS RANGE AS
CONCERT MANY RETAILERS
CALIFORNIA EXPERTS YOU FLUSH ROB
EVENTS WERE INDIVIDUALS PUT
TOGETHER STILL MERCHANDISE AND
DESCEND ON STORES AS A GROUP.
UNDER EXISTING LAW FRESH ROB
PARTICIPANTS WHOORGANIZED A
PROPERTY AND EACH STILL LESS
THAN NINE FIFTY MAY BE CHARGED
WITH PETTY THEFT HOWEVER. THE TO
THE RETAILER IS OFTEN THOUSANDS
OF DOLLARS DUE TO THE
COORDINATED NATURE OF THE CRIME.
TO ADDRESS THIS ISSUE A. B.
TWENTY THREE FOR THE SIX
RECOGNIZES THAT INDIVIDUALS OF
COORDINATED. AFTER NOT OPERATE
ALONE AND THEIR AGGREGATED
ACTIONS OFTEN PASSED THE
THRESHOLD FOR GROUND STAFF.
RESPECT US RIGHT. THANK YOU DO
WE HAVE ANY WITNESSES. NOT NOT
CORRECT. ARE THERE IN. ANYWAY
HERE IN A ROOM AND SUPPORT.
SEEING NONE- WILL GO TO
WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION I WOULD
I WOULD GO TO THE PHONE LINES
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT. BEACON
SUPPORT PLEASE PRESS ONE AND
ZERO ONE MOMENT WHILE OUR FIRST
LINE GET THEIR LINE NUMBER.
AGAIN PRESS ONE TO TEN ZERO TO
SPEAK. AND FIRST WE HAVE. I
NUMBER THREE ELEVEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. CHEN MEMBERS ON BEHALF OF
CONSUMER REPORT IN SUPPORT OF
THE LOBAL THE BILL BUT WE DO
HAVE REMAIN CONCERNED ABOUT THE
LANGUAGE AND LOOK FORWARD TO
CONTINUING TO WORK WITH THE
AUTHOR OF THE MOVE TO THE
LEGISLATIVE PROCESS. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU. AND I HAVE NO ONE
ELSE IN Q. EIGHT NO IT WAS SENT
TO WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION. I
SEE ACLU ADVOCATE. TESTIFIED IN
PERSON. NO ONE OKAY THEN WILL GO
TO ANYONE IN OPPOSITION LEFT IN
THE ROOM. HI AGAIN SERIGNE
INITIATE JUSTICE RESPECT
OPPOSITION THANK YOU THANK YOU
THE NUMBER OF PHONE LINES A
WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION. AND TO
SPEAK IN OPPOSITION PLEASE PRESS
ONE THEN ZERO. AND FIRST WE'LL
GO TIMELINE ONE EIGHTY EIGHT
PLEASE GO AHEAD. BOLIVIA
CAMPBELL IN OPPOSITION THANK YOU. AND NEXT. THEY HAVE LINE
NUMBER TWO SEVEN ZERO PLEASE GO
AHEAD. MISTER MEMBER STEVE
MCCARTY ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA RETAILERS ASSOCIATION
WE DO NOT HAVE A POSITION ON
THIS BILL BUT WE DO HAVE
CONCERNS THAT IT APPLIES ONLY TO
A NARROW SUBSET OF SERIAL THEFT
CASES WE AGREE YOUR CREATOR IN
OUR SUPPORT FOR A FULL.
STAKEHOLDER MEETING TO ADDRESS
THESE ISSUES AND REESTABLISH A
BROAD BASED SERIAL SUCH STATUTE.
THANK YOU. AND I HAVE NO ONE
ELSE IN Q. THANK YOU BRING ABOUT
TO COMMITTEE MEMBERS ANY
QUESTIONS CONCERNS COMMENTS. CNN
YOU MAY CLOSE RESPECT OUR
STRUGGLE THANK YOU AND I AND I
WANNA I WANNA PERSONALLY. THANK
YOU MISTER RODRIGUEZ FOR TAKING
THIS ON NOT MANY OTHER MEMBERS
AT THE COURAGE TO MOVE ON WITH
THIS- JUST AS IMPORTANT. AS
CLARIFYING- THAT YOU CAN EVERY
DAY AND- THAT AND THAT WE NOW
HAVE IT. WE DON'T HAVE GOT TO
GET THROUGH THE PROCESS BUT
WE'LL HAVE IT IN STATUTE AND
HOPEFULLY. A LAW ENFORCEMENT
WILL LOOK AT THIS AS AN
OPPORTUNITY TO USE IT TO GO
AFTER ORGANIZED RETAIL THEFT
AND- WE WILL MEET. WITH ALL
PARTIES CONCERNED ABOUT
ORGANIZED RETAIL THEFT BUT I
WILL TELL YOU WHAT YOU'RE DOING
NOW THIS BILL WILL BE THE
STARTING POINT AND OF THE
CORNERSTONE OF OUR DISCUSSION ON
HOW WE MOVE FORWARD SO- YOU MAY
. THE FIRST AND ONLY AMENDMENT.
THE PROPER SEVEN SO- AND A LOT
OF WHICH NEED TO BE
CONGRATULATED JUST A BATTLE
ALONE- IF WE'RE ABLE TO GET THIS
THROUGH. THANK YOU AGAIN CHAIRS
RECOMMENDED AYE VOTE THANK YOU.
THE BILL'S BEEN MOVED AND
SECONDED ON AB TWENTY THREE
FIFTY SIX BY SEPTEMBER RODRIGUEZ
THE MOTION IS TO PASS JONES
SAWYER JONES SAWYER IRAQI.
LACKEY HI BONTA BONTA HI BRIAN.
WORK I WORK I SANTIAGO. SEYARTO
THERE TO AYE. THE MEASURE PASSES
THANK YOU YOU'RE WELCOME AGAIN
THANK YOU- I BELIEVE WE CAN
FINALLY GET TO MISTER MISS BONTA
. HER TO. ARE YOU WITNESSES HERE.
AB TWENTY TWO FIFTY NAY B.
TWENTY D. FIVE FIFTY SEVEN.
WHICHEVER ONE YOU WANT TO DO
FIRST. AS A MEMBER OF THE
COMMITTEE YOU GET TO CHOOSE.
LET'S MOVE FORWARD WITH AB
TWENTY FIVE FIFTY SEVEN THE
PEACE OFFICER RECORDS.
GOOD AFTERNOON MR CHAIRMAN
MEMBERS I WOULD LIKE TO EXPRESS
MY APPRECIATION TO THE COMMITTEE
STAFF FOR THEIR TIME AND HELPING
US ENGAGE WITH OTHER
ORGANIZATIONS IN THIS PROCESS I
AM COMMITTED TO WORKING ON
ISSUES OUTLINED IN THE ANALYSIS
TO ENSURE THIS BILL ACHIEVES
THIS GOAL TO ENSURING GREATER
TRANSPARENCY AND ACCOUNTABILITY.
AB TWENTY FIVE FIFTY SEVEN WILL
REPEAL A CALIFORNIA SUPREME
COURT DECISION WHICH HAS
HAMPERED THE ABILITY OF CIVILIAN
LAW ENFORCEMENT AGENCIES TO
CONDUCT THEIR INVESTIGATIONS
CIVILIAN LAW ENFORCEMENT
OVERSIGHT AGENCIES HAVE OPERATED
AS AN I DID CHECK ON LAW
ENFORCEMENT THERE INDEPENDENT
INVESTIGATIONS HAVE HELPED
ENSURE CLOSER TO ENGAGE
MISCONDUCT ARE HELD ACCOUNTABLE
UNFORTUNATELY BECAUSE OF A
TWENTY AT THE TWO THOUSAND SIX
K. TWENTY SUPREME COURT
DECISION. KNOWN AS THE COPLEY
PRESS PRESS INC VERSUS SUPERIOR
COURT THESE AGENCIES HAVE BEEN
REQUIRED TO WITHHOLD FROM THE
PUBLIC MOST IF NOT ALL OF THEIR
RECORDS OF INVESTIGATION OF LAW
ENFORCEMENT MISTER. THIS IS THE
COURT IN THE COPLEY PRESS IN
CASE HELD THAT RECORDS AND
INFORMATION OBTAINED FROM
RECORDS OF CIVILIAN LAW
ENFORCEMENT OVERSIGHT AGENCIES
ARE CONFIDENTIAL PERSONNEL
RECORDS. AND COULD NOT BE
DISCLOSED UNDER THE CALIFORNIA
PUBLIC RECORDS ACT. PRIOR TO THE
PIVOTAL DECISION CIVILIAN LAW
ENFORCEMENT AGENCIES OPERATED
WITH MUCH GREATER TRANSPARENCY.
THE CIVIL UNREST IN THE WAKE OF
THE MURDER OF JUDGE GEORGE FLOYD
AT THE HANDS OF FORMER
MINNEAPOLIS POLICE OFFICER DEREK
SIOBHAN. AND NUMEROUS OTHER
SIMILAR ACTIONS COMMITTED BY LAW
ENFORCEMENT HIGHLIGHTS THE
URGENT NEED FOR THE PUBLIC TO
HAVE ACCESS TO THESE MISCONDUCT
INVESTIGATIONS. CURRENT STATUTE
DOES NOT GIVE THE COMMUNITY
MEMBERS WHO ISSUE COMPLAINTS OR
THE COMMUNITY AT LARGE MUCH
INFORMATION OR INSTRUCTION ABOUT
CIVILIAN OVERSIGHT FINDINGS.
CONSEQUENTLY HARM TO PERSON GETS
A SIMPLE STATEMENT. YOUR
COMPLAINT ON SUSTAINED. A LACK
OF TRANSPARENCY IN THE
PROCEDURES USED TO HOLD THESE
AND LAW THE MONTFORT'S MEANT
WITH WHO HARM HURT OR KILLED ON.
ACCOUNTABLE FOR THEIR ROADS AT
THE PUBLIC TRUST AND MAKES ALL
OF US LESS SAFE. WHY AB TWENTY
FIVE FIFTY SEVEN IS URGENTLY
NEEDED. AB TWENTY FIVE FIFTY
SEVEN IS A FRESH APPROACH.
BUILDING OFF OF THE LONGSTANDING
AND PRINCIPLED COMMITMENT OF THE
CALIFORNIA STATE LEGISLATURE
TOWARD INCREASING. THANK YOU AND
AS WITNESSES WITH E TODAY I
HAVE LARRY WHITE HAS BEEN HERE
FOR THE MAJORITY OF THE DAY
THANK YOU. A MEMBER OF THE OPEN
COALITION FOR POLICE
ACCOUNTABILITY AND REGINA
JACKSON A RECENT CHAIR AND
CURRENT MEMBER OF THE OAKLAND
POLICE COMMISSION. WHO WILL BE
APPEARING BY PHONE. THANK YOU
WHENEVER YOU'RE READY TO BEGIN
AND THEN WE'LL GO TO LINE- THANK
YOU ASSEMBLY MEMBER BONTA THANK
YOU MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE- I AM MY NAME IS LARRY
WHITE I AM A VOLUNTEER ATTORNEY
WITH THE- OAKLAND BASED
COALITION FOR POLICE
ACCOUNTABILITY. WE ARE THE
ORGANIZATION THAT IS RESPONSIBLE
FOR BRINGING CREATING AND-
GETTING AS A OF VOTE ON CHANGES
THE CITY CHARTER IN OAKLAND TO
CREATE THE STRONGEST OF CIVILIAN
POLICE REVIEW OVERSIGHT
ORGANIZATION PROBABLY IN THE
STATE PERHAPS IN THE COUNTRY-
AND I'LL TELL YOU WHERE WE'RE
COMING FROM AS I'VE I'VE BEEN
SITTING HERE ALL DAY LISTENING
TO THE VERY WEIGHTY MATTERS THAT
YOU'VE BEEN DEALING WITH- AND-
AND- ARE CONCERNED. IN OAKLAND
AND ACROSS THE STATE IS- MAKING
SURE PARTLY WE WANT TO MAKE SURE
THE POLICE ARE EFFECTIVE AND
BECAUSE THE PEOPLE WHO ARE
AFFECTED BY CRIME. ARE IN LARGE
PART BLACK AND BROWN PEOPLE- IN
THE WAY WE THE WAY WE DECIDED TO
MOVE FORWARD ON THAT IS TO TRUE
BUT TRY TO CREATE TRUST IN THE
COMMUNITY FOR THE POLICE AND THE
ONLY WAY TO HAVE THAT TRUST IS
TO HAVE ACCOUNTABILITY FOR
MISCONDUCT- AND THAT'S WHY WE
OF- A- SPONSOR THIS BILL AND WE
ARE. VERY EXCITED THE
POSSIBILITY OF IT PASSING
BECAUSE- UNDER CURRENT LAW. OF
POLICE RECORDS OF POLICE
MISCONDUCT ARE CONFIDENTIAL ON
EXCEPT FOR EXCEPT FOR CERTAIN
EXCEPTIONS THAT ARE IN THE LAW.
OF WHAT WE ARE TRYING TO DO IS
CHANGE THAT FOR CIVILIAN POLICE
OVERSIGHT OPERATIONS. RECORDS
WOULD BE NON CONFIDENTIAL EXCEPT
FOR CERTAIN EXCEPTIONS- AND THIS
IS NOT A NEW IT'S NOT NEW IN
CALIFORNIA AS ASSEMBLY MEMBER
POINTED OUT THIS WAS THE CASE
BEFORE TWO THOUSAND AND SIX
BEFORE THE SUPREME COURT THROUGH
A CLOAK OF SECRECY OVER OVER ALL
POLICE RECORDS BEFORE THAT. IF A
PERSON- IF AS A CIVILIAN WHO HAD
BEEN MISTREATED BY POLICE
OFFICER BROUGHT A COMPLAINT TO
IN THE OVERSIGHT AGENCY THEY
WOULD KNOW THE THEY WOULD BE
ABLE TO ATTEND A HEARING. ON
THAT COMPLAINT THEY WOULD BE
THEY WOULD KNOW THE NAME OF THE
OFFICER THEY WOULD KNOW THE
CHARGES THEY WOULD THEY WOULD
KNOW THE CHARGES- THEY WOULD
KNOW THAT WHETHER WITNESSES WERE
INTERVIEWED THEY WOULD KNOW THE
INVESTIGATIVE PROCESS. UP AND
THEY WOULD KNOW THE DISCIPLINE
IMPOSED IF THERE WAS ANY
DISCIPLINE IMPOSED. UNDER
CURRENT LAW NONE OF THAT IS
AVAILABLE. THE NEW THEY WON'T BE
A PERSON WHO HAS A COMPLAINT.
WE'LL FIND OUT WHAT THE FINAL
DISPOSITION OTHER WORDS IT WILL
BE SUSTAIN NOT SUSTAINED-
EXONERATED SO ON BUT EVEN
ASSISTING CASE THEY WILL NOT
KNOW WHAT THE WHAT THE- WHAT THE
PUNISHMENT WAS SO- HOW CAN HOW
CAN WE BUILD TRUST BETWEEN THE
THERE IS THIS COMPLETE LACK OF
TRANSPARENCY. THIS BILL WOULD
CHANGE THAT AND N. WOULD MAKE
THAT ALL THAT INFORMATION THAT
WAS AVAILABLE BEFORE AVAILABLE
TO THE PUBLIC AGAIN- YOU HAVE A
MINUTE LET ME GIVE YOU A QUICK
EXAMPLE- OR L. ME ON BECAUSE I
KNOW I DON'T HAVE MUCH TIME SO
JUST GIVE YOU A QUICK EXAMPLE OF
SOMETHING THAT CAME OUT AS A
RESULT OF- A LAWSUIT. BASED ON
THE PUBLIC RECORDS ACT BUT A
LAWSUIT BY SOME MEDIA
ORGANIZATIONS WHICH DISCOVERED
THAT IN THE CITY OF RICHMOND
CALIFORNIA. BETWEEN THE BETWEEN
TWENTY FOURTEEN AND TWENTY
NINETEEN. THERE HAD BEEN SEVENTY
CASES OF POLICE DOGS BITING.
CIVILIANS INCLUDING AN EIGHT
YEAR OLD BOY. NOBODY KNEW ABOUT
THIS FOR FIVE YEARS NOBODY KNEW
ABOUT THIS. UNTIL A MEDIA
ORGANIZATION THAT HAD ENOUGH A
MONEY AND EMPOWER TO BRING A
LAWSUIT WAS ABLE TO BRING IT TO
LIGHT THIS KIND OF PATTERN OF
MISCONDUCT. WOULD BE UNDER IF
OUR BILL WAS WERE PASSED YOU
WOULD NOT BE ABLE TO HAVE A
SITUATION WHERE THE THIS KIND OF
MISCONDUCT COULD GO ON FOR YEARS
AND YEARS BECAUSE IT WOULD BE.
THE COMPLAINTS WOULD BE IN FRONT
OF THE PUBLIC THEY WOULD KNOW
WHAT'S GOING ON HOW CAN WE SOLVE
THE PROBLEM UNLESS PEOPLE KNOW
WHAT THE PROBLEM IS THANK YOU
VERY MUCH AND I URGE YOU TO VOTE
AYE ON THIS BILL. AND YOU HAVE A
WITNESS ON THE FILE- EIGHTEEN T.
OPERATOR COULD YOU BRING THAT
WITH TO SEND FOR ANOTHER MINUTE. HELLO MY TURN REGINA JACKSON.
YES- SO THANK YOU CHAIR- JOHN
LAWYER AND COMMITTEE MEMBERS FOR
YOUR TIME AND ATTENTION THANK
YOU LARRY FOR SHARING THE
DETAILED OVERVIEW OF THE
PROPOSED CHANGE IN LAW AND THANK
YOU TO ASSEMBLY MEMBER MEMBER
BONTA FOR YOUR LEADERSHIP ON
THIS ISSUE AND PROVIDE PROVIDING
ME THE OPPORTUNITY TO SPEAK
TODAY. MY NAME IS REGINA JACKSON
ASSEMBLY MEMBER BOB YOU
MENTIONED ONE OF MY MANY WILL
BECAUSE OF THE VOLUNTEER
APPOINTEE TO THE OAKLAND POLICE
COMMISSION ASSEMBLY BODY FOR THE
CITY OF OAKLAND SERVING THE
PEOPLE OF. MY PASSERBY'S THAT IN
TWENTY AND I HAVE A THIRD AS
CHAIR FOR THREE YEARS IT'S BEEN
AND CONTINUES TO BE ONE OF THE
GREATEST. AND GONE SHE JUST. THE
PURPOSE OF THE- COMPLETE COMMIT
IS TO- OVERSEE THE OAKHAM
DEPARTMENT TO INSURANCE POLICIES
PRACTICES AND CUSTOM CONFORM TO
NATIONAL STANDARDS OF
CONSTITUTIONAL POLICING. AND
OVERSEEING THE OFFICE OF THE
INSPECTOR GENERAL LED BY THE
CIVLIAN OFFICE OF INSPECTOR
GENERAL FOR THE DEPARTMENT. AS
WELL AS THE COMMUNITY POLICE
REVIEW AGENCY CPR AND LED BY THE
EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR OF THE AGENCY
WHICH- INVESTIGATES POLICE
CONDUCT AND RECOMMENDS
DISCIPLINE. I SURE ALL THIS TO
EMPATHIZE IN AB TWO FIVE FIVE
SEVEN WOULD DIRECTLY IMPACT OUR
WORK AND THAT OF THE AGENCIES WE
OVERSEE. ON MARCH THIRTY FIRST
TWENTY TWENTY TO THE OAKLAND
POLICE COMMISSION VOTED
UNANIMOUSLY TO SUPPORT AB TWO
FIVE FIVE SEVEN. WE ARE NOT
ALONE AS YOU SEE A BROAD
COALITION OF REGISTERED
SUPPORTERS. THE BILLION
OVERSIGHT AGENCIES HAVE BEEN
CREATED BY LOCAL JURISDICTIONS
BECAUSE OF THE CONVINCING
EVIDENCE. THAT POLICE ARE UNABLE
TO ADEQUATELY MONITOR AND
DISCIPLINE THEMSELVES. THESE
AGENCIES HAVE BEEN CREATED BY
COMMUNITY DEVELOPMENT SHOULD
STATE LEGISLATION LOCAL
ORDINANCES AS WELL AS THE
FEDERAL CONCENTRICALLY. AT LEAST
TWENTY FIVE CALIFORNIA
MUNICIPALITIES INCLUDING MOST OF
OUR LARGEST CITIES HAVE
ESTABLISHED CIVILIAN LAW
ENFORCEMENT OVERSIGHT BOARDS TO
PROVIDE THE NECESSARY PUBLIC
OVERSIGHT OF POLICING ACTIVITIES
IN THE COMMUNITY. THEY ALL SERVE
AS A MEANS TO CREATE AND SUSTAIN
NECESSARY AND REQUIRED REFORMS
IN POLICY AND PRACTICE. AS SUCH
OVERSIGHT ABOUT BODIES AND
AGENCIES CANNOT FULLY FUNCTION
AS INTENDED ONE OF THE OUTCOMES
AND IMPACT OF THEIR WORK CAN BE
DISCLOSED TO THE PUBLIC.
CURRENTLY THE COMMISSION I
CERVANTES AND THE CIVILIAN
INVESTIGATORY AGENCY WE OVERSEE
ARE EXTREMELY LIMITED AND WHAT
FINANCED CAN BE DISCLOSED TO THE
PUBLIC. SO MUCH SO THAT I FEAR
WE CONTINUE TO ERODE THE TRUST
IN LAW ENFORCEMENT. IMAGINE A
PERSON THE SERVER SIGNIFICANT
HARM AT THE HANDS OF LAW
ENFORCEMENT THEY- MUSTER UP THE
COURAGE TO REPORT THAT HARM
AFTER NEARLY A YEAR THEY
RECEIVED A NOTICE LIMITED TO A
SINGLE WORD. I'M STAYING
EXONERATED OR UNFOUNDED.
SUBSEQUENTLY THERE INFORMED THAT
THE PERSON WHO HARM THEM THE
REINSTATED ONCE AGAIN WEARING A
BADGE IN UNISON. NOW THE
COMMUNITY IS ASKED TO TRUST THE
PROCESS. RESULTED IN A FINDING
WITHOUT ANY ADDITIONAL
INFORMATION. FINDINGS OF THE
INVESTIGATION MONTHS SHOULD BE
RELEASED WOMEN OFFICERS HAVE
BEEN CLEARED THE LONG TERM. THE
INFORMATION RELATING TO AN
INVESTIGATION NOT RESULTING IN
ASSISTING FUNDING OF MISCONDUCT.
IS VITALLY IMPORTANT TO THE
PUBLIC INTEREST. AB TWO FIVE
FIVE SEVEN WILL ENHANCE THE
RELATIONSHIP BETWEEN THE
COMMUNITY POLICE AND CIVILIAN
OVERSIGHT BODIES. IF YOU
REVEREND LARRY MENTIONED
TRANSPARENCY YES MA'AM YES SIR
TRANSPARENCY AND FLEXIBILITY
LATENCIES ABILITY TO HOLD LAW
ENFORCEMENT ACCOUNTABLE IS WHAT
WILL BUILD THE TRUST WITH LAW
ENFORCEMENT PERSONNEL WHO MUST
EXECUTE THEIR RESPONSIBILITY
CONSTITUTIONALLY AND EQUITABLY.
IT IS CRITICAL MORE THAN EVER
THE DECISION CONCERNING
COMMUNITY POLICING OCCUR IN THE
FULL LIGHT OF DAY YOUR
COMMUNITIES CAN UNDERSTAND
PRECISELY THE SCOPE OF THE
SYSTEMATIC. SYSTEMIC PROBLEM OF
ABUSE OF POLICE TACTICS SOMEONE
A LOCAL GOVERNMENTS CAN DO THE
BEST ELIMINATE THOSE ABUSES.
THIS BILL IS PRACTICAL HI MOM
AND THAT'S A FAIRLY I URGE YOUR
AYE VOTE THANK YOU SO MUCH.
THANK YOU. AND NOW WE'LL HEAR
FROM- ANY WITNESSES IN ROOM IN
SUPPORT. EMILY HARRIS ELLA BAKER
CENTER IN SUPPORT THANK YOU.
MARCO CHARGE CALIFORNIA PUBLIC
DEFENDERS ASSOCIATION IN SUPPORT
I THANK YOU. NOW GO TO PHONE
LINES ANY WITNESSES IN SUPPORT.
IF YOU WISH TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT
OF AB TWENTY FIVE FIFTY SEVEN
PLEASE PRESS ONE THEN ZERO. AND
FIRST WE'LL GO TO LINE TWO FORTY
EIGHT PLEASE GO AHEAD. FORTY
EIGHT YOUR LINE IS OPEN. AND
THEY REMOVE THEMSELVES. NINE
THREE FOURTEEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
BRIAN HOPE FOR ON BEHALF OF
SECURE JUSTICE HERE IN SUPPORT.
NOT MINE ONE EIGHTY FOUR PLEASE
GO AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON IGOR
TRACK OF THE ALAMEDA COUNTY
DEMOCRATIC PARTY IN SUPPORT.
1-040-451-4401 PLEASE GO AHEAD.
YOU HEAR ME. YES HELLO CAN YOU
HEAR ME YES. YES HI I'M BARBARA
TOWARD I'M BEGIN BY HELP YOU
HAVE A BYE STYLE AND THE SAN
FRANCISCO- CHAPTER OF THE
NATIONAL LAWYERS GUILD SPEAKING
IN SUPPORT- I'VE BEEN A THE
LETTER AS- THE LAWYERS CARE
THANK YOU. NEXT WE HAVE NINE
ZERO SIX PLEASE GO AHEAD. YES
I'M CITY SPOKE ABOUT B. X. FOCAL
OF OSCAR GRANT- ALSO- FOUNDER OF
CALIFORNIA FAMILIES UNITED FOR
JUSTICE WE ARE IN STRONG SUPPORT
FOR A BI TWENTY FIVE FIFTY SEVEN
. HERE NEXT LINE THREE TWENTY
PLEASE GO AHEAD. YES HELLO DRAKE
WITH THE ALAMEDA COUNTY
DEMOCRATIC CENTRAL COMMITTEE THE
WELCOME DEMOCRATIC RENEWAL CLUB
AND THE BLOCK BY BLOCK
ORGANIZING NETWORK ALL IN STRONG
SUPPORT. ONE ONE HUNDRED PLEASE
GO AHEAD. HI GARY WITH OAKLAND
PRIDE IN SUPPORT OF AB TWENTY
FIVE FIFTY SEVEN. THANK YOU. AT
NINE ONE EIGHTY EIGHT PLEASE GO
AHEAD. OLYMPIA CAMPBELL IN
SUPPORT THANK YOU. AND LINE
THREE THIRTEEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
I REMEMBER BEING WITH SB JUNK
FOOD GROUP AND SUPPORT. NINE
THREE SEVENTEEN PLEASE GO AHEAD
. WHAT MADE BY YOURS ON BEHALF
WITH THE OPEN A NEW PUBLISHER.
GOOD FOR THE- THANK YOU LINE TO
SIXTY ONE PLEASE GO AHEAD. YES
MY NAME IS SCOTT RUSHING I'M
CALLING ON BEHALF OF MY SON WHO
WAS KILLED IN AN OFFICER
INVOLVED SHOOTING- AND ACUTELY
AWARE OF THE NEED FOR CIVILIAN
OVERSIGHT OF LAW ENFORCEMENT.
THANK YOU FOR LISTENING. HERE
FIND CA NINETY TWO PLEASE GO
AHEAD. YEAH MY NAME IS MARY VALE
I AM A LONG TIME RESIDENT OF THE
BAY AREA I'VE WORKED FOR- OVER
FORTY FIVE YEARS ARE BOTH IN SAN
FRANCISCO AND OAKLAND TO BUILD-
W. OVERSIGHT- SYSTEMS I KNOW
WHAT THE LAW WAS LIKE ON THE
PRACTICE BEFORE THE COMPANY
DECISION. AND AFTER.
TRANSPARENCY THANK YOU ASCENTIAL
HELLO EVERYONE THANK YOU. NEXT
TO FIFTY NINE PLEASE GO AHEAD.
MY NAME IS MILLIE CLEVELAND I AM
A MEMBER OF THE COALITION OF
POLICE ACCOUNTABILITY I'M
CALLING IN TO SHARE MY POSITION
I AM IN IN STRONG SUPPORT OF AB
TWO FIVE FIVE SEVEN. THANK YOU.
STREAMLINED TWO SIX EIGHT PLEASE
GO AHEAD. HI MY NAME IS CAROL
DRIVES IN I AM A CULT MEMBER AND
SEIU TEN TO ONE AND THE
COALITION OF POLICE
ACCOUNTABILITY IN OAKLAND AND I
AM SPEAKING IN STRONG SUPPORT OF
AB TWO FIVE FIVE SEVEN THANK YOU
. AND I HAVE NO ONE ELSE IN Q.
THANK YOU HOWEVER ANY WITNESSES
IN OPPOSITION. DAVID NYSTAGMUS.
THE WITNESSES THERE IN ROME
BETTER IN OPPOSITION. GOOD
AFTERNOON MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS
AND SHAUN MUTCHLER ON BEHALF OF
THE CALIFORNIA LAW ENFORCEMENT
ASSOCIATION OF RECORDS
SUPERVISORS AS WELL AS THE
CALIFORNIA STATE SHERIFFS
ASSOCIATION RESPECTFULLY ON IN
OPPOSITION TO AB TWENTY FIVE
FIFTY SEVEN- TWO SIGNIFICANT
PIECES OF LEGISLATION OVER THE
PAST FEW YEARS SB FOURTEEN
TWENTY ONE AND SB SIXTEEN HAVE
BEEN AND MADE SEVERAL CLASSES OF
PEACE OFFICER PERSONNEL RECORDS.
DISCLOSEABLE TO THE PUBLIC.
HOWEVER IN SO DOING- THOSE
MEASURES GENERALLY LIMITED
DISCLOSURE TO RECORDS REGARDING
SUSTAINED FINDINGS OF MISCONDUCT
IN CERTAIN CIRCUMSTANCES- AB
TWENTY FIVE FIFTY SEVEN GREATLY
EXPANDS THE UNIVERSE OF RECORDS
THAT WOULD BE PUBLIC. AND OFFERS
ONLY A MODEST ABILITY TO BE
DACTYLS RECORDS IN LIMITED
FASHION AS A FOIL TO THIS
MASSIVE BLOW TO OFFICER PRIVACY.
AND THE IMPLICATIONS OF RECENT
LEGISLATION ARE STILL BEING
SORTED OUT AND SIMPLY ALLOWING
ANY PEACE OFFICER PERSONAL
RECORDS THAT FIND THEIR WAY TO
CIVILIAN OVERSIGHT BODY DEVIATES
FROM DESPAIRED OF PROTECTING
EMPLOYEE PRIVACY. FOR THESE
REASONS AND THOSE STATED ABOVE-
WE MUST RESPECTFULLY OPPOSE AB
TWENTY FIVE FIFTY SEVEN THANK
YOU THANK YOU. AND I BELIEVE
REPRESENTATIVE FROM PORAC
CALCIFIED. YES SIR DAVID MISTAKE
ME. CAN YOU HEAR ME YES WE CAN
HEAR YOU MAY BEGIN. GOOD
AFTERNOON- I APPRECIATE THE
OPPORTUNITY TO APPEAR ON BEHALF
OF PORAC. BY LABOR LAW PRACTICE
FOCUSES ON REPRESENTING. PUBLIC
EMPLOYEES AND THEIR UNIONS AND
MY LAW ENFORCEMENT CLIENTS
UNDERSTAND THE CONTINUING NEED
FOR POLICE REFORM. THAT'S WHY WE
WORK TIRELESSLY WITH THE
STAKEHOLDERS AND WITH THE
LEADERSHIP ON USE OF FORCE
STANDARDS. TRAINING THE
CERTIFICATION AND OF COURSE
INCREASE TRANSPARENCY ALTHOUGH
WELL INTENDED AB TWO FIVE FIVE
SEVEN WHAT AND DO THE IMPORTANT
WORK OF SENATOR SKINNER. WITH
RESPECT TO SB FOURTEEN TWENTY
ONE AND SIXTEEN. I PERSONALLY
WORK WITH HER TO FIND COMMON
GROUND AMONG THE STAKEHOLDERS
AND STRIKE THE PROPER BALANCE
BETWEEN THE DISCLOSURE OF
SUSTAINED SERIOUS MISCONDUCT IN
THE LEGITIMATE PRIVACY INTERESTS
OF OFFICERS AGAINST THE
DISCLOSURE OF UNPROVEN OR MINOR
ALLEGATIONS. THIS BILL WOULD
DISCARD THAT LEGISLATIVE WORK
THE LAST THREE OR FOUR YEARS AND
ESSENTIALLY CONVERT ALL
PERSONNEL RECORDS INCLUDING
UNSUSTAINABLE LOCATIONS. IN THE
PUBLIC RECORDS IN ANY
JURISDICTION WHERE CIVILIAN
OVERSIGHT OF THE POLICE
DISAPPROVAL AT FEUDED POLICE
DISCIPLINARY PROCESS EXISTS.
EVEN FOR THIS IS THAT CIVILIAN
REVIEW BOARDS DEPEND ON ACCESS
TO THE INTERNAL AFFAIRS
INVESTIGATION WHICH IS GRANTED
BY THE EMPLOYING AGENCY THEY
TYPICALLY DON'T HAVE THE
RESOURCES OR THE STAFFING TO
CONDUCT COMPLETELY INDEPENDENT
INVESTIGATIONS. AND SO THE
CIVILIAN REVIEW BOARDS RIGHT TO
INVESTIGATE MAKE FINDINGS AND
MAKE RECOMMENDATIONS ALL OF THIS
THROUGH THE NEXUS OF THE
EMPLOYER. AS THE COURTS HAVE
RECOGNIZED FOR EXAMPLE IN THE
CITY OF SACRAMENTO. THE POLICE
DEPARTMENT'S OFFICE OF PUBLIC
SAFETY ACCOUNTABILITY WHICH ARE
ALL CIVILIAN THEY HAVE FULL
ACCESS TO EVERY. COMPLAINT OF
MISCONDUCT REGARDLESS OF THE
NATURE. M. THAT IS INVESTIGATED
BY THE INTERNAL AFFAIRS
DEPARTMENT THEY HAVE EVEN THE
ABILITY TO SIT IN DURING THE
INTERVIEW OF OFFICERS. IT'S NOT
JUST COMPLAINTS THAT THEY
RECEIVE AND THEY REVIEW THE
FINDINGS THEY GIVE IT. ARE MEANT
ARE STILL. IN CHARGE TAKEN INTO
CONSIDERATION IN THE DISCIPLINE
PROCESS AND THEN ALSO RELEASES
AN ANNUAL REPORT YOU CAN FIND IT
ON THE WEBSITE TO TAKE A LOOK AT
IT AND AGAIN I THINK IT'S RIGHT
TO THE RIGHT BALANCE WHERE IT
HAD SUMMARIES. AND WE CAN REVIEW
IS IMPORTANT TO MAINTAIN PUBLIC
CONFIDENCE IN LAW ENFORCEMENT
BUT YOU HAVE TO STRIKE THE RIGHT
BALANCE. BETWEEN LOOKING AT
SUSTAIN SERIOUS MISCONDUCT
ALLEGATIONS AS OPPOSED TO JUST
ANY ALLEGATION. ANOTHER FACTOR
THAT'S IMPORTANT TO CONSIDER IS
THAT AGENCIES HAVE A YEAR
GENERALLY AND SOMETIMES LONGER
TO COMPLETE AN INVESTIGATION OF
MISCONDUCT. WHAT THAT RESULTS IN
REAL LIFE IS THAT THERE'S OFTEN
A LAG OF NINE TEN MONTHS BETWEEN
A STIGMATIZING ALLEGATION AND
THE ULTIMATE FINDING THAT MAY
VERY WELL CLEAR AN OFFICER UNDER
THIS BILL AND THEN IT'S AN
OFFICER WHO'S ACCUSED OF THE
STIGMATIZING. ALLEGATION WOULD
HAVE THAT AND PUBLICIZE MONTHS
BEFORE THEIR NAME IS EVENTUALLY
CLEARED AND WE ALL KNOW THAT THE
CALL. NOT GONNA GET THE SAME
POOL. AS THE INITIAL ALLEGATION
AND THAT'S WHY SENATOR SKINNER'S
WORK WAS SO IMPORTANT IN LOOKING
AT. ALLEGATIONS OF SERIOUS
MISCONDUCT THIS BILL IN MY VIEW
WITH THE SERI AT CIVILIAN REVIEW
BOARD FINDINGS RECOMMENDATIONS
AND INVESTIGATIONS ARE ALREADY
PUBLIC RECORDS THE FOURTEEN
TWENTY ONE NSP SIXTEEN ARE THEY
INVOLVED SUSTAINED ALLEGATIONS
OF SERIOUS MISCONDUCT WE THINK
COURT DECISION. IT DOESN'T
MATTER WHO GENERATED A RECORD
AFTER RECORD FALLS WITHIN THOSE
STATUTES IT'S DISCLOSEABLE BY
ANY ENTITY THAT POSSESSES THOSE
RECORDS AND THOSE BILL SET FORTH
A LAUNDRY LIST OF THE TYPES OF
DOCUMENTS. THAT ARE DISCLOSEABLE
AND SO WHERE YOU HAVE AN OUT OF
THREE. ADULTS AND AT LEAST A
STAINED THIS CIVILIAN OVERSIGHT
RECORDS ARE GOING TO BE
CORRECTED JUST LIKE THE- WE'RE-
I WANT TO MAKE IS THAT I THINK
THERE'S SOME UNINTENDED. FROM
THIS BILL WHICH WOULD BE TO
ENCOURAGE AGE HE'S NOT TO HAVE
CIVILIAN OVERSIGHT OR SEVERELY
REVIEW ACCESS TO THE INFORMATION
THAT THEY GET OUT OF FEAR THAT
THE TYPE OF INFORMATION ON
PROVING THAT. COME PUBLIC AND
THAT'S NOT A HYPOTHETICAL
CONCERN THAT'S SOMETHING THAT WE
SAW A FEW YEARS AGO IN THE
COUNTY OF SACRAMENTO WHERE THE
INDEPENDENT INVESTIGATOR WAS
LOCKED OUT OF ACCESS TO THAT
INFORMATION. THE CURRENT SYSTEM
AND CLOSE IT STRIKES THE RIGHT
BALANCE OF ONLY DISCLOSING
SERIOUS MISCONDUCT WANT TO
IMPROVE THAT PROTECTS INNOCENT
OFFICERS AND ALL GIVES PUBLIC
MASON IT NEEDS THANK YOU FOR
YOUR TIME. ARE YOU DONE. SIR. I
GUESS YOU'RE DONE. YES SOME SO I
CAN NOT HEAR ME OKAY- WE'RE NOT
GOING TO INTO ROOM FOR ANY
ANYONE ANYONE IN OPPOSITION NAME
AN ORGANIZATION OR ORGANISE.
SINCE MISTER RYAN SHERMAN WITH
THE SURE SO. AND STRONG
OPPOSITION ALSO REPRESENTING- IN
OPPOSITION THE CLAREMONT POLICE
OFFICERS ASSOCIATIONS AND THE
POLICE OFFICER ASSOCIATIONS OF
CORONA POMONA PALACE VERDES.
NEWPORT BEACH UPLAND SANTA ANA
BURBANK INGLEWOOD ARCADIA
RIVERSIDE FULLERTON COVER CITY
LA SCHOOL POLICE AND CALIFORNIA
COALITION OF SCHOOL SAFETY
PROFESSIONALS ALL IN OPPOSITION
TO THE- THANK YOU ANYONE ELSE.
WE NOW GO TO THE PHONE LINES IN
OPPOSITION. THANK YOU AND IF
YOU'RE IN A POSITION PLEASE
PRESS ONE AND ZERO. AND WE DO
HAVE LINE TWO FIFTY FIVE PLEASE
GO AHEAD. THE JUDGE HEARING
MEMBERS GENERAL ROUTE ONE BEHALF
OF THE CALIFORNIA STATEWIDE LAW
ENFORCEMENT ASSOCIATION AND THE
CALIFORNIA FRATERNAL ORDER OF
POLICE AND THAT BERNARDINO
COUNTY SHERIFF'S. THANK YOU NEXT. NINE THREE TWENTY FIVE PLEASE
GO AHEAD. GOOD MORNING OUR
AFTERNOON CHAIRMAN- AND MEMBERS
CARE LUCIEN- TESTIFYING
OPPOSITION ON BEHALF OF THE LOS
ANGELES POLICE PROTECTIVE LEAGUE
AND THE DEPUTY SHERIFFS
ASSOCIATION SAN DIEGO. THANK YOU
A BOTTOM LINE THREE TWENTY SEVEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. THANK YOU CAN
FELLOW STONE ADVOCACY ON BEHALF
OF THE CALIFORNIA DISTRICT
ATTORNEYS ASSOCIATION AND
RESPECTFUL OF. WELL MOVING TO
LINE THREE TWENTY TWO. GOOD
AFTERNOON CHAIR AND MEMBERS OF
THE MICHELLE COLOR WITH ERIN
REED AND ASSOCIATES AND I'M
CALLING ON BEHALF OF PORAC AM
CALIFORNIA THIRTY. TOLD ME H. E.
AND WE ARE AGREEMENT WITH IN
AGREEMENT WITH EVERYTHING IN THE
FACT THAT THEY.
THIS IS MATTHEW REALLY WITH THE
CALIFORNIA CORRECTIONAL PEACE
OFFICERS ASSOCIATION IN
OPPOSITION THANK YOU. AT THIS
TIME THERE'S NO ONE I THINK YOU.
THANK WE NOW BRING IT BACK TO
COMMITTEE ANY QUESTIONS MR WORK
. SO ASSEMBLY MEMBER BONTA WE'RE
GOOD FRIENDS AND WE'VE HAD
DISCUSSIONS ON THIS. WHAT I'VE
SAID IS I THERE'S STILL. THERE'S
ALMOST NOTHING THAT I CAN
SUPPORT. BOB BUT I WILL GIVE YOU
AN AYE VOTES YOU CAN GO ON TO
JUDICIARY AND THAT'S IMPORTANT.
BOB BECAUSE YOU NEED TO GET THE
FEEDBACK FROM THE JUDICIARY
COMMITTEE AS WELL AS THIS
COMMITTEE. SO THE TWO PROBLEMS I
HAVE HIS NUMBER ONE. THIS WOULD
ONLY CHANGE THINGS FOR
JURISDICTIONS WHICH HAVE A
POLICE REVIEW BOARD UP AND SOME
OF THE LARGER CITIES TO HAVE
THEM BUT MY DAHLE. SO THAT IT
WOULD NOT SOME YOU SHOULD.
PLEASE PART OF THE OTHER THING
WE HAVE WORK CARE AND CAN WE
DISK THE- AB ONE CAN SCHOOL SO
WHAT FOR TO- HOW BILLS BY SKI.
WHICH TO ME MY MIND MAYBE YOU
DIFFERENCE IN TERMS OF WHAT CAN
BE DISCLOSED IN. THE PRESS INTO
THIS AND IT'S GREAT- AND THERE
PROBABLY ARE MORE THINGS WE CAN
DISCLOSE BUT THE REASON GIVEN BY
. MISSION YOU KNOW SO. TOTALLY
UNPACKED CHARGE OF IT COULD RUIN
A PERSON'SREPUTATION AND YET
THERE COULD BE NO EVIDENCE FOR
IT AND I WOULDN'T WANT TO BE ON
THE OTHER HAND IF THAT. ON THE
END OF IT- BEING A POLITICIAN.
GOD KNOWS THAT PROBABLY DOES
HAPPEN TO US MATTER OF FACT
THERE'S MY WIKIPEDIA ARTICLE I
CAN POINT OUT A FEW THINGS. BOB
BUT- WE DO THAT BECAUSE- BECAUSE
OF BUT POLICE OFFICERS SHOULD BE
IN THAT POSITION SO WE JUST NEED
TO. NATIONALEN SHOULD BE
DISCLOSED AND I THINK THERE
PROBABLY IS SOME BUT THIS IS
JUST TOO BROAD FOR ME SO AGAIN
I'M GET MY IPHONE THE ADVANCE
OF THE- INPUT. YES SLAPPY YEAH
LET ME SAY FIRST OF ALL YOUR I
DON'T DISAGREE THAT AB FACTORS I
FULLY HARDLY AGREE THAT OKAY
BILLION TRANSPARENCY HAS TO BE
PART OF MAX STRUS FORTUNATE OF.
BUT I WILL TELL YOU AS YOUNG ONE
HERE ON THIS EDDIE. ZACKS DOT
TESTING TIONS AGAINST-
ALLEGATIONS. AND SOMETIMES
ACTIONS COMMITTED BY LAW
ENFORCEMENT THAT- IN THE HEARTS
OF SOME PEOPLE THERE IS A
RETALIATORY AND SENATE TO PURSUE
THIS PROCESS AND TO ABUSE IT
AND- IT'S UNFORTUNATE WHEN THAT
HAPPENS BUT IT IS A REALITY. AND
YOU. STE IT'S VERY DANGEROUS
VERY DANGEROUS AND IT DOESN'T
HELP THE TRUST THAT WE'RE TRYING
TO BUILD BECAUSE I THINK THAT'S
THE INTENTION. AND THE FACT IS
TO ROADS THAT THAT CLOUDS TRUTH.
AND I DON'T THINK THAT SHOULD BE
THE INTENTION OF ANY LEGISLATIVE
EFFORT- I WOULD JUST TELL YOU
THAT- THE OTHER BILLS THAT- HAVE
IMPROVED- THE DISCLOSURE AND THE
TRANSPARENCY ARE IMPORTANT TO
BUILD BACK THIS TRUST BUT I
THINK THAT THIS GOES. THE ONLY.
OKAY SHINS IT CAN N. AND IT WILL
RUINSOME PEOPLE BECAUSE THERE
ARE SOME VERY VERY. OUTRAGEOUS
DEMANDED I'VE INVESTIGATED AND
SOMETIMES THOSE OUTRAGEOUS
DEMANDS PROVED TO BE TRUE.
HOWEVER IF THEY'RE NOT TRUE AND
THEY'RE RELEASED TO THE PUBLIC
IT DOES A HUGE DISSERVICE TO ALL
PARTIES INVOLVED AND SO
THEREFORE NOT ABLE TO SUPPORT
THIS BECAUSE I'M REALLY REALLY
UNDERSTAND. THIS BEING. SANTIAGO
YEAH I HAD THAT LOOK AT A- I
UNDERSTAND WHAT YOU'RE GETTING
AT I THINK IT'S IMPORTANT THAT
WE CONTINUE THAT WORKS ON THANK
YOU FOR MOVING THE CONVERSATION. FOR- I JUST I DON'T WANNA
SPEND TOO MUCH TIME ON ECHO WHAT
HAS ALREADY BEEN ECHOED AND BUT
THERE IS A BIG DIFFERENCE
BETWEEN. ACCUSATIONS ARE
UNFOUNDED. AND THOSE THINGS A
PERSON TO DO I MEAN WE HAVE
APPLE TRANSPARENCY TO GET
SOMETHING OUT PERSONS AND-
PRIVATE HEALTH DECISIONS RIGHT
AT. BUT IT IF THIS MAKE UP
NUMBER SEVEN OF US HERE WERE TO
. ACCUSE MISTER TURNER'S TIME AS
AN OFFICER THAT. YOU MAY HAVE
DONE SOMETHING WHEN YOU HAD A
BILLS SEVEN ITEMS GOING RECORD
UNLESS THEY'RE PROVEN I DO BUT
IT COULD. TAKE A DAMAGE
SOMEBODY'S LIFE AND REPUTATION-
OF THE NOBILITY TO DEFEND
THEMSELVES ARE THE FLIP SIDE.
AND I RECOGNIZE THE THIS WILL
MOVE AND IT SHOULD BUT I JUST
WANT TO THINK ABOUT THAT PIECE.
DOWN THE LINE THE DIFFERENCE
BETWEEN FULL TRANSPARENCY IN
TRADE AND TRYING TO IMPROVE ON
PUBLIC SAFETY. N. IN SOME PLACE
WERE MAY NOT BE MERITED WHETHER
OUR ACCUSATIONS THAT ARE NOT-
THE AVERA. WHAT'S THE RIGHT WORD
SAY OR THEY'RE NOT- LEGITIMATE
WITH A LOT WITH WITH WITH THAT
WILL SUSTAIN IS ONE THING BUT
ALSO WITH A COULD BE A FRIVOLOUS
ACCUSATIONS AFTERWARDS LOOKING
FOR OUR- WITH GERMAN. OR SUSTAIN
IF YOU WILL I THANK YOU FOR
HAVING THIS CONVERSATION AND
HOPE THAT YOU WOULD TAKE A LOOK
AT. THE TAKE A LOOK AT IT MORE
COMMITTEE WOULD BECAUSE WE'RE
TAKING A LOOK AT IT IS IN THE
PUBLIC AND- EVEN HAVE. FOR
YEARS. SIGN UP. BELIEVE IN
OAKLAND. ON THE SENATE SIDE HAD
HAD HAD THAT DEBATE- INSTRUCT
THAT BALANCE SO MUCH THANK YOU
FOR FROM THE FOUR BUT JUST WANT
TO PUT MY TWO CENTS OUT THERE.
ON THANK YOU ANY OTHER COMMENTS
YOU MAY CLOSE. WHAT I WANT TO
THANK MY COLLEAGUES ON BOTH
SIDES OF THE AISLE FOR THE
FEEDBACK AND- AND DO YOU KNOW
THAT THERE ARE THERE'S AN
OPPORTUNITY TO FIGURE OUT HOW WE
CAN GET BACK TO THE PRE COPLEY
MOMENT ACTUALLY WILL. R. O. IN
THE- IS IT BEING A TO A PROVIDE
THE GREAT LEVEL ACCOUNTABILITY
THROUGH INDEPENDENT COMMISSIONS
UP AND CIVILIAN OVERSIGHT IN
THAT BODY I DO RECOGNIZE THE
NEED TO CONTINUE TO WORK ON THIS
BILL SO THAT OPPORTUNITY TO
ADDRESS SOME OF THE ISSUES
RAISED TERMS OF. PRIVILEGE DON'T
PART OF WEAPONS THAT CAN BE USED
AGAINST OUR OUR PEACE OFFICERS
WHICH IS NOT THE INTENTION ALL
OF THE BILL ENGINE IT PROVIDE
CIVILIAN OVER M. IN THE MAY. IN
THIS THAT WE JOINT. BUT IT IT
FROM UP TO PRESS. AND WE DO HAVE
LED THAT HAS BEEN PASSED AND
CAREFULLY THREADED THE NEEDLE WE
I DO THINK DO THINK WE DO NEED
TO LOOK AT THE UNIVERSE OF THE
THINGS THAT ARE NOT SEEN- IN
ORDER TO BE ABLE TO MAKE SURE
THAT THOSE DON'T OF SHOT THAT
THEY ARE CURRENTLY ON. WE'RE TO
WORKING WITH THE- I'M ALLIES IN
IN THE MY LEGISLATIVE COLLEAGUES
TO TRY TO IDENTIFY A PATH FOR
THAT WILL CONTINUE TO THREATEN
VERY CAREFUL I APPRECIATE THE
FEEDBACK ON. WITH THAT I RESPECT
QUESTION. IN M. WE TALKED TO
SOME CLEVER YOU'RE GOING TO
CLOSELY LOOK AT THIS YOU KNOW I
MR SANTIAGO AND MISTER BRIAN AND
I COME FROM AN AREA WHERE YOU
HAVE- A LOS ANGELES POLICE
COMMISSION WHICH WILL WHICH
TRIED TO BE AFFECT.
THEY HAVE A REALLY GOOD
RELATIONSHIP. AS OPPOSED TO THE
COUNTY OF LOS ANGELES WE'RE
TOTALLY DYSFUNCTIONAL- WHERE THE
SHERIFF DOESN'T DOESN'T EVEN
TALK TO THE OVERSIGHT GROUP AND
IS OPEN BE REBELLIOUS TOWARDS IT
AND SO I'D I KNOW. WHEN IT COMES
TO TRANSPARENCY IS REALLY
IMPORTANT I THINK IT WOULD HELP
FOR EXAMPLE. IS IT IT IS HELPED
L. A. P. E. N. AND MOVING
FORWARD WITH REFORMS AND THINGS
THAT NATURE I THINK IT WOULD
REALLY HELP THE SHERIFF'S
DEPARTMENT IF IT WOULD OPEN UP
TO CIVILIAN OVERSIGHT AND LET
PEOPLE SEE WHAT'S REALLY GOING
ON AND WE COULD GET RID OF WHAT
THE DOCTORS. THERE WHETHER
THERE'S THIS CORRUPTION WHETHER
OR NOT THERE'S ABOUT ISN'T. IF
YOU ALLOW DISAPPEAR NINETY DAYS
WHERE YOU'RE NEED TO LET'S HAVE
THAT TRANSPARENCY- AND SO MAYBE
THE MODEL. OR THE BEGINNING
MODEL MIGHT BE. ON THE LAPD
SITES SO- BUT GOING TO HAVE TO
MOVE FORWARD WITH THIS ON TO
THE- UP. TO TWO TO. THE NEXT
STEP WHICH IS- JUDICIARY I THINK
YOU'RE BEGIN TO HASH OUT SOME OF
THIS FOR AND SO THE CHURCH
RECOMMENDED I- OF THE COMMOTION
. NO MOVE. A SECOND AND THINK
YOU. MATT SECRETARY CALL THE
ROLL ON AB TWO FIVE FIVE SEVEN
BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER BONTA MUCH
MOTION IS THE PATH TO THE
JUDICIARY COMMITTEE JONES SAWYER
JONES SAWYER BLACKIE BLACKIE
NOPE BONTA BONTA HI BRIAN QUIRK
ARTWORK HYPHEN CAPITAL SAN DIEGO
ACR. THAT. YOUR CALL NEEDS ONE
MORE.
VACANCY THANK YOU. AB TWENTY
DAYS MY TALKING POINTS HERE SAY
GOOD MORNING ED RESEARCHER AND
MEMBERS. FIRST I WOULD LIKE TO
EXPRESS MY APPRECIATION FOR THE
COMMITTEE'S STAFF FOR HELPING TO
STRENGTHENING THE STRENGTH IN
THE BILL LANGUAGE ON THIS IN THE
PAST FORTY YEARS WOMEN BEEN.
THIS GROWING FRUSTRATED. IN AT A
RATE OF 50% MORE THAN THEIR MALE
COUNTERPARTS ACROSS THE UNITED
STATES. SINCE NINETEEN EIGHTY
THE NUMBER. OF WOMEN AND-
PRIESTER BY FOUR HUNDRED AND
THIRTY THREE PERCENT. THERE ARE
NONE. SEVEN FEET VENDORS IN
RATED IN CALIFORNIA THREE
EQUIPMENT CALIFORNIA'S THREE
WOMEN'S PRISONS AND CALIFORNIA
IS HOME TO THE LARGEST WOMEN'S
PRISON IN THE WORLD IN ADDITION
DATA CDC ART REVIEW. THAT OVER
SIXTY ONE HAVING CAR. WOMEN
EITHER BLACK OR LET. IN AN
EFFORT TO REDUCE RECIDIVISM
CALIFORNIA HAS SUPPORTED THE
CREATION AND XIN REENTRY
PROGRAMS THESE PROGRAMS PROVIDE
ACADEMIC VOCATIONAL REHAB. FOR
IN FOLLOW THERE FROM PRISON AND
- MY REENTRY PROGRAMS ARE
HEAVILY OR SOLELY FOR ON ME AND
- NO ATTENTION TO AND CULTURAL
SPECIFIC BACK FOR THE PER
RESPONSE. THAT WOMEN OFTEN FACE
AS THE PRIMARY CARETAKERS AND
THEIR HOUSEHOLD. WE KNOW THAT
FEMALE PRISONERS ARE MORE LIKELY
TO BE ECONOMICALLY DISADVANTAGED
VICTIMS OF ABUSE SUFFER FROM
MENTAL ILLNESS AND HAVE MINOR
CHILDREN TO CARE FOR UPON
RELEASE. ADDITIONALLY IN
CONSIDERING THE UNIQUE
CHALLENGES AND BARRIERS FOR
WOMEN OF COLOR WHO ARE IMPACTED
BY THE CRIMINAL JUSTICE SYSTEM
THERE'S A CLEAR NEED TO. CONFORM
FAMILY FOCUS AND CULTURE COMPACT
CULTURE CAN REACT PROGRAMS THAT
FACILITATE DEVELOPMENT AND
ECONOMIC POWER AND FELT TO KEEP
. AB TWO FIFTH. CULTURE AND-
PILOT PROGRAM THAT WAS THE ONLY
THREE WOMEN- BY PROVIDING THEM
WITH SUPPORT SPECIALISTS
EMPLOYMENT AND SKILLS TRAINING
AND HOUSING STABILIZATION
SERVICES WITH ME TODAY TO
TESTIFY IN SUPPORT OF THIS BILL
BOB JONES TO BE A- JEFF CREATED.
REST RESTORATIVE OPPORTUNITIES
AND PROGRAM WHO WILL BE
APPEARING BY PHONE. K. A. T. T.
OFFERS OPERATOR IF WE COULD-
HAVE MISTER JONES AND I'M
ACTUALLY HURT. I GUESS WE DON'T
NEED THE OPERATOR WE GOT YOU
RIGHT THERE. ONES ON PHONES ALL
WILL IT FIRST PERFECT I KNOW
IT'S BEEN A LONG DAY I
APPRECIATE YOUR TIME- IT'S ONE
TO BUY A- ARE. GOOD AFTERNOON
CHAIR AND- MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE I LIKE TO START BY CAN
YOU FOR A LONG THE OPPORTUNITY.
AT THE CONTEST THE MONEY TO THE
NEED. THAT A BIT. FIFTY S. I'M
IS BOB TELLING THE FOUND OF YOUR
ONE A NATIONAL REENTRY. PER THAT
LEVERAGES TECH. AND THE
EXPERIENCES OF FORMERLY
INCARCERATED INDIVIDUALS BY
FACILITATING COLLABORATION
AMONGST CRIMINAL JUSTICE SYSTEM
STAKEHOLDERS. WALKER IF YOU'RE
WHAT OF ALSO PLAYED IN WORKFORCE
DEVELOPMENT. FOR THE PAST THREE
YEARS. ALLIES IF THE CENVAT
TOOLS. AND COUNTIES. AND LIKE MY
WHO WAS SPEAK AFTER ME I TWO AM
FORMERLY INCARCERATED. NOW
ALTHOUGH I CAN SPEAK TO YOU FROM
MY PROFESSIONAL EXPERIENCE I
LIKE TO SPEAK TODAY. MORE HUMAN
CENTRIC PERSONAL CAPACITY.
ACCORDING TO A TWENTY TWENTY ONE
ARTICLE NATIONAL INSTITUTE OF
JUSTICE. FEMA PROPOSE ARE MORE
LIKELY TO BE ECONOMICALLY
DISADVANTAGED IN COMPARISON TO
MALE PRISONERS AND THE AVERAGE
FEMALE PRISONER HAS ABOUT TWO
POINT FIVE CHILDREN. LIKE THEIR
MALE COUNTERPARTS. THESE WOMEN
WILL GO ON TO HAVE SOLE CUSTODY
OF THEIR CHILDREN AND PLAN TO
RESUME THEIR PARENTING ROLE
AFTER RELEASE. ADDITIONAL DATA
FROM PRISON POLICY INITIATIVE
FOUND THAT CHILDREN WITH ADVERSE
CHILDHOOD EXPERIENCES SUCH AS
POVERTY AND HOUSING AND
SECURITY. AND WHO HAVE A FAMILY
MEMBER WITH SEVEN CAR. ARE AT AN
INCREASED. FOR IN CAR THEMSELVES
. I MYSELF EXPERIENCED THIS
MEMBERS OF THE FAMILY THIS BILL
IS NOT ONLY DESIGNED TO ADDRESS
THE UNIQUE NEEDS IDENTIFIED BY
HUNDREDS OF WOMEN OF VARIOUS
ETHNIC AND CULTURAL BACKGROUNDS
IT HAS THE SHOW MUCH MORE. WHEN
I THIS BILL I SEE NOT BE FOR
WOMEN TO BERMAN CHANGE THEIR
LIVES AN AMICABLE. THIS GIVE THE
TOOLS AND SO NEEDED EXCESSIVE.
IT CASE AND COULD. WHEN WE
CONSIDERING THE POTENTIAL IN OF
ONE TALKING ABOUT HUNDREDS WOMEN
WERE ALSO TALKING TO IMPROVING
THE QUALITY LIFE OPPORTUNITY
FOUR THOUSAND OF CHILDREN AS
WELL WITH TENSIONS MEANS OF
ALMOST ONE SIXTY NOT OVER I
YEARS WHEN THEY WOMEN NOT RE OF.
YOU'LL BE CREATING A PROGRAM
WHICH LEVERAGES THE PEER
NAVIGATOR MODEL A BEST PRACTICE
METHODS SHOWN TO DECREASE
RECIDIVISM IMPROVE ECOLOGICAL
BEING CREASE EMOTIONAL BENEFITS
THAT PROP TO SELF EMPOWERMENT.
FOR THEM BUT IN THE- WOMEN TO
TRANSFORM THEMSELVES FROM BEING
DEPENDENT UPON GOVERNMENT
BENEFITS AND RESOURCES TO
BECOMING INDEPENDENT TAX
CONTRIBUTING MEMBERS OF SOCIETY
. WHETHER YOU CHOOSE TO DO THIS
BILL FROM ABOUT THE CALL OR
ECONOMICAL PERSPECTIVE THE
DECISION TO PASS THIS BILL
SHOULD BE CLEAR THUS I URGE YOU
TO VOTE HI I'M AB TWENTY FIFTY.
IF YOU. EIGHTY EIGHT RIGHT NOW
HEAR FROM TERRA LAWYER. CAN YOU
HEAR ME. WE CAN PLEASE PROCEED
ARE FROM GOOD AFTERNOON CHAIR
AND MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE MY
NAME IS CHERYL LAWYER HARPER AND
EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR OF THE CROP
OF MEDICATION I'D LIKE TO START
OUT WITH OFFER THE OPPORTUNITY.
TO I'D HAVE TO THE ASSEMBLY
TWENTY. THE FOLLOWING
CONSTRUCTION I KNOW FIRST HAND
THE OF THE TO MY QUEUE WITHOUT
ADEQUATE SUPPORT AND RESOURCES
IN PLACE FOR TO POP MANAGE. I
WROTE THE OVER HUNDRED AND
TWENTY HOUSING PROVIDERS TRY TO
SECURE HOUSING PROPERTY MIGHT
BUT WITH VERY SUCCESS. I WOULD
FINALLY AND- HI. ROGER I. WHICH
WERE THE RIGHT TREATMENT THAT
THE ALSO WE IN POCKET. UPON MY
RELEASE IN NOVEMBER OF TWENTY
SEVENTEEN I ALREADY HAD SEVERAL
JOB OFFERS AVAILABLE YET I WAS
NOT ABLE TO BEGIN WORKING IN
THREE AFTER BEING PROGRAM
BECAUSE BLACK. AND OTHER
RESTRICTIONS. I WOULD ALSO
REGISTER TO CAN DAMPEN THANK YOU
. BUT I COULDN'T AND ROLL IT
BACK IN. THE MASTER BECAUSE SO
TRACK REQUIRED ME TO TAKE THIRTY
EIGHT HOURS OF THEIR PROGRAM
THROUGHOUT THE WEEK. WHAT
INSPECTION WHICH I DO NOT HAVE A
TOUGH ABUSE HAS. I DON'T I'M
STARTING TO TEACH VERY. THEY
OFFER. BECAUSE I AM A CERTIFIED
AOD COUNSELOR. ADDITIONALLY
AFTER BEING AWAY FROM MY LOVED
ONES FOR OVER FIFTEEN YEARS. I
WAS ABLE TO SEE MY FAMILY MORE
WHEN I WAS IN PERSON AND AFTER.
BROWN'S BECAUSE IT. GOT ME ON
THE PATIENT. ALONE L. THE NEED
FOR IMPROVEMENT. I BEEN A
PROFESSIONAL IN THE CRIMINAL
JUSTICE SPACE FOR OVER TEN. I
HER LEAD THE CROP OR NEW JERSEY
WHICH IS A NON THAT PROVIDES
CLEAR PATHWAY PROJECT INVOLVED
INDIVIDUAL WITH. SUPPORT AB
TWENTY TWO FIFTY BECAUSE OF THE
CRITICAL IMPROVEMENT THE BILL
HAS ON OUR RE ENTRY I'M- YOU
NEED ME OF WENT. THEY TRY LONG
WHEN THEY ARE RELEASED THEIR
TURN. TOWARD HIGHER EDUCATION
UPWARD CAREER MOBILITY FAMILY
REUNIFICATION AND BUILDING A
HEALTHY SUPPORT NETWORK NETWORK
WILL BE ACHIEVED WITH APPROVAL
OF THE BILL. CAN ANYONE WITH A
CRIMINAL HISTORY OUR FIRST IN
COLLEGE AND TRAINING STUDENT
THEY OFTEN CANNOT LEAN ON YOUR
FAMILY FOR CAREER DEVELOPMENT
SUPPORT AND SHE HELPED ADVOCATE
. AB TWENTY TWO FIFTY FOUR
DRESSES CONCERNED HAD ONLINE AND
OUR LEGAL RIGHTS UNDER THE- I
STRONG SUPPORT THIS BILL AND
RESPECTIVELY- URGE YOUR I. THANK
YOU. THANK YOU. IT'S NOW TIME
FOR THOSE IN THE ROOM THAT WOULD
LIKE TO EXPRESS OUR SUPPORT COME
FORWARD PLEASE AND- NAME AND-
WHO YOU REPRESENT. THANK YOU
DEREK MORGAN WITH THE OTHER
BAKER CENTER FOR HUMAN RIGHTS
YOUR SUPPORT. THANK YOU.
SERAPEUM HAVE INITIATE JUSTICE
IN STRONG SUPPORT THANK YOU.
DANYCH ARAMBULA BEHALF OF THE
TRANSFORMATIVE IN PRISON
WORKGROUP IN STRONG SUPPORT
THANK YOU. PARCO GEORGE ON
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA PUBLIC
DEFENDERS ASSOCIATION IN SUPPORT
THANK YOU THANK YOU. OKAY DO WE
HAVE ANY WITNESSES- IN
OPPOSITION. I DON'T SEE ANY.
OKAY SO NOW WILL GO TO THE
PHONES AND ALLOW THOSE TO
EXPRESS THEIR THEIR SUPPORT OR
OPPOSITION A. T. AND T. OPERATOR
. THANK YOU AND IF YOU ARE IN
SUPPORT PLEASE. PLEASE PRESS ONE
ZERO. THANK YOU AND- OUR FIRST
CALLER IS THREE TWENTY SIX
PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON
CARE MEMBERS PERSONAL GET OFF ON
BEHALF OF THE CENTER FOR
EMPLOYMENT OPPORTUNITIES IN
STRONG SUPPORT THANK YOU. NINE
THREE TWENTY EIGHT PLEASE GO
AHEAD. BRIAN HOPE FOR ON BEHALF
OF SECURE JUSTICE HERE IN
SUPPORT. THANK YOU AND IF YOU
ARE OPPOSED TO PLEASE PRESS ONE
AND ZERO AT THIS TIME. AND AT
THIS TIME WE HAVE NO ONE IN Q.
OKAY THANK YOU WHEN I BRING IT
BACK TO COMMITTEE ANYBODY LIKE
TO EXPRESS THEIR SUPPORT
OPPOSITION OR QUESTIONS. YES
GREAT PAL. OKAY THAT WAS QUICK.
ANYBODY ELSE. WELL RELATED CLOSE
SOMEWHERE BONTA THANK YOU TO
ADEQUATELY SUPPORT CALIFORNIA'S
REENTRY GOALS WE CANNOT LEAVE
BEHIND THE GROWING POPULATION OF
INCARCERATED WOMEN WILL BE
COMING HOME TO THEIR FAMILIES
AND OUR COMMUNITIES. BUT SERVICE
IS HUNDREDS OF MEN BEING
RELEASED FROM PRISON WILL BE
ABLE TO REBUILD THEIR LIVES
RESTORE THEIR FAMILY CONNECTIONS
AND BREAK THE CYCLE OVER
GENERATIONAL POVERTY. THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIRMAN SURVIVE SHARE
BERS YEAH I RESPECTFULLY REQUEST
YOUR HIGHEST POVERTY I THOUGHT.
OKAY WELL CALL FOR THE QUESTION
IS. AN EIGHTY TWENTY TO FIFTY BY
SOME MEMBER BONTA THE MISSION IS
TO PASS TO THE APPROPRIATIONS
COMMITTEE JONES SAWYER. LACKEY
THE STATE LACKEY ABSTAIN BONTA.
HI BONTA HI BRIAN QUIRK. I WORK
AYE SANTIAGO SAN DIEGO HI FI ARE
TO. THANK YOU FOR CALLING YOUTH
MEASURES LOCAL NEEDS A COUPLE
MORE.
NO. MOVE THE BELL. YOU MAY
PROCEED. THANK YOU. I APPRECIATE
THE OPPORTUNITY TO PRESENT THIS
BILL AFTER VERY- ENGAGING DAY-
AS WE ALL KNOW. THE CULTURE OF
VIOLENCE THAT PERMEATES OUR
PRISON SYSTEM NEEDS TO BE
ADDRESSED. UNITED STATES
NATIONAL YOUR MAPS IS NATIONAL
INSTITUTE OF HEALTH PUBLISHED A
STUDY FINDING APPROXIMATELY 21%
OF MALE MATES WERE PHYSICALLY
ASSAULTED IN A SIX MONTH PERIOD
OF TIME. IN IT GEN THE
CALIFORNIA SENATOR CONCLUDED IN
THEIR TWENTY NINETEEN REPORT
THAT DESPITE THE GRADUAL LAWYER
LOWERING OF TOTAL INMATES IN
PRISON. RECIDIVISM OF THE
POPULATION REMAINS STEADY
HOVERING AROUND 46% WITH THE
TROUBLED PRISON SYSTEM WE NEED
TO FIND A WAY TO QUELL THESE
RATES. IT WILL EXPAND THE TOOL
WILL THE PEACE OFFICERS TASKED
WITH ENSURING THE SAFETY. OF THE
INSTITUTION ORGANIZING IN MADE
COHESION. THIS WILL ALLOW FOR
THE PROTECTION OF BOTH THE
OFFICERS AND INMATES ALIKE. NOW
I WOULD LIKE TO INTRODUCE- I
THINK MISTER LEVELS HERE YES.
AND FOR CANADA BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA CORRECTIONAL
SUPERVISORS ORGANIZATION. OKAY
WHO'S GOING FIRST. MR LEVEL IT
IS GREAT TO SEE YOU AGAIN WE'VE
MISSED YOU- A LITTLE AND I THINK
FOR THE CALIFORNIA CORRECTIONS
SUPERVISOR THIS IS MIKE ON-
SEVENTY BETTER OKAY THANK YOU-
JOHN LEVEL AND THE LEGISLATIVE
ADVOCATE FOR THE CALIFORNIA
CORRECTIONAL SUPERVISORS
ORGANIZATION OF THIS IS AN
IMPORTANT BILL. THAT REALLY WILL
ENHANCE DOES THE AUTHOR POINTED
OUT. SAFETY ALARM IN OUR
INSTITUTIONS NOT ONLY FOR
INMATES BUT ALSO FOR STAFF- IT
ALSO WILL WORK ON THE OTHER END
OF THIS TO PROTECT PEOPLE WHO
ARE NOT IN CUSTODY WHO FIND OUT
INFORMATION ABOUT. PRISON
DIRECTED POTENTIAL HOMICIDES-
NOW I DO WANT TO CORRECT
SOMETHING IN THE BILL THAT'S AN
ERROR AND PLEASE DON'T
MISUNDERSTAND ME I HAVE ENORMOUS
RESPECT FOR THE AMERICAN CIVIL
LIBERTIES UNION IN FACT WHEN MY
FATHER PASSED AWAY. WE GAVE IN
LIEU OF HIS DONATIONS TO THE
ACLU THAT SAID THERE IS- AN
ASSERTION THAT IS JUST FACTUALLY
INACCURATE- THE- LETTER OF THEIR
OPPOSITION SAYS THERE BEEN
SEVERAL PREVIOUS EFFORTS TO
EXPAND THIS AUTHORITY REFERRING
TO THIS BILL. YOU CAN SIMPLY
CLOSE THE JEFFORDS. ALL HAVE
EITHER BEEN. BY THE LEGISLATURE
OR VETOED BY THE GOVERNOR AND
THAT IS FACTUALLY INACCURATE
ASSEMBLY BILL TWO SIX SIX NINE-
BY THE CHAIRMAN- ACTUALLY WAS
ADOPTED BY THIS COMMITTEE
ADOPTED BY THE LEGISLATURE AND
SIGNED INTO LAW- I WAS
PERSONALLY INVOLVED WITH. US
SENATE BILL FOUR TO FOUR BY DR
PAN WHICH DEALT WITH THE USE OF-
PRETEXT COASTER LEVEL COULD YOU-
WHY NOT WRAP IT UP BUT I JUST-
THAT THE USE OF PRETEXT CALLS IN
STUDENT SEXUAL ASSAULT CASES
ALSO WAS PASSED. PLEDGE ARE
MA'AM. AND SIGNED BOB THE
GOVERNOR OF FORD CANNOT WHO'S
REALLY AN EXPERT ON THIS
PARTICULAR BILL IS ALSO TESTIFY
. MAN IF HIS TESTIMONY TO YOU I
GOOD GO AHEAD. WHAT I GUESS WAS
ST CHAIRMAN'S GONE BUT- AND THE
VICE CHAIR BUT I USED TO JUDGE
MCCARTY MILAN DAY. AIR MMHM OKAY
SO FORD CANNOT TIME OF A
MINISTRY RIPPED THE CALIFORNIA
CORRECTIONAL SUPERVISORS
ORGANIZATION WE REPRESENT MAJORS
AND SUPERVISORS IN THE
DEPARTMENT OF STATE HOSPITALS
AND THE AND OF COURSE IT'S- IN.
O. C. WHICHIS OFFICE OF CRAIG
SAY. DOESN'T ACTUALLY WORK IN
THE PRISONS THEIR AGENTS ARE OUT
ON THE STREETS AND ELLA THEY
WILL THEY MONITOR OF. TRAFFIC
BETWEEN THE GANGS ON THE STREETS
AND THE INMATES IN THE PRISONS
AND- THEY WORK 50% OF THEIR TIME
WITH THE F. BY OR- OF THE PEACE
OFFICER OF COMMUNITIES. BASED ON
THE FACT THAT THEY HAVE
CONFIDENTIAL INFORMANTS A WHOLE
CALIFORNIA ALL THE WAY DOWN TO
SAN DIEGO. AND UTILIZED THESE OF
CI IS- TO GET INFORMATION THAT
THEY NEED TO INVESTIGATE. OF THE
PROBLEM IS THAT- THE DISTRICT
ATTORNEY OR THE JUDGES AREN'T
GOING TO GIVE A WARRANT BASED
OFF OF COMFORT ACTUAL FOR STATE
. SO THEY OUT EN AND-
INFORMATION AND THEY FIND THAT-
THEY'RE TRYING TO KILL SOME MAN
MADE IN PRISON. OF FOR EITHER UP
DROPPING OUT OF THE GATE ANGLE.
DOING YOUR DRUG WHATEVER REACH
THEY WANT TO SPUR DID. THEY
NOTICE THE PER TO PER ROOM THE
INMATE AND PUTS THEM IN A SAFE
PLACE. SO THEY'VE DONE THEIR JOB
SOMEWHAT BUT THE PROBLEM IS THAT
THEY CAN CONTINUALLY DO THE SAME
THING. OF WE CAN'T PROSECUTE HIM
BECAUSE THEY DIDN'T HAVE A
WARRANT TO GET THE INFORMATION.
AND THE INFORMATION WILL BE A
PERMISSIBLE IN COURT FOR. YOU
COMMIT BURKE- BELOW CANTOR.
ALLIES THIS IS WOULD YOU WRAP UP
YOUR FIFTH YES SIR PUT A OCS
INTO OF. COLD SIX THREE WOULD
GIVE THEM THE ABILITY PRY THE P.
CALLING FOR THE MURDERS. L.
WHICH RIGHT NOW THEY HAVEN'T
BEEN ABLE TO DO THEY THEY DO
STOP THE MURDERS THEY TO STOP
THE MERGE ON THE STREET A GUY
PAROLES THEY WANT TO KILL THEM
THE THEY STOP THAT BUT THEY
CAN'T PROSECUTE THE PEOPLE THAT
ARE TRYING TO MAKE IT HAPPEN. A
LOT LESS THE- IN PENAL CODE SIX
THIRTY THREE ALL RIGHT IT'S-
DOES ANYONE IN THE ROOM I WANT
TO SPEAK IN FAVOR. OF TWENTY
SEVEN TWENTY SIX OUR
ORGANIZATION AND POSITION. OKAY
WE'LL GET TO THE PHONES LATER-
LET'S HEAR FROM THE OPPOSITION-
I BELIEVE WE'LL HEAR FROM MARGO
GEORGE- AND- KAELIN DEAN FROM
THE ACLU OR- CHAU IS MARCO HERE
YEAH. OKAY ARE THERE SHE IS OKAY.
MARCO GEORGE ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA PUBLIC DEFENDERS AND
OPPOSITION TO THIS BILL ON AND
MISS TEEN HAD TO LEAVE- SH YOU
HAVE HER LETTER I BELIEVE IN THE
PACKET SO THAT SPEAKS FOR
ITSELF- FIRST I JUST WANNA SAY.
THAT OSC ON WHAT THEY'RE SEEKING
TO DO HERE WOULD MAKE THEM A
MEGA POLICING ORGANIZATION
BECAUSE AS THE PROPONENTS OF
SAID THEY ALREADY WORK. IN
CONJUNCTION WITH THE FBI AND
WITH LOCAL LAW ENFORCEMENT AND
BOTH OF THOSE GROUPS HAVE THE
ABILITY TO GET WARRANTS IF THEY
SEE FIT MOREOVER FROM ANYONE
WHO'S EVER HAD A PHONE CALL FROM
STATE PRISON ARE COMMUNICATED
WITH AND WITH MONEY AT THE STATE
PRISON. KNOWS THAT EVERY SINGLE
PHONE CALL THAT'S GOING OUT FROM
THE INSTITUTION OR DURING THE
LIMITED TIME- WITH COVERT
EXPENDED THE- PHONE CALLS YOUR
CONVERSATIONS WERE MONITORED
EVEN UNFORTUNATELY SOMETIMES
LAWYER- CLIENT CONVERSATIONS GOT
SWEPT UP IN THIS AND THIS WOULD
OF COURSE- MAKE THE LIKELIHOOD
OF THAT EVEN GREATER. BUT THE
REASON THIS IS BAD POLICY IS
BECAUSE THERE IS NO REASON FOR.
ON OSC TO BE ABLE TO OCS SKEWS
ME TO DO THIS BECAUSE- IF LOCAL
LONG ENFORCEMENT THAT THERE ARE
ALREADY COOPERATING WITH I THINK
THAT THIS IS A REASONABLE
REQUEST FOR A WARRANT THEY HAVE
THE ABILITY TO GO AND MAKE THAT
HAPPEN. AND EVEN IF THEY WERE
OCS WERE TO OBTAIN THE
INFORMATION THEY STILL HAVE TO
COOPERATE WITH LOCAL PROSECUTORS
OR THE U. S. ATTORNEY AND A
ORDER TO PROSECUTE ANYTHING. SO
ON I THINK ONE OF THE THINGS
THAT WE'RE GRAPPLING WITH HERE
IS THAT MANY JURISDICTIONS HAVE
DECIDED THAT THE GANG DATABASE
IS OVERBROAD THEY REFUSE TO-
PARTICIPATE. IN IT ANY MORE- AND
IN FACT THE CALIFORNIA STATE
AUDITOR HAS- CRITICIZED IT
EXTENSIVELY AS BEING- KANNST GAG
GATHERING UP ALL KINDS OF PEOPLE
WHERE THERE IS NO PROVEN GANG
ALLEGATION. THIS WOULD CURB THE
O. O. C. R. THE ABILITY NOT ONLY
TO MONITOR CONVERSATIONS WITH IN
THE PRISON WALLS MONITOR
CONVERSATIONS BY A PRISONER TO
PERSON OUTSIDE BUT IT WOULD
GIVE. A C. S. ABILITY TO MONITOR
THE CONVERSE. WHEN THE FAMILY-
ARE PERSON OUTSIDE IN ANYONE
THEY CALLED SO FOR THOSE
REASONS. OF WE RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR YOUR CELL PHONE. ALL RIGHT-
IS THERE ANYONE IN THE ROOM WHO
WISHES TO SPEAK IN OPPOSITION.
TO A. B. TWO SEVEN TWO SIX. ALL
RIGHT NOW WE'RE GOING TO GO TO
THE PHONE. AND YET- WE'RE IT'S
AB TWO SEVEN TWO SIX. WE'D LIKE
TO HEAR NAME. ORGANIZATION AND
WHETHER YOU'RE FOR OR AGAINST SO
OPERATOR BY ANYONE WHO WISHES TO
SPEAK FOR OR AGAINST TWO SEVEN
TWO SIX PLEASE GET ON THE PHONE
. THANK YOU AND PLEASE PRESS ONE
ZERO IF YOU'RE FOR OR AGAINST.
WE DO HAVE LINE A ONE EIGHTY
EIGHT PLEASE GO AHEAD. OLYMPIA
CAMPBELL IN STRONG OPPOSITION
THANK YOU. ENACTUS FOUNDATIONAL
ONE I THINK YOU. ALL RIGHT THANK
YOU FROM SPEAKING TO- MR- FORD
CANUTE YES SIR YES SO WHY IS IT
DIFFICULT TO GET AN
AUTHORIZATION FOR A WIRETAP FOR
THE PRISON INVESTIGATORS ARE YOU
SAID THAT THE PROBLEM IS IT'S
BASED UPON. THINGSTHAT YOU HEAR
AROUND THE PRISON WHY WHY IS
THAT A PROBLEM THEY THEY MAKE
MOST THEIR CONTACTS THROUGH
ILLEGAL CELLPHONES THAT ARE IN
THE PRISON THEY DON'T DO IT ON
THE EVERYBODY KNOWS. THAT THOSE
. IN UNDER SO THEY DON'T USE OF
CITIES ILLEGAL CELLPHONES RIGHT
AND MOSTLY INFORMATION COMES
FROM CONFIDENTIAL INFORMANTS OUT
ON THE STREETS FEWER JUST SEE AN
OCS AGED. THEY THEY LOOK LIKE A
GANG MEMBER OR NOTHING LIKE A
HOMELESS MAN OR WHATEVER THEY
BLEND IN AND THEY GO UNDERCOVER
IN THESE ORGANIZATIONS AND THEY
GET THE INFORMATION- WHICH UNDER
THE VEHICLE IS SIX THIRTY THREE
OVER HEARD. OR THEY'LL HAVE A
RECORDER IN OUR POCKET THEY
DON'T USE OF WIRETAPS OKAY THE
PART OF HEAVY IDEAS IS SO IS THE
POLICE BUT 50% OF THE TIME.
THEY'RE WORKING WITHOUT THE
SCOTTISH THE- AUTHOR. WITHOUT
THE POWER OF THE FBI OR THE
LOCAL PIZZA OKAY BUT THIS. THIS
BILL. HOW DOES IN- I THOUGHT
INVOLVED WHAT WHAT IS THE POINT
OF THE BILL THEN IF THEY CAN GET
THE WHY IS IT THAT THE
INFORMATION THEY GET ISN'T. ABLE
TO BE USED IN COURT. BECAUSE
THEY DIDN'T GET A WARRANT FIRST
OKAY BUT WHAT DO THEY NEED TO
WARRANT FLORIDA WARRANT
OFFICIELLE YOU STATEMENT SO THEN
THEY HAVE TO GO GET THE
INFORMATION. THE INFORMATION IS
NO GOOD OKAY BUT WHAT IS GETTING
THE WARRANT FOR. TO INVESTIGATE
THE ALLEGATION CURVES CHARACTER
SO IT'S NOT A WARRANT FOR A WIRE
TAP HER AGE WE DON'T DO THEY
DON'T THEY DON'T DO WIRE TAPS
SO- SO YOU NEED A WAR JUST TO DO
THE INVESTIGATION. YES IT ARE
ALLOWS THEM TO PROCEED GET THE
INFORMATION NOW IT'S USABLE IN
COURT. I SEE. BUT OUR RIGHTS NOT
USABLE IN COURT IF THEY DON'T
HAVE THE WARRANT FIRST YEAH IT
WAS KIND OF LIKE THE CART BEFORE
THE HORSE. AND SO THERE THEY'RE-
THEY'RE CATCHING ALL THIS AND
THEY'RE STOPPING THE MURDERS.
BUT THEY CAN'T PROSECUTE THE
PEOPLE ARE THAT ARE CONSPIRING.
I SEE WELL I THINK WE NEED TO
PROTECT BOTH THE PRISONERS AND-
OUR PRISON GUARD OFFICERS WHO
MAY BE UNDER THREAT. THIS IS I
THINK PRISON GUARDS THE TOUGHEST
JOB IN THE STATE I DON'T THINK
THERE'S ANY QUESTION. SO I'LL BE
SUPPORTING THE BILL- QUESTIONS
FROM. COMMENTS MISTER SEYARTO
MOTION YET. BUT IT'S ALREADY
HAPPENED YES MYSELF AND- MR
SANTIAGO. SO WITH THAT WOULD YOU
LIKE TO CLOSE NO I WOULD JUST
ASK THAT THIS COMMITTEE- PROTECT
BOTH THE INMATE AND THE OFF AND
PROCEED WITH AN AYE VOTE. WITH
THAT FOR OUR LAST BILL. BY THE
WAY MR SECRETARY THANK YOU VERY
MUCH FOR HAVING THE FORESIGHT TO
KEEP THIS ROOM FOR US ALL
AFTERNOON THERE WERE TIMES WE
COULDN'T DO THIS AND REALLY
APPRECIATE THAT AND YOUR FINE
WORK THROUGHOUT THE YEAR SO GO
AHEAD AND CALL THE ROLL. ON AB
TWENTY SEVEN TWENTY SIX BY THE
MEMBER LACKEY THE MOTION IS TO
PASS JONES SAWYER. LACKEY LACKEY
I. BONTA NOT VOTING BRIAN BRIAN
NOT VOTING CORK I WORK AT A SAN
DIEGO SAN DIEGO HI FI ARE TOO
HIGH THEY ARE TO I. NEEDS ONE
AND I KNOW THE CHAIR'S GONNA
VOTE WITH USE THANK YOU VERY
MUCH THANK YOU ALL RIGHT. SO
WE'VE ONLY PASSED ONE BILL TODAY. BUT WE HAVE WELL YES WE HAVE
QUITE A FEW ON CONSENT- IT'S
TIME TO- YEAH IT WE HAVE
EVERYONE HERE BUT THE CHAIR
MISTER CHAIR PLEASE COME. ALL
RIGHT WE'RE GONNA GO THROUGH ALL
THE MEASURES LIFTING CALLS TO DO
ANY ADD ONS OR VOTE CHANGES.
WHEN YOU GET BACK OKAY WE'LL DO
THE CHAIR WHEN HE GETS BACK ALL
RIGHT. I THINK THE FIRST ON CALL
MEASURES NUMBER FOUR HUNDRED
MOMENT ON THE CONSENT CALENDAR
SANTIAGO. SANTIAGO I REMEMBER
WHEN WAS ON CONSENT. ITEM NUMBER
TWO WAS PULLED BY THE AUTHOR.
ITEM NUMBER THREE WITHOUT
CONSENT. ITEM NUMBER FOUR AB
EIGHTEEN TWENTY SEVEN BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER COOPER CORK I.
WORK I ME NO A FEW THINGS WRONG
I WAS LOOKING ON AB EIGHTEEN
TWENTY SEVEN QUIRK NO. SANTIAGO
ON A. B. EIGHTEEN TWENTY SEVEN
ITEM NUMBER FOUR BY SEVEN MEMBER
COOPER. SANTIAGO SANTIAGO NOT
VOTING. ADAM NUMBER FIVE WAS
PULLED BY THE AUTHOR. ADAM
NUMBER SIX. AB SIXTEEN AWAY BY
SUMMER GIPSON THIS MEASURE WAS
ON CALL QUIRK I WORK I SANTIAGO
. SANTIAGO HI THAT MEASURE NOW
PASSES. I ITEM NUMBER SEVEN AB
SIXTEEN TWENTY ONE BY SOME
MEMBER GIPSON CORK. HI COURT HI
THAT MEASURE NOW PASSES. I DON'T
NUMBER EIGHT AB TWENTY EIGHTY
FIVE BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER HOLDEN
SANTIAGO. SANTIAGO HI THAT
MEASURE NOT HOUSES. ITEM NUMBER
NINE AB TWENTY SIX THIRTY TWO BY
SEPTEMBER HOLDEN SANTIAGO
SANTIAGO HI THAT MEASURE PASSES
. I REMEMBER TEN AB TWENTY ONE
SIXTY SEVEN BY IF THE MEMBER
KALRA LACKEY. LACKEY NO BONTA.
BONTA HI BRIAN BRIAN HI SANTIAGO
SAN DIEGO HI FI ARE TO SEE OUR
TO KNOW THAT MEASURE PASSES.
ITEM NUMBER ELEVEN AB TWENTY
FOUR EIGHTEEN BIASA MEMBER KALRA
SANTIAGO. SANTIAGO I SEYARTO THE
R. TEN NO. EXCUSE ME SEYARTO
ABSTAINED ON A B. TWENTY FOUR
EIGHTEEN. THE ITEM NUMBER.
TWELVE EIGHTY SEVENTEEN OH EIGHT
BY A SEVEN MEMBER KILEY BRIAN.
BRIAN NO SANTIAGO. SANTIAGO NOW. IT'S NOT A PROBLEM ON ITEM
NUMBER THIRTEEN EIGHTY SIX
SIXTEEN EIGHTY WITHOUT CONSENT
ITEM FOURTEEN EIGHTY TWENTY FIVE
EIGHT EIGHT WITHOUT CONSENT. I
DON'T FIFTEEN AB TWENTY SIX
SIXTY WAS ON CONSENT ITEMS
SIXTEEN EIGHTY TWENTY FIVE FIFTY
ONE WAS ON CONSENT. I AM
SEVENTEEN AB TWENTY SEVEN SIXTY
ONE BY SOME MEMBER MCCARTY THIS
MEASURES ON CALL. JONES SAWYER
LACKEY. LACKEY ABSTAIN BONTA. HI
BONTA I SANTIAGO. YES BY SOME
REMEMBER MCCARTY SANTIAGO HI
SEYARTO. SEYARTO I THAT MEASURE
PASSES. I DON'T NUMBER EIGHTEEN
TWENTY SEVEN SEVENTY EIGHT WITH
A CONSENT ITEM NINETEEN AB
TWENTY THREE NINETY WAS PULLED
BY AUTHOR I DON'T TWENTY ONE
THIRTY EIGHT WAS PULLED BY
AUTHOR. I DON'T NUMBER TWENTY
ONE AB TWENTY FIVE FORTY FIVE
LACKEY LACKEY HI BONTA. BONTA
NOT VOTING SANTIAGO SANTIAGO NOT
VOTING SEYARTO THEY ARE TO I.
THE ITEM NUMBER TWENTY TWO AB
TWENTY SIX SEPT FUSE ME TWENTY
SEVEN SIXTY NINE WITH FULL BY
AUTHOR. I REMEMBER TO TWENTY TWO
FORTY SIX BY SUMMER
PETRIE-NORRIS SANTIAGO. NOT A
PROBLEM. YEAH. I BELIEVE THE
CHAIR RECOMMENDED NOW YES.
SANTIAGO NOW. I AM TWENTY FOUR
AB TWENTY THREE FIFTY SIX
RODRIGUEZ BY FUSE ME BY SUMMER
RODRIGUEZ BRIAN. NOT VOTING
BRIAN NOT BOATING SANTIAGO
SANTIAGO I. I AM TWENTY FIVE
EIGHTY TWENTY TWENTY WAS PULLED
BY THE AUTHOR. ITEM NUMBER
TWENTY SIX AB TWENTY FOUR
SEVENTEEN BY A FAMILY MEMBER
TEAM LACKEY. LACKEY HI BONTA.
BONTA I SANTIAGO SAN DIEGO HI
SEYARTO THEY ARE TURNOUT VOTING
THAT MEASURE WAS ON CALL AND NOW
PASSES. I AM TWENTY SEVEN AB
TWENTY SEVEN SEVENTEEN WITHOUT
CONSENT. ITEM NUMBER TWENTY
EIGHT AB TWENTY TWO FIFTY. BY
SUMMER BONTA THIS MEASURE WAS ON
CALL JONES SAWYER JONES SAWYER
HI BRIAN BRIAN I SEE YOUR TO THE
OUR TURN NOW THAT MEASURE NOW
PASSES. I AM TWENTY NINE AB TWO
FIVE FIVE SEVEN. BY A SEVEN
MEMBER BONTA THIS MEASURE WAS ON
CALL BRIAN BRIAN HI FI ARE TO
THE ARE TO KNOW THAT MEASURE NOW
PASSES. ITEM THIRTY EIGHTY BY
THE MEMBER SEYARTO SANTIAGO SAN
DIEGO I. I AM THIRTY ONE AB
TWENTY SEVEN TWENTY SIX BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER LACKEY JONES THIS
MEASURE WAS ON CALL JONES SAWYER
. THE ANSWER HI THAT MEASURE NOW
PASSES. YEAH I DON'T NUMBER
THIRTY TWO EIGHTY TWENTY FORTY
THREE BY SUMMER JONES SAWYER
THIS MEASURE WAS ON CALL BRIAN.
BRIAN I SANTIAGO. SANTIAGO I
THAT MEASURE NOW PASSES. ITEM
THIRTY THREE AB TWENTY TWO
NINETY FOUR BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER
JONES SAWYER THIS MEASURE WAS ON
CALL LACKEY. LACKEY NO BONTA. HI
BONTA HI SANTIAGO SAN DIEGO I
SEE YOUR TO THEY ARE TOO NARROW
THAT MEASURE NOW PASSES. ATTY A
COUPLE THINGS LEFT. IT'S BEEN
FUN ONE DAY. RIGHT FOR THANK YOU
CHAIR. WITH THE FOURTEENTH. GIVE
ME ONE MOMENT PLEASE. WE DO WE
SCHEDULE HONEST ON ITEM NUMBER
SEVENTEEN AB TWENTY SEVEN SIXTY
ONE BY SOME MEMBER MCCARTY JONES
SAWYER HI JONES SAWYER HI AS
AMENDED YES IT'S GOING WITH THEM
YES IT'S GOING AS AMENDED START. WHICH WHAT I MAY FIND IT
DIFFERENT IN AMERICA OR DIRECTLY
FOR THE NIGHT IN AMERICA WHO WAS
SEVENTEENTH WITH THAT KIND OF
THE ATHLETES LIKE YES ON ITEM
SEVENTEEN. ON TWENTY TWENTY
SEVEN SIXTY ONE MCCARTY. WHAT
WOULD YOU LIKE TO DO SIR. HI.
SEYARTO I TO NOT VOTING. ON
EIGHTY TWENTY SEVEN SIXTY ONE.
WE SO IT'S FINE MISTER SAWYER
DONE MORE. ALL RIGHT OR- THIS
CONCLUDES THE BUSINESS OR THE
ASSEMBLY PUBLIC SAFETY COMMITTEE
. ON THEY'RE LOOKING AT THE END
OF.